hi everyone welcome to this artificial
intelligence 2022 full course video by
simply
loan AI also
called the top machine learning
algorithms that are used to build
intelligent
machines or serve every member of the
House a customized cup of coffee makes
your day easier doesn't it these are the
products of artificial intelligence but
why use the term artificial intelligence
well these machines are artificially
Incorporated with humanlike intelligence
to perform tasks as we do this
intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but AI may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact AI is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an AI do at
its core here is a robot we built in our
lab which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the AI robot must perform as expected
this ability to react appropriately to a
new situation is called generalized
learning the robot is now at a Crossroad
one that is paved and the other Rocky
the robot must determine which path to
take based on the circumstances this
portrays the robot's reasoning ability
after a short stroll the robot now
encounters a stream that it cannot swim
across using the plank provided as an
input the robot is able to cross this
stream so our robot uses the given input
and finds the solution for a problem
this is problem solving
these three capabilities make the robot
artificially intelligent in short AI
provides machines with the capability to
adapt reason and provide
Solutions well now that we know what AI
is let's have a look at the two broad
categories an AI is classified into weak
AI also called narrow AI focuses solely
on one task for example alphago is a
maestro of the game go
but you can't expect it to be even
remotely good at chess this makes
alphago a weak AI you might say Alexa is
definitely not a weak AI since it can
perform multiple tasks well that's not
really true when you ask Alexa to play
despasito it picks up the key words play
and despacito and runs a program and is
trained to Alexa cannot respond to a
question it isn't trained to answer
for instance try asking Alexa the status
of traffic from work to home Alexa
cannot provide you this information as
she is not trained to and that brings us
to our second category of AI strong AI
now this is much like the robots that
only exist in fiction as of now Ultron
from Avengers is an ideal example of a
strong AI That's because it's self-aware
and eventually even develops emotion
this makes the ai's response
unpredictable You Must Be Wondering well
how is artificial intelligence different
from machine learning and deep learning
we saw what AI is machine learning is a
technique to achieve Ai and deep
learning in turn is a subset of machine
learning machine learning provides a
machine with the capability to learn
from data and experience through
algorithms deep learning does this
learning through ways inspired by the
human brain this means through deep
learning data and patterns can be better
perceived Ray kheel a well-known
futurist predicts that by the year 2045
we would have robots as smart as humans
this is called the point of Singularity
well that's not all in fact Elon Musk
predicts that the human mind and body
will be enhanced by AI implants which
would make us partly cyborgs so here's a
question for you which of the below AI
projects don't exist yet a an AI robot
with citizenship B a robot with a
muscular skeletal system C AI that can
read its owner's emotions D AI that
develops emotions over time give it a
thought and leave your answers in the
comment section below since the human
brain is still a mystery it's no
surprise that AI 2 has a lot of
unventured domains for now ai is built
to work with humans and make our tasks
easier however with the maturation of
Technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of AI holds for us well
that is artificial intelligence for you
in short do not forget to leave your
answer to the quiz in the comment
section below also like share and
subscribe to our Channel if you enjoyed
this video stay tuned and keep
learning no
let's look at the different types of
artificial
intelligence so AI can be classified
based on capabilities and
functionalities under capabilities there
are three types of artificial
intelligence they are narrow AI General
Ai and super AI under functionalities we
have four types of artificial
intelligence reactive machine limited
memory theory of mind and self-awareness
let's look at them one by
one first we will look at the different
types of artificial intelligence based
on
capabilities so what is narrow AI narrow
AI also known as weak AI focuses on one
narrow task and cannot perform Beyond
its limitations it aims at a single
subset of cognitive abilities and
advances in that Spectrum applications
of narrow AI are becoming increasingly
common in our day-to-day lives as
machine learning and deep learning
methods continue to
evolve
Apple Siri is a simple example of an
narrow AI that operates with a limited
predefined range of functions Siri often
has challenges with tasks outside its
range of abilities IBM Watson
supercomputer is another example of
narrow AI which applies cognitive
Computing machine learning and natural
language processing to process
information and answer your
questions IBM Watson once outperformed
human contestant Ken Jenkins to become
the champion on the popular game show
Jeopardy
other examples of narrow AI include
Google Translate image recognition
software recommendation systems spam
filtering and Google's page ranking
algorithm next we have General
artificial intelligence or general AI
General AI also known as strong AI has
the ability to understand and learn any
intellectual task that a human can
General artificial intelligence has
received a$1 billion investment from
Microsoft through open AI it allows a
machine to apply Knowledge and Skills in
different contexts AI researchers and
scientists have not achieved strong AI
so far to succeed they would need to
find a way to make machines conscious
programming a full set of cognitive
abilities Fujitsu built the K computer
which is one of the fastest computers in
the world it is one of the most notable
attempts at achieving strong AI it took
40 minutes to simulate a single second
of neural activity so it is difficult to
determine whether or not strong AI will
be achieved in the near
future tan 2 is a superc computer
created by China's national university
of Defense technology it currently holds
the record for CPS at 33.86 petaflops
although it sounds exciting the human
brain is estimated to be capable of one
exaflop now CPS means characters per
second that A system can
process
third in the list of AI that is based on
capabilities we have super AI super AI
exceeds human intelligence and can
perform any task better than a
human the concept of artificial super
intelligence sees AI evolved to be so
akin to human emotions and experiences
that it doesn't just understand them it
evokes emotions needs beliefs and
desires of its own its existence is
still hypothetical some of the key
characteristics of super AI include the
ability to think solve puzzles make
judgments and decisions on its
own now if you have enjoyed watching
this video so far please make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to stay updated with all
the latest Technologies also if you have
any questions related to this video
please put it in the chat section our
team of experts will help you address
your
questions moving ahead now we will see
the different types of artificial
intelligence based on functionalities
in this category first we have reactive
machine a reactive machine is the basic
form of AI that does not store memories
or use past experiences to determine
future actions it works only with
present data the simply perceive the
world and react to it reactive machines
are given certain tasks and don't have
capabilities Beyond those
duties IBM's deep blue which defeated
just Grandmaster Gary casprov is a
reactive machine that sees the pieces on
a chess board and reacts to them it
cannot refer to any of its prior
experiences and cannot improve with
practice deep blue can identify the
pieces on a chest board and know how
each moves it can make predictions about
what moves might be next for it and its
opponent it can CH data for a specific
period of time they cannot add it to a
library of their
experiences this kind of technology is
used for self-driving vehicles they
observe how other vehicles are moving
around them in the present and as time
passes that ongoing collected data gets
added to the static data within the AI
machine such as Lane markers and traffic
lights they're included when the vehicle
decides to change lanes to avoid cutting
of another driver or being hit by a
nearby vehicle Mitsubishi Electric is a
company that has been figuring out how
to improve such technology for
applications like self-driving cars
then we have theory of Mind theory of
Mind represents a very advanced class of
technology and exists as a concept this
kind of AI requires a thorough
understanding that the people and the
things within an environment can alter
feelings and
behaviors it should be able to
understand people's emotions sentiment
and
thoughts even though a lot of
improvements are there in this field
this kind of a is not complete yet one
real world example of theory of Mind AI
is Kismet a robot head made in the late
'90s by a Massachusetts Institute of
Technology researcher kmet can mimic
human emotions and recognize them both
abilities are key advancements in theory
of Mind AI but Kismet can't follow gazes
or convey attention to humans Sofia from
Hansen robotics is another example where
the theory of Mind AI was implemented
cameras within Sophia's eyes combined
with computer algorithms allow her to
see SE and follow faces sustain eye
contact and recognize individuals she is
able to process speech and have
conversations using natural language
subsystem finally we have
self-awareness self-awareness AI only
exists
hypothetically such systems understand
that internal traits States and
conditions and perceive human emotions
these machines will be smarter than the
human
mind this type of AI will not only be
able to understand an evoke emotions in
those it interacts with but also have
emotions needs and beliefs of its own
while we are probably far away from
creating machines that are self-aware we
should focus our efforts towards
understanding memory learning and the
ability to base decisions on past
experiences I am K and today we shall be
talking about the top 10 artificial
intell elligence Technologies before
getting into the video here's a gentle
reminder to subscribe to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon so that you wouldn't
miss any update from us so without
further Ado let's quickly jump into the
topic in the list we have natural
language generation smart devices
virtual agents speech recognition
augmented reality machine learning
robotic process automation
decision management deep learning and
finally image recognition please note
that the list is in no particular
order natural language
generation communicating or conveying
the information efficiently and
transparently is very much crucial in
communication to say the right words in
the right sequence to convey the message
clearly humans often find it tricky and
when it comes to machines it's
trickier natural language generation is
a subdiscipline of artificial
intelligence and is a trendy technology
that converts the structured data into a
native language the machines are
programmed in such a way that the
algorithms convert the data into a
desirable format for the
users this technology is widely used in
customer service report generat ation
and summarizing business intelligence
insights some of the sample vendors are
at EV automated insights SAS Cambridge
semantics digital reasoning narrative
science
Etc on the list next we have Smart
devices with every passing day smart
devices are becoming more popular and
more trendy technologies that people
were using one Once Upon A Time are now
remodeled and modified as smart
devices they can be used in almost every
industry to improve efficiency and
optimize the
operations smart devices are everyday
objects made intelligent with Advanced
computations which include artificial
intelligence and machine
learning they are electronic gadgets
that are able to connect share and
interact with its users and other smart
devices some of the smart devices are
smart watches smart glasses smartph
phones smart speakers Etc virtual agents
they are computer generated intelligence
that provides online customer assistance
they can effectively communicate with
humans in most of the web and mobile
applications we see chatbots as customer
service agents who interact with us
answering our
queries in simple virtual agents are a
manifestation of a technology which aims
to create an effective but digital
impersonation of
humans virtual agents can make
reservations book an appointment place
an order and can even Avail product
information some of the best examples of
virtual agents are Google assistant and
Amazon Alexa and the companies that
provide virtual agents are Microsoft
Google Amazon and assist
AI next we have speech
recognition speech recognition is yet
another subdiscipline of artificial
intelligence which is used to convert
human speech into a comprehensive and
useful format for Computer Applications
to process it can be said as a bridge
between computer comp interactions and
humans it's presently used in
interactive voice response systems and
mobile applications some of the
companies offering speech recognition
services are Nuance Communications open
text nce and weend
systems augmented reality yet another
trendy technology in the field of
artificial intelligence augmented
reality is an enhanced version of the
real physical world that is achieved
using sound digital visual elements and
other sensory stimuli delivered via
technology augmented reality uses the
existing environment and adds
information to it to make a new
artificial environment it Alters the
perception of the real world environment
augmented reality is making its way into
several retail stores that make makeup
selection and Furnishing much more fun
and Interactive acve if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
machine learning machine learning is an
application and an important branch of
artificial intelligence which refers to
machines being able to learn by
themselves without being explicitly
programmed it enables systems to learn
and improve from experience
automatically
machine learning platforms are becoming
more and more popular with the help of
algorithms apis big data and
applications and training tools
Enterprises are heavily investing in
machine learning to reap its benefits
for the various
domains machine learning is widely used
for
categorization and prediction some of
the sample vendors are Amazon fractal
Analytics Google Microsoft Etc robotic
process
automation configuring a robot to
interpret communicate and analyze data
is robotic process automation it uses
scripts and other methods to automate
the human actions which in turn supports
efficient business
processes robotic process automation is
widely used in those areas where the
physical presence of a human is
dangerous Fields like Warfare mining Etc
is where it's currently being used we
need to remember that artificial
intelligence is not meant to replace
humans but instead it is to complement
their abilities and reinforce human
Talent companies that are focusing on
robotic process automation are piga
systems automation anywhere blue prism
Etc next on the list we have decision
management decision management is yet
another technology in artificial
intelligence that helps companies make
valid Decisions by providing upto-date
and relevant information and Performing
analytic
functions artificial intelligence when
combined with decision management helps
translate customer data into predictive
models of key
trends it also helps in making quick
decisions avoidance of risks and in the
automation of the process decision
management is widely used in the
healthcare sector financial sector
Insurance sector e-commerce and many
more some of the companies that provide
this service are Informatica Advanced
systems Concepts Pika systems Mana Etc
deep learning deep learning is a branch
of artificial intelligence that mimics
the workings of the human brain in
processing
data this data is used for a variety of
purposes like recognizing speech
detecting objects translating languages
and making
decisions deep learning uses hierarchy
level of artificial neural networks for
carrying out the process of machine
learning which is used across several
Industries for various
applications some of the sample vendors
are deep Instinct fluid AI math Works
saffron technology
Etc at last we have image recognition
image recognition is the process of
detecting an object or feature in a
digital image or video it can be used to
analyze clients and their opinions
verify users based on their faces detect
license plates and diagnos diseases the
present day image recognition is
comparable to human visual perception
many social media platforms like
Facebook use this technology to enhance
image search and Aid visually impaired
users clarify gums and sste provide this
technology decades ago the term
artificial intelligence was just another
Frankenstein story but today it could be
a citizen in your next door right from
his Genesis artificial intelligence was
programmed to probe into human life and
eliminate the fortifications of the
impossibilities in many areas like
Health Care Transportation communication
and much more there are hundreds and
thousands of organizations Tech
communities and Engineers worldwide
working around the clock to make
Miracles a reality and today we are
going to discuss the top 10 amongst
those who are contributing a significant
part so here we are the top 10
artificial intelligence companies to
watch in
2022 at number 10 we have VI AI this AI
is a revolutionary approach to
dramatically improvise the way
Healthcare is delivered wi AI focuses on
implementing artificial intelligence to
diagnose and detect abnormalities in the
human body via CT CTA MRI X-ray EKG
ultrasound
Etc this AI coordinates both the patient
and Healthcare professionals at the same
time the patient reports are shared Via
Mobile to all the concerned Medical
Teams results are astonishing with whz
aai there is a significant Improvement
in productivity and reduction of time
required for patient treatment and
discharge this AI was founded in 2016
and established in November
2021 the company runs with 223 employees
and the headquarters is in San Francisco
with AI mainly focuses on improving and
filling all the gaps between patients
and Health Care Professionals with AI
offers handsome salaries to its
employees in India the salaries range
from 4 lakhs to 18 lakhs per Anum and in
America the wages range from
$110,000 to $210,000 perom so at number
nine we have Farm wise 10 years ago an
automated wheat killing Robo was science
fiction now it's rise of practical weed
killing Robos with millimeter Precision
thanks to farmwise the first product of
the Californian based company was an
automated Robo weer based on AI computer
vision and also robotics the robo would
eliminate weeds from the vegetable
Fields Farm bu intends to build
Innovative systems and efficient
procedures that help farmers streamline
farming with efficiency farmwise was
established in the year 2020 the company
functions with 50 employees on board and
actively looking for expansion the
company follows the procedure of paying
farming equipment employees and contract
Personnel hourly Farm makes an annual
turnover of $8.5 million us an average
an AIML engineer at Farm wise earns
anywhere
around $13,000
perom up next we have amp robotics at
number eight we have amp robotics While
others are busy trying to revolutionize
mankind with AI EMP robotics came up
with an Innovative idea that happens to
be a kind gesture of gratitude towards
nature amp aai designed an artificial
intelligence Robo that recycles E-Waste
plastic waste and waste from
construction sites and much more the
robo precisely identifies paper Plastics
and metals by learning and recognizing
them via color size shape and a few more
factors the Colorado based company is
currently operational with 137 employees
in total and looking forward to expand
the idea globally AP robotics aims to
reimagining recycling and to create a
world without waste through artificial
intelligence EMP robotics BAS handsome
salaries to their employees with an
average salary of an employee amp
robotics varies between
$96,000 to
$131,000 perom coming up next is a giant
at number seven we have automation
anywhere automation anywhere is a global
robotics Automation and software company
founded in the year 2003 the company's
headquarters is located in San Jose
California the global RPA leader offers
Cloud native web-based intelligent
automation solutions to the world's
leading Cloud companies automation
anywhere's automation 360 offers a
variety of intelligent tools and
self-learning systems to automate every
redundant task automation anywhere is
focusing on transforming the companies
to be RPA oriented and the current coid
situations have triggered the need for
automation even more a recent survey
States the RPA adoption rates will
increase by 57% in just one more year
the globally recognized multinational
company works with more than
2,200 plus employees on board the
company pays decent salaries as well at
number six we have Microsoft AI
Microsoft integrated AI into cloud
computing Microsoft's AI platform
provides robust solutions to Cloud
related problems Microsoft's AI division
is headquartered in Redmond Washington
with around 5,000 employees specifically
in the AI Division and aims to train and
certify 15,000 employees by
2022 Microsoft AI is a robust framework
designed for developing AI Solutions
using machine learning data science
Robotics iot and more AI enabl Services
accelerate productivity to a greater
level Microsoft aure uses AI to get best
of breed infrastructure with Enterprise
cre security availability compliance and
manageability Microsoft also pays
handsome salaries to their employees the
average salary of an employee at the
Microsoft AI division earns up to
$160,000 perom at number five we have
data robo data Robo has its headquarters
in Boston it is one of the AI Cloud
leaders providing a unified plat the
delivery of AI to the cloud data Robo
aims to understand and Leverage The
inherent capabilities of the platform
data Robo has the caliber to help
business analysts in building Predictive
Analytics with no knowledge of machine
learning it uses automated ml to build
and deploy accurate predictive models in
a short fan of time the global Cloud
leader currently operates with more than
a, employees worldwide data Robo
compensates its employees with handsome
salaries an average employee at data
Robo earns up to $160,000 per year and
up to 3ak 400,000 rupees in
India at number four we have Amazon the
Alexa Maker Amazon is one of the tech
Giants interested in adopting AI into
its various divisions
Amazon calls its AI Services Amazon Lex
Amazon poly Amazon recognition and
Amazon machine
learning these services are accessible
through a software API call or console
the Amazon AI suit of services can have
text or voice conversations with an end
user using a conversational chat Ops
interface the Seattle based Tech Giant
is currently using AI for its Smart Home
Solutions AI companies like Alexa and
its business intelligence needs Amazon
is also conducting trials on drone
delivery to save time and efforts to
deliver goods and services to remote
locations with ease Amazon AI aims to
provide biometric payments to its
customers at cashfree stores the
approach is still in Trials Amazon calls
it just walkout
technology Amazon has enormous teams and
pays decent salaries to its employees
for example an employee at Amazon can
earn up to 20 lakh rupees perom in India
and about
$100,000 perom in United States of
America at number three we have data
bricks datab bricks is one of the best
data driven companies data bricks lake
houses combined data warehouses
reliability performance and governance
with the openness and flexibility of
data leaks data brick is headquartered
in San Francisco California and has 15
office locations across 11 countries the
company announces plans on delivering
keynote on data and machine learning
product Innovations and the rise of the
lakeh house architecture
advancements data bricks currently
operates with 2,000 plus employees
globally the organization compensates
its employees with handsome salaries an
average employee at data fa bricks makes
about $154,000 us and around 2.1 lakh
rupees perom in
India next we have meta at number two we
have Meta Meta formerly known as
Facebook is innovating an advanced way
of social interaction meta has
integrated artificial intelligence and
it's being called The Meta AI meta AI
has its headquarters in Toronto Canada
meta AI has redesigned a new material
and touch sensor with potential to boost
the development of meta War a team of
researchers at The Meta wor have worked
jointly with Scientists at Cari melon
University to build reskin a plastic 3
mm thick membrane with Magnetic
particles capable of measuring touch and
sensation a thrilling experiment meta
has under its sleeve I would say meta
currently operates remotely with about
350 employees on board critics also
state that meta pays a vast salary to
its AI experts with an average salary of
$750,000 paid to the employees at meta
AI at number one we have Google AI
Google AI is the division of Google
dedicated to artificial intelligence CEO
Sundar Pai announced it at Google IO 27
17 Google AI has its headquarters in
California Google AI is demonstrating
its Quantum Computing Supremacy with its
new and Powerful cinem more processor
Google's AI is one of the most
widespread Technologies is almost
everywhere from your language
translations to helping people with
speech impairments to have a successful
conversation social media interactions
shopping lists and assist ing users with
GPS sending alerts to its users about
natural calamities and saving them
Google AI has announced that its
research team is designing Next
Generation AI chips for a smart future
in addition a new AI model allows
artificial intelligence to perform chip
design that more efficiently solves
unique aspects of any problem with an
artificial neural network Google AI
currently works with our four divisions
with massive teams we have come to an
end of this session on the top 10 AI
companies to watch out for in 2022 hello
and welcome to machine learning tutorial
part one this is part one of a machine
learning series put on by simplylearn my
name is Richard kersner I'm with the
simplylearn team that's www.s
simplylearn tocom get certified get
ahead what's in it for you today well
we'll start off with a brief explanation
of why machine learning and what is
machine learning and then we'll get into
a few of the types of machine learning
machine learning algorithms linear
regression decision trees support Vector
machine and finally we'll do a use case
where we're going to classify whether
recipe is of a cupcake or a muffin using
the spvm or the support Vector machine
sounds like a delicious way to explore
machine learning so why machine learning
why do we even care about having these
computers come up and be able to do all
these new things for us well because
machine can now drive your car for you
still very in the infant stage but it's
just exploding as we see with Google's
wayo and then Uber head their program
which unfortunately crashed they know
that this is huge this is going to be
the huge industry to change our whole
Transportation infrastructure machine
learning is now used to detect over 50
eye diseases do you know how amazing
that is to have a computer that double
checks for the doctor for things they
might miss that's just huge in the
health industry pretty soon they
actually do already have that in some
areas where maybe not for eyes but for
other diseases where they're using the
camera on your phone to help
pre-diagnosed before you go and see the
doctor and because the machine can now
unlock your phone with your face I mean
that's just cool having it being able to
identify your face or your voice and be
able to turn stuff on and off for you
depending on where you're at and what
you need talking about an ultimate
automation our world we live in and as
we dig in deeper we have a nice example
of Facebook as you can see here they
have the Facebook post with Halloween
comment yes if you want it order here
nobody likes spam posts on Facebook that
annoy them into interacting with likes
shares comments and other actions I
remember the original ones were all if
you don't click on here you will have
bad luck or some kind of Fear Factor
well this is a huge thing in a social
media when people are getting spammed
and so this tactic knowing as engagement
bait takes advantage of Facebook's
Newsfeed algorithm by choosing
engagement in in order to get the
greater reach to eliminate engagement
bait the company reviewed and
categorized hundreds of thousands of
posts to train a machine learning model
that detects different types of
Engagement bait so in this case we have
we're using Facebook but this is of
course across all the different social
media they have different tools are
building and the Facebook scroll GIF
will be replaced kind of like a virus
coming in there it notices that there's
a certain setup with Facebook and it's
able to replace it and they have like
vote baiting react baiting share baiting
they have all these different these are
kind of General titles but there
certainly are a lot of way of baiting
you to go in there and click on
something so they fed all this this data
was fed into the machine and then they
have the new post the new post comes up
that Takes Over part of the Facebook
setup and that's what you're looking at
you're looking at this new post that's
replaced like a virus has replaced that
so what Facebook did to eliminate this
is they start scanning for keywords and
phrases like this and checks the
click-through rate so it starts looking
for people who are clicking through it
without even looking at it or clicking
through it and it's not something that
normally would be clicked through once
Facebook has scanned for these keywords
and phrases it is now able to identify
the spam coming in and this makes your
life easier so you're not getting
spammed it's not like walking through an
airport and in a lot of countries you
have like hundreds of people trying to
sell you time share come join us sign up
for this eliminates that annoyingness so
now you can just enjoy your Facebook and
your cat pictures or maybe it's your
family pictures mine is family certainly
people like their cat pictures too
another good example is Google's Deep
Mind project Alpha go a computer program
that plays a board game go has defeated
the world's number one go player and I
hope I say his name right kyg the
ultimate go challenge game a three of
three was on May 27th 2017 so that's
just last year that this happened and
what makes this so important is that you
know go is just is a game so it's not
like you're driving a car or something
in our real world but they are using G
games to learn how to get the machine
learning program to learn they want it
to learn how to learn and that is a huge
step a lot of this is still in its
infant stage as far as development as we
saw what happened with the as I referred
to earlier the Uber cars they lost their
whole division because they jumped ahead
too fast so it's still an infant stage
but boy is this like the beginning of
just an amazing world that is automated
in ways we can't even imagine what
tomorrow is going to look like we've
looked at a lot of examples of machine
learning so let's see if we can give a
little bit more of a concrete definition
what is machine learning machine
learning is the science of making
computers learn and act like humans by
feeding data and information without
being explicitly programmed we see here
we have a nice little diagram where we
have our ordinary system uh your
computer nowadays you can even run a lot
of this stuff on a cell phone because
cell phones advance so much and then
with artificial intelligence and machine
learning it now takes the data and it
learns from what happened before and
then it predicts what's going to come
next and then really the biggest part
right now in machine learning that's
going on is it improves on that how do
we find a new solution so we go from
descriptive where it's learning about
stuff and understanding how it fits
together to predicting what it's going
to do to post scripting coming up with a
new solution and when we're working on
machine learning there's a number of
different diagrams that people have
posted for what steps to go go through a
lot of it might be very domain specific
so if you're working on Photo
identification versus language versus
medical or physics some of these are
switched around a little bit or new
things are put in they're very specific
to The Domain this is kind of very
general diagram first you want to Define
your objective very important to know
what it is you're wanting to predict
then you're going to be collecting the
data so once you've defined an objective
you need to collect the data that
matches you spend a lot of time in data
science is collecting data and the next
step preparing the data you got to make
sure that your data is clean going in
there's the old saying bad data in bad
answer out or bad data out and then once
you've gone through and we've cleaned
all this stuff coming in then you're
going to select the algorithm which
algorithm are you going to use you're
going to train that algorithm in this
case I think we're going to be working
with svm the support Vector machine then
you have to test the model does this
model work is this a valid model for
what we're doing and then once you've
tested it you want to run your
prediction you want to run your
prediction or your choice or whatever
output it's going to come up with and
then once everything is set and you've
done lots of testing then you want to go
ahead and deploy the model and remember
I said domain specific this is very
general as far as the scope of doing
something a lot of models you get
halfway through and you realize that
your data is missing something and you
have to go collect new data because
you've run a test in here someplace
along the line you're saying hey I'm not
really getting the answers I need so
there's a lot of things that are domain
specific that become part of this model
this is a very general model but it's a
very good model to start with and we do
have some basic divisions of what
machine learning does that's important
to know for instance do you want to
predict a category well if you're
categorizing thing that's classification
for instance whether the stock price
will increase or decrease so in other
words I'm looking for a yes no answer is
it going up or is it going down and in
that case we'd actually say is it going
up true if it's not going up up it's
false meaning it's going down this way
it's a yes no 01 do you want to predict
a quantity that's regression so remember
we just did classification now we're
looking at regression these are the two
major divisions in what data is doing
for instance predicting the age of a
person based on the height weight health
and other factors So based on these
different factors you might guess how
old a person is and then there are a lot
of domain specific things like do you
want to detect an anomaly that's anomaly
detection this is actually very popular
right now for instance you want to
detect money withdrawal anomalies you
want to know when someone's making a
withdrawal that might not be their own
account we've actually brought this up
because this is really big right now if
you're predicting the stock whether to
buy stock or not you want to be able to
know if what's going on in the stock
market is an anomaly use a different
prediction model because something else
is going on you got to pull out new
information in there or is this just the
norm I'm going to get my normal return
on my money invested so being able to
detect anomalies is very big in data
science these days another question that
comes up which is on what we call
untrained data is do you want to
discover structure in unexplored data
and that's called clustering for
instance finding groups of customers
with similar Behavior given a large
database of customer data containing
their demographics and past buying
records and in this case we might notice
that anybody who's wearing certain set
of shoes goes shopping at certain stores
or whatever it is they're going to be
make certain purchases by having that
information it helps us to Market or
group people together so that we can now
explore that group and find out what it
is we want to Market to them if you're
in the marketing world and that might
also work in just about any Arena you
might want to group people together
whether their uh based on their
different areas and Investments and
financial background whether you're
going to give them a loan or not before
you even start looking at whether
they're valid customer for the bank you
might want to look at all these
different areas and group them together
based on unknown data so you're not you
don't know what the data is going to
tell you but you want to Cluster people
together that come together let's take a
quick DeTour for quiz time oh my
favorite so we're going to have a couple
questions here under our quiz time and
um we'll be posting the answers in the
part two of this tutorial so let's go
ahead and take a look at these quiz
times questions and hopefully you'll get
them all right and it'll get you
thinking about how to process data and
what's going on can you tell What's
happen happening in the following cases
of course you're sitting there with your
cup of coffee and you have your check
box and your pen trying to figure out
what's your next step in your data
science analysis so the first one is
grouping documents into different
categories based on the topic and
content of each document very big these
days you know you have legal documents
you have uh maybe it's a Sports Group
documents maybe you're analyzing
newspaper postings but certainly having
that automated is a huge thing in
today's world B identifying handwritten
digits in images correctly so we want to
know whether they're writing an A or
capital A B C what are they writing out
in their hand digit their handwriting C
behavior of a website indicating that
the site is not working as designed D
predicting salary of an individual based
on his or her years of experience HR
hiring uh setup there so stay tuned for
part two we'll go ahead and answer these
questions when we get to the part two of
this tutorial or you can just simply
write at the bottom and send a note to
Simply learn and they'll follow up with
you on it back to our regular content
now these last few bring us into the
next topic which is another way of
dividing our types of machine learning
and that is with supervised
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
supervised learning is a method used to
enable machines to classify predict
objects problems or situations based on
labeled data fed to the machine and in
here you see we have a jumble of data
with circles triangles and squares and
we label them we have what's a circle
what's a triangle what's a square we
have our model training and it trains it
so we know the answer very important
when you're doing supervised learning
you already know the answer to a lot of
your information coming in so you have a
huge group of data coming in and then
you have new data coming in so we've
trained our model the model now knows
the difference between a circle a square
a triangle and now that we've trained it
we can send in in this case a square and
a circle goes in and it predicts that
the top one's a square and the next
one's a circle and you can see that this
is uh being able to predict whether
someone's going to default on a loan
because I was talking about Banks
earlier supervise learning on stock
market whether you're going to make
money or not that's always important and
if you are looking to make a fortune on
the stock market keep in mind it is very
difficult to get all the data correct on
the stock market it is very uh it
fluctuat and ways you really hard to
predict so it's quite a a roller coaster
ride if you're running machine learning
on the stock market you start realizing
you really have to dig for new data so
we have supervised learning and if you
have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning machine learning model finds
the hidden pattern in an unlabeled data
so in this case instead of telling it
what the circle is and what a triangle
is and what a square is it goes in there
looks at them and says for whatever
reason it groups them together maybe
it'll group it by the number of corners
and it notices that a number of them all
have three corners a number of them all
have four corners and a number of them
all have no corners and it's able to
filter those through and group them
together we talked about that earlier
with looking at a group of people who
are out shopping we want to group them
together to find out what they have in
common and of course once you understand
what people have in common maybe you
have one of them who's a customer at
your store or you have five of them are
customer at your store and they have a
lot in common with five others who are
not customers at your store how do you
Market to those five who aren't
customers at your store yet they fit the
demograph of who's going to shop there
and You' like them to shop at your store
not the one next door of course this is
a simplified version you can see very
easily the difference between a triangle
and a circle which is might not be so
easy in marketing reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is an important
type of machine learning where an agent
learns how to behave in an environment
by performing actions and seeing the
result and we have here where the in
this case a baby it's actually great
that they use an infant for this slide
because the reinforcement learning is
very much in its infant stages but it's
also probably the biggest machine
learning demand out there right now or
in the future it's going to be coming up
over the next few years is reinforcement
learning and how to make that work for
us and you can see here where we have
our action in the action in this one it
goes into the fire hopefully the baby
didn't it was just a little candle not a
giant fire pit like it looks like here
when the baby comes out and the News
state is the baby is sad and crying
because they got burned on the fire and
then maybe they take another action the
baby's called the agent because it's the
one taking the actions and in this case
they didn't go into the fire they went a
different direction and now the baby's
happy and laughing and playing
reinforcement learning is very easy to
understand because that's how as humans
that's one of the ways we learn we learn
whether it is you know you burn yourself
on the stove don't do that anymore don't
touch the stove in the big picture being
able to have a machine learning program
or an AI be able to do this is huge
because now it's start starting to learn
how to learn that's a big jump in the
world of computer and machine learning
and we're going to go back and just kind
of go back over supervised versus
unsupervised learning understanding this
is huge because this is going to come up
in any project you're working on we have
in supervised learning we have labeled
data we have direct feedback so
someone's already gone in there and said
yes that's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predicted outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new of data is coming in and
we know what it's going to be and then
with unsupervised trading it's not
labeled so we really don't know what it
is there's no feedback so we're not
telling it whether it's right or wrong
we're not telling it whether it's a
triangle or a square we're not telling
it to go left or right all we do is
we're finding hidden structure in the
data grouping the data together to find
out what connects to each other and then
you can use these together so imagine
you have an image and you're not sure
what you're looking for so you go in and
you have the unstructured data find all
these things that are connected together
and then somebody looks at those and
labels them now you can take that label
data and program something to predict
what's in the picture so you can see how
they go back and forth and you can start
connecting all these different tools
together to make a bigger picture there
are many interesting machine learning
algorithms let's have a look at a few of
them hopefully this give you a little
flavor of what's out there and these are
some of the most important ones that are
currently being used we'll take a look
at linear regression decision tree and
the support Vector machine let's start
with a closer look at linear regression
linear regression is perhaps one of the
most well-known and well understood
algorithms in statistics and machine
learning linear regression is a linear
model for example a model that assumes a
linear relationship between the input
variables X and the single output
variable Y and you'll see this if you
remember from your algebra classes y =
mx + C imagine we are predicting
distance traveled y from speed X our
linear regression model representation
for this problem would be yal M * x + C
or distance equal m * speed + C where m
is the coefficient and C is the Y
intercept and we're going to look at two
different variations of this first we're
going to start with time is constant and
you can see we have a Bist he's got a
safety gear on thank goodness speed
equals 10 m/s and so over certain amount
of time his distance equals 36 km we
have a second bicyclist who's going
twice the speed or 20
m/s and you can guess if he's going
twice the speed and time is a constant
then he's going to go twice the distance
and that's easily to compute 36 * 2 you
get 72 km and so if you had the question
of how fast with somebody is going three
times at speed or 30 m/ second is you
can easily compute the distance in our
head we can do that without needing a
computer but we want to do this for more
complicated data so it's kind of nice to
compare the two but let's just take a
look at that and what that looks like in
a graph so in a linear regression model
we have our distance to the speed and we
have our m equals the ve slope of the
line and we'll notice that the line has
a plus slope and as speed increases
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive relationship
and so your speed of the person which
equals y = mx plus C distance traveled
in a fixed interval of time time and we
could very easily compute either
following the line or just knowing it's
3 times 10 m/s that this is roughly 102
km distance that this third bicep has
traveled one of the key definitions on
here is positive relationship so the
slope of the line is positive as
distance increase so does speed increase
let's take a look at our second example
where we put distance is a constant so
we have speed equals 10 m/ second they
have a certain distance to go and it
takes them a 100 seconds to travel that
distance and we have our second
bicyclist who's still doing 20 m/ second
since he's going twice the speed we can
guess that he'll cover the distance in
about half the time 50 seconds and of
course you could probably guess on the
third one 100 divided by 30 since he's
going three times the speed you can
easily guess that this is 33.33 3
seconds time when we put that into a
linear regression model or a graph if
the distance is assumed to be constant
let's see the relationship between speed
and time and as time goes up the amount
of speed to go that same distance goes
down so now your m equals a minus ve
slope of the line as the speed increases
time decreases hence the variable has a
negative relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship dependent on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this um and even a
significant amount of data let's uh see
with the mathematical implementation of
linear regression and we'll take this
data so suppose we have this data set
where we have xyx = 1 2 3 4 5 standard
series and the Y value is 3 2 2 43 when
we take that and we go ahead and plot
these points on a graph you can see
there's kind of a nice scattering and
you could probably eyeball a line
through the middle of it but we're going
to calculate that exact line for linear
regression and the first thing we do is
we come up here and we have the mean of
XI and remember mean is basically the
average so we added five plus 4 + 3 + 2
+ 1 and divide by 5 that simply comes
out as three and then we'll do the same
for y we'll go ahead and add up all
those numbers and divide by five and we
end up with the mean value of y of I
equals 2.8 where the XI references it's
an average or means value and the Yi
also equals a means value of y and when
we plot that you'll see that we can put
in the Y = 2.8 and the xal 3 in there on
our graph we kind of gave it a little
different color so you could sort of it
out with the dash lines on it and it's
important to note that when we do the
linear regression the linear regression
model should go through that dot now
let's find our regression equation to
find the best fit line remember we go
ahead and take our yal MX plus C so
we're looking for M and C so to find
this equation for our data we need to
find our slope of M and our coefficient
of c and we have y = mx + C where m
equal the sum of x - XX average time y -
y aage or y means and X means over the
sum of x - x means squared that's how we
get the slope of the value of the line
and we can easily do that by creating
some columns here we have XY computers
are really good about iterating through
data and so we can easily compute this
and fill in a graph of data and in our
graph you can easily see that if we have
our x value of one and if you remember
the XI or the means value was three 1 -
3 = a -2 and 2 - 3 = a -1 so on and so
forth and we can easily fill in the
column of x - x i y - Yi and then from
those we can compute x - x i^ 2 and x -
x i * y - Yi and you can guess it that
the next step is to go ahead and sum the
different columns for the answers we
need so we get a total of 10 for our x -
x i^ 2 and a total of 2 for x - x i * y
- Yi and we plug those in we get 2/10
which equals. 2 so now we know the slope
of our line equals 0 2 so we can
calculate the value of c that'd be the
next step is we need to know where
crosses the y axis and if you remember I
mentioned earlier that the linear
regression line has to pass through the
means value the one that we showed
earlier we can just flip back up there
to that graph and you can see right here
there's our means value which is 3 X = 3
and Y = 2.8 and since we know that value
we can simply plug that into our formula
y = .2x + C so we plug that in we get
2.8 = 2 * 3 + C and you can just solve
for C so now we know that our
coefficient equals 2.2 and once we have
all that we can go ahead and plot our
regression line Y = 2 * x + 2.2 and then
from this equation we can compute
new values so let's predict the values
of Y using x = 1 2 3 4 5 and plot the
points remember the 1 2 345 was our
original X values so now we're going to
see what y thinks they are not what they
actually are and we plug those in we get
y of designated with Y of P you can see
that x = 1 = 2.4 x = 2 = 2.6 and so on
and so on so we have our y predicted
values of what we think it's going to be
when we plug those numbers in and when
we plot the predicted values along with
the actual values we can see the
difference and this is one of the things
is very important with linear regression
in any of these models is to understand
the error and so we can calculate the
error on all of our different values and
you can see over here we plotted um X
and Y and Y predict and we drawn a
little line so you can sort of see what
the error looks like there between the
different points so our goal is to
reduce this error we want to minimize
that error value on our linear
regression model minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
Etc we keep moving this line through the
data points to make sure the best fit
line has the least Square distance
between the data points and the
regression line so to recap with a very
simple linear regression model we first
figure out the formula of our line
through the middle and then we slowly
adjust the line to minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math is very much the same it gets much
more complex as we add in different
dimensions so this is only two
Dimensions y = mx plus C but you can
take that out to X Z ijq all the
different features in there and they can
plot a linear regression model on all of
those using the different formulas to
minimize the error let's go ahead and
take a look at decision trees a very
different way to solve problems in the
linear regression model decision tree is
a tree-shaped algorithm used to
determine a course of action each branch
of a tree represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction we have data
which tells us if it is a good day to
play golf and if we were to open this
data up in a general spreadsheet you can
see we have the Outlook whether it's a
rainy overcast Sunny temperature hot
mild cool humidity windy and did I like
to play golf that day yes or no so we're
taking a census and certainly I wouldn't
want a computer telling me when I should
go play golf or not but you could
imagine if you got up in the night
before you're trying to plan your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you in the
morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that this
becomes very beneficial and we see this
in a lot of applications coming out now
where it gives you suggestions and lets
you know what what would uh fit the
match for you for the next day or the
next purchase or the next uh whatever
you know next mail out in this case is
tomorrow a good day for playing golf
based on the weather coming in
and so we come up and let's uh determine
if you should play golf when the day is
sunny and windy so we found out the
forecast tomorrow is going to be sunny
and windy and suppose we draw our tree
like this we're going to have our
humidity and then we have our normal
which is if it's if you have a normal
humidity you're going to go play golf
and if the humidity is really high then
we look at the Outlook and if the
Outlook is sunny overcast or rainy it's
going to change what you choose to do so
if you know that it's a very high
humidity and it's sunny you're probably
not going to play golf cuz you're going
to be out there miserable fighting off
the mosquitoes that are out joining you
to play golf with you maybe if it's
rainy you probably don't want to play in
the rain but if it's slightly overcast
and you get just the right Shadow that's
a good day to play golf and be outside
out on the green now in this example you
can probably make your own tree pretty
easily CU it's a very simple set of data
going in but the question is how do you
know what to split where do you split
your data what if this is much more
complicated data where is not something
that you would particularly understand
like studying cancer they take about 36
measurements of the cancerous cells and
then each one of those measurements
represents how bulbous it is how
extended it is how sharp the edges are
something that as a human we would have
no understanding of so how do we decide
how to split that data up and is that
the right decision tree but so that's a
question that's going to come up is this
the right decision tree for that we
should calculate entropy and information
gain two important vocabulary words
there are the entropy and the
Information Gain entropy entropy is a
measure of Randomness or impurity in the
data set entropy should be low so we
want the chaos to be as low as possible
we don't want to look at it and be
confused by the images or what's going
on there with mixed data and the
Information Gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split also known as entropy reduction
Information Gain should be high so we
want our information that we get out of
the split to be as high as possible
let's take a look at entropy from the
mathematical side in this case we're
going to denote entropy as I of P of and
N where p is the probability that you're
going to play a game of golf and N is
the probability where you're not going
to play the game of golf now you don't
really have to memorize these formulas
there's a few of them out there
depending on what you're working with
but it's important to note that this is
where this formula is coming from so
when you see it you're not lost when
you're running your programming unless
you're building your own decision tree
code in the back and we simply have a
log 2 of P Over p+ N minus n / p+ n *
the log s of n of p+ n but let's break
that down and see what actually looks
like when we're Computing that from the
computer script side entropy of a target
class of the data set is the whole
entropy so we have entropy play golf and
when we look at this if we go back to
the data you can simp L count how many
yeses and no in our complete data set
for playing golf days in our complete
set we find we have 5 days we did play
golf and nine days we did not play golf
and so our I equals if you add those
together 9 + 5 is 14 and so our I equals
5 over 14 and 9 over 14 that's our P
andn values that we plug into that
formula and you can go 5 over 14 = 36 9
over 14 = 64 and when you do the whole
equation you get the minus. 36 logun SAR
of 36 -64 log s Ro TK of 64 and we get a
set value we get
.94 so we now have a full entropy value
for the whole set of data that we're
working with and we want to make that
entropy go down and just like we
calculated the entropy out for the whole
set we can also calculate entropy for
playing golf in the Outlook is it going
to be overcast or rainy or sunny and so
we look at the entropy we have P of
Sunny * e of 3 of 2 and that just comes
out how many sunny days yes and how many
sunny days no over the total which is
five don't forget to put the we'll
divide that five out later on equals P
overcast equal 4 comma 0 plus rainy = 2
comma 3 and then when you do the whole
setup we have 5 over 14 remember I said
there was a total of five 5 over 14 *
the I of 3 of 2 plus 4 over 4 14 * the 4
comma 0 and 514 over I of 23 and so we
can now compute the entropy of just the
part it has to do with the forecast and
we get 693 similarly we can calculate
the entropy of other predictors like
temperature humidity and wind and so we
look at the gain Outlook how much are we
going to gain from this entropy play
golf minus entropy play golf Outlook and
we can take the original .94 for the
whole set minus the entropy of just the
um rainy day in temperature and we end
up with a gain of. 247 so this is our
Information Gain remember we Define
entropy and we Define Information Gain
the higher the information gain the
lower the entropy the better the
information gain of the other three
attributes can be calculated in the same
way so we have our gain for temperature
equals
0.029 we have our gain for humidity
equals 0.152 and our gain for a windy
day equals 048 and if you do a quick
comparison you'll see the. 247 is the
greatest gain of information so that's
the split we want now let's build the
decision tree so we have the Outlook is
it going to be sunny overcast or rainy
that's our first split because that
gives us the most Information Gain and
we can continue to go down the tree
using the different information gains
with the largest information we can
continue down the nodes of the tree
where we choose the attribute with the
largest Information Gain as the root
node and then continue to split each sub
node with the largest Information Gain
that we can compute and although it's a
little bit of a tongue twister to say
all that you can see it's a very easy to
view visual model we have our Outlook we
split it three different directions if
the Outlook is overcast we're going to
play and then we can split those further
down if we want so if the over Outlook
is sunny but then it's also windy if
it's uh windy we're not going to play if
it's uh not windy we'll play so we can
easily build a nice decision Tre to
guess what we would like to do tomorrow
and give us a nice recommendation for
the day so we want to know if it's a
good day to play golf when it's sunny
and windy remember the original question
that came out tomorrow's weather report
is sunny and windy you can see by going
down the tree we go Outlook Sunny
Outlook windy we're not going to play
golf tomorrow so our little Smartwatch
pops up and says I'm sorry tomorrow is
not a good day for golf it's going to be
sunny and windy and if you're a huge
golf fan you might go uhoh it's not a
good day to play golf we can go in and
watch a golf game at home so we'll sit
in front of the TV instead of being out
playing golf in the wind now that we
looked at our decision tree let's look
at the third one of our algorithms we're
investigating support Vector machine
support Vector machine is a widely used
classification algorithm the idea
support Vector machine is simple the
algorithm creates a separation line
which divides the classes in the best
possible manner for example dog or cat
disease or no disease suppose we have a
labeled sample data which tells height
and weight of of males and females a new
data point arrives and we want to know
whether it's going to be a male or a
female so we start by drawing a line we
draw decision lines but if we consider
decision line one then we will classify
the individual as a male and if we
consider decision line two then it will
be a female so you can see this person
kind of lies in the middle of the two
groups so it's a little confusing trying
to figure out which line they should be
under we need to know which line divides
the classes correctly but how the goal
is to choose a hyper plane and that is
one of the key words they use when we
talk about support Vector machines
choose a hyper plane with the greatest
possible margin between the decision
line and the nearest Point within the
training set so you can see here we have
our support Vector we have the two
nearest points to it and we draw a line
between those two points and the
distance margin is the distance between
the hyperplane and the nearest data
point from either set so we actually
have a value and it should be equally
distant between the two um points that
we're comparing it to when we draw the
hyperplanes we observe that line one has
the maximum distance so we observe that
line one has a maximum distance margin
so we'll classify the new data point
correctly and our result on this one is
going to be that the new data point is
Mel one of the reasons we call it a
hyper plane versus a line is that a lot
of times we're not looking at just
weight and height we might be looking at
36 different features or dimensions and
so so when we cut it with a hyper plane
it's more of a three-dimensional cut in
the data or multi-dimensional it cuts
the data a certain way and each plane
continues to cut it down until we get
the best fit or match let's understand
this with the help of an example problem
statement I always start with a problem
statement when you're going to put some
code together we're going to do some
coding now classifying muffin and
cupcake recipes using support Vector
machines so the cupcake versus the
muffin let's have a look at our data set
and we have the different recipes here
here we have a muffin recipe that has so
much flour I'm not sure what measurement
55 is in but it has 55 maybe it's
ounces but has a certain amount of flour
certain amount of milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt and So
based on these measurements we want to
guess whether we're making a muffin or a
cupcake and you can see in this one we
don't have just two features we don't
just have height and weight as we did
before between the male and female in
here we have a number of features
in fact in this we're looking at eight
different features to guess whether it's
a muffin or a cupcake what's the
difference between a muffin and a
cupcake turns out muffins have more
flour while cupcakes have more butter
and sugar so basically the cupcakes a
little bit more of a dessert where the
muffins a little bit more of a fancy
bread but how do we do that in Python
how do we code that to go through
recipes and figure out what the recipe
is and I really just want to say
cupcakes versus muffins like some big
professional wrestling thing before we
start in our cupcakes versus muffins we
are going to be working in Python
there's many versions of python many
different editors that is one of the
strengths and weaknesses of python is it
just has so much stuff attached to it
it's one of the more popular data
science programming packages you can use
in this case we're going to go ahead and
use anaconda and Jupiter notebook the
Anaconda Navigator has all kinds of fun
tools once you're into the anacon
Navigator you can change environments I
actually have a number of environments
on here we'll be using python 36
environment so this is in Python version
36 although it doesn't matter too much
which version you use I usually try to
stay with the 3x because they're current
unless you have a project that's very
specifically in version 2x 27 I think is
usually what most people use in the
version two and then once we're in our
um Jupiter notebook editor I can go up
and create a new file and we'll just
jump in here in this case we're doing
spvm muffin versus Cupcake and then
let's start with our packages for data
analysis and we almost always use a
couple there's a few very standard
packages we use we use import oops
import
numpy that's for number python they
usually denoted as NP that's very comma
that's very common and then we're going
to import pandas as
PD and numpy deals with number arrays
there's a lot of cool things you can do
with the numpy uh setup as far as
multiplying all the values in an array
in a numpy array data array pandas I
can't remember if we're using it
actually in this data set I think we do
as an import it makes a nice data frame
and the difference between a data frame
and a nump array is that a data frame is
more like your Excel spreadsheet you
have columns you have indexes you have
different ways of referencing it easily
viewing it and there's additional
features you can run on a data frame and
pandas kind of sits on numpy so they you
need them both in there and then finally
we're working with the support Vector
machine so from sklearn we're going to
use the sklearn model import svm support
Vector
machine and then as a data scientist you
should all always try to visualize your
data some data obviously is too
complicated or doesn't make any sense to
the human but if it's possible it's good
to take a second look at it so you can
actually see what you're doing now for
that we're going to use two packages
we're going to import map plot library.
pyplot as
PLT again very common and we're going to
import caborn as SNS and we'll go ahead
and set the font scale in the SNS right
in our import line that's what this um
semicolon followed by by a line of data
we're going to set the SNS and these are
great cuz the the Seaborn sits on top of
matap plot Library just like pandas hits
on numpy so it adds a lot more features
and uses and control we're obviously not
going to get into matplot library and
Seaborn it' be its own tutorial we're
really just focusing on the svm the
support Vector machine from sklearn and
since we're in Jupiter notebook uh we
have to add a special line in here for
our met library and that's your
percentage sign or Amber sign matap plot
library in line now if you're doing this
in just a straight code Project A lot of
times I use like notepad++ and I'll run
it from there you don't have to have
that line in there because it'll just
pop up as its own window on your
computer depending on how your computer
set up because we're running this in the
Jupiter notebook as a browser setup this
tells it to display all of our Graphics
right below on the page so that's what
that line is for remember the first time
I ran this I didn't know that and I had
to go look that up years ago it's quite
a headache so map plot Library inline is
just because we're running this on the
web setup and we can go ahead and run
this make sure all our modules are in
they're all imported which is great if
you don't have them import you'll need
to go ahead and pip use the PIP or
however you do it there's a lot of other
install packages out there although pip
is the most common and you have to make
sure these are all installed on your
python setup the next step of course is
we got to look at the data can't run a
model for predicting data if you don't
have actual data so to do that let me go
and open this up and take a look and we
have our uh cupcakes versus muffins and
it's a CSV file or CSV meaning that it's
comma separated
variable and it's going to open it up in
a nice uh spreadsheet for me and you can
see up here we have the type we have
muffin muffin muffin cupcake cupcake
cupcake and then it's broken up into
flour milk sugar butter egg baking
powder vanilla and salt so we can do is
we can go ahead and look at this data
also in our
python let us create a variable recipes
equals we're going to use our pandas
module do read CSV remember is a comma
separated
variable and the file name happened to
be cupcakes versus muffins oops I got
double brackets
there
do it this
way there we go cupcakes versus
muffins because the program I loaded or
the the place I saved this particular
Python program is in the same folder we
can get by with just the file name but
remember if you're storing it in a
different location you have to also put
down the full path on
there and then because we're in pandas
we're going to go ahead and you can
actually in line you can do this but let
me do the full print you can just type
in recipes. head in the Jupiter notebook
but if you're running in code in a
different script You' need to go ahead
and type out the whole print recipes.
head and Panda knows is that's going to
do the first five lines of data and if
we flip back on over to the spreadsheet
where we opened up our CSV
file uh you can see where it starts on
line two this one calls it zero and then
2 3 4 5 six is going to match go and
close that out cuz we don't need that
anymore and it always starts at zero and
these are it automatically indexes it
since we didn't tell it to use an index
in here so that's the index number for
the leftand side and it automatically
took the top row as uh labels so Panda's
using it to read a CSV is just really
slick and fast one of the reasons we
love our pandas not just because they're
cute and cuddly teddy
bears and let's let's go ahead and plot
our data and I'm not going to plot all
of it I'm just going to plot the uh
sugar and
flour now obviously you can see where
they get really complicated if we have
tons of different features and so you'll
break them up and maybe look at just two
of them at a time to see how they
connect and to plot them we're going to
go ahead and use
caborn so that's our SNS and the command
for that is SNS dolm plot
and then the two different variables I'm
going to plot is flour and
sugar data equals recipes the Hue equals
type and this is a lot of fun because it
knows that this is pandas coming in so
this is one of the powerful things about
pandas mixed with Seaborn and
doing
graphing and then we're going to use a
pallet set one there's a lot of
different sets in there you can go look
them up for Seaborn we do a regular a
fit regular equals false so we're not
really trying to fit anything and it's a
scatter
kws a lot of these settings you can look
up in Seaborn half of these you could
probably leave off when you run them
somebody played with this and found out
that these were the best settings for
doing a Seaborn plot let's go ahead and
run that and because it does it in line
it just puts it right on the
page and you can see right here that
just based on sugar and flour alone
there's a definite split
and we use these models because you can
actually look at it and say hey if I
drew a line right between the middle of
the blue dots and the red dots we'd be
able to do an svm and and a hyperplane
right there in the
middle then the next step is to format
or
pre process our
data and we're going to break that up
into two
parts we need to type label and remember
we're going to decide whether it's a
muffin or a cupcake well a computer
doesn't know muffin or cupcake it know
zero and one so what we're going to do
is we're going to create a type label
and from this we'll create a nump array
and P where and this is where we can do
some logic we take our recipes from our
Panda and wherever type equals muffin
it's going to be zero and then if it
doesn't equal muffin which is cupcakes
is going to be one so we create our type
label this is the answer so when we're
doing our training model remember we
have to have a a training data this is
what we're going to train it with is
that it's zero or one it's a muffin or
it's
not and then we're going to create our
recipe
features and if you remember correctly
from right up here the First Column is
type so we really don't need the type
column that's our muffin or cupcake and
in pandas we can easily sort that
out we take our value
recipes do columns that's a pandas
function built into
pandas got values converting them to
values so it's just the column titles
going across the top and we don't want
the first one so what we do is since it
always starts at zero we want
one colon till the
end and then we want to go ahead and
make this a list and this converts it to
a list of
strings and then we can go ahead and
just take a look and see what we're
looking at for the features make sure it
looks right let me go ahead and run
that and I forgot the S on recipes so
we'll go ahead and add the s in there
and then run that and we can see we have
flour milk sugar butter egg baking
powder vanilla and salt and that matches
what we have up here where we printed
out everything but the type so we have
our features and we have our
label Now the recipe features is just
the titles of the columns and we
actually need the
ingredients and at this point we have a
couple options one we could run it over
all the
ingredients and when you're dealing this
usually you do but for our example we
want to limit it so you can easily see
what's going on because if we did all
the ingredients we have you know that's
what um seven eight different
hyperplanes that would be built into it
we only want to look at one so you can
see what the svm is
doing and so we'll take our recipes and
we'll do just flour and sugar again you
can replace that with your recipe
features and do all of them but we're
going to do just flour and sugar and
we're going to convert that to values we
don't need to make a list out of it
because it's not string values these are
actual values on there and we can go
ahead and just
print ingredients and you can see what
that looks
like uh and so we have just the know of
flower and sugar just the two sets of
plots and just for fun let's go ahead
and take this over here and take our
recipe
features and so if we decided to use all
the recipe features you'll see that it
makes a nice column of different data so
it just strips out all the labels and
everything we just have just the value
but because we want to be able to view
this easily in a plot later on we'll go
ahead and take that and just do flour
and
sugar and we'll run that and you'll see
it's just the two
columns so the next step is to go ahead
and fit our
model we'll go and just call it model
and it's a svm we're using a package
called
SVC in this case we're going to go ahead
and set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific setup on there and if
we go to the reference on their website
for the
svm you'll see that there's about
there's eight of them here three of them
are for
regression three are for classification
the SVC support Vector classification is
probably one of the most commonly used
and then there's also one for detecting
outliers and another one that has to do
with something a bit more specific on
the model but SBC and SV are the two
most commonly used standing for support
vector classifier and support Vector
regression remember regression is an
actual value a float value or whatever
you're trying to work on and SBC is a
classifier so it's a yes no true
false but for this we want to know 01
muffin cupcake we go ahead and create
our model and once we have our model
created we're going to do model.fit and
this is very common especially in the
sklearn all their models are followed
with with the fit
command and what we put into the fit
what we're training with it is we're
putting in the ingredients which in this
case we limited to just flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake now in more complicated data
science series you'd want to split into
we won't get into that today we split it
into a training data and test data and
they even do something where they split
it into thirds where a third is used for
where you switch between which one's
training and test there's all kinds of
things go into that and gets very
complicated when you get to the higher
end not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
because this is a very simple set of
data and let's go ahead and run this and
now we have our model fit and I got an
error here so let me fix that real quick
it's Capital SBC it turns
out I did it
lowercase support
Vector classifier there we go let's go
ahead and run that
and you'll see it comes up with all this
information that it prints out
automatically these are the defaults of
the model you notice that we changed the
kernel to linear and there's our kernel
linear on the printout and there's other
different settings you can mess
with we're going to just leave that
alone for right now for this we don't
really need to mess with any of
those so next we're going to dig a
little bit into our newly trained model
and we're going to do this so we can
show you on a
graph and let's go ahead and get the
separating and we're going to say we're
going to use a W for our variable on
here we're going to do model.
coefficient uncore 0 so what the heck is
that again we're digging into the model
so we've already got a prediction and a
train this is a math behind it that
we're looking at right now and so
the W is going to represent two
different coefficients and if you
remember we had y = mx + C so these
coefficients are connected to that but
in two-dimensional it's a
plane we don't want to spend too much
time on this because you can get lost in
the confusion of the math so if you're a
math Wiz this is great you can go
through here and you'll see that we have
a equal minus W of 0 over W of 1
remember there's two different values
there there and that's basically the
slope that we're
generating and then we're going to build
an XX what is XX we're going to set it
up to a numpy array there's our np.
linespace so we're creating a
line of values between 30 and 60 so it
just creates a set of numbers for
x and then if you remember correctly we
have our formula y equal the slope x x
plus The Intercept well to make this
work we can do this as y y equals the
slope times each value in that array
that's the neat thing about numpy so
when I do a * XX which is a whole numpy
array of values it multiplies a across
all of them and then it takes those same
values and we subtract the model
intercept that's your uh remember we had
MX plus C so that'd be the C from the
formula yal X plus
C and that's where all these numbers
come from a little bit confusing because
it's digging out of these different
arrays and we want to do is we're going
to take this and we're going to go ahead
and plot it so plot the parallels to
separating hyperplane that pass through
the support vectors and so we're going
to create b equals a model support
vectors pull in our support vectors out
there here's our YY which we now know is
a set of data and we have uh we're going
to create YY down = a * XX + B1 - A * B
0 and then model support Vector B is
going to be set that to a new value the
minus one setup and y y up equals a * XX
+ B1 minus a * B 0 and we can go ahead
and just run this to load these
variables up if you want to know
understand a little bit more of what's
going on you can see if we
print y y let me just run that you can
see it's an array it's this is a line
it's going to have in this case between
30 and 60 so it's going to be 30
variables in here and the same thing
with y y up y y down and we'll we'll
plot those in just a minute on a graph
so you can see what those look
like just go ahead and delete that out
of here and run that so it loads up the
variables nice clean slate I'm just
going to copy this from before remember
this our SNS our Seaborn plot LM plot
flow
sugar and I'll just go and run that real
quick so you can see what remember what
that looks like it's just a straight
graph on there and then one of the neat
things is because caborn sits on top of
pip plot we can do the PIP plot for the
line going through and that is simply
PLT do
plot and that's our xx and y y are two
corresponding values x y and then
somebody played with this to figure out
that the line width equals two and the
color black would look nice so let's go
ahead and run this whole thing with the
PIP plot on there and you can see when
we do this it's just doing flour and
sugar on
here corresponding line between the
sugar and the flour and the muffin
versus
Cupcake um and then we generated the um
support vectors the YY down and y y up
so let's take a look and see what that
looks
like so we'll do our PL
plot and again this is all against XX
the our x value but this time we have y
y
down and let's do something a little fun
with this we can put in a k dash dash
that just tells it to make it a dotted
line and if we're going to do the down
one we also want to do the up one so
here's our
YY up and when we run that it adds both
sets
aligned and so here's our support and
this is what you expect you expect these
two lines to go through the nearest data
point so the dash lines go through the
nearest muffin and the nearest cupcake
when it's plotting it and then your svm
goes right down the middle so it gives
it a nice split in our data and you can
see how easy it is to see based just on
sugar and flour which one's a muffin or
a
cupcake let's go ahead and create
function to
predict muffin or
cupcake I've got my um recipes I pulled
off the um internet and I want to see
the difference between
a muffin or a cupcake and so we need a
function to push that through and create
a function with
de and let's call it muffin or cupcake
and remember we're just doing flour and
sugar today not doing all the
ingredients and that actually is a
pretty good split you really don't need
all the ingredients to know it's flour
and
sugar and let's go ahead and do an IFL
statement so if model
predict is of flour and sugar equals
zero so we take our model and we do run
a predict it's very common in sklearn
where you have a DOT predict you put the
data in and it's going to return a value
in this case if it equals zero then
print you're looking at a muffin recipe
l else if it's not zero that means it's
one then you're looking at a cupcake
recipe that's pretty straightforward
for function or def for definition DF is
how you do that in Python and of course
you're going to create a function you
should run something in it and so let's
run a cupcake and we're going to send it
values 50 and 20 a muffin or a cupcake I
don't know what it is and let's run this
and just see what it gives us and it
says oh it's a muffin you're looking at
a muffin recipe so it very easily
predicts whether we're looking at a
muffin or a cupcake recipe let's plot
this there we go plot this on the graph
so we can see what that actually looks
like and I'm just going to copy and
paste it from below we we plotting all
the points in
there so this is nothing different than
we did before if I run it you'll see it
has all the points and the lines on
there and what we want to do is we want
to add another point and we'll do PLT
plot and if you remember correctly we
did for our test we did 50 and
20 and then somebody went in here and
decided we'll do yo for yellow or it's
kind of a orangish yellow color is going
to come out marker size nine those are
settings you can play with somebody else
played with them to come up with the
right setup so it looks good and you can
see there it is graph um clearly a
muffin in this case in cupcakes versus
muffins the muffin has won and if you'd
like to do your own muffin cupcake
Contender series you certainly can send
a note down below and the team at simply
learn will send you over the data they
use for the muffin and cupcake and
that's true of any of the data um we
didn't actually run a plot on it earlier
we had men versus women you can also
request that information to run it on
your data setup so you can test that
out so to go back over our setup we went
ahead for our support Vector machine
code we did a predict 40 Parts flower 20
part sugar I think it was different than
the one we did whether it's a muffin or
a cupcake hence we have built a
classifier using SPM which is able to
classify if a recipe is of a cupcake or
a muffin which wraps up our cupcake
versus muffin today in our second
tutorial we're going to cover K means
and linear regression along with going
over the quiz questions we had during
our first tutorial what's in it for you
we're going to cover clustering what is
cluster clustering K means clustering
which is one of the most common used
clustering tools out there including a
flowchart to understand K means
clustering and how it functions and then
we'll do an actual python live demo on
clustering of cars based on Brands then
we're going to cover logistic regression
what is logistic regression logistic
regression curve and sigmoid function
and then we'll do another python code
demo to classify a tumor as malignant or
benign based on features and let's start
with clustering
suppose we have a pile of books of
different genres now we divide them into
different groups like fiction horror
education and as we can see from this
young lady she definitely is into heavy
you can just tell by those eyes in
the maple Canadian leaf on her shirt but
we have fiction horror and education and
we want to go ahead and divide our books
up well organizing objects into groups
based on similarity is clustering and in
this case as we're looking at the books
we're talking about clustering things
with no one categories but you can also
use it to explore data so you might not
know the categories you just know that
you need to divide it up in some way to
conquer the data and to organize it
better but in this case uh we're going
to be looking at clustering in specific
categories and let's just take a deeper
look at that we're going to use K means
clustering K means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool in the machine learning
library K means clustering is an example
of unsupervised learning if you remember
from our previous thing it is used when
you have unlabeled data so we don't know
the answer yet we have a bunch of data
that we want to Cluster into different
groups toine clusters in the data based
on feature similarity so we've
introduced a couple terms here we've
already talked about unsupervised
learning and unlabeled data so we don't
know the answer yet we're just going to
group stuff together and see if we can
find an answer of how things connect
we've also introduced feature similarity
features being different features of the
data now with books we can easily see
fiction and horror and history books but
a lot of times with data some of that
information isn't so easy to see right
when we first look at it and so K means
is one of those tools where we can start
finding things that connect that match
with each other suppose we have these
data points and want to assign them into
a cluster now when I look at these data
points I would probably group them into
two clusters just by looking at them I'd
say two of these group of data kind of
come together but in K means we pick K
clusters and assign random centroids to
clusters where the K clusters represents
two different clusters we pick K
clusters insy random centroids to the
Clusters then we compute distance from
objects to the centroids now we form new
clusters based on minimum distances and
calculate the centroids so we figure out
what the best distance is for the
centroid then we move the centroid and
recalculate those distances repeat
previous two steps iteratively till the
cluster centroid stop changing their
positions and become Static repeat
previous two steps iteratively till the
cluster centroid stop changing and the
positions become Static once the
Clusters become Static then K means
clustering algorithm is said to be
converged and there's another term we
see throughout machine learning is
converged that means whatever math we're
using to figure out the answer has come
to a solution or it's converged on an
answer shall we see the flowchart to
understand make a little bit more sense
by putting it into a nice easy step by
step so we start we choose K we'll look
at the elbow method in just a moment we
assign random centroids to clusters and
sometimes you pick the centroids because
you might look at the data in a in a
graph and say ah these are probably the
central points then we compute the
distance from the objects to the
centroids we take that and we form new
clusters based on minimum distance and
calculate their centroids then we
compute the distance from objects to the
new centroids and then we go back and
repeat those last two steps we calculate
the distances so as we're doing it it
brings into the new centroid and then we
move the centroid around and we figure
out what the best which objects are
closest to each centroid so the objects
can switch from one centroid to the
other as the centroids are moved around
and we continue that until it is
converged let's see an example of this
suppose we have this data set of seven
individuals and their score on two
topics A and B so here's our subject in
this case referring to the person taking
the uh test and then we have subject a
where we see what they've scored on
their first subject and we have subject
B and we can see what they score on the
second subject now let's take two
farthest apart points as initial cluster
centroids now remember we talked about
selecting them randomly or we can also
just put them in different points and
pick the furthest one apart so they move
together either one works okay depending
on what kind of data you're working on
and what you know about it so we took
the two furthest points one and one and
five and seven and now let's take the
two farthest apart points as initial
cluster centroids each point is then
assigned to the closest cluster with
respect to the distance from the
centroids so we take each one of these
points in there we measure that distance
and you can see that if we measured each
of those distances and you use the the
Pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know the X and the
Y and you can figure out the diagonal
line from that or you just take a ruler
and put it on your monitor that'd be
kind of silly but it would work if
you're just just eyeballing it you can
see how they naturally come together in
certain areas now we again calculate the
centroids of each cluster so cluster one
and then cluster two and we look at each
individual dot there's one two three
we're in one cluster uh the centroid
then moves over it becomes 1.8 comma 2.3
so remember was that one and one well
the very center of the data we're
looking at would put it at the one point
roughly 22 but 1.8 and 2.3 and the
second one if we want wanted to make the
overall mean Vector the average Vector
of all the different distances to that
centroid we come up with 4 comma 1 and
54 so we've now moved the centroids We
compare each individual's distance to
its own cluster mean and to that of the
opposite cluster and we find can build a
nice chart on here that the as we move
that Cent around we now have a new
different kind of clustering of groups
and using ukian distance between the
points and the mean we get the same
formula you see new formulas coming up
so we have individual dots distance to
the mean centr of the cluster and
distance to the mean centr of the
cluster only individual three is nearer
to the mean of the opposite cluster
cluster two than its own cluster one and
you can see here in the diagram where
we've kind of circled that one in the
middle so when we've moved the clust the
centroids of the Clusters over one of
the points shifted to the other cluster
because it's closer to that group of
individuals thus individual 3 is
relocated to Cluster 2 resulting in a
new Partition and we generate all those
numbers of how close they are to the
different clusters for the new clusters
we will find the actual cluster
centroids so now we move the centroids
over and you can see that we've now
formed two very distinct clusters on
here on comparing the distance of each
individual's distance to its own cluster
mean and to that of the opposite cluster
we find that the data points are stable
hence we have our final clusters now if
you remember I brought up a concept
earlier k mean on the K means algorithm
choosing the right value of K will help
in less number of iterations and to find
the appropriate number of clusters in a
data set we use the elbow method and
within sum of squares WSS is defined as
the sum of the squared distance between
each member of the cluster and its
centroid and so you see what we've done
here is we have the number of clusters
and as you do the same K means algorithm
over the different clusters and you
calculate what that centroid looks like
and you find the optimal you can
actually find the optimal number of
clusters using the elbow of the graph is
called as the elbow method and on this
we guessed at two just by looking at the
data but as you can see the slope you
actually just look for right there where
the elbow is in the slope and you have a
clear answer that we want two different
to start with k means equals two a lot
of times people end up Computing K means
equals 2 3 4 five until they find the
value which fits on the elbow joint
sometimes you can just look at the data
and if you're really good with that
specific domain remember domain I
mentioned that last time you'll know
that that where to pick those numbers or
where to start guessing at what that K
value is so let's take this and we're
going to use a use case using K means
clustering to Cluster cars into Brands
using parameters such as horsepower
cubic inches make year Etc so we're
going to use the data set cars data
having information about three brands of
cars Toyota Honda and Nissan we'll go
back to my favorite tool the Anaconda
Navigator with the Jupiter notebook and
let's go ahead and flip over to our
Jupiter notebook and in our Jupiter
notebook I'm going to go ahead and just
paste the uh basic code that we usually
start a lot of these off with we're not
going to go too much into this code
because we've already discussed numpy
we've already discussed matplot library
and pandas that be being the number
array pandas being the pandas data frame
and matap plot for the graphing and
don't forget uh since if you're using
the Jupiter notebook you do need the M
plot library in line so that it plots
everything on the screen if you're using
a different python editor then you
probably don't need that cuz it'll have
a popup window on your computer and
we'll go ahead and run this just to load
our libraries and our setup into here
the next step is of course to look at
our data which I've already opened up in
a spreadsheet and you can see here we
have the miles per gallon cylinders
cubic inches horsepower weight pounds
how you how heavy it is time it takes to
get to 60 my card is probably on this
one at about 80 or 90 what year it is so
this is you can actually see this is
kind of older cars and then the brand
Toyota Honda Nissan so the different
cars are coming from all the way from
1971 if we scroll down to uh the 80s we
have between the 70s and 80s a number of
cars that they've put out and let's uh
when we come back here we're going to do
importing the data so we'll go ahead and
do data set equals and we'll use pandas
to read this in and it's uh from a CSV
file remember you can always post this
in the comments and request the data
files for these either in the comments
here on the YouTube video or go to
Simply learn.com and request that the
car CSV I put it in the same folder as
the code that I've stored so my python
code is stored in the same folder so I
don't have to put the full path if you
store them in different folders you do
have to change this and double check
your name variables and we'll go ahead
and run this and uh We've chosen data
set arbitrarily because you know it's a
data set we're importing and we've now
imported our car seal V into the data
set as you know you have to prep the
data so we're going to create the X data
this is the one that we're going to try
to figure out what's going on with and
then there is a number of ways to do
this but we'll do it in a simple Loop so
you can actually see what's going on so
we'll do for I
nx. columns so we're going to go through
each of the columns and a lot of times
it's important I I'll make lists of the
columns and do this because I might
remove certain columns or there might be
column that I want to be processed
differently but for this we can go ahead
and take X of I and we want to go fill
Na and that's a pandas command but the
question is what are we going to fill
the missing data with we definitely
don't want to just put in a number that
doesn't actually mean something and so
one of the tricks you can do with this
is we can take X of I and then addition
to that we want to go ahead and turn
this into an integer because a lot of
these are integers so we'll go ahe and
keep it integer
and let me add the bracket here and a
lot of editors will do this they'll
think that you're closing one bracket
make sure you get that second bracket in
there if it's a double bracket that's
always something that happens regularly
so once we have our integer of X of Y
this is going to fill in any missing
data with the average and I was so busy
closing one set of brackets I forgot
that the mean is also has brackets in
there for the pandas so we can see here
we're going to fill in all the data with
the average value for that column so if
there's missing data in the average of
the data it does have then once we've
done that we'll go ahead and loop
through it
again and just check and see to make
sure everything is filled in correctly
and we'll print and then we take X is
null and this returns a set of the null
value or the how many lines are null and
we'll just sum that up to see what that
looks like and so when I run this and so
with the X what we want to do is we want
to remove the last column because that
had the models that's what we're trying
to see if we can cluster these things
and figure out the models there is so
many different ways to sort the X out
for one we could take the X and we could
go data set our variable we're using and
use the iocation one of the features
that's in
pandas and we could take that and then
take all the rows and all but the last
column of the data set and at this time
we could do values we just convert it to
values so that's one way to do this and
if I let me just put this down here and
print X X it's a capital x we chose and
I run this you can see it's just the
values we could also take out the values
and it's not going to return anything
because there's no values connected to
it what I like to do with this is
instead of doing the iocation which does
integers more common is to come in here
and we have our data set and we're going
to do data set dot or data set. columns
and remember that lists all the columns
so if I come in here
let me just Mark that as red and I print
data set.
columns you can see that I have my index
here I have my MPG cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand would
be to do data Columns of Everything But
the last one minus one so now if I print
this you'll see the brand disappears and
so I can actually just take data set
columns minus
one and I'll put it right in here for
the columns we're going to look
at and let's unmark this and unmark
this and now if I do an x. head I now
have a new data frame and you can see
right here we have all the different
columns except for the brand at the end
of the year and it turns out when you
start playing with the data set you're
going to get an error later on and it'll
say cannot convert St ring to float
value and that's because for some reason
these things the way they recorded them
must have been recorded as strings so we
have a neat feature in here on pandas to
convert and it is simply convert
objects and for this we're going to do
convert oops convert
underscore numeric numeric equals true
and yes I did have to go look that up I
don't have it memorized the convert
numeric in there if I'm working with a
lot of these things I remember them but
um depending on where I'm at what I'm
doing I usually have to look it up and
we run that oops I must have missed
something in here let me double check my
spelling and when I double check my
spelling you'll see I missed the first
underscore in the convert objects and
when I run this it now has everything
converted into a numeric value because
that's what we're going to be working
with as numeric values down
here and the next part is that we need
to go through the data and eliminate
null values most people when they're
doing small amounts working with small
data pools discover afterwards that they
have a null value and they have to go
back and do this so you know be aware
whenever we're formatting this data
things are going to pop up and sometimes
you go backwards to fix it and that's
fine that's just part of exploring the
data and understanding what you
have and I should have done this earlier
but let me go ahead and increase the
size of my window one
notch
there we go easier to
see so we'll do 4 I in working with x.
columns we'll page through all the
columns and we want to take X of I and
we're going to change that we're going
to alter it and so with this we want to
go ahead and fill in X of I pandis Has
the fill in a and that just fills in any
non-existent missing data I we'll put my
brackets up and there's a lot of
different ways to fill this data if you
have a really large data set some people
just void out that data because if and
then look at it later in a separate
exploration of data one of the tricks we
can do is we can take our column and we
can find the
means and the means is in our quotation
marks so we take the columns we're going
to fill in the the non-existing one with
the means the problem is that returns a
decimal float so some of these aren't
decimals certainly we need to be a
little careful of doing this but for
this example we're just going to fill it
in with the integer version of this
keeps it on par with the other data that
isn't a decimal
point and then what we also want to do
is we want to double check A lot of
times you do this first part first to
double check then you do the fill and
then you do it again just to make sure
you did it right so we're going to go
through and test for missing data and
one of the re ways you can do that is
simply go in here and take our X of I
column so it's going to go through the X
ofi column it says is null so it's going
to return any any place there's a null
value it actually goes through all the
rows of each column is null and then we
want to go ahead and sum that so we take
that we add the sum value and these are
all pandas so is null is a panda command
and so is sum and if we go through that
and we go ahead and run
it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns have
zero null values so we've now tested and
double checked and our data is nice and
clean we have no null values everything
is now a number value we turned it into
numeric and we've removed the last
column in our data and at this point
we're actually going to start using the
elbow method to find the optimal number
of clusters so we're now actually
getting into the SK learn part uh the K
means clustering on here
I guess we'll go ahead and zoom it up
one more notot so you can see what I'm
typing in
here and then from sklearn going to or
sklearn cluster we're going to import K
means I always forget to capitalize the
K and the M when I do this so it's
capital K capital M K
means and we'll go and create a um Ray
wcss equals we'll make it an empty array
if you remember from the elbow method
from our
slide within the sums of squares WSS is
defined as the sum of square distance
between each member of the cluster and a
centroid so we're looking at that change
in differences as far as a squar
distance and we're going to run this
over a number of K mean
values in fact let's go for I in range
we'll do 11 of them
range 0 of
11 and the first thing we're going to do
is we're going to create the actual
we'll do it all lower
case and so we're going to create this
object from the K means that we just
imported and the variable that we want
to put into this is in clusters and
we're going to set that equals to I
that's the most important important one
because we're looking at how increasing
the number of clusters changes our
answer there are a lot of settings to
the K means our guys in the back did a
great job just kind of playing with some
of them the most common ones that you
see in a lot of stuff is how you init
your K means so we have K means plus
plus plus this is just a tool to let the
model itself be smart how it picks it
centroids to start with its initial
centroids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times we have a Max
iteration we put in there we have an the
infinit the random State equals zero you
really don't need to worry too much
about these when you're first learning
this as you start digging in deeper you
start finding that these are shortcuts
that will speed up the process as far as
a setup but the big one that we're
working with is the in clusters equals I
so we're going to literally train our K
means 11 times we're going to do this
process 11 times in if you're working
with h Big Data you know the first thing
you do is you run a small sample of the
data so you can test all your stuff on
it and you can already see the problem
that if I'm going to iterate through a
terabyte of data 11 times and then the K
means itself is iterating through the
data multiple times that's a heck of a
process so you got to be a little
careful with this a lot of times though
you can find your elbow using the elbow
method find your optimal number on a
sample of data especially if you're
working with larger data sources so we
want to go ahead and take our K means
and we're just going to fit it if you're
looking at any of the SK learn very
common you fit your model and if you
remember correctly our variable we're
using is the capital x and once we fit
this value we go back to the um array we
made and we want to go and just toin
that value on the
end and it's not the actual fitw pinning
in there it's when it generates it it
generates the value you're looking for
is inertia so K means. inertia we'll
pull that specific spe ific value out
that we
need and let's get a visual on this
we'll do our PLT plot and what we're
plotting
here is first the x axis which is range
01 so that will generate a nice little
plot there and the wcss for our Y
axis it's always nice to give our plot a
title and let's see we'll just give it
the elbow method for the title and let's
get some labels so let's go ahead and do
PLT X
label and what we'll do we'll do number
of clusters for that and PLT y
label and for that we can do oops there
we go wcss since that's what we're doing
on the plot on there and finally we want
to go ahead and display our graph which
is simply PLT do
oops. show there we go and because we
have it set to in line it'll appear in
line hope FL didn't make a type error on
there and you can see we get a very nice
graph you can see a very nice elbow
joint there at uh two and again right
around three and four and then after
that there's not very much now as a data
scientist if I was looking at this I
would do either three or four and I'd
actually try both of them to see what
the um output look like and they've
already tried this in the back so we're
just going to use three as a setup on
here and let's go ahead and see what
that looks like when we actually use
this to show the different kinds of
cars and so let's go ahead and apply the
K means to the cars data set and
basically we're going to copy the code
that we looped through up above where K
means equals K means number of clusters
and we're just going to set that number
of clusters to three since that's what
we're going to look for and you could do
three and four on this and graph them
just to see how they come up
differently' be kind of curious to look
at that but for this we're just going to
set it to three go ahead and create our
own variable y k means for our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops I double equal there to K means
but we're not going to do a fit we're
going to do a fit predict is the setup
you want to use and when you're using
untrained models you'll see um a
slightly different usually you see fit
and then you see just the predict but we
want to both fit and predict the K means
on this this and that's fitcore predict
and then our capital x is the data we're
working
with and before we plot this data we're
going to do a little pandas trick we're
going to take our x value and we're
going to set XS Matrix so we're
converting this into a nice rows and
columns kind of set up but we want the
we're going to have columns equals none
so it's just going to be a matrix of
data in here and let's go ahead and run
that a little warning you'll see These
Warnings pop up because things are
always being updated so there's like
minor changes in the versions and future
versions instead of Matrix now that it's
more common to set it Dov values instead
of doing as Matrix but M Matrix works
just fine for right now and you'll want
to update that later on but let's go
ahead and dive in and plot this and see
what that looks like and before we dive
into plotting this data I always like to
take a look and see what I am plotting
so let's take a look at why K means I'm
just going to print that out down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1 0 2 1 two so it's clustering
these different rows of data based on
the three different spaces it thinks
it's going to
be and then let's go ahead and print X
and see what we have for x and we'll see
that X is an array it's a matrix so we
have our different values in the array
and what we're going to do it's very
hard to plot all the different values in
the array so we're only going to be
looking at the first two or positions
zero and
one and if you were doing a full
presentation in front of the board
meeting you might actually do a little
different and and dig a little deeper
into the different aspects because this
is all the different columns we looked
at but we only look at columns one and
two for this to make it easy so let's go
ahead and clear this data out of here
and let's bring up our plot and we're
going to do a scatter plot here so PLT
scatter
and this looks a little complicated so
let's explain what's going on with this
we're going to take the X
values and we're only interested in y of
K means equals zero the first cluster
okay and then we're going to take value
zero for the x axis and then we're going
to do the same thing here we're only
interested in K means equals z but we're
going to take the second column so we're
only looking at the first two columns in
our answer or in the data and then the
guys in the back played with this a
little bit to make it
pretty and they discovered that it looks
good with as a size equals 100 that's
the size of the dots we're going to use
red for this one and when they were
looking at the data and what came out it
was definitely the Toyota on this so
we're just going to go ahead and label
it Toyota again that's something you'd
really have to explore in here as far as
playing with those numbers and see what
looks good we'll go ahead and hit enter
in there and I'm just going to paste in
the next two lines which is the next two
cars and this is our Nissa and Honda and
you'll see with our scatter plot we're
now looking at where Yore K means equals
1 and we want the zero column and y k
means equals two again we're looking at
just the first two columns zero and one
and each of these rows then corresponds
to Nissan and
Honda and I'll go ahead and hit enter on
there and uh finally let's take a look
and put the centroids on there again
we're going to do a scatter
plot and on the centroids you can just
pull that from our c means the uh model
we created do cluster centers and we're
going to just do
um all of them in the first number and
all of them in the second number which
is 0 one because you always start with
zero and
one and then they were playing with the
size and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow
and we'll label them it's always good to
have some good labels
centroids and then we do want to do a
title PLT
title and pop up there PLT title because
you always make want to make your graphs
look pretty we'll call it clusters of
car
make and one of the features of the plot
library is you can add a legend it'll
automatically bring in it since we've
already labeled the different aspects of
the legend with Toyota a Nissan and
Honda and finally we want to go ahead
and
show so we can actually see it and
remember it's in line so if you're using
a different editor that's not the
Jupiter notebook you'll get a popup of
this and you should have a nice set of
clusters here so we can look at this and
we have a clusters of Honda and green
Toyota and red Nissan and purple and you
can see where they put the centroids to
separate
them now when we're looking at this we
can also plot a lot of other different
data on here as far because we only
looked at the first two columns this is
just column one and two or 01 as as you
label them in computer scripting but you
can see here we have a nice clusters of
car make and we've able to pull out the
data and you can see how just these two
columns form very distinct clusters of
data so if you were exploring new data
you might take a look and say well what
makes these different almost going in
reverse you start looking at the data
and pulling apart the columns to find
out why is the first group set up the
way it is maybe you're doing loans and
you want to go well why is this group
not defaulting on their loans and why is
the last group defaulting on their loans
and why is the middle group 50%
defaulting on their bank loans and you
start finding ways to manipulate the
data and pull out the answers you
want so now that you've seen how to use
K mean for clustering let's move on to
the next topic now let's look into
logistic regression the logistic Reg
ression algorithm is the simplest
classification algorithm used for binary
or multiclassification problems and we
can see we have our little girl from
Canada who's into horror books is back
that's actually really scary when you
think about that with those big eyes in
the previous tutorial we learned about
linear regression dependent and
independent variables so to brush up y =
mx + C very basic algebraic function of
Y and X the dependent variable is the
target target class variable we are
going to predict the independent
variables X1 all the way up to xn are
the features or attributes we're going
to use to predict the target class we
know what a linear regression looks like
but using the graph we cannot divide the
outcome into categories it's really hard
to categorize 1.5 3.6 9.8 uh for example
a linear regression graph can tell us
that with increase in number of hours
studied the mark of a student will
increase but it will not tell us whether
the student will pass or not in such
cases where we need the output as
categorical value we will use logistic
regression and for that we're going to
use the sigmoid function so you can see
here we have our marks 0 to 100 number
of hours studied that's going to be what
they're comparing it to in this example
and we usually form a line that says y =
mx + C and when we use the sigmoid
function we have P = 1/ 1 + eus us y it
generates a sigmoid curve and so you can
see right here when you take the Ln
which is the natural logarithm I always
thought it should be n l not Ln that's
just the inverse of uh e your e to the
minus y and so we do this we get Ln of p
over 1 minus p = m * x + C that's the
sigmoid curve function we're looking for
and we can zoom in on the function and
you'll see that the function as it
derives goes to one or to Z depending on
what your x value is and the probability
if it's greater than 0.5 the value is
automatically rounded off to one
indicating that the student will pass so
if they're doing a certain amount of
studying they will probably pass then
you have a threshold value at the 0 five
it automatically puts that right in the
middle usually and your probability if
it's less than 0. five the value rented
off to zero indicating the student will
fail so if they're not studying very
hard they're probably going to fail this
of course is ignoring the outlier are
that one student who's just a natural
genius and doesn't need any studying to
memorize everything that's not me
unfortunately have to study hard to
learn new stuff problem statement to
classify whether a tumor is malignant or
benign and this is actually one of my
favorite data sets to play with because
it has so many features and when you
look at them you really are hard to
understand you can't just look at them
and know the answer so it gives you a
chance to kind of dive into what data
looks like when you aren't able to
understand the specific domain of the
data but I also want you to remind you
that in the domain of medicine if I told
you that my probability was really good
it classified things that say 90% or 95%
and I'm classifying whether you're going
to have a malignant or a Bine tumor I'm
guessing that you're going to go get it
tested anyways so you got to remember
the domain we're working with so why
would you want to do that if you know
you're just going to go get a biopsy
because you know it's that serious this
is like an all or nothing just
referencing the domain it's important it
might help the doctor know where to look
just by understanding what kind of tumor
it is so it might help them or Aid them
in something they missed from before so
let's go ahead and dive into the code
and I'll come back to the domain part of
it in just a minute so use case and
we're going to do our noral Imports here
we're importing numpy pandas caborn the
matplot library and we're going to do
matplot library in line since I'm going
to switch over to Anaconda so let's go
ahead and flip over there and get this
started so I've opened up a new window
in my anaconda Jupiter
notebook by the way Jupiter notebook uh
you don't have to use Anaconda for the
Jupiter notebook I just love the
interface and all the tools that
Anaconda brings so we got our import
numpy as in P for our numpy number array
we have our Panda's PD we're going to
bring in caborn to help us with our
graphs as SNS so many really nice Tools
in both Seaborn and matplot Library
we'll do our met plot library. pyplot as
PLT and then of course we want to let it
know to do it in line and let's go and
just run that so it's all set
up and we're just going to call our data
data not creative today uh equals PD and
this happens to be in a CSV file so
we'll use a pd. read CSV and I happen to
name the file I renamed it data for
p2.png YouTube and request for the data
set itself or go to the simply learn
website and we'll be happy to supply
that for
you and let's just um open up the data
before we go any further and let's just
see what it looks like in a
spreadsheet so when I pop it open in a
local spreadsheet this is just a CSV
file comma separate variables we have an
ID so I guess they um categorizes for
reference or what id which test was done
the diagnosis M for malignant B for B9
so there's two different options on on
there and that's what we're going to try
to predict is the m and b and test it
and then we have like the radius mean or
average the texture average perimeter
mean area mean smoothness I don't know
about you but unless you're a doctor in
the field most of stuff I mean you can
guess what concave means just by the
term concave but I really wouldn't know
what that means in the measurements
they're taking so they have all kinds of
stuff like how smooth it is uh the
Symmetry and these are all float values
we just page through them real quick and
you'll see there's I believe 36 if I
remember correctly in this
one so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at the different growth the
tumorous growth so back in our data and
I put this in the same folder as a code
so I saved this code in that folder
obviously if you have it in a different
location you want to put the full path
in there and we'll just do um
Panda's first five lines of data with
the data. head and we run that we can
see that we have pretty much what we
just looked at we have an ID we have a
diagnosis if we go all the way across
you'll see all the different columns
coming across displayed nicely for our
data and while we're exploring the data
our caborn which we referenced as
SNS makes it very easy to go in here and
do a joint plot you'll notice the very
similar to because it is sitting on on
top of the um plot Library so the joint
plot does a lot of work for us and we're
just going to look at the first two
columns that we're interested in the
radius mean and the texture mean we'll
just look at those two columns and data
equals data so that tells it which two
columns we're plotting and that we're
going to use the data that we pulled in
let's just run that and it generates a
really nice graph on here and there's
all kinds of cool things on this graph
to look at I mean we have the texture
mean and the radius mean obviously the
axes you can also
see and one of the cool things on here
is you can also see the histogram they
show that for the radius mean where is
the most common radius mean come up and
where the most common texture is so
we're looking at the tech the on each
growth its average texture and on each
radius its average uh radius on there
it's a little confusing because we're
talking about the individual objects
average and then we can also look over
here and see the the histogram showing
the median or how common each
measurement is and that's only two
columns so let's dig a little deeper
into Seaborn they also have a heat map
and if you're not familiar with heat
Maps a heat map just means it's in color
that's all that means heat map I guess
the original ones were plotting heat
density on something and so ever since
then it's just called a heat map and
we're going to take our data and get our
corresponding numbers to put that into
the heat map and that's simply data. C
RR
for that that's a pandas expression
remember we're working in a pandas data
frame so that's one of the Cool Tools in
pandas for our data and let's just pull
that information into a heat map and see
what that looks like and you'll see that
we're now looking at all the different
features we have our ID we have our
texture we have our area our compactness
concave points and if you look down the
middle of this chart diagonal going from
the upper left to bottom right it's all
white that's because because when you
compare texture to texture they're
identical so they're 100% or in this
case perfect one in their
correspondence and you'll see that when
you look at say area or right below it
it has almost a black on there when you
compare it to texture so these have
almost no corresponding data They Don't
Really form a linear graph or something
that you can look at and say how
connected they are they're very
scattered data this is really just a
really nice graph to get a quick look at
your data data doesn't so much change
what you do but it changes verifying so
when you get an answer or something like
that or you start looking at some of
these individual pieces you might go hey
that doesn't match according to showing
our heat map this should not correlate
with each other and if it is you're
going to have to start asking well why
what's going on what else is coming in
there but it does show some really cool
information on here I mean we can see
from the ID there's no real one feature
that just says if you go across the top
line that lights up there's no one
feature that says hey if the area is a
certain size then it's going to be B9 or
maligant it says there's some that sort
of add up and that's a big hint in the
data that we're trying to ID this
whether it's malignant or B9 that's a
big hint to us as data scientists to go
okay we can't solve this with any one
feature it's going to be something that
includes all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it and while we're
exploring exploring the data let's
explore one more area and let's look at
data. is null we want to check for null
values in our data if you remember from
earlier in this tutorial we did it a
little differently where we added stuff
up and summed them up you can actually
with pandas do it really quickly data.
is null and Summit and it's going to go
across all the columns so when I run
this you're going to see all the columns
come up with no null
data so we've just just to reash these
last few steps we've done a lot of
exploration we have looked at the first
two columns and seeing how they plot
with the caborn with a joint plot which
shows both the histogram and the data
plotted on the X Y coordinates and
obviously you can do that more in detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together and then we took and did
the Seaborn heat map the SNS do heat map
of the data and you can see right here
where it did a nice job showing us some
bright spots where stuff correlates with
each other and forms a very nice
combination or points of scattering
points and you can also see areas that
don't and then finally we went ahead and
check the data is the data null value do
we have any missing data in there very
important step because it'll crash later
on if you forget to do this step it will
remind you when you get that nice error
code that says null values
okay so not a big deal if you miss it
but it it's no fun having to go back
when you're you're in a huge process and
you've missed this step and now you're
10 steps later and you got to go
remember where you were pulling the data
in so we need to go ahead and pull out
our X and our y so me just put that down
here and we'll set the x equal to and
there's a lot of different options here
certainly we could do x equals all the
columns except for the first two because
if you remember the first two is the ID
D and the diagnosis so that certainly
would be an option but what we're going
to do is we're actually going to focus
on the worst the worst radius the worst
texture parameter area smoothness
compactness and so on one of the reasons
to start dividing your data up when
you're looking at this information is
sometimes the data will be the same data
coming in so if I have two measurements
coming into my model it might overweigh
them it might overpower
the other measurements because it's
measuring it's basically taking that
information in twice that's a little bit
past the scope of this tutorial I want
you to take away from this though is
that we are dividing the data up into
pieces and our team in the back went
ahead and said hey let's just look at
the worst so I'm going to create a an
array and you'll see this array radius
worst texture worst perimeter worst
we've just taken the worst of the worst
and I'm just going to put that in my X
so this x is still a panda data frame
but it's just those column s and our y
if you remember correctly is going to be
oops hold on one second it's not X it's
data there we go so x equals data and
then it's a list of the different
columns the worst of the worst and if
we're going to take that then we have to
have our answer for our Y for the stuff
we know and if you remember correctly
we're just going to be looking
at the diagnosis that's all we care
about is what is it diagnosed is it Bine
or malignant and since it's a single col
we can just do diagnosis oh I forgot to
put the brackets the there we go okay so
it's just diagnosis on there and we can
also quickly do like x. head if you want
to see what that looks like and y. head
and run this and you'll see um it only
does the last one I forgot about that if
you don't do print you can see that the
the Y do head is just Mmm because the
first ones are all malignant and if I
run this the x. head is just the first
five Val values of radius worst texture
worst parameter worst area worst and so
on I'll go ahead and take that out so
moving down to the next step we've built
our two data sets our answer and then
the features we want to look
at in data science it's very important
to test your
model so we do that by splitting the
data and from sklearn model selection
we're going to import support train test
split so we're going to split it into
two groups there are so many ways to do
this I noticed in one of the more modern
ways they actually split it into three
groups and then you model each group and
test it against the other groups so you
have all kinds of and there's reasons
for that which is past the scope of this
and for this particular example isn't
necessary for this we're just going to
split it into two groups one to train
our data and one to test our data and
the sklearn uh. model selection we have
train test split you could write your
own quick code to do this we just
randomly divide the data up into two
groups but they do it for us
nicely and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this where we're going to generate four
variables capital x train capital X test
so we have our training data we're going
to use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to train the
answer and then we have our test so this
is the stuff we want to see how good it
did on our model and we'll go ahead and
take our train test split that we just
imported and we're going to do X and our
y our two different data that's going in
for our split and then the guys in the
back came up and wanted us to go ahead
and use a test size equals three that's
testore size random State it's always
nice to kind of switch a random State
around but not that important what this
means is that the test size is we're
going to take 30% of the data and we're
going to put that into our test
variables our y test and our X test and
we're going to do 70% into the X train
and the Y train so we're going to use
70% of the data to train our model and
30% to test it let's go ahead and run
that and load those up so now we have
all our stuff split up and all our data
ready to go now we get to the actual
Logistics part we're actually going to
do our create our model so let's go
ahead and bring that in from sklearn
we're going to bring in our linear model
and we're going to import logistic
regression that's the actual model we're
using and this we'll call it log
model the real model and let's just set
this equal to our logistic regression
that we just imported so now we have a
variable log model set to that class for
us to use and with most the uh models in
the SK learn we just need to go ahead
and fix it fit do a fit on there and we
use our X train that we separated out
with our y train and let's go ahead and
run this so once we've run this we'll
have a model that fits this data that
70% of our training
data uh and of course it prints this out
that tells us all the different
variables that you can set on there
there's a lot of different choices you
can make but for word do we're just
going to let all the defaults sit we
don't really need to mess with those on
this particular example and there's
nothing in here that really stands out
as super important until you start
fine-tuning it but for what we're doing
the basic will work just fine and then
let's we need to go ahead and test out
our model is it working so let's create
a variable y predict and this is going
to be equal to our log model and we want
to do a predict again very standard uh
format for the sklearn library is taking
your model and doing a predict on it and
we're going to test y predict against
the Y test so we want to know what the
model thinks it's going to be that's
what our y predict is and with that we
want the capital x x test so we have our
train set and our test set and now we're
going to do our y predict and let's go
ahead and run
that and if we uh
print y predict let me go ahead and run
that you'll see it comes up and it PR a
prints a nice array of uh B and M for B9
and
malignant for all the different test
data we put in there so it does pretty
good we're not sure exactly how good it
does but we can see that it actually
works and it's functional was very easy
to create you'll always discover with
our data science that as you explore
this you spend a significant amount of
time prepping your data and making sure
your data coming in is good uh there's a
saying good data in good answers out bad
data in bad answers out that's only half
the thing that's only half of it
selecting your models becomes the next
part of as far as how good your models
are and then of course fine-tuning it
depending on what model you're using so
we come in here we want to know how good
this came out so we have our y predict
here log model. predict X
test so for deciding how good our model
is we're going to go from the sklearn
metrics we're going to import
classification report and that just
reports how good our model is doing and
then we're going to feed it the model
data let's just print this out
and we'll take our classification
report and we're going to put into
there our test our actual data so this
is what we actually know is true and our
prediction what our model predicted for
that data on the test side and let's run
that and see what that
does so we pull that up you'll see that
we have um a Precision for B9 and
malignant
B&M and we have a Precision of 93 and 91
a total of 92 so it's kind of the
average between these two of 92 there's
all kinds of different information on
here your F1
score your recall your support coming
through on this and for this I'll go
ahead and just flip back to our slides
that they put together for describing it
and so here we're going to look at the
Precision using the classification
report and you see this is the same
print out I had up above some of the
numbers might be different because it
does randomly pick out which data we're
using so this model is able to predict
the type of tumor with
91% accuracy so we look back here that's
you will see where we have a B9 and
inant it actually is 92 coming up here
but we're looking about a 92 91%
precision and remember I reminded you
about domain so we're talking about the
domain of a medical domain with a very
catastrophic outcome you know at 91 or
92% Precision you're still going to go
in there and have some somebody do a
biopsy on it very different than if
you're investing money and there's a 92%
chance you're going to earn 10% and 8%
chance you're going to lose 8% you're
probably going to bet the money because
at that odds it's pretty good that
you'll make some money and in the long
run you do that enough you definitely
will make money and also with this
domain I've actually seen them use this
to identify different forms of cancer
that's one of the things that they're
starting to use these models for because
then it helps the doctor know what to
investigate so that wraps up this
section we're finally we're going to go
in there and let's discuss the an to the
quiz asked in machine learning tutorial
part one can you tell what's happening
in the following cases grouping
documents into different categories
based on the topic and content of each
document this is an example of
clustering where K means clustering can
be used to group the documents by topics
using bag of words approach so if You'
gotten in there that you're looking for
clustering and hopefully you had at
least one or two examples like K means
that are used for clustering different
things then give yourself a two thumbs
up B identifying handwritten digits and
images correctly this is an example of
classification the traditional approach
to solving this would be to extract
digit dependent features like curvature
of different digits Etc and then use a
classifier like svm to distinguish
between images again if you got the fact
that it's a classification example give
yourself a thumb up and if you're able
to go hey let's use svm or another model
for this give yourself those two thumbs
up on it C behavior of a website
indicating that the site is not working
as designed this is an example of
anomaly detection in this case the
algorithm learns what is normal and what
is not normal usually by observing the
logs of the website give yourself a
thumbs up if you got that one and just
for a bonus can you think of another
example of anomaly detection one of the
ones I use for my own business is
detecting anomalies in stock markets
stock markets are very ficked and they
behave very ertical so finding those
erratic areas and then finding ways to
track down why they're erratic was
something released in social media was
something released you can see we're
knowing where that anomaly is can help
you to figure out what the answer is to
it in another area D predicting salary
of an individual based on his or her
years of experience this is an example
of regression this problem can be
mathematically defined as a function
between independent years of experience
and dependent variables salary of an
individual and if you guess that this
was a regression model give yourself a
thumbs up and if you're able to remember
that it was between independent and
dependent variables and that terms give
yourself two thumbs up summary so to
wrap it up we went over what is K means
and we went through also the chart of
choosing your elbow method and assigning
a random centroid to the Clusters
Computing the distance and then then
going in there and figuring out what the
minimum centroids is and Computing the
distance and going through that Loop
until it gets the perfect centroid and
we looked into the elbow method to
choose K based on running our clusters
across a number of variables and finding
the best location for that we did a nice
example of clustering cars with K means
even though we only looked at the first
two columns to make it simple and easy
to graph we can easily extrapolate that
and look at all the different columns
and see how they all fit together and we
looked at what is logistic regression we
discussed the sigmoid function what is
logistic regression and then we went
into an example of classifying tumors
with Logistics I hope you enjoyed part
two of machine learning thank you for
joining us today for more information
visit www.s simply learn.com again my
name is Richard kersner a member of the
simplylearn team get certified get ahead
if you have any questions or comments
feel free to write those down below the
YouTube video or visit us at simply
learn.com we'll be happy to Supply you
with the data sets or other information
as
[Music]
requested hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simply learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click
here today we're going to cover the K
nearest neighbors a l referred to as
knnn and KNN is really a fundamental
place to start in the machine learning
it's a basis of a lot of other things
and just the logic behind it is easy to
understand and Incorporated in other
forms of machine learning so today
what's in it for you why do we need KNN
what is knnn how do we choose the factor
K when do we use
knnn how does KNN algorithm work and
then we'll dive into my favorite part
the use case predict whether a person
will have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model Builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output is
that a dog little kid looking over there
and watching the black cat cross their
path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics cats cats have sharp
claws uses to climb smaller length of
ears meows and purs doesn't love to play
around dogs they have dle claws bigger
length of ears barks loves to run around
you usually don't see a cat running
around people although I do have a cat
that does that where dogs do and we can
look at these we can say we can evaluate
the sharpness of the claws how sharper
their claws and we can evaluate the
length of the ears and we can usually
sort out cats from dogs based on even
those two
characteristics now tell me if it is a
cat or a dog odd question usually little
kids know cats and dogs by now unless
they live a place where there's not many
cats or dogs so if we look at the
sharpness of the claws the length of the
ears and we can see that the cat has
smaller ears and sharper claws than the
other animals its features are more like
cats it must be a cat sharp claws length
of ears and it goes in the cat group
because KNN is based on feature
similarity we can do classification
using KNN classifier so we have our
input value the picture of the black cat
it goes into our trained model and it
predicts that this is a cat coming out
so what is knnn what is the KNN
algorithm K nearest neighbors is what
that stands for it's one of the simplest
supervised machine learning algorithms
mostly used for classification so we
want to know is this a dog or it's not a
dog is it a cat or not a cat the class
classifies a data point based on how its
neighbors are classified KNN stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
we gone from cats and dogs right into
wine another favorite of mine KNN stores
all available cases and classifies new
cases based on a similarity measure and
here you see we have a measurement of
sulfur dioxide versus the chloride level
and then the different wines they've
tested and where they fall on that graph
based on how much sulfur dioxide and how
much chloride K and KN andn is a
perimeter that refers to the number of
nearest neighbors to include in the
majority of the voting process and so if
we add a new glass of wine there red or
white we want to know what the neighbors
are in this case we're going to put k
equals 5 we'll talk about K in just a
minute a data point is classified by the
majority of votes from its five nearest
neighbors here the unknown point would
be classified as red since four out of
five neighbors are red so how do we
choose K how do we know k equals five I
mean that's what the value we put in
there so we're going to talk about it
how do we choose the factor k k andn
algorithm is based on feature similarity
choosing the right value of K is a
process called parameter tuning and is
important for better accuracy so at k
equal 3 we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to three we're going to
look at the three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equal to 7 we class ify as a
triangle depending on what the other
data is around and you can see as the K
changes depending on where that point is
that drastically changes your answer and
uh we jump here we go how do we choose
the factor of K you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get it's like oh my
gosh did I choose the right K did I set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in One
Direction or the other and in terms of
knnn the number number of K if you
choose it too low the bias is based on
it's just too noisy it's it's right next
to a couple things and it's going to
pick those things and you might get a
skewed answer and if your K is too big
then it's going to take forever to
process so you're going to run into
processing issues and resource issues so
what we do the most common use and
there's other options for choosing K is
to use the square root of n so N is a
total number of values you have you take
the square root of it in most cases you
all so if it's an even number so if
you're using uh like in this case
squares and triangles if it's even you
want to make your K value odd that helps
it select better so in other words
you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
N and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the K value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use KNN we
can use KNN when data is labeled so you
need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is Noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 Hello Kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where I
you might get into gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because KNN is a lazy learner I.E it
does learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the KNN but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the KNN and also just
using for smaller data sets KNN works
really good how does a KNN algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we can see right here we have two
variables you know true false they're
either normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using KNN so if
we have new data coming in this says 57
kg and 177 cm is that going to be normal
or underweight to find the nearest
neighbors we'll calculate the ukian
distance according to the ukian distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates XY and
ab is given by distance D equals the
Square t of x - a^ 2 + y - b^ 2 and you
can remember that from the two edges of
a triangle we're Computing the third
Edge since we know the X side and the
yide let's calculate it to understand
clearly so we have our unknown point and
we placed it there in red and we have
our other points where the data is
scattered around the distance D1 is a
square < TK of 170 - 167 2 + 57 - 51 2ar
which is about 6.7 and distance two is
about 13 and distance three is about
13.4 similarly we will calculate the
ukian distance of unknown data point
from all the points in the data set and
because we're dealing with small amount
of data that's not that hard to do and
it's actually pretty quick for a
computer and it's not a really
complicated Mass you can just see how
close is the data based on the ukian
distance hence we have calculated the
ukian distance of unknown data point
from all the points as showing where X1
and y1 equal 57 and 170 whose class we
have to classify so now we're looking at
that we're saying well here's the ukian
distance who's going to be their closest
neighbors now let's calculate the
nearest neighbor at k equals 3 and we
can see the three closest neighbors puts
them at normal and that's pretty
self-evident when you look at this graph
it's pretty easy to say okay what you
know we're just voting normal normal
normal three votes for for normal this
is going to be a normal weight so
majority of neighbors are pointing
towards normal hence as per K&N
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so recap of knnn positive integer
K is specified along with a new sample
we select the K entries in our database
which are closest to the new sample we
find the most common classification of
these entries this is the classification
we give to the new sample so as you can
see it's pretty straightforward we're
just looking for the closest things that
match what we got so let's take a look
and see what that looks like in a use
case in Python so let's dive into the
predict diabetes use case so use case
predict diabetes the objective predict
whether a person will be diagnosed with
diabetes or not we have a data set of
768 people who were or were not
diagnosed with diabetes and let's go
ahead and open that file and just take a
look at that data and this is in a
simple spreadsheet format the data
itself is comma separate ated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through I
that's what 1 2 3 four five 6 seven
eight um eight columns with a particular
tribute and then the ninth column which
is the outcome is whether they have
diabetes as a data scientist the first
thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes that's why
they're taking it and that could cause
issue on some of the machine learning
packages but for a very basic setup this
works fine for uh doing the KNN and the
next thing you notice is it didn't take
very much to open it up um I can scroll
down to the bottom of the data there's
768 it's pretty much a small data set
you know at 769 I can easily fit this
into my ram on my computer I can look at
it I can manipulate it and it's not
going to really tax just a regular
desktop computer you don't even need an
Enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what IDE I'm using
certainly you can use any particular
editor for python but I like to use for
doing uh very basic visual stuff the
Anaconda which is great for doing demos
with the Jupiter notebook and just a
quick view of the Anaconda Navigator
which is the new release out there which
is really nice you can see under home I
can choose my application we're going to
be using python 36 I have a couple
different uh versions on this particular
machine if I go under environments I can
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where I can install
different packages so if I click on that
button and open the terminal I can then
use a simple pip install to install
different packages I'm working with
let's go ahead and go back under home
and we're going to launch our notebook
and I've already you know kind of like
uh the old cooking shows I've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case I'm going
it's going to open up Chrome because
that's my default that I use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see I have
a number of windows open up at the top
the one we're working in and uh since
we're working on the KNN predict whether
a person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and I'm
also going to go up here and click on
Cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then I'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
I'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run as python it's a markdown language
so if I run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice mind us what we're working on and
by now now you should be familiar with
doing all of our Imports we're going to
import the pandas as PD import numpy as
NP pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
Imports so we've brought in our pandas
our numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our train test split by now used to be
familiar with splitting the data we want
to split part of it for training our
thing and then training our particular
model model and then we want to go ahead
and test the remaining data just see how
good it is pre-processing a standard
scaler pre-processor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number pregnancies
isn't going to get very large where the
amount of insulin they take and get up
to 256 so 256 versus 6 that will skew
results so we want to go ahead and
change that so that they're all uniform
between minus one and one and then the
actual tool this is the K neighbors
classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it let me just put
down test on there and we have our
confusion Matrix our F1 score and our
accuracy so we have our two general
python modules we're importing and then
we have our six module specific from the
sklearn setup and then we do need to go
ahead and run this so these are actually
imported there we go and then move on to
the next step and so in this set we're
going to go ahead and load the data
database we're going to use pandas
remember pandas is PD and we'll take a
look at the data in Python we looked at
it in a simple spreadsheet but usually
i' like to also pull it up so that we
can see what we're doing so here's our
data set equals pd. read CSV that's a
pandas command and the diabetes folder I
just put in the same folder where my
IPython script is if you put in a
different folder you'd need the full
length on there we can also do a quick
length of uh the data set that is a
simple python command Len for length we
might even let's go ahead and print that
we'll go print and if you do it on its
own line link. datet in the jupyter
notebook it'll automatically print it
but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there if you
put a bunch of these in a row you know
the data set one head data set two head
it only prints out the last last one so
I us always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame Panda
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the Run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood PR
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
Factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness uh and this is a nice way when
you're working with columns is to list
the columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on uh very common thing
to do and then for this particular setup
we certainly could use the there's some
Panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the na but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals data set column.
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do a direct there's also one that
that you look for your n a lot of
different options in here but the Nan
nump Nan is what that stands for is is
non doesn't exist so the first thing
we're doing here is we're replacing the
zero with a numpy none there's no data
there that's what that says that's what
this is saying right here so put the
zero in and we're going to replace zeros
with no data so if it's a zero that
means the person's well hopefully not
dead hopefully it just didn't get the
data the next thing we want to do is
we're going to create create the mean
which is the in integer from the data
set from the column do mean where we
skip Nas we can do that that is a
panda's command there the skip na so
we're going to figure out the mean of
that data set and then we're going to
take that data set column and we're
going to replace all the
npn with the means why did we do that
and we could have actually just uh taken
this step and gone right down here and
just replace zero and Skip anything
where except you could actually there's
a way to skip zeros and then just
replace called the zeros but in this
case we want to go ahead and do it this
way so you can see that we're switching
this to a non-existent value then we're
going to create the mean well this is
the average person so if we don't know
what it is if they did not get the data
and the data is missing one of the
tricks is you replace it with the
average what is the most common data for
that this way you can still use the rest
of those values to do your computation
and it kind of just brings that
particular value or those missing values
out of the equation let's go ahead and
take this and we'll go ahead and run it
doesn't actually do anything so we're
still preparing our data if you want to
see what that looks like we don't have
anything in the first few lines so it's
not going to show up but we certainly
could look at a row let's do that let's
go into our data set with printed data
set and let's pick in this case let's
just do glucose and if I run this this
is going to print all the different
glucose levels going down and we
thankfully don't see anything in here
that looks like missing data at least on
the ones it shows you can see it skipped
a bunch in the middle because that's
what it does if you have too many lines
in Jupiter notebook it'll skip a few and
and go on to the next in a data set let
me go and remove this and we'll just
zero out that and of course before we do
any processing before proceeding any
further we need to split the data set
into our train and testing data that way
we have something to train it with and
something to test it on and you're going
to notice we did a little something here
with the panda database code there we go
my drawing tool we've added in this
right here
of the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the PD pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the iocation and it is all rows that's
what that says so we're going to keep
all the rows but we're only looking at
zero column 0 to 8 remember column 9
here it is right up here we printed in
in here is outcome well that's not part
of the training data that's part of the
answer yes it's column nine but it's
listed as eight number eight so 0o to
eight is nine columns so uh eight is the
value and when you see it in here 0o
this is actually 0 to 7 it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to Y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column 8 and
you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the SK learn right
there and we simply put in our X and our
y we're going to do random State equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seed
it that's a seed number I think the
default is one when you SE it I'd have
to look that up and then the test size
test size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20% of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any print out other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there but the
actual writing of our KNN we need to go
ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scaler which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is 1 to six we're going to set
that all so that all the data is between
minus one and one that's what that
standard scaler does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scaler with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the X
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scaler we're going
to call it scor X for the scaler and
we're going to import the standard
scaler into this variable and then our X
train equals score x. fit transform so
we're creating the scaler on the X train
variable and then our X test we're also
going to transform it so we've trained
and transformed the X train and then the
X test isn't part of that training it
isn't part of the of training the
Transformer it just gets transformed
that's all it does and again we're going
to go and run this and if you look at
this we've now gone through these steps
all three of them we've taken care of
replacing our zeros for key columns that
shouldn't be zero and we replace that
with the means of those columns that way
that they fit right in with our data
models we've come down here and we split
the data so now we have our test data
and our training data and then we've
taken and we scaled the data so all of
our data going in now no we don't tra we
don't train the Y Y part the Y train and
Y test that never has to be trained it's
only the data going in that's what we
want to train in there then Define the
model using K neighbors classifier and
fit the train data in the model so we do
all that data prep and you can see down
here we're only going to have a couple
lines of code where we're actually
building our model and training it
that's one of the cool things about
Python and how far we've come it's such
an exciting time to be in machine
learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of Y and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math. square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be xtrain before we do this let's go
ahead and do import math and do math
square root length of Y test and when I
run that we get
12.49 I want to see show you where this
number comes from we're about to use 12
is an even number so if you know if
you're ever voting on things remember
the neighbors all vote don't want to
have an even number of neighbors voting
so we want to do something odd and let's
just take one away we'll make it 11 let
me delete this out of here that's one of
the reasons I love jupyter notebook
because you can flip around and do all
kinds of things on the fly so we'll go
ahead and put in our classifier we're
creating our classifier now and it's
going to be the K Neighbors classifier
in Neighbors equal 11 remember we did 12
minus 1 for 11 so we have an odd number
of Neighbors P equals 2 because we're
looking for is it are they diabetic or
not and we're using the ukian metric
there are other means of measuring the
distance you could do like square square
means value there's all kinds of measure
this but the ukan is the most common one
and it works quite well it's important
to evaluate the model let's use the
confusion Matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion Matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the F1 score and finally accuracy score
which is probably the most commonly used
quoted number when you go into a meeting
or something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion Matrix y test
y predict so those are the two values
we're going to put in there and let me
go ahe and run that and print it out and
the way you interpret this is you have
the Y predicted which would be your
title up here you could do uh let's just
do
p predicted across the top and actual
going down actual it's always hard to to
write in here actual that means that
this column here down the middle that's
the important column and it means that
our prediction said 94 and prediction
and the actual agreed on 94 and 32 this
number here the 13 and the 15 those are
what was wrong so you could have like
three different if you're looking at
this across three different variables
instead of just two you'd end up with
the third row down here in the column
colum going down the middle so in the
first case we have the the and I believe
the zero is a 94 people who don't have
diabetes the prediction said that 13 of
those people did have diabetes and were
at high risk and the 32 that had
diabetes it had correct but our
prediction said another 15 out of that
15 it classified as incorrect so you can
see where that classification comes in
and how that works on the confusion
Matrix then we're going to go ahead and
print the F1 score let me just run that
and you see we get a 69 in our F1 score
the F1 takes into account both sides of
the balance of false positives where if
we go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the F1 score the F score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the F1 score but the F1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82% not too bad
for a quick flash look at people's
different statistics and running an
sklearn and running the knnn the K
nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using KNN which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accurate score we got the
0 818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80%
tells us that is a pretty fair fit in
the model the principal component uh
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction principal
component analysis what is it important
PCA terminologies and you'll see it
abbrev ated uh normally as PCA principal
component analysis PCA properties PCA
example and then we'll pull up some
python code in our jupyter notebook and
have some Hands-On demo on the PCA and
how it's used dimensionality reduction
dimensionality reduction refers to the
technique that reduces the number of
input variables in a data set and so you
can see on the table on the right shows
the orders made at an automobile parts
retailer the ret teller sells different
automobile parts from different
companies and you can see we have
company uh bpex isomax and they have the
item the tire the axle an order ID a
price number and a quantity in order to
predict the future cells we find out
that using correlation analysis that we
just need three attributes therefore we
have reduced the number of attributes
from five to three and clearly we don't
really care about the part number I
don't think the part number would have
an effect on how many tires are bought
um and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things we are in the
descriptive phase we're describing the
data and we're pre-processing the data
what can we do to clean it up why
dimensionality reduction well number one
less di mentions for a given data set
means less computation or training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models uh
and you're rerunning them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models so this is huge this is probably
the hugest part as far as reducing um
our data set redundancy is removed after
removing similar entries from the data
set again pre-processing some of our
models like a neural network if you put
into the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just once we want to get rid of that
redundancy it also increases the
processing time if you have multiple uh
data coming in space required to store
the data is
reduced so if we're committing this into
a big data uh pool we might not send the
company that bought it why would we want
to store two whole extra columns when we
added into that pool of data makes the
data easy for plotting in 2D and 3D
plots this is my favorite part very
important you're in your shareholder
meeting you want to be able to give them
a really good um clear and simplified
version you want to reduce it down to
something people can take in it helps to
find out the most significant features
and skip the rest which also comes in in
post scribing uh leads to better human
interpretation that kind of goes with
number four what makes data easy for
plotting you have a better
interpretation when we're looking at it
principal component analysis so what is
it uh principal component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the PCA we
reduce the variables we end up with a
reduced variable
setup this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result we
have the different colors all lined up
so what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here uh
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some Toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle uh we get the back
of a lot of heads not many
faces uh so we'll do it from here we
might get the one person up front
smiling a lot of the people in the class
are missing so we have um a huge amount
off to the right of blank space Maybe
from up here again we have the back of
someone's head and uh it turns out that
the best angle to click the picture from
might be this bottom left angle you look
at it and you say hey that makes sense
it's a a good um configuration of all
the people in the picture now when we're
talking about data it's not you really
can't do it by what you think is going
to be the best we need to have some kind
of mathematical formula so it's
consistent and so it makes sense in the
back end one of the projects I worked on
many years ago uh has something similar
to the iris and if you've ever done the
Irish data set it's probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower and they're measuring
the ston uh in the pedals and they have
width and they have length of the
pedal instead of putting through the
width and the length of the pedal we
could just as easily do the um width to
length ratio we can divide the width by
the the length and you get a single
number where you had two that's the kind
of idea that's going on into this in
pre-processing and looking at what we
can do to bring the data down the very
simplified example on my uh Iris pedal
example when we look at the similarity
in PCA we find the best picture or
projection of the data points and so we
look down at from one angle we've drawn
a line down there uh we can see these
data points based on in this case just
two variabl now keep in mind we're
usually talking about 36 40 variables um
almost all of your business models
usually have about 26 to 27 different
variables they're looking at uh same
thing with like a bank loan model we're
talking 26 to 36 different variables
they're looking at that are going in so
what we want to do is we want to find
the best view in this case we're just
looking at the
XY we look down at it and we have our
second um idea PC two and again we're
looking at the XI this XY this time from
a different direction here for our ease
we can consider that we get two
principal components namely pc1 and
PC2 comparing both the principal
components we find the data points are
sufficiently spaced in
pc1 so if you look at what we got here
we have uh pc1 you can see along the
line how the data points are spaced
versus the spacing in PC2 and that's
what they're coming up with what is
going to give us the best look for these
data points when we combine them and
we're looking at them from just a single
angle whereas in PC2 they are less
spaced which makes the observation and
further calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc1 and not the
PC2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the backend calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more
valuable this gives you an idea idea
though that when we're talking about
this we're talking about the perspective
uh which would help in understanding how
PCA analysis
works we want to go ahead and do is dive
into the important terminologies under
PCA and important terminologies are
views the perspective through which data
points are
observed and so you'll hear that if
someone's talking about a PCA
presentation and they're not taking the
time to reduce it to something that the
average person shareholder is can
understand you might hear them refer to
it as the different views what view are
we taking Dimension number of columns in
a data set are called the dimensions of
that data set we talked about you'll
hear features Dimensions um I was
talking about features there's usually
when you're running a business you're
talking 25 26 27 different features
minimal and then you have the principal
component new variables that are
constructed as linear combinations or
mixtures of the initial
variables principal component is very
important it's a combination if you
remember my flower example it would be
the width over the length of the petal
as opposed to putting both width and
length in you just put in the um ratio
instead which is a single number versus
two separate numbers
projections the perpendicular distance
between the principal component and the
data
points and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those Point how those points fall
onto the line important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of
attributes that just makes Common Sense
uh you're not going to do 10 principal
properties with only three features
you're trying to reduce them so that's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw weird
code out there and just randomly do
stuff instead of really thinking it
through principal components are
orthagonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line we when
we do pc1 we're looking at how those
points fall onto that line uh same thing
with PC2 we want to make sure that pc1
does not equal PC2 we don't want to have
the same two principal points uh when we
do two
points the priority of principal
components decreases as their numbers
increase this is important to understand
if you're going to create
uh one
principle component everything is
summarized into that one component as we
go to two components the priority um how
much it holds value decreases as we go
down so if you have five different
points each one of those points is going
to have less value than just the one
point which has everything summarized in
it how PCA works I said there was more
in the back end when we talk about the
math this is what we're talking about is
how does it actually work so now we have
understanding that you're you're looking
at a perspective uh now we want to see
how that math side Works PCA performs
the following operations in order to
evaluate the principal components for a
given data
set first we start with the
standardization then we have a
covariance matrix
computation and we use that to generate
our ige vectors and IG
values which is the feature vector and
if you remember the ige vector is like a
translation for um uh moving the data
from xal 1 to xals 2 or whatever
altering it and the IG value is the
final value that we
generate when we talk about
standardization the main aim of this
step is to standardize the range of the
attributes so that each one of them lie
within similar boundaries this process
involves removal of the mean from the
variable values and scaling the data
with respect to the standard
deviation and you can see here we have Z
equals the variable values minus the
mean over the standard
deviation The co-variance Matrix
computation covariance Matrix is used to
express the correlation between any two
or more attributes in multi-dimensional
data set the covariance Matrix has the
entries as the variance and the
co-variance of the attribute values the
variance is denoted by VAR and the
co-variance is denoted by Cove on the
right we can see the co-variance Matrix
for two attributes and their
values when we do a Hands-On look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like for now you can
just notice that this is a matrix that
we're generating with the variance and
then the co-variance of x to Y on the
right side we can see the covariance
table for more than two attributes in a
multi-dimensional data set
set this is what I was talking about we
usually are looking at uh not just one
feature or two features we're usually
looking at 25 30 features going on and
so if we do a setup like this we should
see all those different features as the
different
variables covariance Matrix tells us how
the two or more variables are related
positive covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is directly
proportional to the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not and then we have the ige
values and the ige vectors igene values
and igene vectors are the mathematical
value that are extracted from the
co-variance table they are responsible
for the generation of a new set of
variables from the old set of variables
which further lead to the the
construction of the principal components
IG vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation IG values
are the scalars or the magnitude of the
ige vectors and again this is just ch
transforming that data so we're going to
change uh the vector B to the B Prime as
denoted on the chart and so when we have
like multiple variables how do we
calculate that new variable and then we
have feature vectors feature vectors is
simply a matrix that has IG vectors of
the components that we decide to keep as
the
columns here we decide whether we must
keep or discard the less significant
principal components that we have
generated in the above steps this
becomes really important as we start
looking at U the back end of this and
we'll do this in the demo uh but one of
the more important steps to
understand and so we have the PCA
example consider Matrix x with within
rows or observations and K columns or
variables now for this Matrix we would
construct a variable space with as many
dimensions as the
variable but for our Simplicity let's
consider this three dimensions for
now now each observation row of the
Matrix X is placed in the K dimensional
variable space such that the rows in the
data table form a swarm of points in
this
space now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the
plot the first principal component is a
line the best accounts for the shape of
the point swarm it represents the
maximum variance Direction in the
data each observation may be projected
onto this line in order to get a
coordinate value along the pc1 this
value is known as a
score usually only one principal
component is insufficient to model the
systematic variation for a data set thus
a second principal axis is
created the second principal component
is oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthagonal to pc1
PC2 also passes through the average
Point let's go ahead and pull this up
and just see what that means uh inside
our python
scripting I'm going to use the Anaconda
Navigator and I will be in Python 3. 6
for this example I believe there's even
like a 3.9 out I tend to stay in 3.6
because a lot of the models I use
especially with the neural networks are
stable in
36 and then we open up our uh Jupiter
I'm in Chrome and go ahead and create a
new Python
3 and for ease of use uh our team in the
back was nice enough to put this
together for me and we'll go and start
with the libraries the first thing I
like to do whenever I'm looking at any
new setup uh well you know what Let's do
let's do the libraries first we're going
to do our basic libraries which is Matt
plot Library uh the PT from the M plot
Library pandas our data frame uh PD
numpy our numbers array NP caborn for
graphing SNS that goes with the plot
that actually sits on Matt plot Library
so the Seaborn sits on there
and then we have our Amber sign because
we're in jupyter Notebook map plot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that um but I
put it in there either anyway just
because I'm so used to
it and then we want to go ahead and take
a look at the
data and in this case we're going to
pull in uh certainly you can have lots
of fun with different data but we're
going to use the cancer data set uh one
of the reasons a cancer data set is is
it has like 36 35 different features so
it's kind of fun to use that as our base
for this and we'll go ahead and run this
and look at our
keys and the first thing we notice in
our keys for the cancer data set uh is
we have our data we have our Target our
frame Target names description feature
names and file
name so what we're looking for in all
this is um well let's take a look at the
description let's go in here and pull up
the description on here
I'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description um because this
is we don't want to get into a medical
domain we want to focus on our PCA setup
uh what's important is you start looking
at what the different attributes are
what they mean um if you were in the
medical field you'd want to note all
these different things whether what
they're measuring where it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different um measurements are
taking no missing a
attributes we page all the way to the
bottom and you're going to have your
data in this case our
Target and if you dig deep enough to the
Target uh let's actually do this let's
go ahead and print Target
names real quick here I always like to
to just take a look and see what's on
the other end of this uh
Target
names run
that and so the target name is is it
malignant or is it B9 um so in other
words is this uh dangerous growth or is
it something we don't have to worry
about that's the bottom line with the
cancer in this
case and then we can go ahead and load
our data and uh you know what let me go
up a just a notch here for easy of
reading it's hard to get that just right
I guess I'll be have to do uh so let's
go ahead and look at our data uh our our
we're going to use our pandas and we're
going to go ahead and uh do our data
frame it's going to equal cancer data
columns equals cancer feature equals
feature names so remember up here we
already loaded the the um names up of
our of the features in there what is
going to come out of this let me just
see if I can get to
that it's at the top of Target names um
that's just this list of names here in
the
setup and we can go ahead and run this
code and it'll print the head and you
can see here we have the mean radius the
mean texture mean perimeter I don't know
about you this is a wonderful data set
if you're playing with it because like
many of the data that most of the data
that comes in half the time we don't
even know what we're looking at uh we're
just handed a bunch of stuff as a data
scientist going what the heck is this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there and we have no idea
what these feature means or where they
come from we want to just look at the
data and figure that
out and now we actually are getting into
the PCA side of it as we've noticed
before it is difficult to visualize
high-dimensional data we can use PCA to
find the first two principal components
and visualize the data this new
two-dimensional space with a single
scatter plot uh before we do this we
need to go ahead and scale our
data now
I haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this um but as
just a
general runtime I almost do that as the
first step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here um in
neural networks that is so important
with PCA visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the PCA uh but just
in case it's always good to scale it and
and then we're going to take our uh PCA
with the pyit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with pyit learn we
instantiate a PCA object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to keep when creating
the PCA
object and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit
ahead let me go and run this code uh so
the code for
this is from sklearn decomposition
import PCA PCA equals PCA in components
equals two and that's really important
to note that um because we're only going
to want to look at two
components I would never go over four
components uh especially if you're going
to demo this with somebody else if
you're showing this to the shareholder
there the whole idea is to reduce it to
something people can
see uh and then the PCA fit we're going
to uh is going to take the scale data
that we generated up here and then you
can see we've created our PCA model with
in components equals
two now whenever I use a new tool I like
to go in there and actually see what I'm
using so let's go to the pit uh web page
for the
PCA and you can see in here here's our
call statement it describes what all the
different uh setups you have on
there probably the biggest one to look
at would be um well the biggest one is
your components how many components do
you want uh which you have to put in
there pretty much and then you also
might look at the SVD solver it's on
auto right now but you can override that
and do different things with it it does
a pretty good job as it
is and if we go down all the way down
to
um here we go to our methods if you
notice we have fit we have fit
transform nowhere in here is predict
because this is not used for prediction
uh it's used to look at the data again
we're in the describe setup we're
fitting the data we're taking a look at
it uh we've already looked at our
minimum Max we've already looked at
what's in each quarter we've done a full
description of the data this is part of
describing the data um that's the
biggest thing I take away when I come
zooming in here and of course they have
examples of it down here if you
forget um and the biggest one of course
is the number of components and then uh
I mean the rest you can play with um the
actual solver whether you're doing a
full or randomize there's different
things it does pretty good on the
auto and now we can transform this data
to its first two principal
components and so we have our um X
PCA we're going to set that equal to PCA
transform scaled
data uh so there we go there's our first
transformation and let's just go ahead
and print the scaled data shape and the
X PCA data
shape and the reason we want to do this
is just to show us
um what's going on here we've taken 30
features I think I said 36 or something
like that but it's 30 and we've
compressed it down to two features and
we decided we wanted two features and
that's where this comes from uh we still
have 569 data sets I mean data rows not
data sets we still have 569 rows of data
but instead of computing 30 features
we're now only doing our model on two
features
so let's go ahead and uh uh plot these
and take a look and see what's going
on and
uh we're just going to use our PLT
figure we're going to set the figure
size on here here's our scatter plot um
X
PCA xor PCA of uh of one these are our
two different perceptions we're using uh
and then you'll see right here see for
color cancer equals Target and so
remember we have zero we have one and if
I remember correctly zero was malignant
one was
B9 uh so everything in the zero column
is going to be one color and the other
color is going to be one and then we're
going to use the plasma map just kind of
telling you what color it is add some
labels first principal component second
principal component we'll go and run
this and you can see here instead of
having a chart one of those heat maps
with 30 different columns in it we can
look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good
job of separating the
data and a couple things when I'm
looking at this that I notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together um where it's going to
be B9 and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be uh malignant or I think
I had that backwards and then in the
middle because we're dealing with
something in this particular case cancer
we would try to separate I would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out in other words there's an area
where everything overlaps and we're not
going to have a clear result on it uh
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently versus going in
and saying just cutting into the can
into the cancer so the body of absorbs
it and it dissipates versus uh actively
going in there removing it testing it
going through chemo and all the
different things that's a big difference
you know as far as what's going to
happen here in that middle line where
they overlap is going to be huge that's
domain specific uh going back to the
data we can see here uh clearly by using
these two components we can easily
separate these two classes so the next
step is what does that mean interpreting
the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes the cost
of not being able to easily understand
what these components represent I don't
know what principal component one looks
represents or second principle the
components correspond to combinations of
original features the components
themselves are stored as an attribute of
the filtered PCA object and so when we
talk look at that we can go ahead and do
a look at the PCA components this is in
our model we built we trained it we can
run that and you can see here's the
actual components uh it's the two
components have each have their own
array and within the array you can see
the um what the scores they're using and
these actually give weight to what
features are doing
what so in this numpy Matrix array each
row represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features what's really neat about this
is we can now go in
reverse and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing uh what this means and
so let me go ahead and just put this
down oops I already got it down
here uh we go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our um DF comp data
frame and we do our PCA
components and I want you to notice how
easy this is uh we're going to set our
columns equal to cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy and we're
dumping it into a data frame what's neat
about a data frame is when we get to
Seaborn it will pull that data frame
apart and uh and set it up for us way we
want and so we're just going to do the
CN the caborn heat map of our data frame
uh composition and we'll use the plasma
coloring and it creates a nice little
color graph here you can see we have the
mean radius and all the different
features along the bottom on the right
uh we have a scale so we can see we have
the dark colors all the way to the
really light colors which are what's
really shining there this is like the
primary stuff we want to look
at so this heat map and the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component
itself so you know very powerful map to
look at and then you can go in here and
we might notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is um on some of this uh so you have
some interesting correlations here that
change the variations on that and what
means what this is more when you get to
uh uh
postribosomal bias and variance what is
overfitting what is underfitting and
those are like the biggest things right
now in data science is overfitting and
underfitting what does that mean and
what is regularization and then we'll do
a quick Hands-On demo to take a look at
this so fitting the data let's start
with fitting the data and we talk about
uh what is data fitting it's a process
of plotting a series of data points and
drawing the best fit line to understand
the relationship between the variables
and this is what we called Data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph we're
going to go in a little deeper on there
uh so we might have in this case just a
two Dimensions we have an efficiency of
the car and we have the distance
traveled in 1,000
kilometers and so what is data fitting
well it's a linear relationship and a
linear
relationship very specifically linear
means line uh the line used to represent
the relationship ship is a straight line
that passes through the data points and
the variables have linear
relationship linear
regression so let's start with uh how
linear regression Works a linear
regression uh finds the line that best
fits the data point and gives a
relationship between the two
variables and so you can see here we
have the efficiency of the car um versus
the distance traveled and you can see a
nice straight line drawn through there
and when you talk about multi mulle
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line it now becomes a
plane it gets a little more complicated
with multiple variables but they all
come down to this linear kind of uh
drawing a line through your data and
finding what fits the the data the
best and so we can consider an example
uh let's say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream and we're looking at how
warm it is outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store and suppose we have two lines
we're going to draw L1 and L2 and we're
going to kind of guess which one we
think is the best fit and which claim to
describe the relationship between the
variables and so first we find the
square of the distance between the line
L1 and each data point and add them all
and find the mean
distance and I want you if think about
that when we um uh Square something if
it's a negative or positive number it no
longer matters because a minus 2^ 2ar is
4 2^2 is 4 so we're removing what side
of the line it's on and we're just
looking for the error in this case the
mean distance of each of the little
dotted lines you see
here this way of calculating the square
of the distance adding them and then
taking the mean is called mean square
error or loss function and we about loss
how far off are we that's what we're
really talking about what did we miss uh
and we have a positive distance and a
negative distance and of course when we
Square it it is neither it just becomes
a positive
error and so we take the mean square
error and a lot of times you'll see it
referred to as msse uh if I look in a
code and I'm going through my python
code and I see MSE I know that's a mean
squared error and we take all the dotted
lines and we calculate this error we add
them all together and then we average it
or find the
means and in this case they ran a demo
on this and it was uh 1,1
127.23 uh for our L1 line now we find
the loss function for line L2 in a
similar fashion and we get the mean
square error to be
6,397 and it's computed the same way so
maybe you put this line just way outside
the data range and this is the error you
get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function or the mean square
error is less for L1 than L2 hence L1 is
the best fit
line uh this process describes a lot of
machine learning processes is we're
going to keep guessing and get as close
as we can to find the right answer we
have to have some way to invi to um
calculate this and figure out which
one's the best and the mean square error
is one of the better fits to doing for
doing this and most commonly
used we really want to talk about bias
and variance very important terms to
know in machine learning and with linear
regression so bias bias occurs when an
algorithm has limited flexibility to
learn from
data variance defines the algorithm
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have um the two
different setups uh bias you can think
is very generalized where variance is
very
specific uh and so when we talk about
bias such models pay very little
attention to the training data and
oversimplify the model therefore the
validation error or prediction error and
training error follow similar
Trends and uh with bias if you
oversimplify it so much you're going
going to miss your um local uh if if you
have like a really good fit you're going
to miss it you're you're going to just
kind of guess what the average is and
that's what your answer is going to
be with variance a model with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other such models always lead to a high
error on training and test data as a
bias does where variance such models
usually perform very well on training
data but have high error rates on test
data and I want you to think about this
um when we're talking about a bias uh
the error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of getting
an average we're not really fitting it
close with variance we're fitting it so
close that the test data does really
good it's going to nail it every time uh
if you're doing categorical testing
that's a car that's a truck that's a
bicycle um but with variant suddenly a
truck has to have certain features and
it might have to be red uh because you
had so many red pictures so if it has if
it's an 18-wheeler it has to be red if
it's uh blue then it has to be a bicycle
that's the kind of variance we're
talking about where it picks up on
something and it it cannot get the right
answer unless it gets a very specific
data
and we see that so that as you're
testing it your models and you
programmed it you got to look for how I
trained it what is coming out and if
it's not if it's not looking good on
either bias or or if it's not looking
good on the training or on the test data
then your bias uh than your bias in your
data if it really looks good on the
training data then that's going to be
your variance you've overfitted the data
and those are very important things to
know when you are building your models
uh in regression of any kind or any kind
of uh setup for
predicting so in dark games if all the
data fall on a particular pointer this
can be considered as a biased throw and
the player aims for the particular score
for variance if all the darts fall on
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer then this can be S
considered as a varied throw and the
player aims for various
scores uh again the bias sums everything
up in one point kind of averages it to
together where the variance really looks
for the individual uh predictions coming
out so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting uh when we talk about
overfitting it's a scenario where the
machine learning model tries to learn
from the details along with the noise
and the data tries to fit each data
point on the curve uh you can see that
um if you plug in your coordinates
you're just going to get the whatever
it's fitted every point on the data
stream there's no average there's no two
points that might have the you mean know
why might have two different answers
because uh if the wind blows a certain
way um and your efficiency of your car
maybe you have a headwind so your car
might alter how efficient it is as it
goes and so there's going to be this
variance on here and this says no you
can't have any variance with you know
the this is it's going to be exactly
this it can't be any you can't be the
same speed or the same car and have a
slightly different
efficiency
so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the
prediction uh so you'll get like a
really high error on
here and so uh reasons for overfitting
uh data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage values in it
you can spend so much time cleaning your
data and it's so important it's so
important that if you have if you have
some kind of something wrong with the
data coming in it needs to be addressed
whether it's a source of the data maybe
they use in medical different measuring
tools uh so you now have to adjust for
data that came in from hospital a versus
Hospital b or even off of machine a and
machine B that's testing something and
those those numbers are coming in
wrong the model has a high variance uh
again wind is a good example I was
talking about that with the car you may
have 100 tests but because the wind's
blowing it's all over the
place uh size of training data used is
not enough so a small amount of data is
going to also cause this problem you
only have a few points and you try to
plot everything the model is too complex
uh this comes up a lot we put too many
pieces together and how they interact
can't even be tracked um and so you have
to go back back break it up and find out
actually what correlates and what
doesn't
so what is underfitting a scenario where
machine learning models can neither
learn the relationship between the data
points nor predict or classify a new
data point and you can see here we have
our efficiency of our car and our line
drawn and it's just going to be way off
for both the training and the predicting
data as the model doesn't fully learn
the patterns it accepts every new data
point during the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern uh we just kind of accept
everything data used for training is not
cleaned and contains noise garbage and
values again underfitting and
overfitting same issue you got to clean
your
data the model has a high bias uh we've
seen this in all kinds of things
from uh the mo the most common is the
driving cars to facial identification or
or whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model would have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have um five people from India and 10
people from um Africa and 20 people from
the US you've created a bias uh because
it's looking at the 20 people and you
only have a small amount of data to work
with size of training data used is not
enough uh that goes with the size I was
just talking about so we have a model
with a high bias we have size of
training data used it's not enough the
model is too
simple again this a one straight line
through all the data when it needs has a
slight shift to it for other
reasons so what is a good fit uh a
linear curve that best fits the data is
neither overfitting or underfitting
models but is just right and of course
we have the nice example here where we
have overfitting lines going up and down
every Point's starting to be include
included
underfitting uh the line really is off
from where the data is and then a good
fit is got to get rid of that minimize
that um error coming through
regularization is taking the guesswork
out you're looking at this graph and
you're going oh which one is that really
overfit or is that underfit that was
pretty hard to
tell so we talk about
regularization regularization techniques
are used to calibrate the linear
regression models and to minimize the
adjusted loss function and prevent
overfitting or
underfitting so what that means uh in
this case we're going to go ahead and
take a look at a couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model
we'll look at the Ridge regularization
and the lasso
regularization and these models are just
like uh just like we did the um MLP the
multi-layered positron in the sklearn
module you could bring in the ridge
module and you can bring in the lassel
module so when we talk about um Ridge
regression it modifies the overfitted or
underfitted models by adding the penalty
equivalent to the sum of the squares of
the magnitude of the
coefficients and so we have a cost
function equals loss equals uh Lambda
time the sum of W squared or the
absolute value of w depending on how
you're doing it now remember we talked
about error where we either Square it or
we absolute value it uh because it
removes a plus or minus sign on there
and there's reasons to do it either way
but it is more common to square the
value and then we have our uh um in this
case the Lambda is going to be the
penalty for the errors we've thrown in a
Greek character for you just to confuse
everybody and W is the slope of the
curve of the
line so uh we're going to look at this
and we're going to draw a line this is
going to be like a linear regression
model so if you had in sklearn you could
import just a standard linear regression
model uh it would plot this line across
whatever data we're working
on and we look at this and of course
we're just extrapolating this um I I
know they use some specific data but we
don't want to get into the actual domain
and so for a linear regression line
let's consider two points that are on
the
line and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equal zero uh considering the two points
on the line we'll go and do Lambda equal
1 we'll set our W is going to be
1.4 then the cost function equals 0 + 1
* 1.42 which equal
1.96 uh so really don't get caught up
too much in the math on this other than
understanding um that this is something
that's very easy for a computer to
calculate and if you ever see the loss
plus the plus the Lambda time W the sum
of w^2
and then let's say we have a ridge uh
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the
data and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals. 3^2 +22 = .13 so
when they put all the calculations
through of the two points we end up with
a 0.0
62 uh so we now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model and the ridge regression model
plots a little differently than the
standard linear regression
model and comparing the two models with
all the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression
line and I find this true on a lot of
data I work with I'll end up using
either the ridge regression model or the
lasso uh Mars regression model for
fitting um especially dealing with a lot
of like uh stock markets daily um setup
they come out slightly better you get a
slightly better um
fit and so we have our lasso we just
talked about lasso coming in
here and the cost function equals uh um
instead of doing a squared we're just
going to do the absolute value and so if
you remember this is where Ridge
regression changes where's my Ridge
regression model uh we're squaring the
value
here and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of the of the the squared
individuals um and here is
our Lambda symbol again penalty for
errors and W equals the slope of the
curve and comparing the two models with
all the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression
line and this is like I said I I use
these two models a lot uh the Ridge and
this is important this is this is kind
of the med to the matter how do you know
which one to use some of it is you just
do it a bunch of times and then you
figure it out uh Ridge regularization is
useful when we have many variables with
relatively smaller data samples the
bottle does not encourage convergence
towards zero but is likely to make them
closer to zero and prevent
overfitting the Lasser regularization
model is preferred when we are fitting a
linear model with fewer
variables so in the in the iris thing we
had four or five variables as they
measured the different Leaf pieces uh
you might be doing the measurements on
the cancer project which has 36
different
variables um so as we get down to the
iris with four variables lolar will
probably uh work pretty good where you
might use the ridge regularization with
more model with if you have something uh
significantly larger and it encourages
the coefficients of the variables to go
toward zero because of the shape of the
constraint which is an absolute
value and with any of this we want to go
ahead and uh do a demo and lasto in
Ridge regression so let's take a look
and see what that looks like in our code
and bring up our Jupiter notebook we'll
start with our Imports pandas as PD
import numpy as NP import map plot
Library as PLT um sklearn we're going to
import our data sets it's kind of more
generic um we usually just import one
data set instead of all of them but you
know quick and dirty when you're putting
some of these together uh we have our
sklearn model selection we're going to
import our train test split for
splitting our data up and then we'll
bring in our linear regression
model and we'll go ahead and run these
just to load them up and then load our
data set we were just talking about that
uh you could just um um have imported
the load Boston and Boston data set in
there instead of loading all the data
sets
um and then once we've loaded our data
set we want to go ahead and take a look
at that data and see what we got here
let me just go and pop that down there
and go and run it and so we've gone
ahead and taken our uh Boston uh data
we're going to load we put it into our
pandas data frame um the Boston data set
and then the Boston columns we want to
see what's going on with them um we have
our Target we have the house price uh
Etc and our x equals Boston um
iocation now remember in pandas the new
updates to pandas they want iocation if
you're going to pull data we used to be
able to leave this off but it does
something different it creates a slice
versus a direct um setup so make sure
using that ey location and the I the
output so this is all just bringing our
data
together and we can see here if we do uh
we print the Boston um Panda's head we
we can see here all of our different um
aspects we're looking
for and if you're following the X and
the Y the x is um
everything except for the last column
where Y is uh all the it's that's what
this means all the rows except for the
last column and then Y is all the rows
but just the last column so Y is our
house price and the x is the Prim Zan
industry Chaz Knox and all these other
different um statistics they've
collected for house sales in
Boston there we go oops control
ah so we'll go ahead and split our data
uh XT train and our x uh test YT train y
test equals the train test split which
we imported and we have our Boston U you
could have easily used the X and Y on
here as opposed to Boston um
ication and we'll create our test size
we're going to take 25% of the data and
put it in as a
test uh and then we'll go ahead and run
this
uh need an extra drink there uh so we
have our train and test and then of
course the print the train data
shape I love doing this kind of thing
whenever I'm working with this data
print out the shape make sure everything
looks correct uh so that we have 127 by
133 and 127 by 1 379 by 13 they should
match and if they're if the the data
sets are not quite matching then you
know something's wrong and you're going
to get all those errors I don't know how
many times I've gone through here and
it's dropped a row on one of them and
not on the other or something weird has
happened when I'm cleaning the data this
is pretty straightforward and simple
because the data comes in a nice
prepackage it's all clean for
you so let's go ahead and apply apply
the multiple linear regression
model and uh we'll call this l r lre
linear regression we're going to go
ahead and fit that linear regression
model to X train and Y
train then we'll generate the prediction
on the test Set uh so here's our lre y
predict with our X test going into the
prediction and let's calculate that mean
Square eror MSE I told you you'll see
MSE used a lot um people use it in
variables and things like that it's
pretty common and we get our mean
squared error equals uh this is just the
basic formula we've already been talking
about what's the difference
squared uh then we look for the average
of that we'll go ahead and just run
this and you can see when we get through
the end of this we have our mean square
error on
test we have our total and then we have
each column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with it's not
going to mean a whole lot so if it's in
your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see see these
kinds of numbers coming up uh but if
it's not it's just a bunch of numbers
and that's okay at least that's okay for
this demo uh and then we're going to go
ahead and plot these so we can see
what's going on and this is always kind
of fun it's always nice to have a nice
visual of what you're looking at and you
can see here uh
we plot the coefficient scores on here
and we the guys in the back did a great
job putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice and setting up the
columns you can see here uh your nox has
like just a huge coefficient um when I
look at a table like this I look for
what has very
little um different coefficients they're
not using a huge change and what has
huge changes and that Flags you for all
kinds of things as you're working with
the data but it depends so much on the
domain you're working with these are
great things though as a just a quick
look to see what's going on with your
data and what you're looking
for and of course once we look at this
now our motive is to reduce the
coefficient score so now we want to take
these and and uh bring them down as much
as we can and for that we're going to
work with the ridge regression on here
so let's start by go ahead and we're
going to import our Ridge model
the rid regression from the sklearn
library or the S kit and we're going to
go ahead and train the model so here's
our Ridge um R equals Alpha equals 1 and
I mentioned that earlier um when I work
with the ridge model you'll see Alpha
equals 1 if you set Alpha equal to zero
that's a standard linear regression
model so you have Alpha equals 1 2 3 4
and you usually use 1 two or 3 four and
a standard integer on there and we'll go
ahead and fit the ridge model on there
with our X train and our y train data
generate a prediction for that um for
our X test and we'll calculate the mean
square error uh just like we did before
this should all look
familiar and we'll go ahead and print
that out and we'll look at the uh Ridge
coefficients for our data and see what
that looks
like now if I jump up and down between
these
two you'll get a headache uh
you'll still see the nox value let's
just look at the nox because that was
the biggest value was a minus 9 here and
if we go back up here the nox value is a
minus 18 so right off the bat I'm seeing
a huge change um in the biggest
coefficient
there uh so if we're going to do that
nice setup we want to go ahead and just
print it and see what that looks
like
here we go and we've uh set up our um
plot subplots and again the team put
together some nice color so it makes it
look good we're doing an xar based on
the
columns and our um L regress
coefficients color equals color a spine
bottom and so forth uh so just puts
together a nice little
graph and you're starting to see uh one
this when you compare this if you put on
the same graph as this one up here this
is up here at minus8
this is at Min - 99 and so this graph is
half the size of the graph above uh the
same thing with these values here they
might look the same but they're actually
all um almost half the value on
here and then finally you can do the
same thing for the lasso
regression this will all look uh very
similar as far as what we worked on
before and I'm just going to ahead and
print that on here and run it and again
let's go up to uh KNX look where KNX is
it's all the way down to zero and if we
look at our next biggest coefficient is
minus8 and really here's our
22.73 we go up
here um
16.7 and we go up here and we look at
the same number uh
16.69% look at this uh if I was running
this and doing a working on a project
with this I would look at these numbers
I start with the 16. 69 uh come down
here and compare it to uh
16.78% is Central and the other ones
aren't quite as good and so we might
start looking at just certain setups
like what is our what is this particular
coefficient because it might have a
certain meaning to us and so forth and
so you got to look at all those
different thing um items in there again
but the bottom dollar is our first model
did better than our other two models our
mean square error on the test set um
continues to come down on this we're
going to cover reinforcement learning
today and what's for you we'll start
with why reinforcement learning we'll
look at what is reinforcement learning
we'll see what the different kinds of
learning strategies are that are being
used today in computer models under
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement we'll cover important
terms specific to reinforcement learning
we'll talk about markov's decision
process and we'll take a look at a
reinforcement learning example but we'll
teach a tic-tac-toe how to play why
reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us further the data provided might
not be reliable learning from a small
subset of actions will not help expand
the vast realm of solutions that may
work for a particular problem and you
can see here we have the robot learning
to walk um very complicated setup when
you're learning how to walk and you'll
start asking questions like if I'm
taking one step forward and left what
happens if I pick up a 50 lb object how
does that change how a robot would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular
problem and we'll see here it learned
how to walk this is going to slow the
growth that technology is capable of
machines need to learn to perform
actions by themselves and not just learn
off humans
and you see the objective climb a
mountain real interesting point here is
that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment and we can
adjust for it and kind of explore and
play with it most of the models the
non-reinforcement models in computer uh
machine learning aren't able to do that
very well uh there's a couple of them
that can be used or integrated see how
it goes is what we're talking about with
re enforcement learning so what is
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is a subbranch of machine
learning that trains the model to return
an Optimum solution for a problem by
taking a sequence of decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another the robot is given a
scenario and must arrive at a solution
by itself the robot can take different
paths to reach the
destination it will know the best path
by the time taken on each path and might
might even come up with a unique
solution all by itself and that's really
important is we're looking for Unique
Solutions uh we want the best solution
but you can't find it unless you try it
so we're looking at uh our different
systems our different model we have
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning and with the
supervised learning that is probably the
most controlled environment uh we have a
lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks um there's all kinds of
things in between decision trees the
data provided is labeled data with
output values specified and this is
important because when we talk about
supervised learning you already know the
answer for all this information you
already know the picture has a
motorcycle in it so you're supervised
learning you already know that um the
outcome for tomorrow for you know going
back a week you're looking at stock you
can already have like the graph of what
the next day looks like so you have an
answer for
it and you have labeled data which is
used you have an external supervision
and solves Problems by mapping labeled
input to No One output so very
controlled unsupervised learning and
unsupervised learning is really
interesting because it's now taking part
in many other models they start with an
you can actually insert an unsupervised
learning model um in almost either
supervised or reinforcement learning as
part of the system which is really cool
uh data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions used to solve
association with clustering problems
unlabeled data used no supervision
solves Problems by understanding
patterns and discovering
output uh so you can look at this and
you can think um some of these things go
with each other they belong together so
it's looking for what connects in
different ways and there's a lot of
different algorithms that look at this
um when you start getting into those are
some really cool images that come up of
what unsupervised learning is how it can
pick out say uh the area of a donut one
model will see the area of the donut and
the other one will divide it into three
sections based on this location versus
what's next to it so there's a lot of
stuff that goes in with unsupervised
learning and then we're looking at
reinforcement learning probably the
biggest industry in today's market uh in
machine learning or growing Market it's
very it's very infant stage uh as far as
how it works and what it's going to be
capable of
the machine learns from its environment
using rewards and errors used to solve
reward based problems no predefined data
is used no supervision follows Trail and
error problem solving approach uh so
again we have a random at first you
start with a random I try this it works
and this is my reward doesn't work very
well maybe or maybe it doesn't even get
you where you're trying to get it to do
and you get your reward back and then it
looks at that and says well let's try
something else and it starts to play
with these different things finding the
best route so let's take a look at
important terms in today's reinforcement
model and this has become pretty
standardized over the last uh few years
so these are really good to know we have
the agent uh agent is the model that is
being trained via reinforcement learning
so this is your actual U entity that has
however you're doing it with using a
neural network or a q table or whatever
combination thereof this this is the
actual agent that you're using this is
the
model and you have your environment uh
the training situation that the model
must optimized to is called its
environment uh and you can see here I
guess we have a robot who's trying to
get a chest full of gems or whatever and
that's the output and then you have your
action this is all possible steps that
can be taken by the model and it picks
one action and you can see here it's
picked three different uh routes to get
to the chest of diamonds and
gems we have a state the current
position condition returned by the
model and you could look at this uh if
you're playing like a video game this is
the screen you're looking at uh so when
you go back here uh the environment is a
whole game board so if you're playing
one of those Mobius games you might have
the whole game board going on uh but
then you have your current position
where are you on that game board what's
around that what's around you um if you
were talking about a robot the
environment might be moving around the
yard where it is in the yard and what it
can see what input it has in that
location that would be the current
position condition returned by the model
and then the reward uh to help the model
move in the right direction it is
rewarded points are given to it to
appraise some kind of action so yeah you
did good or if uh didn't do as good
trying to maximize the reward and have
the best reward
possible and then policy policy
determines how an agent will be behave
at any time it acts as a mapping between
action and present State this is part of
the model what what is your action that
you're you're going to take what's the
policy you're using to have an output
from your agent one of the reasons they
separate uh policy as its own entity is
that you usually have a prediction um of
a different options and then the policy
well how am I going to pick the best
based on those predictions I'm going to
guess at different op options and we'll
actually weigh those options in and find
the best option we think will work uh so
it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works let's go Ahad and take a look at a
reinforcement learning example and just
in looking at this we're going to take a
look uh consider what a dog um that we
want to train uh so the dog would be
like the agent so you have your your
puppy or whatever uh and then your
environment is going to be the whole
house or whatever it is you're training
them and then you have an action we want
to teach the dog to
fetch so action equals fetching uh and
then we have a little biscuit so we can
get the dog to perform various actions
by offering incentives such as a dog
biscuit as a
reward the dog will follow a policy to
maximize this reward and hence will
follow every command and might even
learn new actions like begging by itself
uh so you have B you know so we start
off with fetching it goes oh I get a
biscuit for that it tries something else
and you get a handshake or begging or
something like that and it goes oh this
is also reward-based and so it kind of
explores things to find out what will
bring it is biscuit and that's very much
like how a reinforced model goes is it
uh looks for different rewards how do I
find can I try different things and find
a reward that
works the dog also will want to run
around and play and explore his
environment uh this quality of model is
called exploration so there's a little
Randomness going on in Exploration
and explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the
sofa so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process uh markov's
decision process is a reinforcement
learning policy used to map a current
state to an action where the agent
continuously interacts with the
environment to produce new Solutions and
receive rewards and you'll see here's
all of our different uh vocabulary we
just went over we have a reward our
state our agent our environment inter
our action and so even though the
environment kind of contains everything
um that you you really when you're
actually writing the program your
environment's going to put out a reward
in state that goes into the agent uh the
agent then looks at this uh state or it
looks at the reward usually um first and
it says okay I got rewarded for whatever
I just did or I didn't get rewarded and
then it looks at the state then it comes
back and if you remember from policy the
policy comes in um and then we have a
reward the policy is that part that's
connected at the bottom and so it looks
at that policy and it says hey what's a
good action that will probably be
similar to what I did or um uh sometimes
they're completely random but what's a
good action that's going to bring me a
different
reward so taking the time to just
understand these different pieces as
they go is pretty important in most of
the models today um and so a lot of them
actually have templates based on this
you can pull in and start using um
pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works uh you can
see your environment send it says hey
this is the agent did this if you're a
character in a game this happened and it
shoots out a reward in a state the agent
looks at the reward looks at the new
state and then takes a little guess and
says say I'm going to try this action
and then that action goes back into the
environment it affects the environment
the environment then changes depending
on what the action was and then it has a
new state and a new reward that goes
back to the agent so in the diagram
shown we need to find the shortest path
between Noe A and D each path has a
reward associated with it and the path
with a maximum reward is what we want to
choose the nodes AB b c d denote the
nodes to travel from node uh A to B is
an action reward is the cost of each
path and policy is each path
taken and you can see here a can go uh
to b or a can go to C right off the bat
or it can go right to D and if explored
all three of these uh you would find
that a going to D was a zero reward um a
going to C and D would generate a
different reward or you could go AC b d
there's a lot of options here um and so
when we start looking at at this diagram
you start to
realize that even though uh today's
reinforced learning models do really
good uh um finding an answer they end up
trying almost all the different
directions you see and so they take up a
lot of work uh or a lot of processing
time for reinforcement learning they're
right now in their infant stage and
they're really good at solving simple
problems and we'll take a look at one of
those in just a minute in a tic tac toe
game uh but you can see here uh once
it's gone through through these and it's
explored it's going to find the
ACD is the best reward it gets a full 30
points for it so let's go ahead and take
a look at a reinforcement learning
demo uh in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a tic tac
toe game you'll be playing this game
Against the Machine learning
model and we'll go ahead and we're doing
it in Python so let's go ahead and go
through I always uh not always actually
have a lot of python tools let's go
through um Anaconda which will open up a
Jupiter notebook seems like a lot of
steps but it's worth it to keep all my
stuff separate and it's also has a nice
display when you're in the Jupiter
notebook for doing
python so here's our Anaconda Navigator
I open up the notebook which is going to
take me to a web page and I've gone in
here and created a new uh python folder
in this case I've already done it and
enabled it to change the name to
tic-tac-toe uh and then for this example
uh we're going to go ahead and
import a couple things we're going to um
import numpy as NP we'll go ahead and
import pickle numpy of course is our
number array and then uh pickle is just
a nice way sometimes for storing uh
different information uh different
states that we're going to go through on
here uh and so we're going to create a
class called State we're going to start
with
that and there's a lot of lines of code
to this uh class that we're going to put
in here don't let that scare you too
much there's not as much here um it
looks like there's going to be a lot
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in our class date
and so we have up here we're going to
initialize it um we have our board um
it's a Tic Tac Toe board so we're only
dealing with nine spots on the board uh
we have player one player
two uh is end we're going to create a
board hash uh we'll look at that in just
a minute we're just going to stir some
information in there symbol of player
equals one um so there's a few things
going on as far as the
initialization uh then something simple
we're just going to get the hash um of
the board we're going get the
information from the board on there
which is uh columns and rows we want to
know when a winner occurs uh so if you
get three in a row that's what this
whole section here is for um me go ahead
and scroll up a little bit and you can
get a copy of this code if you send a
note over to simply learn we'll send you
over um this particular file and you can
play with it yourself and see how it's
put together I don't want to spend a
huge amount of time on this uh because
this is just some real General python
coding uh but you can see here we're
just going through um all the rows and
you add them together and if it equals
three three in a row same thing with
columns uh diagonal so you got to check
the diagonal that's what all this stuff
does here is it just goes through the
different areas actually let me go ahead
and
put there we
go um and then it comes down here and we
do our sum and it says true uh minus
three just says did somebody win or is
it a tie so you got to add up all the
numbers on there anyway just in case
they're all filled up and next we also
need to know available positions um
these are ones that don't no one's ever
used before this way when you try
something or the computer tries
something uh it's not going to give it
an illegal move that's what the
available positions is doing uh then we
want to update our state and so you have
your position going in we're just
sending in the position that you just
chose and you'll see there's a little
user interface we put in there you P
pick the row and column in
there and again I mean this is a lot of
code uh so really it's kind of a thing
you'd want to go through and play with a
little bit and just read through it get
a copy of it uh great way to understand
how this works and here is a given
reward um so we're going to give a
reward result equals self winner this is
one of the hearts of what's going on
here uh is we have have a result self.
winner so if there's a winner then we
have a result if the result equals one
here's our
feedback uh if it doesn't equal one then
it gets a zero so it only gets a reward
in this particular case if it
wins and that's important to know
because different uh systems of
reinforced learning do rewarding a lot
differently depending on what you're
trying to do this is a very simple
example with a a 3X3 board imagine if
you're playing a video game uh certainly
you only have so many actions but your
environment is huge you have a lot going
on in the environment and suddenly a
reward system like this is going to be
just um it's going to have to change a
little bit it's going to have to have
different rewards and different setup
and there's all kinds of advanced ways
to do that as far as weighing you add
weights to it and so they can add the
weights up depending on where the reward
comes in so it might be that you
actually get a reward in this case you
get the reward at the end of the game
and I'm spending just a little bit of
time on this because this is an
important thing to note but there's
different ways to add up those rewards
it might have like if you take a certain
path um the first reward is going to be
weighed a little bit less than the last
reward because the last reward is
actually winning the game or scoring or
whatever it is so this reward system
gets really complicated on some of the
more advanced uh
setups um in this case though you can
see right here that they give a um a 0.1
and a 0. five
reward um just for getting a picking the
right value and something that's
actually valid instead of picking an
invalid value so rewards again that's
like key it's huge how do you feed the
rewards back in uh then we have a board
reset that's pretty straightforward it
just goes back and resets the board to
the beginning because it's going to try
out all these different things while
it's learning it's going to do it by
trial and error so you have to keep
resetting it and then of course there's
the play we want to go ahead and play uh
rounds equals 100 depends on what you
want to do on here um you can set this
different you obviously set that to a
higher level but this is just going to
go through and you'll see in here uh
that we have player one and player two
this is this is the computer playing
itself uh one of the more powerful ways
to learn to play a game or even learn
something that isn't a game is to have
two of these models that are basically
trying to beat each other and so they
they keep finding explore new things
this one works for this one so this one
tries new things it beats this we've
seen this in um chess I think was a big
one where they had the two players in
chess with reinforcement learning uh was
one of the ways they train one of the
top um computer chess playing
algorithms uh so this is just what this
is it's going to choose an action it's
going to try something and the more it
tries stuff um the more we're going to
record the hash we actually have a board
hash where they self get the hash setup
on here where it stores all the
information and then once you get to a
win one of them wins it gets the reward
uh then we go back and reset that and
try again and then kind of the fun part
we actually get down here is uh we're
going to play with a human so we'll get
a chance to come in here and see what
that looks like when you put your own
information in and then it just comes in
here does the same thing it did above it
gives it a reward for its things um or
sees if it wins or
ties um looks at available positions all
that kind of fun stuff and then finally
we want to show the board uh so it's
going to print the board out each
time really um as an integration is not
that exciting what's exciting uh in here
is one looking at this reward system
whoops Play One More up the reward
system is really the heart of this how
do you reward the different uh setup and
the other one is when it's playing it's
got to take an action and so what it
chooses for an action is also the heart
of reinforcement learning how do we
choose that action and those are really
key to right now where reinforcement
learning is um in today's uh technology
is uh figuring this out how do we reward
it and how do we guess the next best
action so we have our uh environment and
you can see the environment is we're
going to be or the state uh which is
kind of like what's going on we're going
to return the state depending on what
happens and we want to go ahead and
create our agent uh in this CL our
player so each one is let me go and grab
that and so we look at a class player
um this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a state uh that it can
look at and a reward uh so we want to
take a look at this we have uh name uh
self State this is class player and when
you say class player we're not talking
about a human player we're talking about
um just a uh the computer players and
this is kind of interesting so remember
I told you depending on what you're
doing there's going to be a Decay gamma
um explor rate uh these are what I'm
talking about is how do we train it
um as you try different moves it gets to
the end the first move is important but
it's not as important as the last one
and so you could say that um the last
one has the heaviest weight and then as
you as you get there the first one let
see the first move gives you a five
reward the second gives you a two reward
and the third one gives you a 10 reward
because that's the final ending you got
it the 10's going to count more in the
first step uh and here's our uh we're
going to you know get the board
information coming in and then choose an
action this was the second part that I
was talking about that was so important
uh so once you have your training going
on we have to do a little Randomness and
you can see right here is our NP random
U uniform so it's picking out a random
number take a random action this is
going to just pick which row and which
column it is um and so choosing the
action this one you can see we're just
doing random States um Choice length of
positions action position and then it
skips in there and takes a look at the
board uh for p in positions you it's
actually storing the different boards
each time you go through so it it has a
record of what it did so it can properly
weigh the values and this simply just
depends hash State what's the last state
pin it to the uh um to our states on
here here's our
feedback reward so the reward comes in
and it's going to take a look at this
and say is it none uh what is the reward
and here is that formula remember I was
telling you about up here um that was
important because it has Decay gamma
times a reward this is where as it goes
through each step and this is really
really important this is this is kind of
the heart of this of what I was talking
about earlier uh you have step
one and this might have a a reward of
two you have step two I should probably
should have done ABC this has a step
three uh step
four so on till you get to step in and
this might have a reward of
10 uh so reward a
10 we're going to add that but we're not
adding uh let's say this one right here
uh let's say this reward here right
before 10 was um let's say it's also 10
it just makes a the math easy so we had
10 and 10 we had 10 this is 10 and 10 n
whatever it is but it's time it's 0. n
uh so instead of putting a full 10 here
we only do nine that's a 09
time
and so this
formula um as far as the Decay times the
reward minus the cell State value uh it
basically adds in it says here's one or
here's two I'm sorry I should have done
this ABC it would have been easier uh so
the first move goes in here and it puts
two in
here uh then we have our s uh setup on
here you can see how this gets pretty
complicated in the math but this is
really the key is how do we train our
states and we want the the final State
the win to get the most points if you
win you get most points um and the first
step gets the least amount of points so
you're really training this almost in
Reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now where I
need to sum up my rewards and I want to
sum them up going in reverse and I want
to find the answer in Reverse kind of an
interesting uh uh play on the mind when
you're trying to figure this stuff
out
and of course we want to go ahead and
reset the board down here uh save the
policy load
policy these are the different things
that are going in between the agent and
the state to figure out what's going on
let's go ahead and load that up and then
finally we want to go ahead and create a
human
player and the human player is going to
be a little different uh in that uh you
choose an action row and column here's
your action uh if action is if action in
positions meaning positions that are
available uh you return the action if
not it just keeps asking you until you
get an action that actually works and
then we're going to go ahead and append
to the hash state which uh we don't need
to worry about because it Returns the
action up
here and feed forward uh again this is
because it's a
human um at the end of the game bat
propagate and update State values this
part isn't being done because it's not
programming uh the model uh the model is
getting its own rewards so we've gone
ahead and loaded this in here uh so
here's all our pieces and the first
thing we want to
do is set up uh P1 player one uh P2
player two and then we're going to send
our players to our state so now it has
P1 P2 and it's going to play and it's
going to play 50,000 rounds now we can
probably do a lot less than this and
it's not going to get the full results
in fact you know what uh let's go ahead
and just do five um just to play with it
because I want to show you something
here oops somewhere in there I forgot to
load
something there we go I must have St
forgot to run this
run oops forgot a reference there for
the board rows and columns
3x3 um there is actually in the state it
reference is that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning uh so now I've only set this
up with um see where are we going here
I've only set this up to
train five times and the reason I did
that is we're going to uh come in and
actually play it and then I'm going to
change that and we can see how it
differs on
there there we go and I didn't even make
it through a run and we're going to go
ahead and save the
policy um so now we have our player one
and our player two policy uh the way we
set it up it has two separate policies
loaded up in
there and then we're going to come in
here and we're going to do uh player one
is going to be the computer experience
rate zero load policy one human player
human and we're going to go ahead and
play this I remember I only went through
it um uh just one round of training in
fact minimal training and and so it puts
an X there and I'm going to go ahead and
do row 0o column 1 you can see this is
very uh basic on here and so I put in my
zero and then I'm going to go zero block
it zero zero and you can see right here
it let me win uh just like that I was
able to win
zero two and woo human wins so I only
trained it five times we're going to run
this again and this time uh instead of
five let's do 5,000 or 50,000 I think
that's with the guys in the back had and
this takes a while to train it this is
where reinforcement learning really
falls apart look how simple this game is
we're talking about uh a 3X3 set of
columns and so for me to train it on
this um I could do a q table which would
take which which would go much quicker
um you could build a quick Q table with
almost all the different options on
there and uh you would probably get a
the same result much quicker we're just
using this as an example so when we look
at reinforcement learning you need to be
very careful what you apply it to it
sounds like a good deal until you do
like a large neural network where you're
doing um you set the neural network to a
learning increment of one so every time
it goes through it learns
and then you do your action so you pick
from the learning uh setup and you
actually try actions on the learning
setup until you get the what you think
is going to be the best action so you
actually feed what you think is right
back through the neural network there's
a whole layer there which is really fun
to play
with and then it has an output well
think of all those processes I mean that
is just a huge amount of work it's going
to do uh let's go ahead and Skip ahead
here give it a moment it's going to take
a a minute or two two to go ahead and
run now to train it uh we went ahead and
let it run and it took a while this this
took um I got a pretty powerful
processor and it took about five minutes
plus to run it and we'll go ahead and uh
run our player setup on here oops it
brought in the last whoops it brought in
the last round so give me just a moment
to redo the policy save there we go I
forgot to save the policy back in
there and then go ahead and run our
player again so we we've saved the
policy and then we want to go ahead and
load the policy for P1 as the computer
and we can see the computer's gone in
the bottom right corner I'm going to go
ahead and go uh one one which is the
center and it's gone right up the top
and if you have ever played tic-tac-toe
you know the computer has me uh but
we'll go ahead and play it out row zero
column
two there it is and then it's gone here
and so I'm going to go ahead and go row
01 two no 01 there we go and column zero
that's where I wanted oh and it says I
okay you your action there we go boom uh
so you can see here we've got a didn't
catch the win on this it said tie um
kind of funny they didn't catch the win
on
there but if we play this a bunch of
times you'll find it's going to win more
and more the more we train it the more
the reinforcement
happens this lengthy training process uh
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning as this changes reinforcement
learning will be one of the more
powerful uh packages evolving over the
next decade or two in fact I would even
go as far as to say it is the most
important uh machine learning tool and
artificial intelligence tool out there
as it learns not only a simple Tic Tac
Toe board but we start learning
environments and the environment would
be like in language if you're
translating a language or something from
one language to the other so much of it
is lost if you don't know the context
it's in what's the environments it's in
and so being able to attach environment
and context and all those things
together is going to require
reinforcement learning to
do so again if you want to get a copy of
the Tic Tac Toe board it's kind of fun
to play with uh run it you can test it
out you can do um you know test it for
different uh uh values you can switch
from P1
computer um where we loaded the policy
one to load the policy 2 and just see
how it varies there's all kinds of
things you can do on there so what is Q
learning Q learning is reinforcement
learning policy which will fill the next
best action given a current state it
chooses this action at random and aims
to maximize the reward and so you can
see here's our standard reinforcement
learning graph um by now if you're doing
any reinforcement learning you should be
familiar with this where you have your
agent your agent takes an action the
action affects the environment and then
the environment sends back the reward or
the feedback and the state it's the new
state the agents in where is it at on
the chessboard where's it at in the
video game um if your robots out there
picking trash up off the side of the
road where is it at on the road consider
an ad recommendation system usually when
you look up a product
online you get ads which will suggest
the same product over and over
again using Q learning we can make an ad
recommendation system which will suggest
related products to our previous
purchase the reward will be if user
clicks on the suggested
product and again you can see um you
might have a lot of products on uh your
web advertisement or your pages but it's
still not a float number it's still a
set number and that's something to be
aware of when you're using Q learning
and you can see here that if you have a
100 people clicking on ads and you click
on one of the ads it might go in there
and say okay this person clicked on this
ad what is the best set of ads based on
clicking on this ad or these two ads
afterwards based on where they are
browsing so let's go a and take a look
at some important terms when we talk
about Q learning uh we have States the
state s represents the current position
of an agent in an
environment um the action the action a
is the step taken by the agent when it
is particular State rewards for every
action the agent will get a positive or
negative
[Music]
reward and again uh when we talk about
States we're usually not with when
you're using a q table you're not
usually talking about float variables
you're talking about true false um and
we'll take a closer look at that in a
second and episodes when an agent ends
up in a terminating State and can't take
a new
action uh this might be if you're
playing a video game your character
stepped in and is now dead or whatever
uh Q values used to determine how good
an action a taken at a particular State
s is QA of s and temporal difference a
formula used to find the Q value by
using the value of the current state and
action and previous state and action and
very I mean there's bellman's equation
which basically is the equation that
kind of uh covers we just looked at in
all those different terms the Bellman
equation is used to determine the values
of a particular State and deduce how
good it is to be in take that state the
optimal the optimal state will give us
the highest optimal value Factor
influencing Q values the current state
and action that's your saay so your
current state and your
action uh then you have your previous
date in action which is your s um I
guess Prime I'm not sure how they how
they reference that S Prime a prime so
this is what happened before uh then you
have a reward for Action so you have
your R reward and you have your maximum
expected future
reward and you can see there's also a
learning rate put in there and a
discount rate uh so we're looking at
these just like any other model we don't
want to have an absolute um final value
on here we don't want it to if you do
absolute values instead of taking
smaller steps you don't really have that
approach to the solution you just have
it jump and then pretty soon if you jump
one solution out that's what's going to
be the new solution whichever one jumps
up really high first um kind of ruining
the whole idea of doing a random
selection and I'll go into the random
selection just a second steps in Q
learning step one create an initial Q
table with all values initialized to
zero again we're looking at
01 uh so are you you know here's our
action we start we're an idol we took a
wrong action we took a correct action
and int and then we have our um actions
fetching sitting and running of course
we're just using the dog example and
choose an action and perform it update
values in the table and of course when
we're choosing an action we're going to
kind of do something random and just
randomly pick one so you start out and
you sit and you have then a a
then depending on that um action you
took you can now update the value for
sitting after you start from start to
sitting get the value of the reward and
calculate the Val the value Q value
using the Bellman equation and so now we
attach a reward to
sitting and when we attach all those
rewards we continue the same until the
table's filled with or an episode
ends and and my IM is going to come back
to the random side of this and there's a
few different formulas they use for the
random um setup to pick it I usually let
whatever Q model I'm using do their
standard one because someone's usually
gone and and done the math uh for the
optimal uh spread uh but you can look at
this if I have running has a reward of
10 sitting has a reward of seven
fetching has a reward of five um just
kind of without doing like a a uh means
you know using the bell curve for the
means value and like I said there's some
math you can put in there to pick um so
that you're more like so that running
has even a higher chance um but even if
you were just going to do an average on
this you could do an average a random
number by adding them all together uh so
you get 10 plus 7 + 5 is 22 you could do
0 to 22 and or 0 to 21 but 1 to 22 one
to five would be fetching uh and so
forth you know the last 10 so you can
just look at this as what percentage are
you going to go for that particular
option
um and then that gets your random setup
in there and then as you slowly
increment these up uh you see that uh um
if you're Idol um where's one here we go
sitting at the end if you're at the end
of wherever you're at sitting gets a
reward of one um where's the good one on
here oh wrong action running for a wrong
action gets almost no reward so that
becomes very very less likely to happen
but it still might happen it still might
have a percentage of coming up and
that's where the random programming and
Q learning comes in the below table
gives us an idea of how many times an
action has been taken and how positively
correct action or negatively wrong
action it is going to affect the next
state so let's go ahead and dive in and
pull up a little piece of code and see
what this looks like um in
Python uh in this demo we'll use Q
learning to find the shortest path
between two given points if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more if
you seen my videos before um I like to
do it in the uh Anaconda Jupiter
notebook um setup just because it's
really easy to see and it's a nice demo
uh and so here's my anaconda this one
I'm actually using uh python 36
envirment that I set up in here and
we'll go ahead and launch the Jupiter
Notebook on this and once we're in our
Jupiter notebook uh which has the kernel
loaded with Python 3 we'll go ahead and
create a new Python 3 uh folder in
here and we'll call this uh
Q
learning and to start this
demo let's go ahead and import our numpy
array we'll just run that so it's
imported and like a lot of these uh
model programs when you're building them
you spend a lot of time putting it all
together um
and then you end up with this really
short answer at the
end uh and we'll we'll take a look at
that as we come into it so we we go
ahead and start with our location to
State uh so we have um L1 L2 these are
our nine locations one to nine and then
of course the state is going to be 0 1 2
3 4 it's just a mapping of our location
to a integer on there and then we have
our actions our actions are simply uh
moving
from um one
location to another so I can go to I can
go to location zero I can go to location
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 uh so these are my
actions I can choose these are the
locations of our
state and if you remember earlier I
mentioned uh um that the limitation is
that you you don't want to put in um a
continually growing table because you
can actually create a dynamic Q table
where you continually add in new values
as they arise
because um if you have float values this
just becomes infinite and then your
memory in your computer's gone or you
know does it's not going to work at the
same time you might think well that kind
of really limits the the Q uh T learning
setup but there are ways to use it in
conjunction with other systems and so
you might look
at uh well I do um been doing some work
in stock um and one of the questions
that comes out is to buy or sell the
stock and the stake coming in might be
um you might take it create what called
buckets um where anything that you
predict is going to return more than a
certain amount of money um the error for
that stock that you've had in the past
you put those in buckets and suddenly as
you start putting the creating these
buckets you realize you do have a
limited amount of information coming in
you no longer have a float number you
now have um bucket one two three and
four and then you can take those buckets
put them through a a q learning table
and come up with the best action which
stock should I buy it's like gambling
stock is pretty much gambling if you're
doing day trading you're not doing
long-term um Investments and so you can
start looking at it like that a lot of
the um current feed say that the best
algorithms used for day Traders where
you're doing it on your own is really
asked a question do I want to trade the
stock yes or no and now you have it in a
q learning table and now you can take it
to that next level and you can see where
that can be a really powerful tool at
the end of doing a basic linear
regression model or something um what is
the best investment and you start
getting the best reward on
there uh and so if we're going to have
rewards these rewards we just create um
it says uh if basically if you're um
this should match our Q table because
it's going to be uh you have your state
and you have your action across the top
if you remember from the dog and so we
have whatever state we're in going down
and then the next action and what the
reward is for it um and of course if you
were actually doing a um something more
connected your reward would be based on
um the actual environment it's in and
then we want to go ahead and create a
state to location uh so we can map the
indexes so just like we defined our
rewards uh we're going to go do state to
location um and you can see here it's a
a dictionary setup for location State
and location to state with
items and we also need to
um Define what we want for learning
rates uh you remember we had our two
different rates um as far as like
learning from the past and learning from
the current so we'll go ahead and set
those to uh 75 and the alpha set to 0.9
and we'll see that when we do the
formula and of course any of this code
uh send a note to our simply learn team
they'll get you a copy of this code on
here let's go ahead and
pull there we
go the new next two
sections um since we're going to keep it
short and
sweet here we go so let's go ahead and
create our agent um so our agent is
going to have our initialized ation
where we sended all the information uh
we'll Define our s gamma equals gamma we
could have just set the gamma rate down
here instead of uh submitting it it's
kind of nice to keep them separate
because you can play with these numbers
uh our self Alpha um then we have our
location State we'll set that in here uh
we have our choice of actions um we're
going to go ahead and just embed the
rewards right into the agent so
obviously this would be coming from
somewhere else uh instead of from uh
self-generated and then a self state to
location equals our state to location
dictionary and we go ahead and create a
q learning table and I went ahead and
just set the Q learning table up to um
uh 0 to zero what what what the setup is
uh location to State how many of them
are there uh this just creates an array
of zero to zero setup on
there and then the big part is the
training we have our rewards new equals
a copy of self.
rewards ending State equals the self
location state in location so this is
whatever we end up at rewards new equals
ending State plus ending State equals
999 just kind of goes to a dead end and
we start going through
iterations and we'll go ahead um let's
do this uh so this we're going to come
back and we're going to call call it on
here uh let me just just erase that
switch it to an
arrow there we go uh so what we're doing
is we're going to send in here to train
it we're going to say hey um I want to
iterate through this a thousand times
and see what happens now this part would
actually be instead of iterating you
might have your external environment and
they're going back and forth and you
iterate through outside of here uh but
just for ease of use our agent's going
to come in here and iterate through this
sometimes I'll put this iteration in
here and I'll have it call the
environment and say hey this is what I
did what's the next state and the
environment does its thing right in here
as I iterate through
it uh and then we want to go ahead and
pick a random state to start with that's
what's going on here you have to start
somewhere um and then you have your
playable actions we're going to start
with just an empty thing for playable
actions and we'll fill that up so that's
what choices I have and so we're going
to iterate through the rewards Matrix to
get the states uh directly reachable
from the randomly chosen current state
assign those states to a list named
playable
actions and so you can see here we have
uh range nine I usually use length of
whatever I'm looking at uh which is our
locations or States as they are uh we
have a reward so we want to look at the
current the rewards uh the new
reward is our uh is in our chart here of
rewards uncore new uh current state um
plus J uh J being what is the next date
we want to try and so we go aad and do
our playable actions and we append
J and so we're doing is we're randomly
trying different things in here to see
what's going to generate a better
reward and then of course we go ahead
and choose our next State uh so we have
our random Choice playable actions and
if you remember mentioned on this let me
just go ahead and uh oops let's do a
free form when we were talking about the
next State uh this right here just does
a random selection instead of a random
uh selection you might do something
where uh whatever the best selection is
which might be option three here and
then so you can see that it might use a
bell curve and then option two over here
might have a bell curve like this
oops and we start looking at these
averages and these spreads um or we can
just add them all together and pick the
one that kind of goes in all of those uh
so those are some of the options we have
in here we just go with a random Choice
uh that's usually where you start play
with it um and then we have our reward
section down here and so we want to go
ahead and find well in this case a
temporal difference uh so you have your
rewards new plus the self gamma and this
is the formula we were looking at this
is bellman's equation here uh so we have
our current value our learning rate our
discount rate involved in there the
reward system coming in for that um and
we can add it all together this is of
course our U maximum expected future
setup in here uh so this is all of our
our bellman's equation that we're
looking at here and then we come up in
here and we update our Q table that's
all this is on this one that's right
here we have have um self Q current
state next state and we add in our um
Alpha because we don't want to we don't
want to train all of it at once in case
there's slight differenes coming in
there we want to slowly approach the
answer uh and then we have our route
equals to start
location and next location equals start
location so we're just incrementing we
took a step forward and then finally
remember I was telling you how uh we're
going to do all this and just have some
simple thing at the end or just gener
generates a simple path we're going to
go ahead and and get the optimal route
we want to find the best route in here
and so we've created a definition for
the optimal route down here just scroll
down for that and we get the optimal
route we go ahead and put the
information in including the Q table
self uh start location end location next
location route q and it says while next
location is not equal to in location so
while we can still go our start location
equals self-location to State start
location so we already have our best
value for the start
location uh the next state looks at the
Q table and says hey what's H the next
one with the best value and then the
next location we go ahead and pull that
in and we just append it that's what's
going on down
here and then our start location equals
the next location and we just go through
all the steps and we'll go ahead and run
this and now that we have our Q table
our um Q agent loaded we're going to go
ahead and uh take our Q agent load them
up with our Alpha Gamma that we set up
above um along with the location step
action rewards state to
location and uh our goal is to plot a
course between L9 and
L1 and we're going to go through a 100 a
thousand iterations on here and so when
I run that it runs pretty quick uh why
is this so fast um if youve been running
neural networks and you've been doing
these other models you sit here and wait
a long time well we're a very small
amount of data these are all integers
these aren't float values there's not a
the math is not heavy on the on the
processing end and this is where Q
tables are so powerful if you have a
small amount of information coming in
you very quickly uh get an answer off of
this even though we went through it a
thousand times to train it and you'll
see here we have l985 2 and one and
that's based on our reward table we we
had set up on there and this is the
shortest path going between these
different uh setups in here and if you
remember on our reward table uh you can
see that if you start here you can go to
here there's places you can't go that's
how this reward table was set up so I
can only go to certain
places uh so kind of a little maze setup
in there and you can play with it this
is really fun uh setup to play with uh
and you can see how you can take this
whole code and you can like I was saying
earlier you can embed it into another
setup in model and predictions where you
put things into buckets and you're
trying to guess the best investment the
best course of action long as you can
take that course of action and and uh uh
reduce it down to a yes no um or if
you're using text you can use a one hot
encoder which word is next there's all
kinds of things you can do with a Q
table uh depending on just how much
information you're putting in there so
that wraps up our demo in this demo
we've uh found the shortest distance
between two paths based on whatever
rules or state rewards we have to get
from point A to point B and what
available actions there are hello and
welcome to this tutorial on deep
learning my name is moan and in the next
about 1 one and a half hours I will take
you through what is deep learning and
into tensor flow environment to show you
an example of deep learning now there
are several applications of deep
learning really very interesting and
Innovative applications and one of them
is identifying the geographic location
based on a picture and how does this
work the way it works is pretty much we
train an artificial neural network with
millions of images which are tagged
their geolocation is tagged and then
when we feed a new picture it will be
able to identify the geolocation of this
new image for example you have all these
images especially with maybe some
significant monuments or or U
significant locations and you train with
millions of such images and then when
you feed another image it need not be
exactly one of those that you have
claimed it can be completely different
that is the whole idea of training it
will be able to recognize for example
that this is a picture from Paris
because it is able to recognize the
Eiffel T so the way it works internally
if we have to look a little bit under
the hood is these images are nothing but
this is digital information in the form
of pixels so each image could be a
certain size it can be 256x 256 pixel
kind of a resolution and then each pixel
is either having a certain grade of
color and all that is fed into the
neural network and it then gets trained
in and it's able to based on these pixel
pixel information it is able to get
trained and able to recognize the
features and extract the features and
thereby it is able to identify these
images and the location of these images
and then when you feed a new image it
kind of based on the training it will be
able to figure out where this image is
from so that's the way a little bit
under the hood how it works so what are
we going to do in this tutorial we will
see what is deep learning and what what
do we need for deep learning and one of
the main components of deep learning is
neural network so we will see what is
neural network what is a perceptron and
how to implement logic gates like and or
nor and so on using perceptrons the
different types of neural networks and
then applications of deep learning and
we will also see how neural networks
works so how do we do the training of
neural networks and at the end we will
end up with a small demo code which will
take you through intens of flow now in
order to implement deep learning code
there are multiple libraries or
development environments that are
available and tensorflow is one of them
so the focus at the end of this would be
on how to use tensor flow to write a
piece of code using python as a
programming language and we will take up
a an example which is a very common one
which is like the hollow word of deep
learning the handwriting number
recognition which is a mnist commonly
known as mnist database so we will take
a look at amness database and how we can
train a neural network to recognize
handwritten numbers so that's what you
will see in this particular video so
let's get started what is deep learning
deep learning is like a subset of what
is known as a high level concept called
artificial intelligence you must be we
already familiar must have heard about
this term artificial intelligence so
artificial intelligence is like the high
level concept if you will and in order
to implement artificial intelligence
applications we use what is known as
machine learning and within machine
learning a subset of machine learning is
deep learning machine learning is a
little bit more generic concept and deep
learning is one type of machine learning
if you will and we will see a little
later in maybe the following slides a
little bit more in detail how deep
learning is different from traditional
machine learning but to start with we
can mention here that deep learning uses
one of the differentiators between deep
learning and traditional machine
learning is that deep learning uses
neural networks and we will talk about
what are neural networks and how we can
Implement neural networks and so on and
so forth as a part of this tutorial so a
little deeper into deep learning deep
learning primarily involves working with
complicated unstructured data compared
to traditional machine learning with
where we normally use structured data in
deep learning the data would be
primarily images or Voice or maybe text
file so and it is large amount of data
as well and deep learning can handle
complex operations it involves complex
operations and the other difference
between traditional machine learning and
deep learning is that the feature EXT
raction happens pretty much
automatically in traditional machine
learning feature engineering is done
manually the data scientists we data
scientists have to do feature
engineering feature extraction but in
deep learning that happens automatically
and of course deep learning for large
amounts of data complicated unstructured
data deep learning gives very good
performance now as I mentioned one of
the secret sources of deep learning is
neural networks let's see what neural
networks is neural networks is based on
our biological neurons the whole concept
of deep learning and artificial
intelligence is based on human brain and
human brain consists of billions of tiny
stuff called neurons and this is how a
biological neuron looks and this is how
an artificial neuron looks so neural
networks is like simulation of our human
brain human brain has billions of
biological neurons and we are trying to
simulate the human brain using
artificial neurons this is how a
biological neuron looks it has dendrites
and the corresponding component with an
artificial neural network is or an
artificial neuron are the inputs they
receive the inputs through dendrites and
then there is the cell nucleus which is
basically the processing unit in a way
so in artificial neuron also there is a
piece which is an equivalent of this
cell nucleus and based on the weights
and biases we will see what exactly
weights and biases are as we move the
input gets processed and that results in
an output in a biological neuron the
output is sent through a synapse and in
an artificial neuron there is an
equivalent of that in the form of an
output and biological neurons are also
interconnected so there are billions of
neurons which are interconnected in the
same way artificial neurons are also
interconnected so this output of this
neuron will be fed as an input to
another neuron and so on now in neural
network one of the very basic units is a
perceptron so what is a perceptron A
perceptron can be considered as one of
the fundamental units of neural networks
it can consist at least one neuron but
sometimes it can be more than one neuron
but you can create a perceptron with a
single neuron and it can be used to
perform certain functions it can be used
as a basic binary classifier it can be
trained to do some basic binary
classification and this is how a basic
perceptron looks like and this is
nothing but a neuron you have inputs X1
X2 X to xn and there is a
function and then there is what is known
as an activation function and based on
this input what is known as the weighted
sum the activation function either gets
gives an output like a zero or a one so
we say the neuron is either activated or
not so that's the way it works so you
get the inputs these inputs are each of
the inputs are multiplied by a weight
and there is a bias that gets added and
that whole thing is fed to an activation
function and then that results in an
output and if the output is correct it
is accepted if it is wrong if there is
an error then that error is fed back and
the neuron then adjust the weights and
biases to give a new output and so on
and so forth so that's what is known as
the training process of a neuron or a
neural network there's a concept called
perceptron learning so perceptron
learning is again one of the very basic
learning processes the way it works is
somewhat like this so you have all these
inputs like X1 to xn and each of these
inputs is multiplied by a weight and
then that sum this is the formula of the
equation so that sum wi
ixi Sigma of that which is the sum of
all these product of X and W is added up
and then a bias is added to that the
bias is not dependent on the input but
or the input values but the bias is
common for one neuron however the bias
value keeps changing during the training
process once the training is completed
the values of these weights W1 W2 and so
on and the value of the bias gets fixed
so that is basically the whole training
process and that is what is known as the
perceptron training so the weights and
biases keep changing till you get the
accurate output and the summation is of
course passed through the activation
function as you see here this WI x i
summation plus b is passed through
activation function and then the neuron
gets either fired or not and based on
that there will be an output that output
is compared with the actual or expected
value which is also known as labeled
information so this is the process of
supervised learning so the output is
already known and um that is compared
and thereby we know if there is an error
or not and if there is an error the
error is fed back and the weights and
biases are updated accordingly till the
error is reduced to the minimum so this
iterative process is known as perceptron
learning or perceptron learning Rule and
this error needs to be minimized so till
the error is minimized this iteratively
the weights and biases keep changing and
that is what is the training process so
the whole idea is to update the weights
and the bias of the perceptron till the
error is minimized the error need not be
zero the error may not ever reach zero
but the idea is to keep changing these
weights and bias so that the error is
minimum the minimum possible that it can
have so this whole process is an
iterative process and this is the
iteration continues till either the
error is zero which is uh unlikely
situation or it is the minimum possible
Within These given conditions now in
1943 two scientists Warren mik and
Walter Pitts came up with an experiment
where they were able to implement the
logical functions like and or and nor
using neurons and that was a significant
breakthrough in a sense so they were
able to come up with the most common
logical Gates they were able to
implement some of the most common
logical Gates which could take two
inputs Like A and B and then give a
corresponding result so for example in
case of an and gate A and B and then the
output is a in case of an orgate it is a
plus b and so on and so forth and they
were able to do this using a single
layer perceptron now most of these gats
it was possible to use single layer
perceptron except for XR and we will see
why that is in a little bit so this is
how an end gate works the inputs A and B
the output should be fired or the neuron
should be fired only when both the
inputs are one so if you have 0 0 the
output should be zero for 0 1 it is
again 0 1 0 again 0 and 1 one the output
should be one so how do we implement
this with a neuron so it was found that
by changing the values of Weights it is
possible to achieve this logic so for
example if we have equal weights like 7
7 and then if we take the sum of the
weighted product so for example 7 into 0
and then 7 into 0 will give you zero and
so on and so forth and in the last case
when both the inputs are one you get a
value which is greater than one which is
the threshold so only in this case the
neuron gets activated and the output is
the is an output in all the other cases
there is no output because the threshold
value is one so this is implementation
of an and gate using a single perceptron
or a single neuron similarly an orgate
in order to implement an orgate in case
of an orgate the output will be one if
either of these inputs is one so for
example 01 will result in one or other
in all the cases it is one except for 0
0 so how do we implement this using a
perceptron once again if you have a
perceptron with weights for example 1.2
now if you see here if in the first case
when both are zero the output is zero in
the second case when it is 0 and 1 1.2
into 0 is 0 and then 1.2 into 1 is 1 and
in the second case similarly the output
is 1.2 in this last case when both the
inputs are one the output is 2.4 so
during the training process these
weights will keep changing and then at
one point where the weights are equal to
W1 is equal to 1.2 and W2 is equal to
1.2 the system learns that it gives the
correct output so that is implementation
of orgate using a single neuron or a
single layer perceptron now exor gate
this was one of the challenging ones
they tried to implement an XR gate with
a single level perceptron but it was not
possible and therefore in order to
implement an XR so this was like a a
roadblock in the progress of of neural
network however subsequently they
realize that this can be implemented an
XR gate can be implemented using a
multi-level perceptron or MLP so in this
case there are two layers instead of a
single layer and this is how you can
Implement an XR gate so you will see
that X1 and X2 are the inputs and there
is a hidden layer and that's why it is
denoted as H3 and H4 and then you take
the output of that and feed it to the
output at 05 and provide a threshold
here so we will see here that this is
the numerical calculation so the weights
are in this case for X1 it is 20 and
minus 20 and once again 20 and- 20 so
these inputs are fed into H3 and H4 so
you'll see here for H3 the input is
0111 and for H4 it is 1011 and if you
now look at the output final output
where the threshold is taken as one if
you use a sigmoid with the threshold one
you will see that in these two cases it
is zero and in the last two cases it is
one so this is a implementation of XR in
case of XR only when one of the inputs
is one you will get an output so that is
what we are seeing here if we have
either both the inputs are one or both
the inputs are zero then the output
should be zero so that is what is an
exclusive or gate so it is exclusive
because only one of the inputs should be
one and then only you'll get an output
of one which is Satisfied by this
condition so this is a special
implementation XR gate is a special
implementation of perceptron now that we
got a good idea about perceptron let's
take a look at what is a neural network
so we have seen what is a perceptron we
have seen what is a neuron so we will
see what exactly is a neural network so
neural network is nothing but a network
of these neurons and there are different
types of neural networks there are about
five of them these are artificial neural
network convolutional neural network
then recursive neural network or
recurrent neural network deep neural
network and deep belief Network so and
each of these types of neural networks
have a special you know they can solve
special kind of problems for example
convolutional neural networks are very
good at performing image process cring
and image recognition and so on whereas
RNN are very good for speech recognition
and also text analysis and so on so each
type has some special characteristics
and they can they're good at performing
certain special kind of tasks what are
some of the applications of deep
learning deep learning is today used
extensively in gaming you must have
heard about alphao which is a game
created by a startup called Deep Mind
which got acquired by Google and alphago
is an AI which defeated the human world
champion leas at all in this game of Go
so gaming is an area where deep learning
is being extensively used and a lot of
research happens in the area of gaming
as well in addition to that nowadays
there are neural networks or special
type called generative adversarial
Network Works which can be used for
synthesizing either images or music or
text and so on and they can be used to
compose music so the neural network can
be trained to compose a certain kind of
music and autonomous cars you must be
familiar with Google Google's
self-driving car and today a lot of
Automotive companies are investing in
this space and uh deep learning is a
core component of this autonomous cars
the cars are trained to recognize for
example the road the the lane markings
on the road signals any objects that are
in front any obstruction and so on and
so forth so all this involves deep
learning so that's another major
application and uh robots we have seen
several robots including Sofia you may
be familiar with sopia who was given a
citizenship by Saudi Arabia and there
are several such robots which are are
very humanlike and the underlying
technology in many of these robots is
deep learning medical Diagnostics and
Health Care is another major area where
deep learning is being used and within
Healthcare Diagnostics again there are
multiple areas where deep learning and
image recognition image processing can
be used for example for cancer detection
as you may be aware if cancer is
detected early on it can be be cured and
one of the challenges is in the
availability of Specialists who can
diagnose cancer using these diagnostic
images and various scans and and so on
and so forth so the idea is to train
neural network to perform some of these
activities so that the load on the
cancer specialist doctors or oncologists
comes down and there is a lot of
research happening here and there are
already quite a few applications that
are are claimed to be performing better
than human beings in this space can be
lung cancer it can be breast cancer and
so on and so forth so Healthcare is a
major area where deep learning is being
applied let's take a look at the inner
working of a neural network so how does
an artificial neural network let's say
identify can we train a neural network
to identify the shapes like squares and
circles and triangles when these images
are fed so this is how it works any
image is nothing but it is a digital
information of the pixels so in this
particular case let's say this is an
image of 28x 28 pixel and this is an
image of a square there's a certain way
in which the pixels are lit up and so
these pixels have a certain value maybe
from 0 to 256 and zero indicates that it
is black or it is dark and 256 indicates
it is completely it is white or lit up
so that is like an indication or a
measure of the how the pixels are lit up
and so this is an image is let's say
consisting of information of 784 pixels
so all the information what is inside
this image can be kind of compressed
into this 784 pixels the way each of
these pixels is lit up provides
information about what exactly is the
image so we can train neural networks to
use that information and identify the
images so let's take a look how this
works so each neuron the value if it is
close to one that means it is white
whereas if it is close to zero that
means it is black now this is a an
animation of how this whole thing works
so these pixels one of the ways of doing
it is we can flatten this image and take
this complete 784 pixels and feed that
as input to our neural network the
neural network can consist of probably
several layers there can be a few hidden
layers and then there is an input layer
and an output layer now the input layer
take the 784 pixels as input the values
of each of these pixels and then you get
an output which can be of three types or
three classes one can be a square a
circle or a triangle now during the
training process there will be initially
obviously you feed this image and it
will probably say it's a circle or it
will say it's a triangle so as a part of
the training process we then send that
error back and the weights and the
biases of these neurons are adjusted
till it correctly identifies that this
is a square that is the whole training
mechanism that happens out
here now let's take a look at a circle
same way so you feed these 784 pixels
there is a certain pattern in which the
pixels are lit up and the neural network
is trained to identify that pattern and
during the training process once again
it would probably initially identify it
incorrectly saying this is a square or a
triangle and then that error is fed back
and the weights and biases are adjusted
finally till it finally gets the image
correct so that is the training process
so now we will take a look at same way a
triangle so now if you feed another
image which is consisting of triangles
so this is the training process now we
have trained our neural network to
classify these images into a triangle or
a circle and a square so now this neural
network can identify these three types
of objects now if you feed another image
and it will be able to identify whether
it's a square or a triangle or a circle
now what is important to be observed is
that when you feed a new image it is not
necessary that the image or the the
triangle is exactly in this position now
the neural network actually identifies
the patter turns so even if the triangle
is let's say positioned here not exactly
in the middle but maybe at the corner or
in the side it would still identify that
it is a triangle and that is the whole
idea behind pattern recognition so how
does this training process work this is
a quick view of how the training process
works so we have seen that a neuron
consists of inputs it receives inputs
and then there is a weighted sum which
is nothing but this X X I wi summation
of that plus the bias and this is then
fed to the activation function and that
in turn gives us a output now during the
training process initially obviously
when you feed these images when you send
maybe a square it will identify it as a
triangle and when you maybe feed a
triangle it will identify as a square
and so on so that error information is
fed back and initially these weights can
be random maybe all of them have Z
values and then it will slowly keep
changing so the as a part of the
training process the values of these
weights W1 W2 up to WN keep changing in
such a way that towards the end of the
training process it should be able to
identify these images correctly so till
then the weights are adjusted and that
is known as the training process so and
these weights are numeric values could
be.
52535 and so on it could be positive or
it could be negative ative and the value
that is coming here is the pixel value
as we have seen it can be anything
between 0 to 1 you can scale it between
0 to 1 or 0 to 256 whichever way 0 being
black and 256 being white and then all
the other colors in between so that is
the input so these are numerical values
this multiplication or the product W ixi
is a numerical value and the bias is
also a numerical value you need to keep
in mind that the bias is fixed for a
neuron it doesn't change with the inputs
whereas the weights are one per input so
that is one important point to be noted
so but the bias also keeps changing
initially it will again have a random
value but as a part of the training
process the weights the values of the
weights W1 W2 WN and the value of B will
change and ultimately once the training
process is complete these values are
fixed for this particular neuron W1 W2
up to WN and plus the value of the B is
also fixed for this particular neuron
and in this way there will be multiple
neurons and each there may be multiple
levels of neurons here and that's the
way the training process works so this
is another example of multi-layer so
there are two hidden layers in between
and then you have the input layer values
coming from the input layer then it goes
through multiple layers hidden layers
and then there is an output layer and as
you can see there are weights and biases
for each of these neurons in each layer
and all of them gets keeps changing
during the training process and at the
end of the training process all these
weights have a certain value and that is
a trained model and those values will be
fixed once the training is completed all
right then there is something known as
activation function neural networks
consists of one of the components in
neural networks is activation function
and every neuron has an activation
function and there are different types
of activation functions that are used it
could be a relu it could be sigmoid and
so on and so forth and the activation
function is what decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not so whether
the output should be zero or one is
decided by the activation function and
the activation function in turn takes
the input which is the weighted sum
remember we talked about wixi + B that
weighted sum is fed as a input to the
activation function and then the output
can be either a zero or a one and there
are different types of activation
functions which are covered in an
earlier video you might want to watch
all right so as a part of the training
process we feed the inputs the labeled
data or the training data and then it
gives an output which is the predicted
output by the network which we indicate
as y hat and then there is a labeled
data because we for supervised learning
we already know what should be the
output so that is the actual output put
and in the initial process before the
training is complete obviously there
will be error so that is measured by
what is known as a cost function so the
difference between the predicted output
and the actual output is the error and U
the cost function can be defined in
different ways there are different types
of cost functions so in this case it is
like the average of the squares of the
error so and then all the errors are
added which can sometimes be called as
sum of squares some of square errors or
SSC and that is then fed as a feedback
in what is known as backward propagation
or back propagation and that helps in
the network adjusting the weights and
biases and so the weights and biases get
updated till this value the error value
or the cost function is minimum now
there is a optimization technique which
is used here called gradient dis
optimization and this algorithm Works in
a way that the error which is the cost
function needs to be minimized so
there's a lot of mathematics that goes
behind this for example they find the uh
local Minima the global Minima using the
differentiation and so on and so forth
but the idea is this so as a training
process as a as a part of training the
whole idea is to bring down the error
which is like let's say this is the
function the cost function at certain
levels it is very high the cost value of
the cost function the output of the cost
function is very high so the weights
have to be adjusted in such a way and
also the bias of course that the cost
function is minimized so there is this
optimization technique called gradient
descent that is used and this is known
as the learning rate now gradient
descent you need to specify what should
be the learning rate and the learning
rate should be optimal because if you
have a very high learning rate then the
optimization will not converge because
at some point it will cross over to the
site on the other hand if you have very
low learning rate then it might take
forever to convert so you need to come
up with the optimum value of the
learning rate and once that is done
using the gradient descent optimiz Iz
ation the error function is reduced and
that's like the end of the training
process all right so this is another
view of gradient descent so this is how
it looks this is your cost function the
output of the cost function and that has
to be minimized using gradient descent
algorithm and these are like the
parameters and weight could be one of
them so initially we start with certain
random values so cost will be high and
then the weights keep changing and in
such a way that the cost function needs
to come down and at some point it may
reach the minimum value and then it may
increase so that is where the gradi IND
descent algorithm decides that okay it
has reached the minimum value and it
will kind of try to stay here this is
known as the global Minima now sometimes
these curves may not be just for
explanation purpose this has been drawn
in a nice way but sometimes these curves
can be pretty erratic there can be some
local Minima here and then there is a
peak and then and so on so the whole
idea of gradient descent optimization is
to identify the global Minima and to
find the weights and the bias at that
particular point so that's what is
gradian descent and then this is another
example so you can have these multiple
local Minima so as you can see at this
point when it is coming down it may
appear like this is a minimum value but
then it is not this is actually the
global minimum value and the gradient
desent algorithm will make an effort to
reach this level and not get stuck at
this point so the algorithm is already
there and it knows how to identify this
Global minimum and that's what it does
during the training process now in order
to implement deep learning there are
multiple platforms and languages that
are available but the most common
platform nowadays is tensor flow and so
that's the reason we have uh this
tutorial we have created this tutorial
for tensorflow so we will take you
through a quick demo of how to write a
tensorflow code using Python and
tensorflow is uh an open source platform
created by Google so let's just take a
look at the details of tens oflow and so
this is a a library a python Library so
you can use python or any other
languages it's also supported in other
languages like Java and R and so on but
python is the most common language that
is used so it is a library for
developing deep learning applications
especially using neural networks and it
consists of primarily two parts if you
will so one is the tensors and then the
other is the graphs of the flow that's
the way the name that's the reason for
this kind of a name called tensor flow
so what are tensors tensors are like
multi-dimensional arrays if you will
that's one way of looking at it so
usually you have a onedimensional array
so first of all you can have what is
known as a scalar which means a number
and then you have a onedimensional array
something like this which means this is
like a set of numbers so that is a
onedimensional array then you can have a
two-dimensional array which is like a
matrix and beyond that sometimes it gets
difficult so this is a three-dimensional
array but tens of flow can handle many
more Dimensions so it can have
multi-dimensional arrays that is the
strength of tens of flow and which makes
computation deep learning computation
much faster and that's the reason why
tensorflow is used for developing deep
learning applications so tensor flow is
a deep learning tool and this is the way
it works so the data basically flows in
the form of tensors and the way the
programming works as well is that you
first create a graph of how to execute
it and then you actually execute that
particular graph in the form of what is
known as a session we will see this in
the tensor flow code as we move forward
so all the data is managed or
manipulated in tensors and then the
processing happens using this graphs
there are certain terms called like for
example ranks of a tensor the rank of a
tensor is like a dimensional
dimensionality in a way so for example
if it is scalar so there is just a
number just one number the rank is
supposed to to be zero and then it can
be a
one-dimensional vector in which case the
rank is supposed to be one and then you
can have a
two-dimensional Vector typically like a
matrix then in that case we say the rank
is two and then if it is a
three-dimensional array then it rank is
three and so on so it can have more than
three as well so it is possible that you
can store multi-dimensional arrays in
the form of t
so what are some of the properties of
tensorflow I think today it is one of
the most popular platform tensorflow is
the most popular deep learning platform
or Library it is open source it's
developed by Google developed and
maintained by Google but it is open
source one of the most important things
about tensorflow is that it can run on
CPUs as well as gpus GPU is a graphical
Processing Unit just like CPU is central
processing unit now in earlier days GPU
was used for primarily for graphics and
that's how the name has come and one of
the reasons is that it cannot perform
generic activities very efficiently like
CPU but it can perform iterative actions
or computations extremely fast and much
faster than a CPU so they are really
good for computational activities and in
deep learning there is a lot of
iterative computation that happens so in
the form of Matrix multiplication and so
on so gpus are very well suited for this
kind of computation and tensorflow
supports both GPU as well as CPU and
there's a certain way of writing code in
tensorflow we will see as we go into the
code and of course tensorflow can be
used for traditional machine learning as
well but then that would be an Overkill
but just for understanding it may be a
good idea to start writing code for a
normal machine learning use case so that
you get a hang of how tens the flow code
works and then you can move into neural
networks so that is um just a suggestion
but if you're already familiar with how
tens oflow works then probably yeah you
can go straight into the neural networks
part so in this tutorial we will take
the use case of recognizing handwritten
digits this is like a hollow world of
deep learning and this is a nice little
Ms database is a nice little database
that has images of handwritten digits
nicely formatted because very often in
deep learning and neural networks we end
up spending a lot of time in preparing
the data for training and with amness
database we can avoid that you already
have the data in the right format which
can be directly used for training and
amnest also offers a bunch of built-in
utility functions that we we can
straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mes database is very popular
for training purposes initially when
people want to learn about deep learning
and tensor flow this is the database
that is used and it has a collection of
70,000 handwritten digits and a large
part of them are for training then you
have test just like in any machine
learning process and then you have
validation and all of them are labeled
so you have the images and their label
and these images they look somewhat like
this so they are handwritten images
collected from a lot of individuals
people have these are samples written by
human beings they have handwritten these
numbers these numbers going from 0 to 9
so people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is amness
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our tensor flow is we
will feed this data especially the
training data along with the label
information and uh the data is basically
these images are stored in the form of
the pixel information as we have seen in
one of the previous slides all the
images are nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and and for Simplicity what we will do
is we will flatten these pixels so
instead of taking them in a
two-dimensional arrangement we just
flatten them out so for example it
starts from here it is a 28 by 28 so
there are
7484 pixels so pixel number one starts
here it goes all the way up to 28 then
29 starts here and goes up to 56 and so
on and the pixel number 784 is here so
we take all these pixels flatten them
out and feed them like one single line
into our neural network and this is a
what is known as a softmax layer what it
does is once it is trained it will be
able to identify what digit this is so
there are in this output layer there are
10 neurons each signifying a digit and
at any given point of time when you feed
an image only one of these 10 neurons
gets activated so for example if this is
strained properly and if you feed a
number nine like this then this
particular neuron gets activated so you
get an output from this neuron let me
just use uh a pen or a laser to show you
here okay so you're feeding a number
nine let's say this has been trained and
now if you're feeding a number nine this
will get activ ated now let's say you
feed one to the trained Network then
this neuron will get activated if you
feed two this neuron will get activated
and so on I hope you get the idea so
this is one type of a neural network or
an activation function known as soft Max
layer so that's what we will be using
here this is one of the simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so this is
how the code would look we will go into
our lab environment in the cloud and uh
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
uh let me run you through briefly here
and then we will go into the Jupiter
notebook where the actual code is and we
will run that as well so as a first step
first of all we are using python here
and that's why the syntax of the
language is Python and the first step is
to import the tens oflow Library so and
we do this by using this line of code
saying import tens of flow as TF TF is
just for convenience so you can name
give any name and once you do this TF is
tens flow is available as an object in
the name of TF and then you can run its
uh methods and accesses its attributes
and so on and so forth and mnus database
is actually an integral part of
tensorflow and that's again another
reason why we as a first step we always
use this example Mist database example
so you just simply import mnist database
as well using this line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
uh let me just uh use the pen to show
what exactly it is so when you do this
one hot true what happens is each label
is stored in the form of an array of 10
digits and let's say the number is uh
eight okay so in this case all the
remaining values there will be a bunch
of zeros so this is like array at
position zero this is at position one
position two and so on and so forth
let's say this is position seven then
this is position 8 that will be one
because our input is eight and again
position 9 will be zero okay so one hot
encoding this one hot encoding true will
kind of load the data in such a way that
the labels are in such a way that only
one of the digits has a value of one and
that indicates So based on which digit
is one we know what is the label so in
this case the eighth position is one
therefore we know this sample data the
value is eight similarly if you have a
two here let's say then the labeled
information will be somewhat like this
so you have your labels so you have this
as zero the zeroth position the first
position is also zero the second
position is one because this indicates
number two and then you have third as
zero and so on okay so that is the
significance of this one hot true all
right and then we can check how the data
is uh looking by displaying the the data
and as I mentioned earlier this is
pretty much in the form of digital form
like numbers so all these are like pixel
values so you will not really see an
image in this format but there is a way
to visualize that image I will show you
in a bit and uh this tells you how many
images are there in each set so the
training there are 55,000 images in
training and in the test set there are
10,000 and then validation there are
5,000 so altogether there are 70,000
images all right so let's uh move on and
we we can view the actual image by uh
using the matplot clip library and this
is how you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in Gray
scale so the cmap is what tells in what
way we want to view it and what are the
maximum values and the minimum values of
the pixel values so these are the Max
and minimum values so of the pixel
values so maximum is one because this is
a scaled value so one means it is uh
White and zero means it is black and in
between is it can be anywhere in between
black and white and the way to train the
model there is a certain way in which
you write your tensorflow code and um
the first step is to create some place
holders and then you create a model in
this case we will use the softmax model
one of the simplest ones and and um
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and uh then of
course you will have variables which are
your remember these are your weights and
biases so for in our case there are 10
neurons and uh each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
78 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with a weight and that's what
we are talking about here so these are
this is a a matrix of
784 values for each of the neurons and
uh so it is like a 10x 784 Matrix
because there are 10 neurons and uh
similarly there are biases now remember
I mentioned biases only one per neuron
so it is not one per input unlike the
weights so therefore there are only 10
biases because there are only 10 neurons
in this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is something little new in tens of flow
you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constants so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything as variables or at the
most variables and constants but in tens
of flow you have three different types
placeholders variables and constants and
then you create what is known as a graph
so tensorflow programming consists of
graphs and tensors as I mentioned
earlier so this can be considered
ultimately as a tensor and then the
graph tells how to execute the whole
implementation so that the execution is
stored in the form of a graph and in
this case what we are doing is we are
doing a multiplication TF you remember
this TF was created as a tensorflow
object here one more level one more so
TF is available here now tensor flow has
what is known as a matrix multiplication
or matal function so that is what is
being used here in this case so we are
using the matrix multiplication of
tensor flow so that you multiply your
input values x with W right this is what
we were doing x w + B you're just adding
B and this is in very similar to one of
the earlier slides where we saw Sigma XI
wi so so that's what we are doing here
matrix multiplication is multiplying all
the input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to Define what is our loss function and
what is our Optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensor flows apis so tf.
NN softmax cross entropy with logits is
the uh API that we will use and reduce
mean is what is like the mechanism
whereby which says that you reduce the
error and Optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what Optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
Optimizer we discussed about this in
couple of slides uh earlier and for that
you need to specify the learning rate
you remember we saw that there was a a
slide somewhat like this and then you
define what should be the learning rate
how fast you need to come down that is
the learning rate and this again needs
to be tested and tried and to find out
the optimum level of this learning rate
it shouldn't be very high in which case
it will not converge or shouldn't be
very low because it will in that case it
will take very long so you define the
optimizer and then you call the method
minimize for that Optimizer and that
will Kickstart the training process and
so far we've been creating the graph and
in order to actually execute that graph
we create what is known as a session and
then we run that session and once the
training is completed we specify how
many times how many iterations we want
it to run so for example in this case we
are saying Thousand Steps so that is a
exit strategy in a way so you specify
the exit condition so a training will
run for thousand iterations and once
that is done we can then evaluate the
model using some of the techniques shown
here so let us get into the code quickly
and see how it works so this is our
Cloud environment now you can install
tensor flow on your local machine as
well I'm showing this demo on our
existing Cloud but you can also install
Tor flow on your local machine and uh
there is a separate video on how to set
up your tflow environment you can watch
that if you want to install your local
environment or you can go for or other
any cloud service like for example
Google Cloud Amazon or Cloud Labs any of
these you can use and U run and try the
code okay so it has got
started we will log
in all right so this is our deep
learning tutorial uh code and uh this is
our tensor flow envir
ment and uh so let's get started the
first we have seen a little bit of a
code walk through uh in the slides as
well now you will see the actual code in
action so the first thing we need to do
is import tensor flow and then we will
import the data and we need to adjust
the data in such a way that the one hot
is encoding is set to True one hot
encoding right as I explained earlier so
in this case the label value Val will be
shown appropriately and if we just check
what is the type of the data so you can
see that this is a data sets python data
sets and if we check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float 32
similarly the number if you want to see
what is the number
of training images there are 55,000 then
there test images 10,000 and then
validation images 5,000 now let's take a
quick look at the data itself
visualization so we will use um matte
plot lip for this and um if we take a
look at the shape now shape gives us
like the dimension of the tensors or or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we sees
the size of the training data set using
the method shape it says there are
55,000 and 55,000 by 784 so remember the
784 is nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into
28 so that is equal to 784 so that's
what it is uh showing now we can take
just uh one image and just see what is
the the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
784 similarly you can look at the image
itself the data of the first image
itself so this is how it it shows so
large part of it will probably be zeros
because as you can imagine in the image
only certain areas are written rest is U
black so that's why you will mostly see
zeros either it is black or white but
then there are these values are so the
values are actually they are scaled so
the values are between zero and one okay
so this is what you're seeing so certain
locations there are some values and then
other locations there are zeros so so
that is how the data is stored and
loaded if we want to actually see what
is the value of the handwritten image if
you want to view it this is how you view
it so you create like do this reshape
and um matplot lib has this um feature
to show you these images so we will
actually use the function called um IM
show and then if you pass this
parameters
appropriately you will be able to see
the different images now I can change
the values in this position so which
image we are looking at right so we can
say if I want to see what is there in
maybe
5,000 right
so 5,000 has three similarly you can
just say five what is in five five as 8
what is in
50 again H so basically by the way if
you're wondering uh how I'm executing
this code shift enter in case you're not
familiar with jupyter notebooks shift
enter is how you execute each cell
individual cell and if you want to
execute the entire program you can go
here and say run all so that is
how this code gets executed and um here
again we can check what is the maximum
value and what is the minimum value of
these pixel values as I mentioned this
is it is scaled so therefore it is
between the values lie between 1 and
zero now this is where we create our
model the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create one
placeholder and we create two variables
which is for the weights and biases
these two variables are actually
matrices so each variable has 784 by 10
values okay so one for this 10 is for
each neuron there are 10 neurons and 784
is for the pixel values inputs that are
given which is 28 into 28 and the biases
as I mentioned one for each neuron so
there will be 10 biases they are stored
in a variable by the name b and this is
the graph which is basically the
multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of X into W and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize the
error so let me just execute I think
this code is executed then we Define
what is our the Y value is basically the
label value so this is another
placeholder we had X as one placeholder
and Yore true as a second placeholder
and this will have values in the form of
uh 10 digigit 10 digigit arrays and uh
since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the label for that particular
number all right then we have cross
entropy which is nothing but the loss
loss function and we have the optimizer
we have chosen gradient descent as our
Optimizer then the training process
itself so the training process is
nothing but to minimize the cross
entropy which is again nothing but the
loss function so we Define all of this
in the form of a graph so the up to here
remember what we have done is we have
not exactly executed any tensorflow code
till now we are just preparing the graph
the execution plan that's how the
tensorflow code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice so you may want to view this
uh video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow because the way
tensorflow programming is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who
let's say have done uh maybe spark
programming to some extent will be able
to easily understand this um but even in
spark the the programming the code
itself is pretty straightforward behind
the scenes the execution happens
slightly differently but in tens oflow
even the code has to be written in a
completely different way so the code
doesn't get executed uh in the same way
as you have written so that that's
something you need to understand and a
little bit of practices needed for this
so so far what we have done up to here
is creating the variables and feeding
the variables and um or rather not
feeding but setting up the variables and
uh the graph that's all defining maybe
the uh what kind of a network you want
to use for example we want to use
softmax and so on so you have created
the variables have to load the data
loaded the data viewed the data and
prepared everything but you have not yet
executed anything in tens of flow now
the next step is the execution in tens
of flow so the first step for doing any
execution in tensor flow is to
initialize the variables so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to run this piece of code
always so you need to basically create
what is known as a a node for
initializing so this is a node you still
are not yet executing anything here you
just create a node for the
initialization so let us go ahead and
create that and here onwards is where
you will actually execute your code uh
intensive flow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensorflow session so tf. session will
give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as as a with Loop so you have a
with tf. session as SS and with a uh
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and this session is valid till this
block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf. session as says you say cs. run in
it now cs. run will execute a node that
is specified here so for example here we
are saying cs. run cess is basically an
instance of the session right so here we
are saying tf. session so an instance of
the session gets created and we are
calling that sess and then we run a node
within that one of the nodes in the
graph so one of the nodes here is in it
so we say run that particular node and
that is when the initialization of the
variables happens now what this does is
if you have any variables in your code
in our case we have W is a variable and
B is a variable so any variables that we
created you have to run this code you
have to run the initialization of these
variables otherwise you will get an
error okay so that is the that's what
this is do doing then we within this
width block we specify a for Loop and we
are saying we want the system to iterate
for thousand steps and perform the
training that's what this for Loop does
run training for thousand
iterations and what it is doing
basically is it is fetching the data or
these images remember there are about
50,000 images but but it cannot get all
the images in one shot because it will
take up a lot of memory and performance
issues will be there so this is a very
common way of Performing deep learning
training you always do in batches so we
have maybe 50,000 images but you always
do it in batches of 100 or maybe 500
depending on the size of your system and
so on and so forth so in this case we
are saying okay get me 100 uh images at
a time and get me only the training
images remember we use only the training
data for training purpose and then we
use test data for test purpose you must
be familiar with machine learning so you
must be aware of this but in case you
are not in machine learning also not
this is not specific to deep learning
but in machine learning in general you
have what is known as training data set
and test data set your available data
typically you will be splitting into two
parts and using the training data set
for training purpose and then to see how
well the model has been trained you use
the test data set to check or test the
validity or the accuracy of the model so
that's what we are doing here and You
observe here that we are actually
calling an Mist function here so we are
saying mnist train. nextt batch right so
this is the advantage of using mnist
database because they have provided some
very nice helper functions which are
readily available otherwise this
activity itself we would have had to
write a piece of code to fetch this data
in batches that itself is a a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using amness database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
X and the labels into Y and then you use
this batch of 100 images and you run the
training so s. run basically what we are
doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously the
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the Ws and B get
updated till it reaches thousand
iterations in this case the exit
criteria is thousand but you can also
specify probably accuracy rate or
something like that for the as an exit
criteria so here it is it just says that
okay this particular image was wrongly
predicted so you need to update your
weights and biases that's the feedback
given to each neuron and that is run for
thousand iterations and typically by the
end of this thousand iterations the
model would have learned to recognize
these hand it in images obviously it
will not be 100% accurate okay so once
that is
done after so this happens for thousand
iterations once that is done you then
test the accuracy of these models by
using the test data set right so this is
what we are trying to do here the code
may appear a little complicated because
if you're seeing this for the first time
you need to understand uh the various
methods of tensor flow and so on but it
it is basically comparing the output
with what has been what is actually
there that's all it is doing so you have
your test data and uh you're trying to
find out what is the actual value and
what is the predicted value and seeing
whether they are equal or not TF do
equal right and how many of them are
correct and so on and so forth and based
on that the accuracy is uh calculated as
well so this is the accuracy and uh that
is what we are trying to see how ACC at
the model is in predicting these uh
numbers or these digits okay so let us
run this this entire thing is in one
cell so we will have to just run it in
one shot it may take a little while let
us see and uh not bad so it has finished
the thousand iterations and what we see
here as an output is the accuracy so we
see that the accuracy of this model is
around
91% okay now
which is pretty good for such a short
exercise within such a short time we got
90% accuracy however in real life this
is probably not sufficient so there are
other ways in to increase the accuracy
we will see probably in some of the
later tutorials how to improve this
accuracy how to change maybe the hyper
parameters like number of neurons or
number of layers and so on and so forth
and uh so that this ACC accy can be
increased Beyond 90% hello and welcome
to the tensorflow object detection API
tutorial in this video I will walk you
through the tensorflow code to perform
object detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically you're
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example lpai
we need image I/O datetime and pill and
so on and so forth and of course M plot
lib so we import all these libraries and
then there are a bunch of variables
which have some parts for the files and
folders so this is regular stuff let's
keep moving then we import the M plot
lib and make it in line and uh a few
more Imports all right and then these
are some warnings we can just ignore
them so if I run this code once again
it'll go away all right and then here
onwards we do the model preparation now
what we're going to do is we're going to
use an existing neural network model so
we are not going to train a new one
because that really will take a long
time and uh it needs a lot of uh
computation resources and so on and it
is really not required there already
models that have been trained and in
this case it is the SSD with mobile net
that's the model that we are going to
use and uh this model is trained to
detect objects and uh it is readily
available as open source so we can
actually use this and if you want to use
other models there are a few more models
available so you can click on this link
here and uh let me just take you there
there are a few more models but we have
chosen this particular one because this
is faster it may not be very accurate
but that is one of the faster models but
on this link you will see a lot of other
models that are readily available these
are trained models some of them would
take a little longer but they may be
more ACC at and so on so you can
probably play around with these other
models okay so we will be using that
model so this piece of code this line is
basically importing that model and this
is also known as uh Frozen model the
term we use as Frozen model so we import
download and import that and then we
will actually use that model in our code
all right so these two cells we have
downloaded and imported the model model
and then once it is available locally we
will then load this into our program all
right so we are loading this into memory
and uh you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to to map the numbers to text as
you may be aware when we actually build
the model and when we run predictions
the model will not give a text the
output of the model is us usually a
number so we need to map that to a text
so for example if the network predicts
that the output is five we know that
five means it is an aeroplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
used for doing object detection in
images so this is where the actual
detection starts so here this is the
path for where the images are stored so
this is here once again we are reusing
the code which we wrote for detecting
objects in an image so this is the path
where the image is get stored and this
is the extension and this was done for
about two or three images so we will
continue to use this and uh we go down
I'll skip this section so this is the
cell where we are actually loading the
video and converting it into frames and
then using frame by frame we are
detecting the objects in the image so in
this code what we are doing basically is
there a few lines of code what they do
is basically once they find an object a
box will be drawn around those uh each
of those objects and the input file the
name of the input video file is uh
traffic it is the extension is MP4 and
uh we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image IO so we can
read and write videos using that and uh
the video that we are going to use is
traffic. MP4 you can use any mp4 file
but in our case I picked up video which
has uh like car so let me just show you
so this is in this object detection
folder I have this mp4 file I'll just
quickly play this video it's a little
slow yeah okay so here we go this is the
video it's a short one relatively small
video so that for this particular demo
and what it will do is once we run our
code it will detect each of these cars
and it will annotate them as cars so in
this particular video we only have cars
we can later on see with another video I
think I have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this uh traffic video so let me go back
so we will be reading this frame by
frame and um know actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic annotated and um we will see the
annotated video so let's go back and run
through this piece of code and then we
will come back and see the annotated uh
video this might take a little while so
I will pause the video after running
this particular cell and then come back
to show you the results all right so
let's go ahead and run it so it is
running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar so at the end of it the last
piece or last line of code should be
video writer. close all right so I'll
pause and then I'll come back okay so I
will see you in a little bit all right
so now as you can see here the
processing is done the glass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video we go back to
my file manager so this was the original
traffic. MP4 and now you have here
traffic uncore annotated MP4 so let's go
and run this and see how it
looks you see here it has got each of
these cars are getting detected let me
pause and show you so we pause here it
says car 70% let us allow it to go a
little further it detects something on
top what is that truck okay so I think
because of the board on top it somehow
thinks there is a truck let's playay
some more and see if it detects anything
else so this is again a car looks like
so let us here so this is a car and it
has confidence level of 69 person okay
this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each every car that is passing
by now we can quickly repeat this
process for another video let me just
show you the other video which is a cat
again there is uh this cat is not really
moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and uh our application
will our network will detect that this
is a cat and uh even when the cat moves
a little bit in the other direction
it'll continue to detect and show that
it is a cat okay so yeah so this is how
the original video is let's go ahead and
change our code to analyze this one and
see if it detects our Network detects
the Cat close this here we go and I'll
go back to my code all we need to do is
change this traffic to cat the extension
it will automatically pick up because it
is given here and then it will run
through so very quickly once again what
it is doing is this video reader video
uncore Read reader has a a neat little
feature or interface whereby you can say
for frame in video reader so it will
basically provide frame by frame so you
are in a loop frame by frame and then
you take that each frame that is given
to you you take it and analyze it as if
it is an image individual image so
that's the way it works so it is very
easy to handle this all right so now
let's once again run just this cell rest
of the stuff Remains the Same so I will
run this cell again it will take a
little while so the hour glasses come
back I will pause and then come back in
a little while all right so the
processing is done let's go and check
the annotated video go here so we have
cat annotated MP4 let's play this all
right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here let's see
yes so what is it trying to show here
it's too small not able to see but uh it
is trying to detect something I think it
is saying there's a car I don't know all
right okay so in this video there's only
pretty much only one object which is the
cat and uh let's wait for some time and
see if it continues to detect it when
the cat turns around and moves as well
just in a little bit that's going to
happen and we will see there we go and
it's in spite of turning the other way I
think our network is able to detect that
it is a cat so let me freeze and then
show here it is actually still continues
to detect it as a cat all right so
that's pretty much it I think that's the
only object that it detects in this
particular video okay so close this so
that's pretty much it thank you very
much for watching this video and you
have a great day and in case you have
any questions please uh put them below
the video here and we will be more than
happy to get back to you and make sure
you put your email ID so that we can
contact you in case you have any
questions thank you once again bye-bye
today we're going to be covering the
convolutional neural network tutorial do
you know how deep learning recognizes
the objects in an image and really this
particular neural network is how image
recognition works it's very Central one
of the biggest building blocks for image
recognition it does it using convolution
neural network and we over here we have
the basic picture of a uh hummingbird
pixels of an image fed as input you have
your input layer coming in so it takes
that graphic and puts it into the input
layer you have all your hidden layers
and then you have your output layer and
your output layer one of those is going
to light up and say oh it's a bird we're
going to go into depth we're going to
actually go back and forth on this a
number of times today so if you're not
catching all the image um don't worry
we're going to get into the details so
we have our input layer accepts the
pixels of the image as input in the form
of arrays and you can see here where
they've actually um labeled each block
of the bird in different arrays so we'll
dive into deep as to how that looks like
and how those matrixes are set up your
hidden layer carry out feature
extraction by performing certain
calculations and manipulation so this is
the part that kind of reorganizes that
picture multiple ways until we get some
data that's easy to read for the neural
network this layer uses a matrix filter
and performs convolution operation to
detect patterns in the image and if you
remember that convolution means to coil
or to twist so we're going to twist the
data around and alter it and use that
operation to detect a new pattern there
are multiple hidden layers like
convolution layer real U is how that is
pronounced and that's the rectified
linear unit that has to do with the
activation function that's used pooling
layer also uses multiple filters to
detect edges corners eyes feathers beak
Etc and just like the term says pooling
is pulling information together and
we'll look into that a lot closer here
so if you're if it's a little confusing
now we'll dig in deep and try to get you
uh squared away with that and then
finally there is a fully connected layer
that identifies the object in the image
so we have these different layers coming
through in the hidden layers and they
come into the final area and that's
where we have say one node or one neural
network entity that lights up that says
it's a bird what's in it for you we're
going to cover an introduction to the
CNN what is convolution neural network
nwor how CNN recognizes images we're
going to dig deeper into that and really
look at the individual layers in the
convolutional neural network and finally
we do a use case implementation using
the CNN we'll begin our introduction to
the CNN by introducing ja Pioneer of
convolutional neural network Yan leun he
was the director of Facebook AI research
group built the first convolutional
neural network called lenette in
1988 so these have been around for a
while and have had a chance to mature
over the years it was used for character
recognition tasks like reading zip code
digits imagine processing mail and
automating that process CNN is a feed
forward neural network that is generally
used to analyze visual images by
producing data with a grid-like topology
a CNN is also known as a convet and very
key to this is we are looking at images
that was what this was designed for and
you'll see the different layers as we
dig in Mirror some of the other some of
them are actually now used since we're
using uh tensorflow and carass in our
code later on you'll see that some of
those layers appear in a lot of your
other neural network Frameworks uh but
in this case this is very Central to
processing images and doing so in a
variety that captures multiple images
and really drills down into their
different features in this example here
you see flowers of two varieties Orchid
and a rose I think the Orchid is much
more dainty and beautiful and the rose
smells quite beautiful I have a couple
rose bushes in my yard uh they go into
the input layer that data is in to all
the different nodes in the next layer
one of the Hidden layers based on its
different weights and its setup it then
comes out and gives those a new value
those values then are multiplied by
their weights and go to the next hidden
layer and so on and then you have the
output layer and one of those nodes
comes out and says it's an orchid and
the other one comes out and says it's a
rose depending on how was well it was
trained what separates the CNN or the
convolutional neural network from other
neural networks is a convolutional
operation forms a basis of any
convolutional neural network in a CNN
every image is represented in the form
of arrays of pixel values so here we
have a real image of the digit 8 uh that
then gets put onto its pixel values
represented in the form of an array in
this case you have a two-dimensional
array and then you can see in the final
in form we transform the digit 8 into
its representational form of pixels of
zeros and one where the ones represent
in this case the black part of the eight
and the zeros represent the white
background to understand the convolution
neural network or how that convolutional
operation Works we're going to take a
side step and look at matrixes and this
case we're going to simplify it we're
going to take two matrices A and B of
one dimension now kind of separate this
from your thinking as we learn that you
want to focus just on the Matrix aspect
of this and then we'll bring that back
together and see what that looks like
when we put the pieces for the
convolutional operation here we've set
up two arrays we have uh in this case
there a single dimension Matrix and we
have AAL 5
37597 and we have b equal 123 so in the
convolution as it comes in there it's
going to look at these two and we're
going to start by doing multiplying them
a * B and so we multiply the arrays
element wise and we get 5 6 6 where five
is the 5 * 1 6 is 3 * 2 and then the
other six is 2 * 3 and since the two
arrays aren't the same size they're not
the same setup we're going to just
truncate the first one and we're going
to look at the second array multiplied
just by the first three elements of the
first array now that it's going to be a
little confusing remember a computer
gets to repeat these processes hundreds
of times so we're not going to just
forget those other numbers later on
we'll see we'll bring those back in and
then we have the sum of the product in
this case 5 + 6 + 6 = 17 so in our a * B
our very first digit in that Matrix of a
* B is 17 and if you remember I said
we're not going to forget the other
digits so we now have 325 we move one
set over and we take 325 and we multiply
that * B and you'll see that 3 * 1 is 3
2 * 2 is 4 and so on and so on WE sum it
up so now we have the second digit of
our a * B product in The Matrix and we
continue on with that same thing so on
and so on so then we would go from uh
375 to 759 to 597 this short Matrix that
we have for a we've now covered all the
different entities in a that match three
different levels of B now in a little
bit we're going to cover where we use
this math at this multiplying of
matrixes and how that works uh but it's
important to understand that we're going
through the Matrix and multiplying the
different parts to it to match the
smaller Matrix with the larger Matrix I
know a lot of people get lost at is you
know what's going on here with these
matrixes uh oh scary math not really
that scary when you break it down we're
looking at a section of a and we're
comparing it to B so when you break that
down your mind like that you realize
okay so I'm I'm just taking these two
matrixes and comparing them and I'm
bringing the value down into one Matrix
a * B we're producing that information
in a way that will help the computer see
different aspects let's go ahead and
flip over again back to our images here
we are back to our images talking about
going to the most basic two-dimensional
image you can get to consider the
following two images the image for the
symbol backs slab when you press the
back slash the above image is processed
you can see there for the image for the
forward slash is the opposite so we
click the forward slash button that
flips uh very basic we have four pixels
going in can't get any more basic than
that here we have a little bit more
complicated picture we take a real image
of a smiley face um then we represent
that in the form of black and white
pixels so if this was an image in the
computer it's black and white and like
we saw before we convert this into the
zeros and ones so with the other one
would have just been a matrix of just
four dots now we have a significantly
larger image coming in so don't worry
we're going to bring this all together
here in just a little bit layers in
convolutional neural network when we're
looking at this we have our convolution
layer and that really is the central
aspect of processing images in the
convolutional neural network that's why
we have it and then that's going to be
feeding in and you have your relu layer
which is you know as we talked about the
rectified linear unit we'll talk about
that a little bit later the reu is an
how it Act is how that layer is
activated is the math behind it what
makes the neurons fire you'll see that
in a lot of other neural networks when
you're using it just by itself it's for
processing smaller amounts of data where
you use the atom activation feature for
large data coming in now because we're
processing small amounts of data in each
image the reu layer works great you have
your pooling layer that's where you're
pulling the data together pooling is a
neural network term it's very commonly
used I like to use a term reduce so if
you're coming from the map and reduce
side you'll see that we're mapping all
this data through all these networks and
then we're going to reduce it we're
going to pull it together and then
finally we have the fully connected
layer that's where our output's going to
come out so we have started to look at
matrixes we've started to look at the
convolutional layer and where it fits in
and everything we've taking a look at
images so we're going to focus more on
the convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform convolution
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixel values consider the
following 5x5 image whose pixel values
are only zero and one now obviously when
we're dealing with color there's all
kinds of things that come in on color
processing but we want to keep it simple
and just keep it black and white and so
we have our image pixels uh so we're
sliding the filter Matrix over the image
and Computing the dot product to detect
the patterns and right here you're going
to ask where does this filter come from
this is a bit confusing because the
filter is going to be derived uh later
on we build the filters when we program
or train our model so you don't need to
worry what the filter actually is but
you do need to understand how a
convolution layer works is what is the
filter doing filter and you'll have many
filters you don't have just one filter
you'll have lots of filters that are
going to look for different aspects and
so the filter might be looking for just
edges it might be looking for different
Parts we'll cover that a little bit more
detail in a minute right now we're just
focusing on how the filter works as a
matrix remember earlier we talked about
multiplying matrixes together and here
we have our two-dimensional Matrix and
you can see we take the filter and we
multiply it in the upper left image and
you can see right here 1 * 1 1 * 0 1 * 1
we multiply those all together then sum
them and we end up with a convolved
feature of four we're going to take that
and sliding the filter Matrix over the
image and Computing the DOT product to
detect patterns so we're just going to
slide this over we're going to predict
the first one and slide it over one
notch predict the second one and so on
and so on all the way through until we
have a new Matrix and this Matrix which
is the same size as a filter has reduced
the image and whatever filter whatever
that's filtering out it's going to be
looking at just those features reduced
down to a smaller uh Matrix so once the
feature maps are extracted the next step
is to move them to the layer so the
realu layer The Next Step first is going
to perform an element wise operation so
each of those Maps coming in if there's
negative pixels so it sets all the
negative pixels to zero um and you can
see this nice graph where it just zeros
out the negatives and then you have a
value that goes from zero up to whatever
value is um coming out of the Matrix
this introduces nonlinearity to the
network uh so up until now we have a we
say linearity we're talking about the
fact that the Fe feature has a value so
it's a linear feature this feature um
came up and has let's say the feature is
the edge of the beak you know it's like
or the backslash that we saw um you'll
look at that and say okay this feature
has a value from -10 to 10 in this case
um if it was one and say yeah this might
be a beak it might not might be an edge
right there a minus five means no we're
not even going to look at it it's a zero
and so we end up with an output and the
output takes all these feature all these
filtered features remember we're not
just running one filter on this we're
running a number of filters on this
image and so we end up with an rectified
feature map that is looking at just the
features coming through and how they
weigh in from our filters so here we
have an input of a looks like a toucan
bird very exotic looking real image is
scanned in multiple convolution and the
reu layers for locating features and you
can see up here is turned it into a
black and white image and in this case
we're looking in the upper right hand
corner for a feature and that box scans
over a lot of times it doesn't scan one
pixel at a time a lot of times it will
Skip by two or three or four pixels uh
to speed up the process that's one of
the ways you can compensate if you don't
have enough resources on your
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter slowly goes across
the image uh you have multiple filters
that been programmed in there so you're
looking at a lot of different filters
going over the different aspects of the
image and just sliding across there and
forming a new Matrix one more aspect to
note about the reu layer is we're not
just having one reu coming in uh so not
only do we have multiple features going
through but we're generating multiple
reu layers for locating the features
that's very important to note you know
so we have a quite a bundle we have
multiple filters multiple railu uh which
brings us to the next step forward
propagation now we're going to look at
the pooling layer the rectified feature
map now goes through a pooling layer
pooling is a down sound sampling
operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map that's
all we're trying to do we're trying to
take a huge amount of information and
reduce it down to a single answer this
is a specific kind of bird this is an
iris this is a rose so you have a
rectified feature map and you see here
we have a rectified feature map coming
in um we set the max pooling with a 2X
two filters and a stride of Two And if
you remember correctly I talked about
not going one pixel at a time uh well
that's where the stride comes in we end
up with a 2X two pulled feature map but
instead of moving one over each time and
looking at every possible combination we
skip a we skip a few there we go by two
we skip every other pixel and we just do
every other one um and this reduces our
rectified feature map which as you can
see over here 16x 16 to a 4x4 so we're
continually trying to filter and reduce
our data so that we can get to something
we can manage and over here you see that
we have the Max uh 34 4 1 and two and in
the max pooling we're looking for the
max value a little bit different than
what we were looking at before so coming
from the rectified feature we're now
finding the max value and then we're
pulling those features together so
instead of think of this as image of the
map think of this as how valuable is a
feature in that area how much of a
feature value do we have and we just
want to find the best or the maximum
feature for that area they might have
that one piece of the filter of the beak
said oh I see a one in this beak in this
image and then it skips over and says I
see a three in this image and says oh
this one is rated as a four we don't
want to sum it together cuz then you
know you might have like five ones and
it say ah five but you might have uh
four zeros and one 10 and that 10 says
well this is definitely a beak where the
ones will say probably not a beak a
little strange analogy since we're
looking at a bird but you can see how
that pulled feature map comes down and
we're just looking for the max value in
each one of those matrixes pooling layer
uses different filters to identify
different parts of the image like edges
corners body feathers eyes beak Etc um I
know I focus mainly on the beak but
obviously uh each feature could be each
a different part of the bird coming in
so let's take a look at what that looks
like structure of a convolution neural
network so far this is where we're at
right now we have our input image coming
in and then we use our filters and
there's multiple filters on there that
are being developed to kind of twist and
change that data and so multiply the
matrixes we take that little filter
maybe it's a 2X two we multiply it by
each piece of the image and if we step
two then it's every other piece of the
image that generates multiple
convolution layers so we have a number
of convolution layers we have um set up
in there just looking at that data we
then take those convolution layers we
run them through the reu setup and then
once we've done through the reu setup
and we have multiple reu going on
multiple layers that are relu then we're
going to take those multiple layers and
we're going to be pooling them so now we
have the pooling layers or multiple
poolings going on up until this point
we're dealing with uh sometimes it's
multiple Dimensions you can have three
dimensions some strange data setups that
aren't doing images but looking at other
things they can have four five six seven
dimensions uh so right now we're looking
at 2D image Dimensions coming in into
the pooling layer so the next step is we
want to reduce those Dimensions or
flatten them so flattening flattening is
a process of converting all of the
resultant two-dimensional arrays from
pulled feature map into a single long
continuous linear Vector so over here
you see where we have a pulled feature
map maybe that's the Birdwing and it has
values 6847 and we want to just flatten
this out and turn it into 6847 or a
single linear vector and we find out
that not only do we do each of the
pulled feature Maps we do all of them
into one long linear Vector so now we've
gone through our convolutional neural
network part and we have the input layer
into the next setup all we've done done
is taken all those different pooling
layers and we flatten them out and
combine them into a single linear Vector
going in so after we've done the
flattening we have a just a quick recap
because we've covered so much so it's
important to go back and take a look at
each of the steps we've gone through the
structure of the network so far is we
have our convolution where we twist it
and we filter it and multiply the
matrixes we end up with our
convolutional layer which uses the relu
to figure out the values going out into
the pooling and you have numerous
convolution layers that then create
numerous pooling layers pulling that
data together which is the max value
which one we want to send forward we
want to send the best value and then
we're going to take all of that from
each of the pooling layers and we're
going to flatten it and we're going to
combine them into a single input going
into the final layer once you get to
that step you might be looking at that
going boy that looks like the normal
inut to most neural network and you're
correct it is so once we have the
flattened Matrix from the pooling layer
that becomes our input put so the
pooling layer is fed as an input to the
fully connected layer to classify the
image and so you can see as our
flattened Matrix comes in in this case
we have the pixels from the flatten
Matrix fed as an input back to our
twocan or whatever that kind of bird
that is um I need one of these to
identify what kind of bird that is it
comes into our forward propagation
network uh and that will then have the
different weights coming down across and
then finally it selects that that's a
bird and that it's not a dog or a cat in
this case even though it's not labeled
the final layer there in red is our
output layer our final output layer that
says bird cat or dog so quick recap of
everything we've covered so far we have
our input image which is twisted and
multiply the filters are multiplied
times the uh matri the two matrixes
multiplied all the filters to create our
convolution layer our convolution layers
there's multiple layers in there because
it's all building multiple layers off
the different filters then goes through
the reu as say activation and that
creates our pooling and so once we get
into the pooling layer we then on the
pooling look for who's the best what's
the max value coming in from our
convolution and then we take that layer
and we flatten it and then it goes into
a fully connected layer our fully
connected neural network and then to the
output and here we can see the entire
process how the CNN recognizes a bird
this is kind of nice cuz it's showing
the little pixels and where they're
going you can see the filter is
generating this convolution network and
that filter shows up in the bottom part
of the convol solution Network and then
based on that it uses the relo for the
pooling the pooling then find out which
one's the best and so on all the way to
the fully connected layer at the end or
the classification and the output layer
so that'd be a classification neural
network at the end so we covered a lot
of theory up till now and you can
imagine each one of these steps has to
be broken down in code so putting that
together can be a little complicated not
that each step of the process is overly
complicated but because we have so many
steps uh we have 1 2 3 four five
different steps going on here with
substeps in there we're going to break
that down and walk through that in code
so in our use case implementation using
the CNN we'll be using the CFR 10 data
set from Canadian Institute for advanced
research for classifying images across
10 categories Unfortunately they don't
let me know whether it's going to be a
twocan or some other kind of bird but we
do get to find out whether it can
categorize between a ship a frog deer
bird airplane automobile cat dog horse
truck so that's a lot of fun and then if
you're looking anything in the news at
all of our automated cars and everything
else you can see where this kind of
processing is so important in today's
world and very Cutting Edge as far as
what's coming out in the commercial
deployment I mean this is really cool
stuff we're starting to see this just
about everywhere in Industry uh so great
time to be playing with this and
figuring it all out let's go ahead and
dive into the code and see what that
looks like when we're we're actually
writing our script before we go on let's
do uh one more quick look at what we
have here let's just take a look at data
batch one keys and remember in Jupiter
notebook I can get by with not doing the
print statement if I put a variable down
there it'll just display the variable
and you can see under data batch one for
the keys since this is a dictionary we
have the batch one label data and file
names uh so you can actually see how
it's broken up in our data set so for
the next step or step four as we're
calling it uh we want to display the
image using Matt plot Library there's
many ways to display the images you
could even uh well there's other ways to
drill into it but map plot library is
really good for this and we'll also look
at our first reshape uh setup or shaping
the data so you can have a little
glimpse into what that means uh so we're
going to start by importing our map plot
and of course since I am doing Jupiter
notebook I need to do the map plot
inline command so it shows up on my page
so here we go we're going to import
matplot library. pip plot is PLT and if
you remember M plot Library the P plot
is like a canvas that we paint stuff
onto and there's my percentage sign map
plot library in line so it's going to
show up in my notebook and then of
course we're going to import numpy as NP
for our numbers python array setup and
let's go ahead and set u x equals to
data batch one so this will pull in all
the data going into the x value and then
because this is just a long stream of
binary data uh we need to go a little
bit of reshaping so in here we have to
go ahead and reshape the data we have
10,000 images okay that looks correct
and this is kind of an interesting thing
it took me a little bit to I had to go
research this myself to figure out
what's going on with this data and what
it is is it's a 32x32 picture and let me
do this let me go ahead and do a drawing
pad on here uh so we have 32 bits by 32
bits and it's in color so there's three
bits of color now I don't know why the
data is particularly like this it
probably has to do with how they
originally encoded it but most pictures
put the three afterward so what we're
doing here is we're going to take uh the
shape we're going to take the data which
is just a long stream of information and
we're going to break it up into 10,000
pieces and those 10,000 pieces then are
broken into three pieces each and those
three pieces then are 32x 32 you could
look at this like an oldfashioned
projector where they have the red screen
or the red projector the blue projector
and the green projector and they add
them all together and each one of those
is a 32x 32 bit so that's probably how
this was originally formatted with in
that kind of Ideal things have changed
so we're going to transpose it and we're
going to take the three which was here
and we're going to put it at the end so
the first part is reshaping the data
from a single line of bit data or
whatever format it is into 10,000 x 3X
32x 32 and then we're going to transpose
the color Factor to the last place so
it's the image then the 32x 32 in the
middle that's this part right here and
then finally we're going to take this uh
which is three bits of data and put it
at the end so it's more like we do we
process images now and then as type this
is really important that we're going to
use an integer 8 you can come in here
and you'll see a lot of these they'll
try to do this with a float or a float
64 what you got to remember though is a
float uses a lot lot of memory so once
you switch this into uh something that's
not integer 8 which is goes up to 128
you are just going to the the amount of
ram let just put that in here is going
to go way up the amount of ram that it
loads uh so you want to go ahead and use
this you can try the other ones and see
what happens if you have a lot of RAM on
your computer but for this exercise this
will work just fine and let's go ahead
and take that and run this so now our X
variable is all loaded and it has all
the images in from the batch one data
batch one and just to show we were
talking about with the as type on there
if we go ahead and take x0 and just look
for its max value let me go ahead and
run that uh you'll see it doesn't oops I
said 128 it's 255 uh you'll see it
doesn't go over 255 because it's an
basically an asky character is what
we're keeping that down to we're keeping
those values down so they're only 255 0
to 255 versus a float value which would
bring this up um exponentially in size
and since we're using the map plot
Library we can do um oops that's not
what I wanted since we're using the map
plot Library we can take our canvas and
just do a PLT do IM for image show and
let's just take a look at what xzero
looks like and it comes in I'm not sure
what that is but you can see it's a very
low grade image uh broken down to the
minimal pixels on there and if we did
the same thing oh let's do uh let's see
what one looks like hopefully it's a
little easier to see run on there not
enter let's hit the run on that uh and
we can see this is probably a semi TR
that's a good guess on there and I can
just go back up here instead of typing
the same line in over and over and we'll
look at three uh that looks like a dump
truck unloading uh and so on you can do
any of the 10,000 images we can just
jump to 55 uh looks like some kind of
animal looking at us there probably a
dog and just for fun let's do just one
more uh uh run on there and we can see a
nice car for image number four uh so you
can see we past through all the
different images and it's very easy to
look at them and they've been reshaped
to fit our view and what the uh map plot
Library uses for its format so the next
step is we're going to start creating
some helper functions we'll start by a
one hot encoder to help us we're
processing the data remember that your
labels they can't just be words they
have to switch it and we use the one hot
encoder to do that and then we'll also
create a uh class uh CFR helper so it's
going to have a knit and a setup for the
images and then finally we'll go ahead
and run that code so you can see what
that looks like and then we get into the
fun part where we're actually going to
start creating our model our actual
neural network model so let's start by
creating our one hot encoder we're going
to create our own here uh and it's going
to return an out and we'll have our
Vector coming in and our values equal 10
what this means is that we have the 10
values the 10 possible labels and
remember we don't look at the labels as
a number cuz a car isn't one more than a
horse that'd be just kind of bizarre to
have horse equals zero car equals 1
plane equals 2 cat equals three so a cat
plus a car equals what uh so instead we
create a numpy array of zeros and
there's going to be 10 values so we have
10 different values in there so you have
uh zero or one one means it's a cat zero
means it's not a cat um in the next line
it might be that uh one means it's a car
zero means it's not a car so instead
instead of having one output with a
value of 0 to 10 you have 10 outputs
with the values of 0 to one that's what
the one hot incoder is doing here and
we're going to utilize this in code in
just a minute so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next helpers we have a few
of these helper functions we're going to
build and when you're working with a
very complicated python project dividing
it up into separate definitions and
classes is very important otherwise it
just becomes really ungainly to work
with so let's go ahead and put in our
next helper uh which is a class and this
is a lot in this class so we we'll break
it down here let's just start uh oops we
put a space right in there there we go
now this a little bit more readable add
a second space so we're going to create
our class the cipher Helper and we'll
start by initializing it now there's a
lot going on in here so let's start with
the uh nit part uh self. I equals z
that'll come in in a little bit we'll
come back to that in the lower part we
want to initialize our training batches
so when we went through this there was
like a meta batch we don't need the meta
batch but we do need the data batch 1 2
3 4 five and we do not want the testing
batch in here this is just the self all
train batches so we're going to come
make an array of of all those different
images and then of course we leftt the
test batch out so we have our self. test
batch uh we're going to initialize the
training images and the training labels
and also the test images and the test
labels so these are just this is just to
izee these variables in here then we
create another definition down here and
this is going to set up the images let's
just take a look and see what's going on
in there now we could have all just put
this as part of the uh init part uh
since this is all just helper stuff but
breaking it up again makes it easier to
read it also makes it easier when we
start executing the different pieces to
see what's going on so that way we have
a nice print statement to say hey we're
now running this and this is what's
going on in here we're going to set up
these self-training images at this point
and and that's going to go to a numpy
array vstack and in there we're going to
load up uh in this case the data for D
and S all train batches again that
points right up to here so we're going
to go through each one of these uh files
or each one of these data sets because
they're not a file anymore we've brought
them in data batch one points to the
actual data and so our self-training
images is going to stack them all into
our into a numpy array and then it's
always nice to get the training length
and that's just a total number of uh
self-training images in there and then
we're going to take the selft trining
images let me switch marker colors CU I
am getting a little too much on the
markers up here oops there we go bring
down our marker change so we can see it
a little better and at this point this
should look familiar where did we see
this well when we wanted to uh uh look
at this above and we want to look at the
images in the matap plot Library we had
to reshape it so we're doing the same
thing here we're taking our
self-training images and and uh based on
the training length total number of
images because we stacked them all
together so now it's just one large file
of images we're going to take and look
at it as our our three video cameras
that are each displaying uh 32x 32 we're
going to switch that around so that now
we have um each of our images that stays
the same place and then we have our 32
by 32 and then by our three our last our
three different values for the color and
of course we want to go ahead and uh
they run this where you say divide by
255 that was from earlier it just brings
all the data into 0 to one that's what
this is doing so we're turning this into
a 0 to one array which is uh all the
pictures 32x 32 by3 and then we're going
to take the self-training labels and
we're going to pump those through our
one hot encoder we just made and we're
going to stack them together and uh
again we're converting this into an
array that goes from uh instead of
having horse equals one dog equals two
and then horse plus dog would equal
three which would be cat no it's going
to be you know an array of 10 where each
one is 0er to one then we want to go
ahead and set up our test images and
labels and uh when we're doing this
you're going to see it's the same thing
we just did with the rest of let me just
change colors right here this is no
different than what we were doing up
here with our training Set uh we're
going to stack the different uh images
uh we're going to get the length of them
so we know how many images in there uh
you certainly could add them by hand but
it's nice to let the computer do it
especially if it ever changes on the
other end and you're using other data
and again we reshape them and transpose
them and we also do the one hot encoder
same thing we just did on our training
images so now our test images are in the
same format so now we have a definition
which sets up all our images in there
and then the next step is to go ahead
and batch them or next batch and let's
do another breakout here for batches
because this is really really important
to understand tends to throw me for a
little Loop when I'm working with tensor
flow or carass or a lot of these we have
our data coming in if you remember we
had like 10,000 photos let me just put
10,000 down here we don't want to run
all 10,000 at once so we want to break
this up into batch sizes and you also
remember that we had the number of
photos in this case uh length of test or
whatever numberers in there uh we also
have 32 by 32 by 3 so when we're looking
at the batch size we want to change this
from 10,000 to um a batch of in this
case I think we're going to do batches
of 100 so we want to look at just 100
the first 100 of the photos and if you
remember we set selfi equal to zero uh
so what we're looking at here is we're
going to create X we're going to get the
next batch from the very initialized
we've already initialized it for zero so
we're going to look at X from zero to
batch size which we set to 100 so just
the first 100 images and then we're
going to reshape that into uh and this
is important to let the data know that
we're looking at 100x 32x 32x 3 now
we've already formatted it to the 32x
32x 3 this just sets everything up
correctly so that X has the data in
there in the correct order and the
correct shape and then the Y just like
the X uh is our labels so our training
labels again they go from zero to batch
size in this case they do selfi plus
batch size cuz the selfi is going to
keep changing and then finally we
increment the selfi cuz we have zero so
we so the next time we call it we're
going to get the next batch size and so
basically we have X and Y X being the
photograph data coming in and Y being
the label and that of course is labeled
through one hot encoder so if you
remember correctly if it was say horse
is equal to zero it would be um one for
the zero position since this is the
horse and then everything else would be
zero in here me just put lines through
there there we go there's our array hard
to see that array so let's go ahead and
take that and uh we're going to finish
loading it since this is our class and
now we're armed with all this um uh our
setup over here let's go ahead and load
that up and so we're going to create a
variable CH with the CFR helper in it
and then we're going to do ch. setup
images uh now we could have just put all
the setup images under the init but by
breaking this up into two parts it makes
it much more readable and um also if
you're doing other work there's reasons
to do that as far as the setup let's go
ahead and run that and you can see where
it says uh setting up training images
and labels setting up test images and
that's one of the reasons we broke it up
is so that if you're testing this out
you can actually have print statements
in there telling you what's going on
which is really nice uh they did a good
job with this setup I like the way that
it was broken up in the back and then
one quick note you want to remember that
batch to set up the next batch since we
have to run uh batch equals CH next
batch of 100 cuz we're going to use the
100 size uh but we'll come back to that
we're going to use that just remember
that that's part of our code we're going
to be using in a minute from the
definition we just made so now we're
ready to create our model first thing we
want to do is we want to import our
tensor flow as TF I'll just go ahead and
run that so it's loaded up and you can
see we got a a warning here uh that's
because they're making some changes it's
always growing and they're going to be
depreciating one of the uh values from
float 64 to float type or it's treated
as an NP float 64 uh nothing to really
worry about cuz this doesn't even affect
what we're working on because we've set
all of our stuff to a 255 value or 0 to
one and do keep in mind that 0o to one
value that we converted to 255 is still
a float value uh but it'll easily work
with either the uh numpy float 64 or the
numpy dtype float it doesn't matter
which one it goes through so the
depreciation would not affect our code
as we have it and in our tensor flow uh
we'll go ahead let me just increase the
size in there just just a moment so you
can get better view of the um what we're
typing in uh we're going to set a couple
placeholders here and so we have we're
going to set x equals TF placeholder TF
float 32 we just talked about the float
64 versus the numpy float we're actually
just going to keep this at float 32 more
than a significant number of decimals
for what we're working with and since
it's a placeholder we're going to set
the shape equal to and we've set it
equal to none cuz at this point we're
just hold holding the place on there
we'll be setting up as we run the
batches that's what the first value is
and then 32x 32x 3 that's what we
reshaped our data to fit in and then we
have our y true equals placeholder T of
float 32 and the shape equals none comma
10 10 is the 10 different labels we have
so it's an array of 10 and then let's
create one more placeholder we'll call
this a hold prob or hold probability and
we're going to use this we don't have to
have a shape or anything for this this
placeholder is for what we call Dropout
if you remember from our Theory before
we drop out so many nodes is looking at
or the different values going through
which helps decrease bias so we need to
go ahead and put a a placeholder for
that also and we'll run this so it's all
loaded up in there so we have our three
different placeholders and since we're
in tensor flow when you use carass it
does some of this automatically but
we're in tensor flow direct carass sits
on tensor flow we're going to go ahead
and create some more helper functions
we're going to create something to help
us initialize the weights initialize our
bias if you remember that each uh layer
has to have a bias going in we're going
to go ahead and work on our our
conversional 2D our Max pool so we have
our pooling layer our convolutional
layer and then our normal full layer so
we're going to go ahead and put those
all into definitions and let's see what
that looks like in code and you can also
grab some of these helper functions from
the MN the uh nist setup let me just put
that in there if you're under the tensor
flow so a lot of these are already in
there but we're going to go ahead and do
our own and we're going to create our uh
a knit weight and one of the reasons
we're doing this is so that you can
actually start thinking about what's
going on in the back end so even though
there's ways to do this with an
automation sometimes these have to be
tweaked and you have to put in your own
setup in here uh now we're not going to
be doing that we're just going to
recreate them for our code and let's
take a look at this we have our weights
and so what comes in is going to be the
shape and what comes out is going to be
uh random numbers so we're going to go
ahead and just nit some random numbers
based on the shape with a standard
deviation of 0.1 kind of a fun way to do
that and then the TF variable uh in nit
random distribution so we're just
creating a random distribution on there
that's all that is for the weights now
you might change that you might have a a
higher standard deviation in some cases
you actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weights configure with each other uh now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with a
constant uh in this case we're using 0.1
a lot of times the bias is just put in
as one and then you have your weights to
add on to that uh but we're going to set
this as 0.1 uh so we want to return a
convolutional 2d in this case a neural
network this is uh would be a layer on
here what's going on with the con 2D is
we're taking our data coming in uh we're
going to filter it strides if you
remember correctly strides came from
here's our image and then we only look
at this picture here and then maybe we
have a stride of one so we look at this
picture here and we continue to look at
the different filters going on there the
other thing this does is that we have
our data coming in as
32 by
32 by 3 and we want to change this so
that it's just this is three dimensions
and it's going to reformat this as just
two Dimensions so it's going to take
this number here and combine it with the
32x 32 so this is a very important layer
here cuz it's reducing our data down
using different me means and it connects
down I'm just going to jump down one
here uh it goes with the convolutional
layer so you have your your kind of your
pre-form formatting and the setup and
then you have your actual convolution
layer that goes through on there and you
can see here we have a knit weights by
the shape a knit bias shape of three
because we have the three different uh
here's our three again and then we
return the tfnn relu with the convention
2D so this convolutional uh has this
feeding into it right there it's using
that as part of it and of course the
input is the XY plus b the bias so
that's quite a mouthful but these two
are the are the keys here to creating
the convolutional layers there the
convolutional 2D coming in and then the
convolutional layer which then steps
through and creates all those filters we
saw then of course we have our pooling
uh so after each time we run through the
convectional layer we want to pull the
data uh if you remember correctly on the
on the pool side and let me just get rid
of all my marks it's getting a little
crazy there and in fact let's go ahead
and jump back to that slide let's just
take a look at that slide over here uh
so we have our image coming in we create
our convolutional layer with all the
filters remember the filters go um you
know the filters coming in here and it
looks at these four boxes and then if
it's a step let's say step two it then
goes to these four boxes and then the
next step and so on uh so we have our
convolutional layer that we generate or
convolutional layers they use the uh
relu function um there's other functions
out there for this though the reu is the
uh most the one that works the best at
least so far I'm sure that will change
then we have our pooling now if you
remember correctly the pooling was Max
uh so if we had the filter coming in and
they did the multiplication on there and
we have a one and maybe a two here and
another one here and a three here three
is the max and so out of all of these
you then create an array that would be
three and if the max is over here two or
whatever it is that's what goes into the
pooling of what's going on in our
pooling uh so again we're reducing that
data down we're reducing it down as
small as we can and then finally we're
going to flatten it out into a single
array and that goes into our fully
connected layer and you can see that
here in the code right here we're going
to create our normal full layer um so at
some point we're going to take from our
pooling layer this will go into some
kind of flattening process and then that
will be fed into the full the different
layers going in down here um and so we
have our input size you'll see our input
layer get shape which is just going to
get the shape for whatever is coming in
uh and then input size initial weights
is also based on uh the input layer
coming in and the input size down here
is based on the input layer shape so
we're just going to already use the
shape and already have our size coming
in and of course uh you have to make
sure you init the bias always put your
bias on there and we'll do that based on
the size so this will return tf. matm
input layer w+b this is just a normal
full layer that's what this means right
down here that's what we're going to
return so that was a lot of steps we
went through let's go ahead and run that
so those are all loaded in there and
let's go ahead and uh create the layers
let's see what that looks like now that
we've done all the heavy lifting and
everything uh we get to do all the easy
part let's go ahead and create our
layers we'll create a convolution layer
one and two two different convolutional
layers and then we'll take that and
we'll flatten that out create a a
reshape pooling in there for our reshape
and then we'll have our full whole uh
layer at the end so let's start by
creating our first uh convolutional
layer then we come in here and let me
just run that real quick and I want you
to notice on here the three and the 32
this is important because coming into
this convolutional layer we have three
different channels and 32 pixels each uh
so that has to be in there the four and
four you can play with this is your
filter size so if you remember you have
a filter and you have your image and the
fil filter slowly steps over and filters
out this image depending on what your
step is for this particular setup 44 is
just fine that should work pretty good
for what we're doing and for the size of
the image and then of course at the end
once you have your convolutional layer
set up you also need to pull it and
you'll see that the pooling is
automatically set up so that it would
see the different shape based on what's
coming in so here we have Max two 2x two
and we put in the convolutional one that
we just created the convolutional we
just created goes right back into it and
that right up here as you can see is the
X it's coming in from here so it knows
to look at the first model and set the
the data accordingly set that up so it
matches and we went ahead and ran this
already I think I ran let me go and run
it again and if we're going to do one
layer let's go ahead and do a second
layer down here and it's uh we'll call
it convo 2 it's also convolutional layer
on this and you'll see that we're
feeding convolutional one in the pooling
so it goes goes from convolutional one
into convolutional one pooling from
convolutional one pooling into
convolutional two and then from
convolutional 2 into convolutional 2
pooling and we'll go ahead and take this
and run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for our flattened
layer uh let's go ahead and we'll do uh
since we have 64 coming out of here and
we have a 4x4 going in let's do 8X 8 by
64 so let's do
4,096 this is going to be the flat layer
so that's how many bits are coming
through on the flat layer and we'll
reshape this so we'll reshape our convo
2 pooling and that will feed into here
the convo two pooling and then we're
going to set it up as a single layer
that's 4,096 in size that's what that
means there we'll go ahead and run this
so we've now created this variable the
convo two flat and then we have our
first full layer this is the final uh
neural network where the flat layer
going in and we're going to again use
the reu for our uh setup on there on a
neural network for evaluation and you'll
notice that we're going to create our
first full layer our normal full layer
that's our definition so we created that
that's creating the normal full layer
and our input for the data comes right
here from the this goes right into it uh
the convo to flat so this tells it how
big the data is and we're going to have
it come out it's going to have uh 1024
that's how big the layer is coming out
we'll go ahead and run this so we now we
have our full layer one and with the
full layer one we want to also Define
the full one Dropout to go with that so
our full layer one comes in uh keep
probability equals whole probability
remember we created that earlier and the
full layer one is what's coming into it
and this is going backwards and training
the data we're not training every weight
we're only training a percentage of them
each time which helps get rid of the
bias so let me go ahead and run that and
uh finally we'll go ahead and create a y
predict which is going to equal the
normal full one Dropout and 10 cuz we
have 10 labels in there now in this
neural network we could have added
additional layers that would be another
option to play with you can also play
with instead of 1024 you can use other
numbers for the way that sets up and
what's coming out and going into the
next one we're only going to do just the
one layer and the one layer Dropout and
you can see if we did another layer it'd
be really easy just to feed in the full
one Dropout into full layer two and then
full Layer Two Dropout would have full
Layer Two feed into it and then you'd
switch that here for the Y prediction
for right now this is great this
particular data set is tried and true
and we know that this will work on it
and if we just type in y predict and we
run that uh we'll see that this is a
tensor object uh shape question mark 10
dtype 32 a quick way to double check
what we're working on so now we've got
all of our uh we've done a setup all the
way to the Y predict which we just did
uh we want to go ahead and apply the
loss function and make sure that's set
up in there uh create the optimizer and
then uh train our Optimizer and create a
variable to initialize all the global TF
variables so before we dive into the um
loss function let me point out one quick
thing or just kind of a rehap over a
couple things and that is when we're
playing with this these setups um we
pointed out up here we can change the 44
and use different numbers there they
change your outcome so depending on what
number you use here will have a huge
impact on how well your model fits and
that's the same here of the 1024 also
this is also another number that if you
continue to raise that number you'll get
um possibly a better fit you might
overfit and if you lower that number
you'll use less resources and generally
you want to use this in um the
exponential growth an exponential being
two 4 8 16 and in this case the next one
down would be 512 you can use any number
there but those would be the ideal
numbers uh when you look at this data so
the next step in all this is we need to
also create uh a way of tracking how
good our model is and we're going to
call this a loss function and so we're
going to create a cross entropy loss
function and so before we discuss
exactly what that is let's take a look
and see what we're feeding it uh we're
going to feed it our labels and we have
our true labels and our prediction
labels uh so coming in here is where're
the two different uh variables we're
sending in or the two different
probability distributions is one that we
know is true and what we think it's
going to be now this function right here
when they talk about cross entropy uh in
information Theory the cross entropy
between two probability distributions
over the same underlying set of events
measures the average number of bits
needed to identify an event drawn from
the set that's a mouthful uh really
we're just looking at the amount of
error in here how many of these are
correct and how many of these um are
incorrect so how much of it matches and
we're going to look at that we're just
going to look at the average that's what
the mean the reduced to the mean means
here so we're looking at the average
error on this and so the next step is
we're going to take the error we want to
know our cross entropy or our loss
function how much loss we have that's
going to be part of how we train the
model so when you know what the loss is
and we're training it you feed that back
into the back propagation setup and so
we want to go ahead and optimize that
here's our Optimizer we're going to
create the optimizer using an ADD
Optimizer remember there's a lot of
different ways of optimizing the data
atoms the most popular used uh so our
Optimizer is going to equal the TF train
atom Optimizer if you don't remember
what the learning rate is let me just
pop this back into here here's our
learning rate when you have your weights
you have all your weights and your
different nodes that are coming out
here's our node coming out um and it has
all its weights and then the error is
being prop sent back through in reverse
on our neural network so we take this
there and we adjust these weights based
on the different formulas in this case
the atom formulas is what we're using we
don't want to just adjust them
completely we don't want to change this
weight so it exactly fits the data
coming through because if we made that
kind of adjustment it's going to be
biased to whatever the last data we sent
through is instead we're going to
multiply that by 0.001 and make a very
small shift in this weight so our Delta
W is only 0.001 of the actual Delta W of
the full change we're going to compute
from the atom and then we want to go
ahead and train it so our training or
set up a training uh uh variable or
function and this is going to equal our
Optimizer minimize cross entropy and we
make sure we go ahead and run this so
it's loaded in there and then we're
almost ready to train our model but
before we do that we need to create one
more um variable in here and we're going
to create a variable to initialize all
the global TF variables and when we look
at this um the TF Global variable
initializer this is a tensorflow um
object object it goes through there and
it looks at all our different setup that
we have going under our tensorflow and
then initializes those variables uh so
it's kind of like a magic wand because
it's all hidden in the back end of
tensorflow all you need to know about
this is that you have to have the
initialization on there which is an
operation um and you have to run that
once you have your setup going so we'll
go ahead and run this piece of code and
then we're going to go ahead and train
our data so let me run this so it's
loaded up there and so now we're going
to go ahead and run the model model by
creating a graph session graph session
is a tensorflow term so you'll see that
coming up it's one of the things that
throws me because I always think of
graphx and Spark and graph as just
general graphing uh but they talk about
a graph session so we're going to go ahe
and run the model and let's go ahead and
walk through this uh what's going on
here and let's paste this data in here
and here we go so we're going to start
off with a with a TF session as cess so
that's our actual TF session we've
created uh so we're right here with the
TF uh session our session we're creating
we're going to run TF Global variable
initializer so right off the bat we're
initializing our variables here uh and
then we have for I in range 500 so
what's going on here remember 500 we're
going to break the data up and we're
going to batch it in at 500 points each
we've created our session run so we're
going to do with TF session as session
right here we've created our variable
session uh and then we're going to run
and we're going to go ahead and
initialize it so we have our TF Global
variables initializer that we created um
that initializes our our session in here
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to go for I in range of 500
batch equals ch. nextext batch so if you
remember correctly this is loading up um
100 pictures at a time and uh this is
going to Loop through that 500 times so
we are literally doing uh what is that
uh 500 time 100 is uh 50,000 so that's
50,000 pictures we're going to process
right there in the first process is
we're going to do a session run we're
going to take our train we created our
train variable or Optimizer in there
we're going to feed it the dictionary uh
we had our feed dictionary that we
created and we have x equals batch zero
coming in y true batch one hold the
probability 0.5 and then just so that we
can keep track of what's going on we're
gonna every uh 100 steps we're going to
run a print So currently onstep format C
accuracy is um and we're going to look
at matches equals tf. equal TF argument
y prediction one tf. AR Max y true comma
one so we're going to look at this as
how many matches it has and here our ACC
uh all we're doing here is we're going
to take the matches how many matches
they have it creates it generates a
chart we're going to convert that to
float that's what the TF cast does and
then we just want to know the average we
just want to know the average average of
the um accuracy and then we'll go ahead
and print that out uh print session run
accuracy feed dictionary so it takes all
this and it prints out our accuracy on
there so let's go ahead and take this
oops F screens there let's go ahead and
take this and let's run it and this is
going to take a little bit to run uh so
let's see what happens on my old laptop
and we'll see here that we have our
current uh we're currently on Step Zero
it takes a little bit to get through the
accuracy and this will take just a
moment to run we can see that on our
Step Zero it has an accuracy of 0.1 or
0128 um and as it's running we'll go
ahead you don't need to watch it run all
the way but uh this accuracy is going to
change a little bit up and down so we've
actually lost some accuracy during our
step
two um but we'll see how that comes out
let's come back after we run it all the
way through and see how the different
steps come out I was actually reading
that backwards uh the way this works is
the closer we get to one the more
accuracy we have uh so you can see here
we've gone from a01 to a point 39 um and
we'll go ahead and pause this and come
back and see what happens when we're
done with the full run all right now
that we've uh prepared the meal got it
in the oven and pulled out my finished
dish here if you've ever watched uh any
of the old cooking shows let's discuss a
little bit about this accuracy going on
here and how do you interpret that we've
done a couple things first we've defined
accuracy um the reason I got it
backwards before is you have uh loss or
accuracy and with loss you'll get a
graph that looks like this it goes oops
that's an S by the way there we go you
get a graph that curves down like this
and with accuracy you get a graph that
curves up this is how good it's doing
now in this case uh one is supposed to
be really good accuracy that means it
gets close to one but it never crosses
one so if you have an accuracy of one
that is phenomenal um in fact that's
pretty much un you know unheard of and
the same thing with loss if you have a
loss of zero that's also unheard of the
zero is actually on this this axis right
here as we go in there so how do we
interpret that because you know if I was
looking at this and I go oh 0.51 that's
uh 51% you're doing 5050 no this is not
percentage let me just put that in there
it is not percentage uh this is
logarithmic what that means is that 0. 2
is twice as good as 0.1 and uh when we
see 04 that's twice as good as 0. 2 real
way to convert this into a percentage
you really can't say this is is a direct
percentage conversion what you can do
though is in your head if we were to
give this a percentage uh we might look
at this as uh 50% we're just guessing
equals 0.1 and if 50% roughly equals 0.1
that's where we started up here at the
top remember at the top here here's our
0.128 the accuracy of 50% then 75% is
about2 and so on and so on don't quote
the those numbers because it doesn't
work that way they say that if you have
.95 that's pretty much saying 100% And
if you have uh anywhere between you'd
have to go look this up let me go and
remove all my drawings there uh so the
magic number is 0.5 we really want to be
over a 0 five in this whole thing and we
have uh both 0.504 remember this is
accuracy if we were looking at loss then
we'd be looking the other way but 0.0
you know instead of High it is we want
how low it is uh but with accuracy being
over a 0. five is pretty valid that
means this is pretty solid and if you
get to a 095 then it's a direct
correlation that's what we're looking
for here in these numbers you can see we
finished with this model at 0. 5135 so
still good um and if we look at uh when
they ran this in the other end remember
there's a lot of Randomness that goes
into it when we see the weights uh they
got
05251 so a little better than ours but
that's fine you'll find your own uh
comes up a little bit better or worse
depending on uh just that Randomness and
so we've gone through the whole model
we've created we trained the model and
we've also gone through on every 100th
run to test the model to see how
accurate it is welcome to the RNN
tutorial that's the recurrent neural
network so we talk about a feed forward
neural network in a feed forward neural
network information flows only in the
forward direction from the input nodes
through the hidden layers if any and to
the output nodes there are no no Cycles
or Loops in the network and so you can
see here we have our input layer I was
talking about how it just goes straight
forward into the hidden layers so each
one of those connects and then connects
to the next hidden layer connects to the
output layer and of course we have a
nice simplified version where it has a
predicted output and they refer to the
input as x a lot of times in the output
as y decisions are based on current
input no memory about the past no future
scope why recurrent neural network
issues in feed forward neural network so
one of the biggest issues is because it
doesn't have a scope of memory or time a
feed forward neural network doesn't know
how to handle sequential data uh it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now and what your output
affects what's happening that's very
important so whatever I put as an output
is going to affect the next one um a
feed forward all doesn't look at any of
that it just looks at this is what's
coming in and it cannot memorize
previous inputs so it doesn't have that
list of inputs coming in solution to
feed forward neural network you'll see
here it says recurrent neural network
and we have our X on the bottom going to
H going to Y that's your feed forward uh
but right in the middle it has a value C
so it's a whole another process it's
memorizing what's going on in the hidden
layers and the hidden layers as they
produce data feed into the next one so
your hidden layer might have an output
that goes off to Y uh but that output
goes back into the next prediction
coming in what this does is this allows
it to handle sequential data it
considers the current imp put and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at General drawings
and um Solutions we should also look at
applications of the RNN image captioning
RNN is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair uh that's
very tough I mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction Any Time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using RNN and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the New York Stock
Exchange in the US produces somewhere in
the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades in fluctuations by the
second um it's like 3 terabytes a day of
data so we're only to look at one stock
just analyzing One stock is really
tricky in here we'll give you a little
jump on that so that's exciting but
don't expect to get rich off of it
immediately another application of the
RNN is natural language processing text
Mining and sentiment analysis can be
carried out using RNN for natural
language processing and you can see
right here the term natural language
processing when you stream those three
words together is very different than I
if I said processing language natural
leave so the time series is very
important when we're analyzing
sentiments can change the whole value of
a sentence just by switching the words
around or if you're just counting the
words you might get one sentiment where
if you actually look at the order
they're in you get a completely
different sentiment when it rains look
for rainbows when it's dark look for
stars both of these are positive
sentiments and they're based upon the
order of which the sentence is going in
machine translation given an input in
one language RNN can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output I myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking English you would say
big cat and if you're speaking Spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in English and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in English and this
little diagram I guess that's denoted by
the flags I have a flag I own it no um
but they're speaking in English and it's
getting translated into Chinese Italian
French German and Spanish languages some
of the tools coming out are just so cool
so somebody like myself who's very
linguistically challenged I can now
travel into Worlds I would never think
of because I can have something
translate my English back and forth
readily and I'm not stuck with a
communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
princi principle of saving the output of
a layer and feeding this back to the
input in order to predict the output of
the layer sounds a little confusing when
we start breaking it down it'll make
more sense and usually we have a
propagation forward neural network with
the input layers the hidden layers the
output layer with the recurrent neural
network we turn that on its side so here
it is and now our X comes up from the
bottom into the hidden layers into Y and
they usually draw very simplified X to H
with c as a loop a to Y where a B and C
are the perimeters a lot of times you'll
see this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the H and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the C goes in and then the X
goes in so the x is going Upward Bound
and C is going to the right a is going
out and C is also going out that's where
gets a little confusing so here we have
xn uh CN and then we have y out and C
out and C is based on HT minus one so
our value is based on the Y and the H
value are connected to each other
they're not necessarily the same value
because H can be its own thing and
usually we draw this or we represent it
as a function h of T equals a function
of C where H of T minus one that's the
last H output and X of T going in so
it's the last output of H combined with
the new input of x uh where HT is the
new state FC is a function with the
parameter C that's a common way of
denoting it uh HT minus one is the Old
State coming out and then X of T is an
input Vector at time of Step T well we
need to cover types of recurrent neural
networks and so the first one is the
most common one which is a onetoone
single output onetoone neural network is
usually known as a vanilla neural
network used for regular machine
learning problems why because vanilla is
usually considered kind of a just a real
basic flavor but because it's a very
basic lot of times they'll call it the
vanilla neural network uh which is not
the common term but it is you know kind
of a slang term people will know what
you're talking about usually if you say
that then we run one to mini so you have
a single input and you might have a
multiple outputs in this case uh image
captioning as we looked at earlier where
we have not just looking at it as a dog
but a dog catching a ball in the air and
then you have many to1 Network takes in
a sequence of inputs examples sentiment
analysis where a given sentence can be
classified as expressing positive or
negative sentiments and we looked at
that as we were discussing if it r look
for a rainbow so positive sentiment
where rain might be a negative sentiment
if you were just adding up the words in
there and then of course if you're going
to do a one to one many to one one to
many there's many to many networks takes
in a sequence of inputs and generates a
sequence of outputs example machine
translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in in English and then
going out in all the different languages
uh you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations you know
if you're a translator you realize just
how difficult it is to translate into
different languages one of the biggest
things you need to understand when we're
working with this neural network is
what's called The Vanishing gradient
problem while training an RNN your slope
can be either too small or very large
and this makes training difficult when
the slope is too small the problem is
known as Vanishing gradient and you'll
see here they have a nice U image loss
of information through time so if you're
pushing not enough information forward
that information is lost and then when
you go to train it you start losing the
third word in the sentence or something
like that or it doesn't quite follow the
full logic of what you're working on
exploding gradient problem Oh this is
one that runs into everybody when you're
working with this particular neural
network when the slope tends to grow
exponentially instead of decaying this
problem is called exploding gradient
issues in gradient problem long tring
time poor performance bad accuracy and
I'll add one more in there uh your
computer if you're on a a lower-end
computer test testing out a model will
lock up and give you the memory error
explaining gradient problem consider the
following two examples to understand
what should be the next word in the
sequence the person who took my bike and
blank a thief the students who got into
engineering with blank from Asia and you
can see in here we have our x value
going in we have the previous value
going forward and then you back
propagate the error like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll have the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from Asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the RNN must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief is singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the RNN must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
Asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the eror to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity in ization so
the first thing we want to do is see if
we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having uh whatever
information it's sending to the next
series we can truncate what it's sending
we can lower that particular uh set of
layers make those smaller and finally is
a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a Vanishing gradient the OPA
problem uh we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation function so we'll
look at that just minimally uh there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short term memory
networks the
lstms and we can make adjustments to
that so just like we can clip the
gradient as it comes out we can also um
expand on that we can increase the
memory Network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's uh setup
is what they call longterm dependencies
suppose we try to predict the last word
in the text the clouds are in the and
you probably said sky here we do not
need any further context it's pretty
clear that that the last word is going
to be Sky suppose we try to predict the
last word in the text I have been
staying in Spain for the last 10 years I
can speak fluent maybe you said
Portuguese or French no you probably
said Spanish the word we predict will
depend on the previous few words in
context here we need the context of
Spain to predict the last word in the
text it's possible that the gap between
the relevant information and the point
where it is needed to become very large
lstm help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default Behavior All recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent H
layer lstm s's also have a chainlike
structure but the repeating module has a
different structure instead of having a
single neural network layer there are
four interacting layers communicating in
a very special way lstms are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default Behavior LST
tms's also have a chain-like structure
but the repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way as you can see the
deeper we dig into this the more
complicated the graphs kit in here I
want you to note that you have X of T
minus one coming in you have X of T
coming in and you have x a t + one and
you have H of T minus one and H of T
coming in and H of T +1 going out and of
course uh on the other side is the
output a um in the middle we have our
tangent H but it occurs in two different
places so not only when we're Computing
the x of t + one are we getting the
tangent H from X of t but we're also
getting that value coming in from the X
of T minus one so the short of it is as
you look at these layers not only does
it does the propagate through the first
layer goes into the second layer back
into itself but it's also going into the
third layer so now we're kind of
stacking those up and this can get very
complicated as you grow that in size it
also grows in memory too and in the
amount of resources it takes uh but it's
a very powerful tool to help us address
the problem of complicated long
sequential information coming in like we
were just looking at in the sentence and
when we're looking at our long shortterm
memory network uh there's three steps of
processing sessing in the lstms that we
look at the first one is we want to
forget irrelevant parts of the previous
state you know uh a lot of times like
you know is as in a unless we're trying
to look at whether it's a plural noun or
not they don't really play a huge part
in the language so we want to get rid of
them then selectively update cell State
values so we only want to update the
cell cell State values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like uh so step one decides how much of
the past it should remember first step
in the lstm is to decide which
information to be omitted in from the
cell in that particular time step it is
decided by the sigmoid function it looks
at the previous state h of minus one and
the current input X of T and computes
the function so you can see over here we
have a function of T equals the sigmoid
function of the weight of f the H at T
minus one and then x a t plus of course
you have a bias in there with any V
neural network so we have a bias
function so F of T equals forget gate
decides which information to delete that
is not important from the previous time
step considering an L STM is fed with
the following inputs from the previous
and present time step Alice is good in
physics JN on the other hand is good in
chemistry so previous output JN plays
football well he told me yesterday over
the phone that he had served as a
captain of his college football team
that's our current input so as we look
at this the first step is the forget
gate realizes there might be a change in
context after encountering the First
full stop Compares with the current
input sentence of exit so we're looking
at that full stop and then Compares it
with the input of the new sentence the
next sentence talks about John so the
information on Alice is deleted okay
that's important to know so we have this
input coming in and if we're going to
continue on with John then that's going
to be the primary information we're
looking at the position of the subject
is vacated and is assigned to John and
so in this one we've seen that we've
weeded out a whole bunch of information
and we're only passing information on
John since that's now the new topic so
step two is then to decide how much
should this unit add to the current
state in the second layer there are two
parts one is the sigmoid function and
the other is the tangent H in the
sigmoid function it decides which values
to let through 0 or one tangent 8
function gives the weightage to the
values which are passed deciding their
level of importance minus one to one and
you can see the two formul that come up
uh the I of T equals the sigmoid of the
weight of i h to T minus one X of t plus
the bias of I and the C of T equals the
tangent of H of the weight of C of H of
T minus 1 xit plus the bias of C so our
I of T equals the input gate determines
which information to let through based
on its significance in the current time
step if this seems a little complicated
don't worry because a lot of the
programming is already done when we get
to the case study understanding though
that this is part of the program is
important when you're trying to figure
out these what to set your settings at
you should also note when you're looking
at this it should have some semblance to
your forward propagation neural networks
where we have a value assigned to to a
wait plus a bias very important steps
than any of the neural network layers
whether we're propagating into them the
information from one to the next or
we're just doing a straightforward
neural network propagation let's take a
quick look at this what it looks like
from the human standpoint um as I step
out in my suit again consider the
current input at xft John plays football
well he told me yesterday over the phone
that he had served as a captain of his
college football team that's our input
input gate analysis the import important
information John plays football and he
was a captain of his college team is
important he told me over the phone
yesterday is less important hence it is
forgotten this process of adding some
new information can be done via the
input gate now this example is as a
human form and we'll look at training
this stuff in just a minute uh but as a
human being if I wanted to get this
information from a conversation maybe
it's a Google Voice listening in on you
or something like that um how do we weed
out the information that he was talking
to me on on the phone yesterday well I
don't want to memorize that he talked to
me on the phone yesterday or maybe that
is important but in this case it's not I
want to know that he was the captain of
the football team I want to know that he
sered I want to know that John plays
football and he was the captain of the
college football team those are the two
things that I want to take away as a
human being again we measure a lot of
this from the human Viewpoint and that's
also how we try to train them so we can
understand these neural networks finally
we get to step three decides what part
of the current cell State makes it to
the output the third step is to decide
what will be our output first we run a
sigmoid layer which decides what parts
of the cell State make it to the output
then we put the cell State through the
tangent H to push the values to be
between minus one and one and multiply
it by the output of the sigmoid gate so
when we talk about the output of T we
set that equal to the sigmoid of the
weight of zero of the H of T minus one
you back One Step in Time by the x of t
plus of course the bias the H of T
equals the out of times the tangent of
the tangent h of C so our oot equals the
output gate allows the past in
information to impact the output in the
current time step let's consider the
example to predicting the next word in
the sentence John played tremendously
well against the opponent and won for
his team for his contributions Brave
blank was awarded player of the match
there could be a lot of choices for the
empty space current input Brave is an
adjective adjectives describe a noun JN
could be the best output after Brave
thumbs up for John awarded player of the
match and if you were to pull just the
nouns out of the sentence team doesn't
look right because that's not really the
subject we're talking about
contributions you know Brave
contributions or Brave team Brave player
Brave match um so you look at this and
you can start to train this these this
neural network so it starts looking at
and goes oh no JN is what we're talking
about so brave is an adjective Jon's
going to be the the best output and we
give John a big thumbs up and then of
course we jump into my favorite part the
case study use case implementation of
lstm let's predict the prices of stocks
using the lstm network based on the
stock price data between 2012 2016 we're
going to try to predict the stock prices
of 2017 and this will be a narrow set of
data we're not going to do the whole
stock market it turns out that the New
York Stock Exchange generates roughly
three terab bytes of data per day that's
all the different trades up and down of
all the different stocks going on and
each individual one uh second to second
or nanc to nanc uh but we're going to
limit that to just some very basic
fundamental information so don't think
you're going to get rich off this today
but at least you can give an a you can
give a step forward in how to start
processing something like stock prices a
very valid use for machine learning in
today's markets use case implementation
of lstm M let's dive in we're going to
import our libraries we're going to
import the training set and uh get the
scaling going um now if you watch any of
our other tutorials a lot of these
pieces just start to look very familiar
CU it's very similar setup uh but let's
take a look at that and um just a
reminder we're going to be using
Anaconda the Jupiter notebook so here I
have my anaconda Navigator when we go
under environments I've actually set up
a caros python 36 I'm in Python 36 and U
nice thing about Anaconda especially the
newer version remember a year ago
messing with anaconda in different
versions of python and different
environments um Anaconda now has a nice
interface um and I have this installed
both on a Ubuntu Linux machine and on
windows so works fine on there you can
go in here and open a terminal window
and then in here once you're in the
terminal window this is where you're
going to start uh installing uh using
pip to install your different modules
and everything now we've already
pre-installed them so we don't need to
do that in here uh but if you don't have
them installed on your particular
environment you'll need to do that and
of course you don't need to use the
anaconda or the Jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python ID you like I'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine I have specifically
installed one for carass since we're
going to be working with carass under
tensorflow we go back to home I've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment I've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch Jupiter
notebook now I've already in my Jupiter
notebook um have set up a lot of stuff
so that we're ready to go kind of like
uh Martha Stewarts in the old cooking
shows we want to make sure we have all
our tools for you so you're not waiting
for them to load and uh if we go up here
to where it says new you can see where
you can um create a new python three
that's what we did here underneath the
setup so it already has all the modules
installed on it and I'm actually renamed
this so if you go under file you can
rename it we I'm calling it RNN stock
and let's just take a look and start
diving into the code let's get into the
exciting part part now we've looked at
the tool and of course you might be
using a different tool which is fine uh
let's start putting that code in there
and seeing what those Imports and
uploading everything looks like now
first half is kind of boring when we hit
the rum button because we're going to be
importing numpy as NP that's uh uh the
number python which is your numpy array
and the mat plot library because we're
going to do some plotting at the end and
our pandas for our data set our pandas
is PD and when I hit run uh it really
doesn't do anything except for load
those modules just a quick note let me
just do a quick uh draw here oops shift
alt there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if I was to divide this
up oops I'm going to actually um let
overlap these here we
go uh this first part that we're going
to do
is our
data prep a lot of prepping
involved um in fact depending on what
your system since we're using carass I
put an overlap here uh but you'll find
that almost maybe even half of the code
we do is all about the data prep and the
reason I overlap this with uh carass let
me just put that down because that's
what we're working in uh is because
carass has like their own preset stuff
so it's already pre-built in which is
really nice so there's a couple Steps A
lot of times that are in the carass
setup uh we'll take a look at that to
see what comes up in our code as we go
through and look at stock and then the
last part is to evaluate and if you're
working with um shareholders or uh you
know classroom whatever it is you're
working with uh the valuate is a next
biggest piece um so the actual code here
cross is a little bit more but when
you're working with uh some of the other
packages you might have like three lines
that might be it all your stuff is in
your pre-processing and your data since
carass has is is Cutting Edge and you
load the individual layers you'll see
that there's a few more lines here and
cross is a little bit more robust and
then you spend a lot of times uh like I
said with the evaluate you want to have
something you present to everybody else
to say hey this is what I did this is
what it looks like so let's go through
those steps this is like a kind of just
general overview and let's just take a
look and see what the next set of code
looks like and in here we have a data
set train and it's going to be read
using the PD or pandas read CSV and it's
the Google stock pric train.csv and so
under this we have training set equals
data set train. iocation
and we've kind of sorted out part of
that so what's going on here let's just
take a look at let's let's look at the
actual file and see what's going on
there now if we look at this ignore all
the extra files on this um I already
have a train and a test set where it's
sorted out this is important to notice
because a lot of times we do that as
part of the pre-processing of the data
we take 20% of the data out so we can
test it and then we train the rest of it
that's what we use to create our neural
network that way we can find out how
good it is uh but let's go ahead and
just take a look and see what that looks
like as far as the file itself and I
went ahead and just opened this up in a
basic word pad text editor just so we
can take a look at it certainly you can
open up an Excel or any other kind of
spreadsheet um and we note that this is
a comma separated variables we have a
date uh open high low close volume this
is the standard stuff that we import
into our stock with the most basic set
of information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download um in this
case we downloaded it from uh Google
that's why we call it the Google stock
price um and it specifically is Google
this is the Google stock values from uh
as you can see here we started off at 13
20102 so when we look at this first
setup up here uh we have a data set
train equals pdor CSV and if you noticed
on the original frame um let me just go
back there they had it set to home
Ubuntu downloads Google stock price
train I went ahead and changed that
because is we're in the same file where
I'm running the code so I've saved this
particular python code and I don't need
to go through any special paths or how
the full path on there and then of
course we want to take out um certain
values in here and you're going to
notice that we're using um our data set
and we're now in pandas uh so pandas
basically it looks like a spreadsheet um
and in this case we're going to do I
location which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
in the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns one and
two and if you remember here from our
data as we switch back on over columns
we always start with zero which is the
date and we're going to be looking at
open and high which would be one and
two we'll just label that right there so
you can see now when you go back and do
this you certainly can extrapolate and
do this on all all the columns um but
for the example let's just limit a
little bit here so that we can focus on
just some key aspects of
stock and then we'll go up here and run
the code and uh again I said the first
half is very boring whenever you hit the
Run button it doesn't do anything
because we're still just loading the
data and setting it up now that we've
loaded our data we want to go ahead and
scale it we want to do what they call
feature scaling and in here we're going
to pull it up from the sklearn or the SK
kit pre-processing import min max scaler
and when you look at this you got to
remember that um biases in our data we
want to get rid of that so if you have
something that's like a really high
value um let's just draw a quick graph
and I have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value One stock has a
value of 100 and another stock has a
value of
five um you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say say Okay 100 is
going to be the Max and five is going to
be the Min and then everything else goes
and then we change this so we just
squish it down I like the word squish so
it's between one and zero so 100 equals
1 or 1 equal 100 and 0 equal 5 and you
can just multiply it's usually just a
simple multiplication we're using uh
multiplication so it's going to be
minus5 and then 100 divided or 95
divided by one so or whatever value is
is divided by
95 and uh once we've actually created
our scale we've toing it's going to be
from 0 to one we want take our training
set and we're going to create a training
set scaled and we're going to use our
scaler SC and we're going to fit we're
going to fit and transform the training
Set uh so we can now use the SC this
this particular object we'll use it
later on our testing set because
remember we have to also scale that when
we go to test our uh model and see how
it works and we'll go ahead and click on
the Run again uh it's not going to have
any output yet because we're just
setting up all the
variables okay so we pasted the data in
here and we're going to create the data
structure with the 60 time steps and
output first note we're running 60 time
steps and that is where this value here
also comes in so the first thing we do
is we create our X train and Y train
variables we set them to an empty python
array very important to remember what
kind of array we're in and what we're
working with and then we're going to
come in here we're going to go for I in
range 60 to 1258 there's our 60 60 time
steps and the reason we want to do this
is as we're adding the data in there
there's nothing below the 60 so if we're
going to use 60 time steps uh we have to
start at 60 because it includes
everything underneath of it otherwise
you'll get a pointer error and then
we're going to take our X train and
we're going to append training set
scaled this is a scaled value between
0er and one and then as I is equal to 60
this value is going to be um 60 - 60 is
0 so this actually is 0 to I so it's
going to be 0 to 60 1 to 61 let me just
circle this part right here 1 to 61 uh 2
to 62 and so on and so on and if you
remember I said 0 to 60 that's incorrect
because it does not count remember it
starts at zero so this is a count of 60
so it's actually 59 important to
remember that as we're looking at this
and then the second part of this that
we're looking at so if you remember
correctly here we go we go from uh 0 to
59 of I and then we have a comma a zero
right here and so finally we're just
going to look at the open value now I
know we did put it in there for one to
two um if you remember correctly it
doesn't count the second one so it's
just the open value we're looking at
just open um and then finally we have y
train. append training set I to zero and
if you remember correctly I to or I
comma 0 if you remember correctly this
is 0 to 59 so there's 60 values in it uh
so when we do I down here this is number
60 so we're going to do this is we're
creating an array and we have 0 to
59 and over here we have number 60 which
is going into the Y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a 0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to
1258 that's where this value here comes
in that's the length of the data we're
loading so we've loaded two arrays we've
loaded one array that has uh which is
filled with arrays from 0 to 59 and we
loaded one array which is just the value
and what we're looking at you want to
think about this as a Time sequence uh
here's my open open open open open open
what's the next one in the series so
we're looking at the Google stock and
each time it opens we want to know what
the next one uh 0 through 59 what's 60 1
through 60 what's 61 2 through 62 what's
62 and so on and so on going up and then
once we've loaded those in our for Loop
we go ahead and take X train and Y train
equals np. array XT tr. NP array ytrain
we're just converting this back into a
numpy array that way we can use all the
cool tools that we get with numpy array
including reshaping so if we take a look
and see what's going on on here we're
going to take our X
train we're going to reshape it wow what
the heck does reshape mean uh that means
we have an array if you remember
correctly um so many numbers by
60 that's how wide it is and so we're
when you when you do XT train. shape
that gets one of the shapes and you get
um XT train. shape of one gets the other
shape and we're just making sure the
data is formatted correctly and so you
use this to pull the fact that it's 60
by um in this case where's that value 60
by
1199 1258 -
60199 and we're making sure that that is
shaped correctly so the data is grouped
into uh
1199 by 60 different arrays and then the
one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the in layer needs to be
one value that's like the leaf of a tree
where this is the branch and then it
branches out some more um and then you
get the Leaf np. reshaped comes from and
using the existing shapes to form it
we'll go ahead and run this piece of
code again there's no real output and
then we'll import our different carass
modules that we need so from carass
Models we're going to import the
sequential model dealing with sequential
data we have our dense layers we have
actually three layers we're going to
bring in our D our lstm which is what
we're focusing on and our Dropout and
we'll discuss these three layers more in
just a moment but you do need the with
the lstm you do need the Dropout and
then the final layer will be the dents
but let's go ahead and run this and
that'll bring Port our modules and
you'll see we get an error on here and
if you read it closer it's not actually
an error it's a warning what does this
warning mean these things come up all
the time when you're working with such
Cutting Edge modules that are completely
being updated all the time we're not
going to worry too much about the
warning all it's saying is that the
h5py module which is part of carass is
going to be updated at some point and uh
if you're running new stuff on carass
and you start updating your caros system
you better make sure that your H5 Pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the H5 Pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and I said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean I meant that and uh we're
going to start off with initializing the
RNN and then we'll start adding those
layers in and you'll see that we have
the lstm and then the Dropout lstm then
Dropout lstm then Dropout what the heck
is that doing so let's explore that
we'll start by initializing the RNN
regressor equals sequential because
we're using the sequential model and
we'll run that and load that up and then
we're going to start adding our lstm
layer and some Dropout
regularization right there should be the
Q Dropout regularization and if we go
back here and remember our exploding
radient well that's what we're talking
about the uh Dropout drops out
unnecessary data so we're not just
shifting huge amounts of data through um
the network so and so we go in here
let's just go ahead and uh add this in
I'll go ahead and run this and we had
three of them so let me go and put all
three of them in and then we can go back
over them there's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go and put two more in I meant
to I said one more in but it's actually
two more in and then let's add one more
after that and as you can see each time
I run these they don't actually have an
output so let's take a closer look and
see what's going on here so we're going
to add our first lstm layer in here
we're going to have units 50 the units
is the positive integer and it's the
dimensionality of the output space this
is what's going out into the next layer
so we might have 60 coming in but we
have 50 going out we have a return
sequence because it is a sequence data
so we want to keep that true and then
you have to tell it what shape it's in
well we already know the shape by just
going in here and looking at at xtrain
shape so input shape equals the xtrain
shape of one comma 1 makes it really
easy you don't have to remember all the
numbers that put in 60 or whatever else
is in there you just let it tell the
regressor what model to use and so we
follow our STM with a Dropout layer now
understanding the Dropout layer is kind
of exciting because one of the things
that happens is we can overtrain our
Network that means that our neural
network will memorize such specific data
that it has trouble predicting anything
anything that's not in that specific
realm to fix for that each time we run
through the training mode we're going to
take 02 or 20% of our neurons and just
turn them off so we're only going to
train on the other ones and it's going
to be random that way each time we pass
through this we don't overtrain these
nodes come back in in the next training
cycle we randomly pick a different 20
and finally they see a big difference as
we go from the first to the second and
third and fourth the first thing is we
don't have to input the shape because
because the shape's already the output
units is 50 here this Auto The Next Step
automatically knows this layer is
putting out 50 and because it's the next
layer it automatically sets that and
says oh 50 is coming out from our last
layer it's coming out you know goes into
the regressor and of course we have our
Dropout and that's what's coming into
this one and so on and so on and so the
next three layers we don't have to let
it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
going to keep the units the same we're
still going to do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence now the next piece of code is
what brings it all together let's go
ahead and take a look at that and we
come in here we put the output layer the
dense layer and if you remember up here
we had the three layers we had uh lstm
Dropout and dense uh dense just says
we're going to bring this all down into
one output instead of putting out a
sequence we just know want to know the
answer at this point and let's go ahead
and run that and so in here you notice
all we're doing is setting things up one
step at a time so far we've brought in
our uh way up here we brought in our
data we brought in our different modules
we formatted the data for training it we
set it up you know we have our YX train
and our y train we have our source of
data and the answers we're we know so
far that we're going to put in there
we've reshaped that we've come in and
built our carass we've imported our
different layers and we have in here if
you look we have what uh five total
layers now carass is a little different
than a lot of other systems because a
lot of other systems put this all in one
line and do it automatic but they don't
don't give you the options of how those
layers interface and they don't give you
the options of how the data comes in
carass is Cutting Edge for this reason
so even though there's a lot of extra
steps in building the model this has a
huge impact on the output and what we
can do with this these new models from
carass so we brought in our dense we
have our full model put together our
regressor so we need to go ahead and
compile it and then we're going to go
ahead and fit the data we're going to
compile the pieces so they all come
together and then we're we're going to
run our training data on there and
actually recreate our regressor so it's
ready to be used so let's go ahead and
compile that and I can go ahead and run
that and uh if you've been looking at
any of our other tutorials on neural
networks you'll see we're going to use
the optimizer atom atom is optimize for
Big Data there's a couple other
optimizers out there uh beyond the scope
of this tutorial but certainly Adam will
work pretty good for this and loss
equals mean squared value so when we're
training it this is what we want to base
the loss on how bad is our error we're
going to we're going to use the mean
squared value for our error and the atom
Optimizer for its differential equations
you don't have to know the math behind
them but certainly it helps to know what
they're doing and where they fit into
the bigger models and then finally we're
going to do our fit fitting the RN into
the training set we have the regressor
do fit XT Trin y train epics and batch
size so we know where this is this is
our data coming in for the X train our y
train is the answer we're looking for of
our data our sequential input epic is
how many times we're going to go over
the whole data set we created a whole
data set of XT train so this is each
each of those rows which includes a Time
sequence of 60 and badge size another
one of those things where carass really
shines is if you were pulling this save
from a large file instead of trying to
load it all into RAM it can now pick
smaller batches up and load those
indirectly we're not worried about
pulling them off a file today this isn't
big enough to uh cause the computer too
much of a problem to run not too
straining on the resources but as we run
run this you can imagine what would
happen if I was doing a lot more than
just one column in one set of stock in
this case Google stock imagine if I was
doing this across all the stocks and I
had instead of just the open I had open
close high low and you can actually find
yourself with about 13 different
variables times 60 cuz it's a Time
sequence suddenly you find yourself with
a gig of memory you're loading into your
RAM which will just completely you know
if it's just if you're not on multiple
computers or cluster you start running
into resource problems but for this we
don't have to worry about that so let's
go ahead and run this and this will
actually take a little bit on my
computer it's an older laptop and give
it a second to kick in there there we go
all right so we have epic so this is
going to tell me it's running the first
run through all the data and as it's
going through it's batching them in 32
pieces so 32 uh lines each time and
there's 1198 I think I said 11.99
earlier but it's $ 1198 I was off by one
and each one of these is 13 seconds so
you can imag imagine this is roughly 20
to 30 minutes run time on this computer
like I said it's an older laptop running
at uh .9 GHz on a dual processor and
that's fine what we'll do is I'll go
ahead and stop go get a drink of coffee
and come back and let's see what happens
at the end and where this takes us and
like any good cooking show I've kind of
got in my latte I also had some other
stuff running in the background so
you'll see these numbers jumped up to
like 19 seconds 15 seconds which you can
scroll through and you can see we've run
it through 100 steps or 100 epics so the
question is what is all this mean one of
the first things you'll notice is that
our loss is over here it kind of stopped
at 0.0014 but you can see it kind of
goes down until we hit about 0.014 three
times in a row so we guessed our epic
pretty close since our loss has remain
the same on there so to find out
where're looking at we're going to go
ahead and load up our test data the test
data that we didn't process yet and real
stock price data set test ey location
this is the same thing we did when we
prepped the data in the first place so
let's go ahead and go through this code
and we see we've labeled it part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing we need
to do is go ahead and read the data in
from our test CSV you see I've changed
the path on it for my computer and uh
then we'll call it the real stock price
and again we're doing just the one
column here and the values from iocation
so it's all the rows and just the values
from these that one location that's the
open Stock open and let's go ahead and
run that so that's loaded in there and
let's go ahead and uh create we have our
inputs we're going to create inputs here
and this should all look familiar this
is the same thing we did before we're
going to take our data set total we're
going to do a little Panda concat from
the data set train now remember the end
of the data set train is part of the
data going in and let's just visualize
that just a little bit here's our train
data let me just put TR for train and it
went up to this value here but each one
of these values generated a bunch of
columns it was 60 across and this value
here equals this one and this value here
equals this one and this value here
equals this one and so we need these top
60 to go into our new data so to find
out what we're looking at we're going to
go ahead and load up our test data the
test data that we didn't process yet and
uh real stock price data set test
iocation this is the same thing we did
when we prepped the data in the first
place so let's go ahead and go through
this code and we can see we've labeled
it part three making the predictions and
visualizing the results so the first
thing we need to do is go ahead and read
the data in from our test CSV and you
see I've changed the path on it for my
computer and uh then we'll call it the
real stock price and again we're doing
just the one column here and the values
from I location so it's all the rows and
just the values from these that one
location that's the open Stock open
let's go ahead and run that so that's
loaded in there and then let's go ahead
and uh create we have our inputs we're
going to create inputs here and this
should all look familiar this is the
same thing we did before we're going to
take our data set total we're going to
do a little Panda concat from the data
State train now remember the end of the
data set train is part of the data going
in and let's just visualize that just a
little bit here's our train data let me
just put TR for train and it went up to
this value here but each one of these
values generated a bunch of columns so
was 60 across and this value here equals
this one and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and so we need these top 60 to go into
our new data cuz that's part of the next
data where it's actually the top 59 so
that's what this first setup is over
here is we're going in we're doing the
real stock price and we're going to just
take the data set test and we're going
to load that in and then the real stock
price is our data test. test location so
we're just looking at that first uh
column the open price and then our data
set total we're going to take pandas and
we're going to concat and we're going to
take take our data set train for the
open and our data set test open and this
is one way you can reference these
columns we've referenced them a couple
different ways we've reference them up
here with the one two but we know it's
labeled as a panda set is open so pandas
is great that way lots of Versatility
there and we'll go ahead and go back up
here and run this there we go and uh
you'll notice this is the same as what
we did before we have our open data set
we pended our two different or
concatenated our two data sets together
we have our inputs equals data set total
length data set total minus length the
data set minus test minus 60 values so
we're going to run this over all of them
and you'll see why this works because
normally when you're running your test
set versus your training set you run
them completely separate but when we
graph this you'll see that we're just
going to be we'll be looking at the part
that we didn't train it with to see how
well it graphs and we have our inputs
equals inputs. reshapes or reshaping
like we did before we're Transforming
Our inputs so if you remember from the
transform between zero and one and
finally we want to go ahead and take our
X test and we're going to create that X
test and for I in range 60 to 80 so
here's our X test and we're pending our
inputs I to 60 which remember is 0 to 59
and I comma 0 on the other side so
that's just the First Column which is
our open column and uh once again we
take our X test we convert it to a numpy
array we do the same reshape we did
before and uh then we get down to the
final two lines and here we have
something new right here on these last
two lines let me just highlight those or
or mark them predicted stock price
equals regressor do predicts X test so
we're predicting all the stock including
both the training and the testing model
here and then we want to take this
prediction and we want to inverse the
transform so remember we put it between
zero and one well that's not going to
mean very much to me to look at a at a
float number between zero and one I want
the dollar amounts I want to know what
the cash value is and we'll go ahead and
run this and you'll see it runs much
quicker than the training that's what's
so wonderful about these neural networks
once you put them together it takes just
a second to run the same neural network
that took us what a half half hour to
train ahead and plot the data we're
going to plot what we think it's going
to be and we're going to plot it against
the real data what what the Google stock
actually did so let's go ahead and take
a look at that in code and let's uh pull
this code up so we have our PLT that's
our uh oh if you remember from the very
beginning let me just go back up to the
top we have our matplot library. pyplot
as PLT that's where that comes in and we
come down here we're going to plot let
me get my drawing thing out again we're
going to go ahead and PLT is basically
kind of like an object it's one of the
things that always threw me when I'm
doing graphs in Python because I always
think you have to create an object and
then it loads that class in there well
in this case PLT is like a canvas you're
putting stuff on so if you've done HTML
5 you'll have a canvas object this is
the canvas so we're going to plot the
real stock price that's what it actually
is and we're going to give that color
red so it's going to be a bright red
we're going to label it real Google
stock price and then we're going to do
our predicted stock we're going to do it
in blue and it's going to be labeled
predicted and we'll give it a title
because it's always nice to give a title
to your H graph especially if you're
going to present this to somebody you
know to your shareholders in the office
and uh the X label is going to be time
because it's a Time series we didn't
actually put the actual date and times
on here but that's fine we just know
they're incremented by time and then of
course the Y label is the actual stock
price PLT do Legend tells us to build
the legend on here so that the color red
and and real Google stock probably show
up on there and then the plot shows us
that actual graph so let's go ahead and
run this and see what that looks like
and you can see here we have a nice
graph and let's talk just a little bit
about this graph before we wrap it up
here's our Legend I was telling you
about that's why we have the legend
showed the prices we have our title and
everything and you'll notice on the
bottom we have a Time sequence we didn't
put the actual time in here now we could
have we could have gone ahead and um
plotted the X since we know what the the
dates are and plotted this to dates but
we also know this only the last piece of
data that we're looking at so last piece
of data which ends somewhere probably
around here on the graph I think it's
like about 20% of the data probably less
than that we have the Google price and
the Google price has this little up jump
and then down and you'll see that the
actual Google instead of a a turn down
here just didn't go up as high and
didn't low go uh down so our prediction
has the same pattern but the overall
value is pretty far off as far as um
stock but then again we're only looking
at one column we're only looking at the
open price we're not looking at how many
volumes were traded like I was pointing
out earlier we talk about stock just
right off the bat there's six columns
there's open high low close volume then
there's whether uh I mean volume shares
then there's the adjusted open adjusted
High adjusted low adjusted close they
have a special formula to predict
exactly what it would really be worth
based on the value of the stock and then
from there there's all kinds of other
stuff you can put in here so we're only
looking at one small aspect the opening
price of the stock and as you can see
here we did a pretty good job this curve
follows the curve pretty well it has
like a you know little jumps on it bends
they don't quite match up so this Bend
here does not quite match up with that
bin there but it's pretty darn close we
have the basic shape of it and the
prediction isn't too far off and you can
imagine that as we add more data in and
look at different aspects in the
specific domain of stock we should be
able to get a better representation each
time we drill in deeper of course this
took a half hour for my program my
computer to train so you can imagine
that if I was running it across all
those different variables might take a
little bit longer to train the data not
so good for doing a quick tutorial like
this so we're going to dive right into
what is carass we'll also uh go all the
way through this into a couple of
tutorials because that's where you
really learn a lot is when you roll up
your sleeves so we talk about what is
carass carass is a highlevel deep
learning API written in Python for easy
imple implementation of neural networks
uses deep learning Frameworks such as
tensor flow pytorch Etc is back in to
make computation
faster and this is really nice because
as a programmer there is so much stuff
out there and it's evolving so fast it
can get confusing and having some kind
of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different neural networks uh is
really powerful it's really powerful to
to um uh have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going so
cross works by using complex deep
learning Frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch um mlpl Etc as a back end for
fast computation while providing a
userfriendly and easy tolearn
frontend and you can see here we have
the carass API uh specifications and
under that you'd have like TF carass for
tensor flow thano carass and so on and
then you have your tensor flow workflow
that this is all sitting on top
of and this is like I said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensor flow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to um dig as deeply into the
heavy-end stuff while still having a
very robust package you can get up and
running rather quickly and it doesn't
distract from the processing time
because all the heavy lifting is done by
packages like tensorflow this is the
organization on top of it so the working
principle of
carass uh the working principle of
carass is carass uses computational
graphs to express and evaluate
mathematical
Expressions you can see here we put them
in blue they have the expression um
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators uh where we have like the
percentage or in this case in Python
that's usually your uh left your um
remainder or multiplication uh you might
have the operator of x uh to the power
of3 and it us is useful for calculating
derivatives by using uh back propagation
so if we're doing with neural networks
when we send the error back up to figure
out how to change it uh this makes it
really easy to do that without really
having not banging your head and having
to hand write everything it's easier to
implement distributed computation and
for solving complex problems uh specify
input and outputs and make sure all
nodes are connected and so this is
really nice as you come in through is
that um as your layers are going in
there you can get some very complicated
uh different setups nowadays which we'll
look at in just a second and this just
makes it really easy to start spinning
this stuff up and trying out the
different models so when we look at
Cross models uh cross model we have a
sequential model sequential model is a
linear stack of layers where the
previous layer leads into the next
layer and this if you've done anything
else even like the sklearn with their
neural networks and propagation and any
of these setups this should look
familiar you should have your input
layer it goes into your layer one layer
two and then into the output layer and
it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models and you can see down here
we have the model equals a coros
sequential this is the actual code you
can see how easy it is uh we have a
layer that's dense layer one as an
activation now they're using the railu
in this particular example and then you
have your name layer one layer dense
railo name Layer Two and so forth uh and
they just feed right into each other so
it's really easy just to stack them as
you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model and
this is really where things are at this
is new make sure you update your carass
or you'll find yourself running this um
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code cuz this is a fairly
new release and he uses multi-input and
multi-output model the complex model
which Forks into two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your coros input shape
equals 32x 32x 3 you have your dense
layers dense 64 activation Ru this
should look similar to what you already
saw before uh but if you look at the
graph on the right it's going to be a
lot easier to see what's going on you
have two two different
inputs uh and one way you could think of
this is maybe one of those is a small
image and one of those is a full-sized
image and that feedback goes into you
might feed both of them into one note
because it's looking for one thing and
then only into one node for the other
one and so you can start to get kind of
an idea that there's a lot of use for
this kind of split and this kind of
setup uh where we have multiple
information coming in but the
information's very different even though
it overlaps
and you don't want it to send it through
the same neural network um and they're
finding that this trains faster and is
also has a better result depending on
how you split the data up and and how
you Fork the models coming
down and so in here we do have the two
complex uh models coming in uh we have
our image inputs which is a 32x 32 by3
or three channels or four if you're
having an alpha channel uh you have your
dense your layers dense is 64 activation
using the railu very common uh x equals
dense inputs X layers dense x64
activation equals Rao X outputs equals
layers dense 10 X model equals coros
model inputs equals inputs outputs
equals outputs name equals n
model uh so we add a little name on
there and again this is this kind of
split here this is setting us up to um
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at corus
you probably already have this answer
what are neural networks uh but it's
always good to get on the same page and
for those people who don't fully
understand neural networks to dive into
them a little bit or do a quick overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex maical
problems and so just like the neuron one
neuron fires in and it fires out to all
these other neurons or nodes as we call
them and eventually they all come down
to your output layer and you can see
here we have the really standard graph
input layer a hidden layer and an output
layer one of the biggest parts of any
data processing is your data
pre-processing uh so we always have to
touch base on that with a neural network
like many of these models they're kind
of uh when you first start using them
they're like a black box you put your
data in you train it and you test it and
see how good it was was and you have to
pre-process that data cuz bad data in is
uh bad outputs so in data pre-processing
we will create our own data examples set
with carass the data consists of a
clinical trial conducted on 2100
patients ranging from ages 13 to 100
with a the patients under 65 and the
other half over 65 years of age we want
to find the possibility of a patient
experiencing side effects due to their
age and you can think of this in today's
world with uh co uh what's going to
happen on there and we're going to go
ahead and do an example of that in our
uh live Hands-On like I said most of
this you really need to have handson to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and uh I'll open that up
and open up a Jupiter notebook for doing
the python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your uh setups I just like
those for doing demos and uh showing
people especially shareholders
it really helps cuz it's a nice visual
so let me go and flip over to our
anaconda and the Anaconda has a lot of
cool to tools they just added datal lore
and IBM Watson Studio clad into the
Anaconda framework but we'll be in the
Jupiter lab or Jupiter notebook um I'm
going to do Jupiter notebook for this
because I use the lab for like large
projects with multiple pieces because it
has multiple tabs where the notebook
will work fine for what we're doing and
this opens up in our browser window
because that's how dup notebook sorry
Jupiter notebook is set to run and we'll
go under new create a new Python 3 and
uh it creates an Untitled python we'll
go ahead and give this a title and we'll
just call this uh
cross
tutorial and let's change that to
Capital there we go we go and just
rename that and the first thing we want
to go ahead and do is uh get some
pre-processing tools involved and so we
need to go ahead and import some stuff
for that like our numpy do some random
number
Generation Um I mentioned sklearn or
your s kit if you're installing sklearn
the sklearn stuff it's a s kit you want
to look
up that should be a tool of anybody who
is um doing data science if you if
you're not if you're not familiar with
the sklearn
toolkit it's huge uh but there's so many
things in there that we always go back
to and we want to go ahead and create
some train labels and train samples uh
for training our
data and then just a note of what we're
we're actually doing in here uh let me
go ahead and change this this is kind of
a fun thing you can do we can change the
code to
markdown and then markdown code is nice
for doing examples once you've already
built this uh our example data we're
going to do
experimental
there we go experimental drug was tested
on 2100 individuals between 13 to 100
years of age half the participants are
under 65 and 95% of participants are
under 65 experience no side effects well
95% of participants over 65 um
experience side effects so that's kind
of where we're starting at um and this
is just a real quick example because
we're going to do another one with a
little bit more uh complicated
information uh and so we want to go
ahead and
generate our setup uh so we want to do
for I in range and we want to go ahead
and create if you look here we have
random
integers train the labels of pin so
we're just creating some random
data uh let me go ahead and just run
that and so once we've created our
random data and if you if I mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from Simply learn they'll send you a
copy of this or you can zoom zo in on
the video and see how we went ahead and
did our train samples a pin um and we're
just using this I do this kind of stuff
all the time I was running a thing on uh
that had to do with errors following a
bell-shaped curve on uh a standard
distribution error and so what do I do I
generate the data on a standard
distribution error to see what it looks
like and how my code processes it since
that was the Baseline I was looking for
in this we're just doing uh uh
generating random data for our setup on
here and uh we could actually go in uh
print some of the data up let's just do
this
print um we'll do
train
samples and we'll just do the first um
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like and you can see the
first five pieces of data in our train
samples is 4985 41 68 19 just random
numbers generated in there that's all
that is uh and we generated
significantly more than that um let's
see 50 up here 1,000 yeah so there's
1,00 here 1,000 numbers we generated and
we could also if we wanted to find that
out we could do a quick uh print the
length of
it and so or you could do a shape kind
of thing and if you're using
numpy although the link for this is just
fine and there we go it's actually 2100
like we said in the demo setup in
there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't
we uh so we could also print do the same
thing oh
labels um and let's change this
to
labels and
[Music]
labels and run that just to double check
and sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one one0 one0 I guess that's if
they have symptoms or not one symptoms
uh zero none and so we want to go ahead
and take our train labels and we'll
convert it into a numpy array and the
same thing with our samples and let's go
ahead and run that and we also Shuffle
uh this is just a neat feature you can
do in uh numpy right here put my drawing
thing on which I didn't have on earlier
um I can take the data and I can Shuffle
it uh so we have our so it's it just
randomizes it that's all that's doing um
we've already randomized it so it's kind
of an Overkill it's not really
necessary but if you're doing uh a
larger package where the data is coming
in and a lot of times it's organized
somehow and you want to randomize it
just to make sure that that you know the
input doesn't follow a certain pattern
uh that might create a bias in your
model and we go ahead and create a
scaler uh the scaler range minimum Max
scaler feature range 0 to
one uh then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled train samples we're going to go
ahead and fit and transform the data uh
so it's nice and scaled and that is the
age uh so you can see up here we have 49
85 41 we're just moving that so it's
going to be uh between zero and one and
so this is true with any of your neural
networks you really want to convert the
data uh to zero and one otherwise you
create a bias uh so if you have like a
100 creates a bias
versus the math behind it gets really
complicated um if you actually start
multiplying stuff because a lot of
multiplication addition going on in
there that higher end value will
eventually multiply down and it will
have a huge bias as to how the model
fits it and then it will not fit as well
and then one of the fun things we can do
in j notebook is that if you have a
variable and you're not doing anything
with it it's the last one on the line it
will automatically
print um and we're just going to look at
the first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five
samples and you can see here we go uh 9
95. 791 so everything's between zero and
one and that just shows us that we
scaled it properly and it looks good uh
it really helps a lot to do these kind
of print UPS halfway through uh you
never know what's going to go on
there I don't know how many times I've
gotten down and found out that the data
sent to me that I thought was scaled was
not and then I have to go back and track
it down and figure it out on
there uh so let's go ahead and create
our artificial neural
network and for doing that this is where
we start diving into tensor flow and
carass uh tensor flow
if you don't know the history of tensor
flow it helps to uh jump into we'll just
use
Wikipedia careful don't quote Wikipedia
on these things because you get in
trouble uh but it's a good place to
start uh back in 2011 Google brain built
disbelief as a proprietary machine
learning setup tensor flow became the
open source for it uh so tensorflow was
a Google product and then it became uh
open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the defacto when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at uh so when you see the
tensorflow
setup it it's got like a huge following
there are some other setups like um the
S kit under the sklearn has our own
little neural network uh but the
tensorflow is the most robust one out
there right now and carass sitting on
top of it makes it a very powerful tool
so we can leverage both the carass uh
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup on top of tensor flow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensor flow uh and
then we have the rest of this is all
carass here from number two down uh
we're going to import from tensorflow
the coros uh connection and then you
have your tensorflow cross models import
sequential it's a specific kind of model
we'll look at that in just a second if
you remember from the that means it goes
from one layer to the next layer to the
next layer there's no funky splits or
anything like
that uh and then we have from tensor
flow across layers we're going to import
our activation and our dense
layer and we have our Optimizer atom um
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize uh your data when you first
do it atom's as good as any atom is
usually uh there's a number of Optimizer
out there there's about uh there's a
couple main ons but atom is usually
assigned to bigger data uh it works fine
usually the lower data does it just F
but atom is probably the mostly used but
there are some more out there and
depending on what you're doing with your
layers your different layers might have
different activations on them and then
finally down here you'll see um our
setup where we want to go ahead and use
the
metrics and we're going to use the
tensorflow cross metrics um for
categorical cross entropy uh so we can
see how everything performs when we're
done that's all that is um a lot of
times you'll see us go back and forth
between tensor flow and then scikit has
a lot of really good metrics also for
measuring these things um again it's the
end of the you know at the end of the
story how good does your model do and
we'll go ahead and load all that and
then comes the fun part um I actually
like to spend hours messing with these
things and uh four lines of C code
you're like ah you're going to spend
hours on four lines of code um no we
don't spend hours on four lines of code
that's not what we're talking about when
I say spend hours on four lines of code
uh what we have here I'm going to
explain that in just a second we have a
model and it's a sequential model if you
remember correctly we mentioned the
sequential up here where it goes from
one layer to the next and our first
layer is going to be your
input it's going to be uh what they call
D which is um you usually it's just DSE
and then you have your input and your
activation um how many units are coming
in we have 16 uh what's the shape What's
the activation and this is where it gets
interesting um because we have in here
uh
railu on two of these and soft Max
activation on one of these there are so
many different options for what these
mean um and how they function how does
the raylo how does the softmax
function and they do a lot of different
things um we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different
activations um and just some of it is
just U um almost like you're playing
with it like an artist you start getting
a feel for like a uh inverse tangent
activation or the tan
activation takes up a huge processing
amount uh so you don't see it a lot yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing Word documents and
you're tokenizing the words and so
you'll see this shift from one to the
other because you're both trying to
build a better model and if you're
working on a huge data set um it'll
crash the system it'll just take too
long to process um and then you see
things like soft Max uh soft Max
generates an interesting um
setup where a lot of these when you talk
about Ray oops let me do this uh railu
there we go railu has um a setup where
if it's less than zero it's zero and
then it goes up um and then you might
have what they call lazy uh setup where
it has a slight negative to it so that
the errors can translate better same
thing with softmax it has a slight
laziness to it so that errors trans
translate better all these little
details make a huge different on your
model um so one of the really cool
things about data science that I like is
you build your uh what they call you
build defil and it's an interesting uh
design setup oops I forgot the end of my
code
here the concept of build a fail is you
want the model as a whole to work so you
can test your model
out so you you can do uh you can get to
the end and you can do your let's see
where was it overshot down here you can
test your test out the quality of your
setup on there and see where did I do my
tensor flow oh here we go I did it was
right above me here we go we start doing
your cross entropy and stuff like that
is you need a full functional set of
code so that when you run
it you can then test your model out and
say hey it's either this model works
better than this model and this is why
um and then you can start swapping in
these models and so when I say I spend a
huge amount of time on pre-processing
data is probably 80% of your programming
time um well between those two it's like
8020 you'll spend a lot of time on the
models once you get the model down once
you get the whole code and the flow down
uh set depending on your data your
models get more and more robust as you
start experimenting with different
inputs different data streams and all
kinds of things and we can do a simple
model summary
here uh here's our sequential here's our
layer our output our
parameter this is one of the nice things
about carass is you just you can see
right here here's our sequential one
model boom boom boom boom everything's
set and clear and easy to read so once
we have our model built uh the next
thing we're going to want to do is we're
want to go ahead and train that
model and so the next step is of course
model training and when we come in here
this a lot of times is just paired with
the model because it's so
straightforward it's nice to print out
the model setup so you can have a
tracking but here's our model uh the
keyw in Cross is
compile Optimizer atom learning rate
another term right there that we're just
skipping right over that really becomes
the meat of uh
the setup is your learning rate uh so
whoops I forgot that I had an arrow but
I'll just underline
it a lot of times the learning rate set
to 0.0 uh set to 0.01 uh depending on
what you're doing this learning rate um
can overfit and underfit uh so you'd
want to look up I know we have a number
of tutorials out on overfitting and
underfitting that are really worth
reading once you get to that point in
understanding and we have our loss um
sparse categorical cross entropy so this
is going to tell carass how far to go
until it stops and then we're looking
for metrics of accuracy so we'll go
ahead and run that and now that we've
compiled our model we want to go ahead
and um run it fit it so here's our model
fit um we have our scaled train
samples our train labels our validation
split um in this case we're going to use
10% of the data for
validation uh batch size another number
you kind of play with not a huge
difference as far as how it works but it
does affect how long it takes to run and
it can also affect the bias a little bit
uh most of time though a batch size is
between 10 to 100 um depending on just
how much data you're processing in there
we want to go ahead and Shuffle it uh
we're going to go through 30 epics and
uh put a verbos of two let me just go
and run this and you can see right here
here's our epic here's our training um
here's our loss now if you remember
correctly up here we set the loss let's
see where was it um compiled our
data there we go loss uh so let looking
at the sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much um how how much does the um
error go down uh is the best way to look
at that and you can see here here the
lower the number the better it just
keeps going down and vice versa accuracy
we want let's see where's my
accuracy value accuracy at the end uh
and you can see 619
6974 it's going up we want the accuracy
would be ideal if it made it all the way
to one but we also the loss is more
important because it's a balance um you
can have 100% accuracy in your model
doesn't work because it's overfitted uh
again you w't look up overfitting and
underfitting
models and we went ahead and went
through uh 30 epics it's always fun to
kind of watch your code going um to be
honest I usually uh um the first time I
run it I'm like oh that's cool I get to
see what it does and after the second
time of running it I'm like I like to
just not see that you can repress those
of course in your code uh repress the
warnings in the
Printing and so the next step is going
to be building a test set and predicting
it now uh so here we go we want to go
ahead and build our test set and we have
just like we did our training
set a lot of times you just split your
your initial setup uh but we'll go ahead
and do a separate set on here and this
is just what we did above uh there's no
difference as far as
um the randomness that we're using to
build this set on here here uh the only
difference is
that we already um did our scaler up
here well it doesn't matter because the
the data is going to be across the same
thing but this should just be just
transform down here instead of fit
transform uh because you don't want to
refit your data um on your testing
data there we go now we're just
transforming it because you never want
to transform the test data um easy
mistake to make especially on an example
like this where we're not doing um you
know we're randomizing the data anyways
so it doesn't matter too much because
we're not expecting something
weird and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model as we take our model we
predict and we're going to do here's our
xcal data batch size 10 verbose and now
we have our predictions in here and we
could go ahead and do a um oh we'll
print
predictions and then I guess I could
just put down predictions and five so we
can look at the first five of the
predictions and what we have here is we
have our
age and uh the prediction on this age
versus on what what we think it's going
to be what what we think is going to
going to have uh symptoms or not and the
first thing we notice is that's hard to
read because we really want a yes no no
answer uh so we'll go ahead and just uh
round off the
predictions using the argmax um the
numpy argmax uh for prediction so it
just goes to a
01 and if you remember this is a Jupiter
notebook so I don't have to put the
print I can just put in uh rounded
predictions and we'll just do the first
five and you can see here 0 one 0 0 0 so
that's what the predictions are that we
have coming out of this um is no
symptoms symptoms no symptoms symptoms
no symptoms and just as uh we were
talking about at the beginning we want
to go ahead and um take a look at this
there we go confusion matrixes for
accuracy check um most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the S kit um the SK learn metrics uh
pyit being where that come comes from
import confusion Matrix uh some
iteration tools and of course a nice map
plot library that makes a big difference
so it's always nice to
um have a nice graph to look at u
pictures worth a thousand
words um and then we'll go ahead and do
call it CM for confusion Matrix y true
equals test labels y predict rounded
predictions and we'll go ahead and load
in our
cm
and I'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting um going over the
different plotting
code um you can spend uh like whole we
have whole tutorials on how to do your
different plotting on there uh but we do
have here is we're going to do a plot
confusion Matrix there's our CM our
classes normalized false title confusion
Matrix cmap is going to be in
blues and you can see here we have uh to
the nearest cmap titles all the
different pieces whether you put tick
marks or not the marks the classes the
color bar um so a lot of different
information on here as far as how we're
doing the printing of the of the
confusion Matrix you can also just dump
the confusion Matrix um into a caborn
and real quick get an output it's worth
knowing how to do all this uh when
you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders you don't want to do this
on the Fly you want to take the time to
make it look really nice uh like our
guys in the back did and uh let's go
ahead and do this forgot to put together
our CM plot labels we'll go and run
that and then we'll go ahead and call
the little the
definition for our
mapping and you can see here plot
confusion Matrix that's our the the
little script we just wrote and we're
going to dump our data into it um so our
confusion Matrix our classes um title
confusion Matrix and let's just go ahead
and run
that and you can see here we have our
basic setup uh no side effects
195 had side effects uh 200 no side
effects that had side effects so we
predicted the 10 of them who actually
had side effects and that's pretty good
I mean I I don't know about you but you
know that's 5% error on this and this is
because there's 200 here that's where I
get 5% is uh divide these both by by two
and you get five out of a 100 uh you can
do the same kind of math up here not as
quick on the flight it's 15 and 195 not
an easily rounded number but you can see
here where they have 15
people who predicted to have no uh with
the no side effects but had side effects
kind of setup on there and these
confusion Matrix are so important at the
end of the day this is really where
where you show uh whatever you're
working on comes up and you can actually
show them hey this is how good we are or
not how messed up it
is so this was a uh I spent a lot of
time on some of the parts uh but you can
see here is really simple uh we did the
random generation of data but when we
actually built the model coming up here
uh here's our model
summary and we just have the layers on
here that we built with our model on
this and then we went ahead and trained
it and ran the prediction now we can get
a lot more complicated uh let me flip
back on over here because we're going to
do another uh demo so that was our basic
introduction to it we talked about the
uh oops here we go okay so implementing
a neural network with carass after
creating our samples and labels we need
to create our carass neural network
model we will be working with a
sequential model which has three layers
and this is what we did we had our input
layer our hidden layers and our output
layers and you can see the input layer
uh coming in uh was the age Factor we
had our hidden layer and then we had the
output are you going to have symptoms or
not so we're going to go ahead and go
with something a little bit more
complicated um training our model is a
twep process we first compile our model
and then we train it in our training
data set uh so we have compiling
compiling converts the code into a form
of understandable by
Machine we used the atom in the last
example a gradient descent algorithm to
optimize a model and then we trained our
model which means it let it uh learn on
training data uh
and I actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
um here's our model that we
created
summarized uh we come down here and we
compile it so it tells it hey we're
ready to build this model and use it uh
and then we train it this is the part
where we go ahead and fit our model and
and put that information in here and it
goes through the training on on there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do and then you
saw we did the creating a confusion
Matrix with carass um as we are
performing classifications on our data
we need a confusion Matrix to check the
results a confusion Matrix breaks down
the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the
accuracy um and so you can see here this
is what we did with the true positive
false positive true negative false
negative and that is what we went over
let me just scroll down
here on the end we printed it out and
you can see we have a nice print out of
our confusion Matrix uh with the true
positive false positive false negative
true negative and so the blue ones uh we
want those to be the biggest numbers
because those are the better side and
then uh we have our false predictions on
here uh as far as this one so it had no
side effects but we predicted let's see
no side effects predicting side effects
and vice versa if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scaleup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more now uh saving
and loading models with carass we're
going to dive into a more complicated
demo um and you're going to say oh that
was a lot of complication before well if
you broke it down we randomized some
data we created the um Kass setup we
compiled it we trained it we predicted
and we ran our
Matrix uh so we're going to dive into
something a lot little bit more fun is
we're going to do a face mask detection
with carass uh so we're going to build a
cross model to check if a person is
wearing a mask or not in real time and
this might be important if you're at the
front of a store this is something today
which is um might be very useful as far
as some of our you know making sure
people are
safe uh and so we're going to look at
mask and no mask and let's start with a
little bit on the data and so in my data
I have with a mask you can see they just
have a number of images showing the
people in masks and again if you want
some of this information uh contact
simply learn and they can send you some
of the information as far as people with
and without masks so you can try it on
your own and this is just such a
wonderful example of this setup on here
so before I dive into the mass detection
uh talk about being in the current with
uh coid and seeing that people are
wearing masks this particular example I
had to go ahead and update to a python
3.8 version uh it might run in a 37 I'm
not sure I hav I kind of skipped 37 and
installed
38 uh so I'll be running in a three
python 38 um and then you also want to
make sure your tensor flow is up to date
because the um they call
functional uh layers with that's where
they split if you remember correctly
from back uh oh let's take a look at
this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers into different
you know different nodes into different
layers and split them uh very powerful
tool very popular right now in the edge
of where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so I've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and go through uh
our next example which includes uh
multiple layers um programming it to
recognize whether someone wears a mask
or not and then saving that model so we
can use it in real time so we're
actually almost a full um end to-end
development of a product here uh of
course this is a very simplified version
and there'd be a lot more to it you'd
also have to do like uh recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this so
let's go ahead and jump into that code
and we'll open up a new Python 3 oops
Python 3 three it's working on it there
we
go um and then we want to go ahead and
train our mask we'll just call this
train
mask and we want to go ahead and train
mask and save it uh so it's it's uh save
mask train mask detection not to be
confused with masking data a little bit
different we're actually talking about a
physical mask on your
face
and then from the cross standpoint we
got a lot of imports to do here and I'm
not going to dig too deep on the Imports
uh we're just going to go ahead and
notice a few of them uh so we have in
here oops me go all D there we go have
something to draw with a little bit here
we have our uh image
processing and the image processing
right here me underline that uh deals
with how do we bring images in because
most images are like a a square grid and
then each value in there has three
values for the three different colors uh
carass and tensorflow do a really good
job of uh working with that so you don't
have to do all the heavy listening and
figuring out what's going to go on uh
and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2D um this again is how do we
deal with the images and pulling them uh
dropout's a cool thing worth looking up
if you haven't when as you get more and
more into carass and tensor flow uh
it'll Auto drop out certain nodes that
way you'll get a better um the notes
just kind of die uh they find that they
actually create more of a bias and a
help and they also add processing time
so they remove them um and then we have
our flatten that's where you take that
huge array with the three different
colors and you find a way to flatten it
so it's just a one-dimensional array
instead of a 2X two by3 uh dense input
we did that in the other one so that
should look a little familiar oops there
we go our input um our model again these
are things we had on the last one here's
our Optimizer with our
atom um we have some pre-processing on
the input that goes along with bringing
in the data in uh more pre-processing
with image to array loading the image um
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of work you have to import all these
different modules in here but the truth
is is it does everything for you you're
not doing a lot of pre-processing you're
letting the software do the
pre-processing um and we're going to be
working with the setting something to
categorical again that's just a
conversion from a number to a category
uh 0o one doesn't really mean anything
it's like true false um label binarized
the same thing uh we're changing our
labels around and then there's our train
test split classification report um our
IM utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here Notch for these this is
something a little different going on
down here this is not part of the uh
tensor flow or the SK learn this is the
S kit setup and tensor flow above uh the
path this is part of um open CV and
we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the open CV so if you
want to know more about Open CV you'll
get a glance on it in uh this software
especially the ne the second piece when
we reload up the data and hook it up to
a video camera we're going to do that on
this round um but this is part of the
open CV thing and you'll see CV2 is
usually how that's referenced um but the
IM utilities has to do with how do you
rotate pictures around and stuff like
that uh and resize them and then the map
plot library for plotting because it's
nice to have a graph tells us how good
we're doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just a straight OS
access wow so that was was a lot of
imports uh like I said I'm not going to
spend I spent a little time going
through them uh but we didn't want to go
too much into
them and then I'm going to create um
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize we have the learning rate
number of epics to train for and the
batch size and if you remember correctly
we talked about the learning rate uh to
the
-4.1 um a lot of times it's 0.001 or
0.001 usually it's in that uh variation
depending on what you're doing and how
many epics and they kind of play with
the epics the epics is how many times
are we going to go through all the
data now I have it as two um the actual
setup is for 20 and 20 works great the
reason I have it for two is it takes a
long time to process one of the
downsides of
Jupiter is that Jupiter isolates it to a
single kernel so even though I'm on an
eight core processor uh with 16
dedicated threads only one thread is
running on this no matter what so it
doesn't matter uh so it takes a lot
longer to run even though um tensor flow
really scales up nicely and the batch
size is how many pictures do we load at
once in process again those are numbers
you have to learn to play with depending
on your data and what's coming in and
the last thing we want to go ahead and
do is there's a directory with a data
set we're going to
run uh and this just has images of mass
and not Mass
s and if we go in here you'll see data
set um and you have pictures with mask
they're just images of people with masks
on their face uh and then we have the
opposite let me go back up here without
masks so it's pretty straightforward
they look kind of a skew because they
tried to format them into very similar
uh setup on there so they're they're
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here and that's
kind of important thing to do on a lot
of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross uh layers and importing
and and dealing with images it does such
a wonderful job of converting these that
a lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with uh so you have a couple things
going on there and so uh we're now going
to be this is now loading the um images
and let me see and we'll go ahead and uh
create data and labels here's our um uh
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out and then for categories in our
list directory directory and if you
remember I just flashed that at you it
had uh uh face mask or or no face mask
those are the two options and we're just
going to load into that we're going to
pin the image itself and the labels so
we're just create a huge array uh and
you can see right now this could be an
issue if you had more data at some point
um thankfully I have a a 32 gig hard
drive or
Ram even that does you could do with a
lot less of that probably under 16 or
even eight gigs would easily load all
this stuff um and there's a conversion
going on in here I told you about how we
are going to convert the size of the
image so it resizes all the images that
way our data is all identical the way it
comes
in and you can see here with our labels
we have without mask without mask
without mask
uh the other one would be with mask
those are the two that we have going in
there uh and then we need to change it
to the one hot
encoding and this is going to take our
um um up here we had was was it labels
and data uh we want the labels uh to be
categorical so we're going to take
labels and change it to categorical and
our labels then equal a categorical list
uh we'll run that and again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10 let's do the last 10 just
because um minus 10 to the end there we
go just so we can see what the other
side looks like we now have one that
means they have a mask one zero one zero
so
on uh one being they have a mask and
zero no mask and if we did this in
Reverse I just realized that this might
not make sense if you've never done this
before let me run this
01 so 0er is uh do they have a mask on
zero do they not have a mask on one so
this is the same as what we saw up here
without mask one equals uh the second
value is without mask so with mask
without mask uh and that's just a with
any of your data
processing we can't really a zero if you
have a 01
output uh it causes issues as far as
training and setting it up so we always
want to use a one hot encoder if the
values are not actual uh linear Val or
regression values they're not actual
numbers if they represent a
thing and so now we need to go ahead and
do our train X test X train y test y um
train split test data and we'll go ahead
and make sure it's going to be uh random
and we'll take 20% of it for testing and
the rest for um setting it up as far as
training their model this is something
that's become so cool when they're
training these Set uh they realize we
can augment the data what does augment
mean well if I rotate the data around
and I zoom in I zoom out I rotate it um
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally um fill mode as I do all
these different things to the data it um
is able to it's kind of like like
increasing the number of samples I have
uh so if I have all these perfect
samples what happens when we only have
part of the face or the fa is tilted
sideways or all those little shifts
cause a problem if you're doing just a
standard set of data so we're going to
create an augment in our image data
generator um which is going to rotate
zoom and do all kinds of cool thing and
this is worth looking up this image data
generator and all the different features
it has um a lot of times I'll the first
time through my models I'll leave that
out because I want to make sure there's
a thing we call build def fail which is
just cool to know you build the whole
process and then you start adding these
different things in uh so you can better
train your model and so we go and run
this and then we're going to load um and
then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
um I haven't run it myself cuz the guys
in the back did this uh we take our base
model and one of the things we want to
do is we want to do a mobile net
V2 um and this what we this is a big
thing right here include the top equals
false a lot of data comes in with a
label on the top row uh so we want to
make sure that that is not the case uh
and then the construction of the head of
the model that will be placed on the top
of the base model uh we want to go ahead
and set that
up and you'll see a warning here I'm
kind of ignoring the warning because it
has to do with with the uh size of the
pictures and the weights for input shape
um so they'll it'll switch things to
defaults just saying hey we're going to
Auto shape some of this stuff for you
you should be aware that with this kind
of imagery we're already augmenting it
by moving it around and flipping it and
doing all kinds of things to it uh so
that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different
domain and so we're going to go back
here and we're going to have we have our
base model we're going to do our head
model equals our base model
output um and what we got here is we
have an average pooling 2D pool size 77
head model um head model flatten so
we're flattening the data uh so this is
all processing and flattening the images
and the pooling has to do with some of
the ways it can process some of the data
we'll look at that a little bit when we
get down to the lower level on this
processing it um and then we have our
dents we've already talked a about a
dense just what you think about and then
the head model has a Dropout of
0.5 uh what we can do with a
Dropout the Dropout says that we're
going to drop out a certain amount of
nodes while training uh so when you
actually use the model you will use all
the notes but this drops certain ones
out and it helps stop biases from a
forming uh so it's really a cool feature
on here they discovered this a while
back uh we have another DSE mode mode
and this time we're using soft Max
activation lots of different activation
options here softmax is a real popular
one for a lot of things U so was a
Ru and you know there we could do a
whole talk on activation formulas uh and
why what their different uses are and
how they work when you first start out
you'll you'll use mostly the ru and the
softmax for a lot of them uh just
because they're they're some of the
basic setups it's a good place to start
uh and then we have our model equals
model inputs equals base model. input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run
that and then we're going to Loop over
all the layers in the base model and
freeze them so they will not be updated
during the first training
process uh so for layer and base model
layers layers. trable equals False A lot
of times when you go through your data
um you want to kind of jump in part way
through through um I I'm not sure why in
the back they did this for this
particular example um but I do this a
lot when I'm working with series and and
specifically in stock data I want it to
iterate through the first set of 30 Data
before it does
anything um I would have to look deeper
to see why they froze it on this
particular one and then we're going to
compile our model uh so compiling the
model
atom and knit layer Decay um initial
learning rate over epics and we go ahead
and compile our loss is going to be the
binary cross entropy which we'll have
that print out Optimizer for opt metrics
is accuracy same thing we had before not
a huge jump as far as um the previous
code and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model uh so train the
head of the network print info training
head
run now I skipped a little time because
it you'll see the run time here is um at
80 seconds per epic takes a couple
minutes for it to get through on a
single
kernel one of the things I want you to
notice on here while we're while it's
finishing the
processing is that we have up here our
augment going on so anytime the train X
and train y go in there's some random
going on there and is jiggling it around
what's going into our setup uh of course
we're batch sizing it uh so it's going
through whatever we set for the batch
values how many we process at a time and
then we have the steps per epic uh the
train X the batch size validation data
here's our test X and Test Y where we're
sending that
in uh and this again it's validation one
of the important things to know about
validation is our um when both our
training data and our test data have
about the same accuracy that's when you
want to stop that means that our model
isn't biased if you have a higher
accuracy on your uh testing you know
you've trained it and your accuracy is
higher on your actual test data then
something in there is probably uh has a
bias and it's overfitted uh so that's
what this is really about right here
with the validation data and validation
steps so it looks like it's let me go
ahead and see if it's done processing
looks like we've gone ahead and gone
through two epics again you could run
this through about 20 with this amount
of data and it would give you a nice
refined uh model at the end we're going
to stop at two because I really don't
want to sit around all afternoon and I'm
running this on a single thread so now
that we've done this we're going to need
to evaluate our model and see how good
it is and to do that we need to go ahead
and make our
predictions um these are our predictions
on our test X to see what it thinks are
going to be uh so now it's going to be
evaluating the network and then we'll go
ahead and go down here and we want need
to uh turn the index in because remember
it's it's either zero or one it's a 0
one01 so you have two outputs uh not
wearing uh wearing a mask not wearing a
mask and so we need to go ahead and take
that argument at the end and change
those predictions to a zero or one
coming out uh and then to finish that
off we want to go ahead and let me just
put this right in here and do it all in
one shot we want to show a nicely
formatted classification report so we
can see what that looks like on here and
there we have it we have our Precision
uh it's 97% with a mask there's our F1
score support without a mask
97% um so that's pretty high high setup
on there you know you three people are
going to sneak into the store who are
without a mask and that thinks they have
a mask and there's going to be three
people with a mask that's going to flag
the person at the front to go oh hey
look at this person you might not have a
mask um that's if I guess it's a setup
in front of a store um so there there
you have it and of course one of the
other cool things about this is if
someone's walking into the store and you
take multiple pictures of them um you
know this is just an it it would be a
way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back back end and this is an
important step because we're going to
this is just cool I love doing this
stuff uh so we're going to go ahead and
take our model and we're going to save
it uh so model save Mass detector. model
we're going to give it a name uh we're
going to save the format um in this case
we're going to use the H5
format and so this model we just
programmed has just been saved uh so now
I can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say say I want to have somebody work on
the other part of the program well I
just save the model they upload the
model and now they can use it for
whatever and then if I get more
information uh and we start working with
that at some
point I might want to update this model
um make a better model and this is true
of so many things where I take this
model and maybe I'm uh running a
prediction on uh making money for a
company and as my model gets
better I want to keep up updating it and
then it's really easy just to push that
out to the actual end user uh and here
we have a nice graph you can see the
training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics uh we only did the you
know only shows just the one Epic coming
in here but you can see right here as
the uh um value loss train accuracy and
value
accuracy starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're um I
know when when I work in the S kit with
sklearn neural networks this is what
they're talking about a convergence is
our loss and our accuracy come together
and also up here and this is why I'd run
it more than just two epics as you can
see they still haven't converged all the
way uh so that would be a cue for me to
keep
going but what we want to do is we want
to go ahead and create a new Python
Program and we just did our train mask
so now we're going to go ahead and
import that and use it and show you in a
live action um get a view of uh both
myself in the afternoon along with my
background of an office which is in the
middle still of reconstruction for
another
month and we'll call this uh
mask
detector and then then we're going to
grab a bunch of um a few items coming
in uh we have our um mobet V2 import
pre-processing input so we're still
going to need that um we still have our
tensor floor image to array we have our
load model that's where most of the
stuff's going on this is our CV2 or open
CV again I'm not going to dig too deep
into that we're going to flash a little
open CV code at you uh and we actually
have a tutorial on that coming out
um our numpy array our IM utilities
which is part of the open CV or CV2
setup uh and then we have of course time
and just our operating system so those
are the things we're going to go ahead
and set up on here and then we're going
to create this takes just a
moment our module here which is going to
do all the heavy
lifting uh so we're going to detect and
predict a mask we have frame face net
Mass net these are going to be generated
by our open CV we have our frame coming
in and then we want to go ahead and and
create a mask around the face it's going
to try to detect the face and then set
that up so we know what we're going to
be processing through our
model um and then there's a frame shape
here this is just our height versus
width that's all HW stands for um the
called it blob which is a CV2 DNN blob
form image frame so this is reformatting
this Frame that's going to be coming in
literally from my camera and we'll show
you that in a minute that little piece
of code that shoots that in here uh and
we're going to pass the blob through the
network and obtain the face
detections uh so fa net. set inport blob
detections faet forward print detections
shape uh so these is this is where it's
going going on here this is that model
we just created we're going to send that
in there and I'll show you in a second
where that is but it's going to be under
face
net uh and then we go ahead and
initialize our list of faces their
corresponding locations and the list of
predictions from our face mask
Network we're going to Loop over the
detections and this is a little bit more
work than you think um as far as looking
for different faces what happens if you
have a fa a crowd of faces um so We're
looping through through the detections
and the shapes going through here and
probability associated with the
detection uh here's our confidence of
detections we're going to filter out
weak detection by ensuring the
confidence is greater than the minimum
confidence uh so we've said it remember
zero to one so 0 five would be our
minimal confidence probably is pretty
good um and then we're going to put in
compute bounding boxes for the object if
I'm zipping through this it's because
we're going to do an open CV and I
really want to stick to just the carass
part and so I'm I'm just kind of jumping
through all this code you can get a copy
of this code from Simply learn and take
it apart or look for the open CV coming
out and we'll create a box uh the box
sets it around the
image ensure the bounding boxes fall
within the dimensions of the
frame uh so we create a box around
what's going what we hope is going to be
the face extract the face Roi convert it
from BGR to RGB
Channel again this is an open CV issue
not really an issue but it has to do
with the order um I don't know how many
times I've forgotten to check the order
colors when working with open CV because
it's all kinds of fun things when red
becomes blue and blue becomes red uh
then we're going to go ahead and resize
it process it frame it uh face frame
setup again the face the CBT color we're
going to convert it uh we're going to
resize it image to array pre-process the
input uh pin the face locate face. x.y
and x boy that was just a huge amount
and I skipped over a ton of it but the
bottom line is we're building a box
around the face and that box because the
open CV does a decent job of finding the
face and that box is going to go in
there and see hey does this person have
a mask on
it uh and so that's what that's what all
this is doing on here and then finally
we get down to this where it says
predictions equals mass net. predict
faces batch size
32 uh so these different images of where
we're guessing where the face is are
then going to go through an generate an
array of faces if you will and we're
going to look through and say does this
face have a mask on it and that's what's
going right here is our prediction
that's the big thing that we're working
for and then we return the locations and
the predictions the locations just tells
where on the picture it is
and then the um prediction tells us what
it is is it a mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up so
we're going to load our serialized face
detector model from dis um and we have
our the path that it was saved in
obviously you're going to put it in a
different path depending on where you
have it or however you want to do it and
how you saved it on the last one where
we trained it uh then we have our
weights path um and so finally our face
net here it is equals CB2 dn. Reet uh
protot text path weights path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run
that and then we also need to I'll just
put it right down here I always hate
separating these things in there um and
then we're going to load the actual mass
detector model from disk this is the the
the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also so this
is pulling in all the different pieces
we need for our model and then the next
part is we're going to create open up
our video uh and this is just kind of
fun because it's all part of the open
CV video
setup and me just put this all in as one
there we go uh so we're going to go
ahead and open up our video we're going
to start it and we're going to run it
until we're
done and this is where we get some real
like kind of liveaction stuff which is
fun this is what I like working about
with images and videos is it when you
start working with images and videos
it's all like right there in front of
you it's Visual and you can see what's
going on uh so we're going to start our
video streaming this is grabbing our
video stream Source zero
start uh that means it's C grabbing my
main camera I have hooked up um and then
you know starting video you're going to
print it out here's our video Source
equals zero start Loop over the frames
from the video
stream oops a little redundancy there uh
um let me
close I'll just leave it that's how they
had it in the code so uh so while true
we're going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels so
here's our frame we're going to read it
uh from our visual uh stream we're going
to resize
it and then we have a returning remember
we returned from the our procedure the
location and the prediction so detect
and predict Ma mask we're sending it the
frame we're sending it the face net and
the mass net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on
here and then it returns our location
and predictions and then for our box and
predictions in the location and
predictions um and the boxes is again
this is an open CV set that says hey
this is a box coming in from the
location um because you have the two
different points on there and then we're
going to unpack the box and predictions
and we're going to go ahead and do mask
without a mask equals
prediction we're going to create our
label no mask we create color if the
label equals mask
l225 and you know this is going to make
a lot more sense when I hit the Run
button here uh but we have the
probability of the label we're going to
display the label and bounding box
rectangle in the output
frame uh and then we're going to go
ahead and show the output from the frame
CV2 I am show frame frame and then the
key equals CV2 wait key1 we're just
going to wait till the next one comes
through from our
feed and we're going to do this until we
hit the stop button pretty much so are
you ready for this let's see if it works
we've distributed our uh our model we've
loaded it up into our distributed uh
code here we've got it hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run
it and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
popup
and there I am in my office with my
funky headset
on uh and you can see in the background
my unfinished wall and it says up here
no mask oh no I don't have a mask on uh
I wonder if I cover my mouth what would
happen uh you can see my no
mask goes down a little bit I wish I'd
brought a mask into my office it's up at
the house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98% that I
don't have a mask on and it's true I
don't have a mask on right now and this
could be distributed this is actually an
excellent little piece of script that
you could start you know you install
somewhere on a a video feed on a on a
security camera or something and then
you'd have this really neat uh setup
saying hey do you have a mask on when
you enter a store or public
transportation or whatever it is where
they're required to wear a mask uh let
me go and stop
that now if you want a copy of this uh
code definitely give us a hauler we will
be going into open CV in another one so
I skipped a lot of the open CV um code
in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the carass uh saving
the model uploading the model and then
processing a streaming video through it
so you can see that the model works we
actually have this working model that
hooks into the video
camera which is just pretty cool and a
lot of
fun so I told you we're going to dive in
and really Roll Up Our Sleeve and do a
lot of coating today uh we did the basic
uh demo up above for just pulling in a
carass and then we went into a cross
model uh where we pulled in data to see
whether someone was wearing a mask or
not so very useful in today's world as
far as a fully running
application and we're going to take a
look at image classification using
carass and the basic setup we'll
actually look at two different demos on
here uh what's in it for you today what
is image
classification Intel image
classification data creating neural
networks with carass and the vgg16
model what is image
classification the process of image
classification refers to assigning
classes to an entire image images can be
classified based on different categories
like we it is a nighttime or daytime
shot what the image represents ET ET and
you can see here we have mountains
looking for mountains we'll actually be
doing some uh uh pictures of scenery and
stuff like that in deep learning we
perform image classification by using
neural networks to extract features from
images and classifies them based on
these
features and you can see here where it
says like what computer sees and it says
oh yeah we see mostly forests maybe a
little bit of mountains because the way
the image is um and this is really where
one of the areas that neural networks
really shines um if you try to run this
stuff through uh more like a linear
regression model you'll still get
results uh but the results kind of miss
a lot of things as they as the neural
networks get better and better at what
they do with different tools we have out
there uh so Intel image classification
data the data being used is the Intel
image classification data set which
consists of images of six types of land
areas and say we have Forest building
glaciers and mountains sea and Street uh
and you can see here there's a couple of
the images out of there as a setup in
the in the um uh Intel image
classification data that they
use and then we're going to go into
creating a neural networks with
carass the convolutional neural network
that we are creating from scratch looks
uh as showing
below you'll see here we have our input
layer
um they have a listed Max pulling uh so
you have as you're coming in with the
input layer and this the input layer is
actually um before this but the first
layer that it's going to go into is
going to be a convolutional neural
network uh then you have a Max pooling
that pulls those the the convolutional
neural network returns uh in this case
they have two of those that is very
standard with convolutional neural
networks uh one of the ones that I was
looking at ear that was standard being
used by um I want one of the larger
companies I can't remember which one for
doing a large amount of identification
had two convolutional neural networks
each with their Max pooling and then
about 17 dense layers after it we're not
going to do that heavy duty of a of a
code but we'll get you head in the right
direction and that gives you an idea of
what you're actually going to be looking
at when you look at the flatten part and
then the dense we're talking like 17
dense layers
afterwards uh I find that a lot of the
stuff I've been working on I end up
maxing it out right around nine dense
layers it really depends on what you
have going in and what you're working
with and the vgg16
model uh vgg16 is a pre-trained CNN
model which is used for image
classification it is trained on a large
varied data set and fine-tune to fit
image classification data sets with
ease and you can see down here we have
the input coming in uh the convolutional
neural network 1: one 1:2 and then
pooling and then we do 2:1 2:2
convolutional neural network then
pooling 3 to2 and you can see there's
just this huge layering of convolutional
neural networks and in this case they
have five such layers going in and then
you three dents going out or uh more now
when they took this setup this actually
won an award uh back in 2019 for this
particular setup
uh and it does it does really good
except that again um we only show the
three dense layers here and as you find
out depending on your data going in and
what you have set up uh that really
isn't enough on one of these setups and
I'm going to show you why we restricted
it because it does take up a lot of
processing power in some of these things
so let's go ahead and roll up our
sleeves and we're going to look at both
the setups we're going to start with the
um uh the first
classification um and then we'll go into
the vgg16 and show you how that's set up
now I'm going to be using anaconda and
let me flip over to my anaconda so you
can see what that looks like now I'm
running in the Anaconda here uh you'll
see that I've set up a main python uh 38
I always put that in there this is where
I'm doing like most of my kind of
playing around uh this is done in Python
version 3.8 we're not going to dig too
much into versions uh at this point you
should already have carass installed on
there usually carass takes a number of
extra
steps and then our usual um uh setup is
the numpy the pandas uh your SK your s
kit which is going to be the sklearn
your caborn and I'll I'll show you those
in just a minute um and then I'm just
going to be in the Jupiter lab where
I've created a new um notebook in here
and let's flip on over there to my blank
notebook now I'm there's a couple cool
things to note in here is that um one I
used the the um Anaconda jupyter
notebook setup because it keeps
everything separate uh except for carass
uh carass is actually running separately
in the back I believe it's a a c program
uh what's nice about that is that it
utilizes the multi-processors on the
computer and I'll mention that just in a
little bit when we actually get down to
running the
code and when we look in here uh a
couple things to note is here's our uh
um oops I thought I grabbed the other
drawing thing uh but here's our numpy
and our pandas right here and our
operating system this is our s kit you
always import it as SK learn for the
classification report uh we're going to
be using well usually import like
Seaborn brings in all of your pip plot
Library
also kind of nice to throw that in there
I can't remember if we're actually using
caborn if they just the people in the
back just threw that together um and
then we have the sklearn shuffle for
shuffling data here's our map plot
library that the Seaborn is pretty much
built on um CV2 if you're not familiar
with that that is our image um module
for importing the image and then of
course we have our tense or flow down
here which is what we're really working
with and then the last thing is just for
visual effect while we're running this
um if you're doing a demo and you're
working with the partners or the
shareholders uh this tqdm is really kind
of cool it's an extensible progress bar
for Python and I I'll show you that too
remember data science is not I mean you
know most of this code when I'm looking
through this code I'm not going to show
half of this stuff to the shareholders
or anybody I'm working with they don't
really care about pandas and all that we
do because we want to understand how it
works uh so we need to go ahead and
import those those different um setup on
there and then the next thing is we're
going to go ahead and set up our
classes uh now we remember if we had
Mountain streak Glacier building sea and
Forest those were the different images
that we have coming
in and we're going to go ahead and just
do class name labels and we're going to
kind of match that class name of I for I
class name uh equals the class names so
our labels are going to match the names
up here
uh and then we have the number of uh
classes and print the class names and
the labels and we'll go ahead and set
the image size this is important that we
resize everything because if you
remember with neural
networks they take one size data coming
in and so when you're working with
images you really want to make sure
they're all resized to the same uh setup
it might squish them it might stretch
them that generally does not cause a
problem in these uh in some of the other
tricks you can do with if you if you
need more data um and this is one that's
used regularly we're not going to do it
in here is you can also take these
images and not only resize them but you
can til them one way or the other crop
parts of them um so they process
slightly differently and it'll actually
increase your accuracy of some of these
predictions uh and so you can see here
we have Mountain equals zero that's what
this class name label is Street equals 1
Glacier equals 2 buildings equals 3 C 4
Forest equals
5 now we did this as an enumerator so
each one is 0 through five uh a lot of
times we do this instead as um uh uh 01
01 01 so you have five outputs and each
one's a zero or a one coming out so the
next thing we really want to do is we
want to go ahead and load the data up
and just put a label in there loading
data just just so you know what we're
doing we going to put in the loading
data down here uh make sure it's well
labeled uh and we'll create a definition
for this and this is all part of your
preprocessing at this point you could
replace this with all kinds of different
things depending on what you're working
on and if you once you download you can
go download this data set uh send a note
to the simply learn team here in YouTube
um and they'll be happy to direct you in
the right direction and make sure you
get this path here um so you have the
right right whatever wherever you saved
it a lot of times I'll just abbreviate
the path or put it as a sub thing and
just get rid of the directory um but
again double check your paths um we're
going to separate this into a segment
for training and a segment for testing
and that's actually how it is in the
folder let me just show you what that
looks
like so when I have my lengthy path here
where I keep all my uh programming
simply learned this particular setup
we're working on image classification
and image classification clearly you
probably wouldn't have that lengthy of a
list and when we go in here uh you'll
see sequence train sequence test they've
already split this up this is what we're
going to train the data in and again you
can see buildings Forest Glacier
Mountain Sea Street uh and if we double
click let's go under Forest you can see
all these different Forest uh images and
and there's a lot of variety here I mean
we have winter time we have
summertime um so it's kind of
interesting you know here's like a
fallen tree versus um a road going down
the middle that's really hard to train
and if you look at the
buildings A lot of these buildings
you're looking up a skyscraper we're
looking down the
setup here's some trees with one I want
to highlight this one it has trees in it
uh let me just open that up so you can
see it a little
closer the reason I want to highlight
this is I want you to think about this
we have trees growing is this the city
or a
forest um so this kind of imagery makes
it really hard for a classifier and if
you start looking at these you'll see a
lot of these images do have trees and
other things in the foreground weird
angles really a hard thing for a
computer to sort out and figure out
whether it's going to be a forest or a
um
city and so in our loading of data uh
one we have to have the path the
directory we're going to come in here we
have our images and our labels so we're
going to load the images in one section
the labels in another
um and if you look through here it just
goes through the different folders uh in
fact let me do this let
me there we go uh as we look at this
we're just going to Loop through the
three the six different folders that
have the different Landscapes and then
we're going to go through and pull each
file
out and each label um so we set the
label we set the folder for file and
list uh here's our image path join the
paths this is all kind of n General
stuff um so I'm kind of skipping through
it really
quick and here's our image setup uh if
you remember we're talking about the
images we have our CV2 reader so it
reads the the image in uh it's going to
go ahead and take the image and convert
it to uh from blue green red to Red
Green Green blue this is a CV2 thing um
almost all the time it Imports it and
instead of importing it as a standard
that's used just about everywhere it
Imports it with the BGR versus RGB um
RGB is pretty much a standard in here
you have to remember that with CV2 uh
and then we're going to go ahead and
resize it this is the important part
right here we've set a we've decided
what the size is and we want to make
sure all the images have the same size
on
them and then we just take our IM and
we're just going toin the image pin the
label um and then the images it's going
to turn into a numpy array this just
makes it easier to process and
manipulate and then the labels is also a
numpy array and then we just return the
output append images and labels and we
return the output down
here so we've loaded these all into
memory uh we haven't talked to much
there'd be a different set set up in
there cuz there is ways to feed the
files directly into your cross model uh
but we want to go ahead and just load
them all it's
really for today's processing and that
what our computers can handle that's not
a big deal and then we go ahead and set
the uh train images train labels test
images test labels and that's going to
be returned in our output of pin and you
can see here we did um uh images and
labels set up in there and it just loads
them in there so we'll have these four
different categories let me just go
ahead and run
that
uh so now we've gone ahead and loaded
everything on
there and then if you remember from
before uh we imported we just go back up
there Shuffle here we go here's our
sklearn utilities import Shuffle and so
we want to take these labels and shuffle
them around a little bit um just mix
them up so it's not having the same if
you run the same process over and over
uh then you might run into some problems
on
there and just real quick let's go ahead
and do uh um a plot so we just you know
we we've looked at them as far as from
outside of our code we pulled up the
files and I showed you what that was
going on we can go a and just display
them here too and I tell you when you're
working with different
people this should be highlighted right
here um this thing is like when I'm
working on code and I'm looking at this
data and I'm trying to figure out what
I'm doing I skip this process the second
I get into a meeting and I'm showing
what's going on to other people I skip
everything we just did so and go right
to here where we want to go ahead and
display some images and take a look at
it and in this display um I've taken
them and I've resized the images to 20
by
20 that's pretty small uh so we're going
to lose just a massive amount of detail
and you can see here these nice
pixelated images um I might even just
stick with the folder showing them what
images we're
processing uh again this is you got to
be a little careful this maybe resizing
it was a bad idea um in fact let me try
it without resizing it and see what
happens oops so I took out the image
size and then we put this straight in
here one of the things again this is
um put the D there we go one of the
things again that we want to
know whenever we're working on these
things uh is the
CV2 there are so many different uh image
classification setups it's really a
powerful package when you're doing
images but you do need to switch it
around so that it works with the p plot
and so make sure you take your numpy
array and change it to a U integer 8
format uh because it comes in as a float
otherwise you'll get some weird images
down there um and so this is just
basically we split up our we've created
a plot we went ahead and did the plot 20
by 20 um or the plot figure size is 20
by 20 um and then we're doing 25 so a
5x5 subplot um nothing really going on
here too exciting but you can see here
where we get the images and
really when you're showing people what's
going on this is what they want to see
uh so you skip over all the code and you
have your meeting you say okay here's
our images of the
building um don't get caught up in how
much work you do get caught up in what
they want to see so if you want to work
in data science that's really important
to
know and this is where we're going to
start uh having fun uh here's our model
this is where it gets exciting when
you're digging into these models and you
have here uh let me
get there we
go when you have here if you look here
here's our convolutional neural network
uh
2D and uh 2D is an image you have two
different dimensions XY and even though
there's three colors it's still
considered 2D if you're running a video
you'd be convolutional neural network 3D
if you're doing a series going across um
a Time series it might be 1D
and on these you need to go ahead and
have your convolutional n network if you
look here there's a lot of really cool
settings going on to dig into um we have
our input shape so everything's been set
to 150 by 150 uh and it has of course
three different color schemes in it
that's important to notice um
activation default is Ru uh this is
small amounts of data being processed on
a bunch of little
um neural
networks and right here is the 32 that's
how many of these convolutional null
networks are being strung up on here and
then the
3X3 uh when it's doing its steps it's
actually looking at a little 3x3 Square
on each image and so that's what's going
on here and with convolutional noral
networks the window floats across and
adds up all these numbers going across
on this data and then eventually it
comes up with 30 in this case 32
different feature options uh that it's
looking for and of course you can change
that 32 you can change the 3X3 so you
might have a larger setup you know if
you're going across
150 um by 150 that's a lot of steps so
we might run this as 15 by 15 uh there's
all kinds of different things you can do
here we're just putting this together
again that would be something you would
play with to find out which ones are
going to work better on this setup um
and there's a lot of play
involved that's really where it becomes
an art form is guessing at what that's
going to be the second part I mentioned
earlier and I I can only begin to
highlight this um when you get to these
dense layers one is the activation is a
Ru they use a railu and a softmax here
um it's a whole whole uh setup just
explaining why these are different um
and how they're different because
there's also an exponential there's a
tangent in fact uh there's just a ton of
these and you can build your own custom
activations depending on what you're
doing a lot of different things go into
these activations uh there are two or
three major thoughts on these
activations and Ru and softmax are uh
well Ru uh you're really looking at just
the number you're adding all the numbers
together and you're looking at ukian
geometry um ax plus b X2 plus
cx3 plus a bias with soft Max this
belongs to the party of um it's
activated or it's not except it's they
call it softmax because when you get to
the to zero instead of it just being
zero uh it's actually slightly a little
bit less than zero so that when it
trains it doesn't get lost um there's a
whole series of these activations
another activation is the
tangent um where it just drops off and
you have like a very narrow area where
you have from minus one to one or
exponential which is 0 to one so there's
a lot of different ways to do the
activation again we can do that' be a
whole separate lesson on here we're
looking at the convolutional neural
network um and we're doing the two pools
this is so common you'll see two two
convolutional n networks St on top of
each other each with its own Max pull
underneath and let's go ahead and run
that so we built our model there and
then we need to go ahead and
um compile the model so let's go ahead
and do
that uh we going to use the atom uh
Optimizer the bigger the data the atom
fits better on there there's some other
Optimizer but I think atom's a default
um I don't really play with the
optimizer too much that's like the if
once you get a model that works really
good you might try some different
optimizers uh but atom's usually the
most and then we're looking at uh
loss pretty standard we want to minimize
our Lo we want
to maximize the loss of error and then
we're going to look at accuracy um
everybody likes say accuracy I'm going
to tell you right
now I start talking to people and like
okay what's what's the loss on this and
that and as a data science yeah I want
to know how the LW what what's going on
with with that and we'll show you why in
a minute but everybody wants to see
accuracy they want to know how accurate
this is uh and then we're going to run
the fit and I wanted to do this just so
I can show you even though we're in uh
python setup in here where Jupiter
notebook is using only a single
processor I'm going to bring over my
little CPU Tool uh this is eight cores
on 16 dedicated threads so it shows up
as 16 processors and up actually I got
to run this and then move it over so
we're going to run this and hopefully it
doesn't destroy my
mic uh and as it comes in you can see
it's starting to do go through the epics
we said I set it for five epics and then
this is really nice because carass uses
all the different uh threads available
so it does a really good job of doing
that uh this is going to take a while if
you look at here it's um ETA 2 minutes
and 25 seconds 24 seconds so this is
roughly 2 and 1 12 minutes per epic uh
and we're doing five epics so this is
going to be done in roughly 15 minutes I
don't know about you but I don't think
you want to sit here for 15 minutes
watching The Green bars go across so
we'll go ahead and let that run and
there we go uh there was our 15 minutes
it's actually less than that uh because
I did when I went in here realized that
uh uh where was
it here we go here's our model compile
here's our model FL uh fit and here's
our epics uh so I did four epics so a
little bit better more like 10 to 11
minutes instead of uh uh doing the
full uh 15 and when we look at this
here's our model we did talked about the
compiler uh here's our history we're
going to um history equals the model fit
we'll go into that in just a minute
and what we're looking at is we have our
epics um here's our validation split so
as we train it uh we're weighing the
accuracy versus you kind of pull some
data off to the side uh while you're
training it and the reason we do that is
that um you don't want to overfit and
we'll look at that chart in just a
minute uh here's batch
size this is just how many images you're
sending through at a time
the larger the batch it actually
increases the processing speed um and
there's reasons to go up or down on the
batch size because of the U the the
smaller of the batch there's a certain
point where um you get too large of a
batch and it's trying to fit everything
at once uh so I 128's kind of big U
depends on the computer you're on what
it can handle and then of course we have
our train images and our train labels
going in telling it what we're going to
train on
and then we look at our four epics here
uh here's our accuracy we want the
accuracy to go up and we get all the way
up to uh
83 or
83% uh this is actual percentage based
pretty much and we can see over here our
loss we want our loss to go down really
fluctuates uh 55 1.2
7748 uh so we have a lot of things going
on there let's go ahead and graph
those turn that off and our our team in
the back did a wonderful job of putting
together um this basic plot setup um
here's our subplot coming in we're going
to be looking at um uh from the history
we're going to send it the accuracy and
the value
accuracy labels and setup on there um
and we're going to also look at loss and
value loss so you can see what this
looks like what's really interesting
about this setup and let me let me just
go ahead and show you because uh without
actually seeing the plots it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense uh it's just
basic plotting of uh of the data using
the PIP plot library and I want you to
look at this this is really interesting
um when I ran this the first time I had
very different
results um and they they vary greatly
and you can see here our accuracy
continues to
climb um and there's a crossover
here put it in here right here's our
crossover and I point that out because
as we get to the right of that crossover
where our
accuracy U and we're like oh yeah I got
8% we're starting to get an overfit here
that's what this this switch over means
um as our value um as a training set
versus the value um accuracy stays the
same and so that this is the one we're
actually really want to be aware of and
where it
crosses is kind of where you want to
stop at um and we can see that also with
the train loss versus the value loss
right here we did one Epic and look how
it just flat lines right there with our
loss so really one Epic is probably
enough and you're say wow okay
8% um certainly if I was working with
the shareholders um telling them that it
has an 80% accuracy isn't quite true and
and we'll look at that a little deeper
it really comes out here that the
accuracy of our actual values is closer
to0 41% right here um even after running
it this number of times and so you
really want to stop right here at that
crossover one Epic would have been
enough um so the is a little overfitted
on this when we do four
epics and uh oops there we are
okay my drawing won't go away um let me
see if I can get there we
go U for some reason I've killed my
drawing ability on my
recorder all right took a couple extra
clicks uh so let's go ahead and take a
look at our ual test loss um so you see
where a cross is over that's where I'm
looking at that's where we start over
fitting the model and this is where if
uh we were going to go back and
continually upgrade the model we would
start taking a look at the images and
start rotating them uh we might start
playing with the convolutional neural
network instead of doing the 3X3 window
um we might expand that or you know find
different things that might make a big
difference as far as the way it
processes these things
um so let's go ahead and take a click at
our uh our test loss now remember we had
our training data now we're going to
look at our test images and our test
labels for our test loss here and this
is just model evaluate uh just like we
did fit up here where was it um one more
model fit with our training data going
in now we're going to evaluate it on the
and and this data has not been touched
yet so this model's never seen this data
this is on uh completely new information
as far as the model is concerned of
course we already know what it is from
the labels we
have and this is what I was talking
about here's the actual accuracy right
here.
48 uh or
4847 so this 49% of the Time guesses
what the image
is uh and I mean really that's a bottom
dollar uh does this work for what you're
needing does 49% work work do we need to
upgrade the model more um in some cases
this might be uh oh what was I doing I
was working on uh stock
evaluations and we were looking at what
stocks were the top performers well if I
get that 50% correct on top
performers uh I'm good with that um
that's actually pretty good for stock
evaluation in fact the number I had for
stock was more like uh um 30 something
per as far as being a top performer
stock much harder to predict um but at
that point you're like well I'm you'll
make money off of that so again this
number right here depends a lot on the
domain you're working
on and then we want to go ahead and
bring this home a little bit more uh as
far as looking at the different setup in
here and one of the uh from SK learned
if you remember actually let's go back
to the top uh we had the classification
report and this came in from our sklearn
or S kit setup and that's right here you
can see it right here on the
um see there we go uh classification
report right here uh sklearn metrics
import classification report that's what
we're going to look at
next a lot of this stuff uh depends on
who you're working with so when we start
looking at um prec PR
ision you know this is like for each
value I can't remember what one one one
was probably mountains so if 44% is not
good enough if if you're doing like um
you're in the medical department and
you're doing cancer is it is this
cancerous or not I'm only 44% accurate
not a good deal you know I would not go
with that um so it depends on what
you're working with on the different
labels and what they're used for
Facebook you know 44% I'm guessing the
right person I would hope it does a
little bit better than that um but
here's our main accuracy this is what
almost everybody looks at they say oh
48% that's what's important um again it
depends on what domain you're in and
what you're working
with and now we're going to do the same
model o somehow I got my there it goes I
thought I was going to get stuck in
there again uh this time we're going to
be using the V
g16 and remember this one has uh all
those layers going into it so it's
basically a bunch of convolutional n
networks getting smaller and smaller on
here uh and so we need to go ahead and
um import all our different stuff from
carass uh we're importing the main one
is the V g16 setup on there just aim
that there we go
um there's kind of a pre-processing
images um application pre-process input
this is all part of the VG g16 setup on
there uh and once we have all those we
need to go ahead and create our
model and we're just going to create a
vgg16 model in here um inputs model
inputs outputs model inputs I'm not
going to spend as much time as I did on
the other one uh we're going to go
through it really quickly one of the
first things I would do is if you
remember in carass you can trate a model
like you would a
layer um and so at this point I would
probably add a lot of dense layers on
after the vgg16 model and create a new
model with all those things in there and
we'll go ahead and uh run this uh
because here's our model coming in and
our setup and it'll take it just a
moment to compile that what's funny
about this is I'm I'm waiting for it to
download the um package since I pre- ran
this um it takes it a couple minutes to
download the vgg16 model into here um
and so we want to go ahead and train
features for the model we're going to
predict the we're going to predict the
train images and we're going to test
features on the predict test images on
here and then I told you I was going to
create another model too and the people
in the back uh did not disappoint me
they went ahead and did just that and
this is really an important part um this
is worth stopping for I told you going
to go through this really quick so
here's our
uh we we have our model
two um coming in and we we've created a
model up here with the vgg16 model
equals model inputs model inputs and so
we have our
vgg16 this has already been
pre-programmed uh and then we come down
here and I want you to notice on this um
right here layer model two layers minus
4 4 to 1 x layer X um we're basically
taking this model and we're adding stuff
onto it and so uh we've taken we've just
basically duplicated this model we could
have done the same thing by using model
up here as a layer um we could have had
the input go to this model and then have
that go down here so we've added on this
whole setup this whole block of code
from 13 to 7
has been added on to our vgg16 model and
we have a new model uh with the layer
input an X down here let's go ahead and
run that and compile it and that was a
lot to go through right there uh when
you're building these models this is the
part that gets so
complicated that you get stuck playing
in and yet it's so fun uh it's like a
puzzle how can I Loop these models
together and in this case you can see
right here that the layers uh we're just
copying layers over and adding each
layer in um this is one way to build a
new model and we'll go ahead and run
that like I said the other way is you
can actually use the model as a layer I
had a little trouble playing with it uh
sometimes when you're using the Straight
model
over you run into issues
um it seems like it's going to work and
then you mess up on uh the input and the
output layers there's all kinds of
things that come up let's go ahead and
do the new model we're going to compile
it uh again here's our metrics accuracy
sparse categorical loss uh pretty
straight forward just like we did before
you got to compile the
model and just like before we're going
to take our create a history uh the
history is going to be uh new model fit
train
128 and just like before if you remember
when we started running this stuff we're
going to have to go ahead and it's going
to light up our uh setup on here and
this this is going to take a little bit
to get us all set up uh it's not going
to just happen in a couple minutes so
let me go ahead and pause the video and
run it and then we'll talk about what
happened okay now when I ran that these
actually took about six minutes each um
so it's a good thing I put it on hold we
did four epics uh actually had to stop
exes at 10 and switch it to four because
I didn't want to wait an
hour and you can see here our
accuracy um and our loss numbers going
down and just at a
glance it actually performed if you look
at the
accuracy
2658 um so our accuracy is going down or
you know
26% um 34% 35% and you can see here at
some point it just kind of kicks a
bucket again this is
overfitting that's always an issue when
you're running on uh programming these
different neural networks
and then we're going to go ahead and
plot the accuracy um history we built
that nice little sub routine up above so
we might as well use it and you can see
it right
here um there's that crossover
again and if you look at this look how
the how the um uh the red shifts up how
the uh our loss functions and everything
crosses over we're overfitting after one
Epic um we're clearly not helping the
problem or doing better um we're just
going to it's just going to Baseline
this one actually shows with the
training versus the
loss um value loss maybe second epic so
on here we're now talking more between
the first and the SE second epic and and
that also shows kind of here so
somewhere in here it starts
overfitting and right about now you
should be saying uhoh uh something went
wrong there I thought that um when we
went up here and ran this look at this
we have the accuracy up here is hitting
that
48% and we're down here
um you look at the score down here that
looks closer to 20% not nearly anywhere
in the ballpark of what we're looking
for and we'll go ahead and run it
through the uh the actual test features
here and and there it is um we actually
run this on the Unseen data and
everything8 or
18% um I don't know about you but I
wouldn't want you know at 18% this did a
lot worse than the other one I thought
this is supposed to be the super model
the model that beats all models the
vgg16 that won the awards and everything
well the reason is is that um one we're
not pre-processing the data uh so it
needs to be more there needs to be more
um as far as like rotating the data at
you know 45 degree angle taking partials
of it so you can create a lot more data
to go through here um and that would
actually greatly change the outcome on
here and then we went up here we only
added a couple dense layers um we added
a couple convolutional neural
networks this huge pre-trained setup is
looking for a lot more information
coming in as far as how it's going to
train and so uh this is one of those
things where I thought it would have
done better and I had to go back and
research it and look at it and say why
didn't this work why am I getting only
uh 18% here instead of 44% or better and
that would be wise it doesn't have
enough training data coming in uh and
again you can make your own training
data so it's not that we'll have a
shortage of data it's that that some of
that has to be switched around and moved
around a little bit and this is
interesting right here too if you look
at the
Precision we're getting it on number two
and yet we had zero on everything else
so for some reason is not
seeing uh the different variables in
here so that'd be something else to look
in and try to find track down um and
that probably has to do with the input
but you can see right here we have a
really good solid 0 48 up here uh and
that's where I'd really go with is
starting with this model and then we
look at this model and find out why are
these numbers not coming up better is it
the data coming in um where's the set up
on there and that is the art of data
science right there is finding out which
models work better and
why so sequential models uh so what
makes this a sequential model sequential
models are linear stacks of layers where
one layer leads to the next it is simple
and easy to implement and you just have
to make sure that the previous layer is
the input to the next layer so uh you
have used for plain stack of layers
where each layer has one input and one
output tensor and this is what tensor
flow is named after is um each one of
these layers is like a tensor each each
node is a tensor and then the layer is
also considered a tensor of
values and it's used for simple
classifier declassify models you can
it's also used for regression models too
so it's not just about uh this is
something this is a teapot this is a cat
this is a dog um it's also used for
generating um uh reg the actual values
you know this is worth $1 that's worth
$30 uh the weather's going to be 90° out
or whatever it is so you can use it for
both classifier and declassify uh
models and one more note when we talk
about sequential models the term
sequential is used a lot and it's used
in different areas and different
notations when you're in data science so
when we talk about time series we'll
talk about sequential that is something
very different uh sequential in this
case means it goes from the input to
layer one to Layer Two to the output so
it's very directional it's important to
note this because if you have a
sequential model can you have a
non-sequential model and the answer is
yes uh if you master the basics of a
sequential model you can just as easily
have another model that shares layers um
you can have another model where you
have an input coming in and it splits
and then you have one set that's doing
one set of uh nodes maybe they're doing
a yes no kind of node where it's either
putting out a zero or a one a classifier
and the other one might be regression
it's just processing numbers and then
you recombine them for the output um
that's what they call a cross uh the
cross
API so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that we're just focusing on
the basic cross model with the
sequential
model so so let's dive into the meat of
the matter let's do a and do a demo on
here uh today's demo in this demo we'll
be performing flower classification
using sequential model and carass and
we'll use our model to classify between
five different types of
flowers now for this demo and you can do
this demo on whatever platform you want
or whatever um user interface for
developing python um I'm actually using
anaconda and then I'm using Jupiter
notebooks to develop in and if you're
not familiar with this um you can go
under environment once you've created
environment you can come in here to open
a terminal window and if you don't have
the different modules in here you can do
youra install whatever module it is um
just happened that this particular setup
didn't have a Seaborn in it which I
already
installed uh so here's our anaconda and
then I'm going to go back
and start up my Jupiter
notebook where I already created a uh
new uh python project Python 3 I'm in
Python 3.8 on this particular one um
sequential model for flowers so lots of
fun there uh so we're going to jump
right into this the first thing is to
make sure you have all your modules
installed so if you don't have numpy
pandas matap plot library and Seaborn in
the carass um and sklearn or sidekit
it's not actually sklearn you'll need to
go ahead and install all of those now
having done this for years and having
switched environments and doing
different things um I get all my imports
done and then we just run it and if we
get an error we know we have to go back
and install something um right off the
bat though we have numpy pandas matplot
Library Seaborn these are built on top
of each other pandas the data frame and
built on top of numpy the uh um data
array and then we bring in our SK learn
or S kit this is the S kit setup SCI uh
kit even though you use sklearn to bring
it in it's a s kit and then our carass
we have our pre-processing the images
image data generator um our model this
is our basic model or sequential
model uh and then we bring in from coros
layers uh import dents um optimizers
these optimizers a lot of them already
come in these are your different
optimizers and it's almost a lot of this
is so automatic now um atom is the a lot
of times the default because you're
dealing with a large data uh and then we
get our SGD which is uh smaller data
does better on smaller pieces of data
and I'm not going to go into all of
these uh different optimizers we didn't
even use these in the actual demo you
just have to be aware that they are
different optimizers and the Digger the
more you dig into these models um you'll
hit a point where you do need to play
with these a little bit but for the most
part leave it at the default when you're
first starting
out and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers
dense and then if we come down a little
bit more uh when they put this together
and they're running the dense layers
you'll also see they have Dropout they
have flatten they have activation uh
they have the uh convolutional layer 2D
Max pooling 2D batch
normalization what are all these layers
uh and when we get to the model we're
going to talk about them uh a lot of
times when you're just starting you can
just uh uh import cross. layers and then
you have your Dropout your flatten uh
your convolutional uh neural network 2D
and we'll we'll cover what these do in
the actual example when we get down
there uh what I want you to take from
here though is you need to run your
Imports um and load your different
aspects of this and of course your
tensorflow TF because this is all built
on tensor flow and then finally uh
import random is RN just for random
generation and then we get down here we
have our uh
CV2 that is your um open image or your
open CV they call it for processing
images that's what the CV2
is uh we have our
tqdm the tqdm is for um is a progress
bar just a fancy way um of adding when
you're running a process you can view
the bar going across in the Jupiter uh
setup not really necessary but it's kind
of fun to have um we want to be able to
shuffle some files uh again these are
all different things pill is another um
image processor and goes with the CV2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we got to bring them
all in
and the next thing is to set up our
directories and so we come into the
directories there's an important thing
to note on here other than we're looking
at a lot of flowers which is
fun uh is we get down here we have our
directory archive flowers that just
happens to be where the different uh
files for different flowers are put in
we're denoting an X and a z and the x is
the data of the image and the Z is the
text for it what kind of flower is this
uh and the image size is really
important because we have to resize
everything if you have a neural network
and if you remember from our neural
networks uh let me flip back to that
slide we look at this slide we have two
input nodes here uh with an image you
have an input node depending on how you
set it up for each pixel and that pixel
has three different color schemes
usually in it sometimes four so if you
have have a picture that's 150 by
150 uh you multiply 150 * 150 * 3 that's
how many nodes input layers coming in I
mean so this is a massive input a lot of
times you think oh yeah it's just a a
small amount of data or something like
that uh no it's a full image coming in
then you have your hidden layers A lot
of times they match what the image size
is coming in so each one of those is
also just as big and then we get down to
just a single output so that's kind of a
a thing to note in here what's going on
behind the scenes and of course each one
of these layers has a lot of processes
and stuff going
on and then we have our our different uh
directories on here let me go and run
that so I'm just setting the directories
that's all this is um archive flowers
Daisy sunflower tulip dandelion Rose uh
just our different directories that
we're going to be looking
at uh and then we want to go ahead and
we're need to assign labels remember we
defined x and
z so we're just going to create a uh uh
definition here um and the first thing
is a return flower type
okay just returns it what kind of flower
it is I guess assign label to it uh but
we're going to go ahead and make our
train data and when you look at this
there's a couple things to take away
from here uh the first one is we're just
appending right onto to our numpy array
the image we're going to let numpy
handle all that different aspects as far
as 1 15 by 150 by 3 uh we just dump it
right into the numpy which makes it
really easy we don't have to do anything
funky on the processing and we want to
leave it like that and I'm going to talk
about that in a minute uh and then of
course we have to have the string a pin
the label on there and I want you to
notice right here uh we're going to read
the image
in and then we're going to size it
and this is important because we're just
changing this to 150 by 150 we're
resizing the image so it's uniform every
image comes in identical to the other
ones uh this is something that's so
important is um when you're resizing or
reformatting your data you really have
to be aware of what's going on with
images it's not a big deal because with
an image you just resize it so it looks
squishy or spread out or stretched um
the neural network picks up on that and
it doesn't really change how it
processes
it so let's go ahead and run that uh and
now we've got our definition set up on
there and then we want to go ahead and
make our
uh training data uh so make the train
data uh daisy flower daisy directory uh
print length of X so here we go let's go
and run that and we're just loading up
the flower daisy uh so this is going all
in there and it's setting um it's adding
it in to the our setup on there to our x
and z setup and we see we have
769 um and then of course you can see
this nice bar here this is the bar going
across is that little added uh code in
there that just makes it really cool for
doing demos uh not necessarily when
you're building your own model or
something like that but if you're going
to display this to other people adding
that little what was it called
um tqdm I can never remember that uh but
the tqdm module in there is really nice
and we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and
of course you could have just uh created
an array of these um but this has an
interesting problem that's going to come
up and I want to show you something it
doesn't matter how good the people in
the back are or how good you are at
programming errors are going to come up
and you got to figure out how to handle
them uh and so when we get all the way
down
to the um where is it dandelion here's
our dandelion directory we're going to
build
um Jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with but at the same time you would want
to go back in there depending on how
many times you rerun this how many times
you pull this so when you're finding
errors uh I'm going in here there's a
couple things you can do and we're just
going to um oh it wasn't there it is
there's our error I knew there was an
error this processed
1,62 out of 1065
now I can do a couple things one I can
go back into our definition and I can
just put in here try and so if it has a
bad conversion because this is where the
errors is coming from uh just skip it
that's one way to do it um when you're
doing a lot of work in data science and
you look at something like this where
you're losing three points of uh data at
the end you just say okay I lost three
points who cares um or you can go in
there and try to delete it um it really
doesn't matter for this particular demo
and so we're just going to leave that
eror right alone and skip over because
it's already added all the other files
in there and this is wonderful thing
about Jupiter notebook is that I can
just continue on there and the x and z
which we're creating is still uh running
and we'll just go right into the next
flower row so all these flowers are in
there um that's just a cool thing about
Jupiter
notebook uh and then we can go ahead and
just take a quick look and
see what we're dealing with and this is
of course really when you're dealing
with a other people and showing them
stuff this is just kind of fun where we
can display it on the plot Library here
and we're just going to go through and
um let's see what we got here uh looks
like we're going to do like five of each
of them I think is that how they set
this up um plot Library 5x two okay oh I
see how they did it okay so two each so
we have 5x two setup on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these
flowers it's always a good thing to look
at some of your data uh no matter what
you're doing we've reformatted this to
150 by 150 you can see how it really
blurs this one up here on the Tulip that
is that resize to 150 by 150 um and
these are what's actually going in these
are all 150 by 150 images you can check
the dimensions on the side
and you can see uh just a quick sampling
of the flowers we're actually going to
process on here and again like I said at
the beginning most of your work in data
science is
reprocessing this different uh
information so we need to go ahead and
take our
labels uh and run a label encoder on
there and then we're just going to Le is
a label encoder one of the things we
imported and then we always use the fit
um to categoric y comma 5 x here's our
array X so if you look at this here's
our fit we're going to transform Z
that's our Z array we
created um and then we have Y which
equals that and then we go ahead and do
uh to categorical we want five different
categories and then we create our x uh
inpay of x xal x over
255 so what's going on here there's two
different Transformations one we've
turned our categories into 0 1 2 3 4 5
as the output and we have taken our X
array and remember the X array is three
values of your different
colors this is so important to
understand when we do this across a
numpy array this takes every one of
those three colors so we have 150 by 150
pixels out of those 150 by 150 pixels
they each have three um color arrays and
those color arrays ra range from zero to
250 so when we take the xal X over
255 I'm sorry range from 0 to 255 this
converts all those pixels to a number
between zero and one and you really want
to do that when you're working with
neural networks uh now if you do a
linear regression model um it doesn't
affect it as much so you don't have to
do that conversion if you're doing
straight numbers but when you're running
neural networks if you don't do this
you're going to create a huge bias and
that means it'll do really good
predicting one or two things and they'll
just totally die on a lot of other
predictions so now we have our um X and
Y values uh X being the data in y being
our no one
output and with any good setup we want
to divide this data into our training so
we have X train uh we have our X test
this is the data we're not going to
program the model with and of course
your y train corresponds to your X train
and your y test corresponds to your X
test the outputs and this is uh when we
do the train test split this was from
the S kit s k learn we imported train
test split and we're just going to go
ahead and do the test size at about a
quarter of the data 0.25 and of course
random is always good this is such a
good tool I mean certainly you can do
your own division um you know you could
just take the first you know 0.25 of the
data or whatever do the length of the
data not real hard to do but this is
randomized so that if you're running
this test a few times you can kind of
get an idea whether it's going to work
or
not sometimes what I will do is um I'll
just split the data into three parts and
then I'll test it on two with one being
the U or train it on two of those parts
with one being the test and I rotate it
so I come up with three different
answers which is a good way of finding
out just how good your model is uh but
for setting up let's stick with the XT
train X test and the SK learn
package and then we're going to go ahead
and uh do a random
seed uh now a lot of times the cross
actually does this automatically but
we're going to go ahead and set it up on
here and you can see we did an NP random
seed um from 42 and we get a nice RN
number um and then we do TF random we
set the seed so you can set your
Randomness at the beginning of your
tensor flow and that's what the tf.
random. set
is so that's a lot of prep all this prep
and then we finally get to the exciting
part um this is where you probably spend
once you have the data prepped and you
have your pipeline going and you have
everything set up on there this is the
part that's exciting is building these
models and so we look at this model one
we're going to designate it sequential
um they have the API which is a coros
the coros tensorflow API versus
sequential sequential means we're going
one layer to the next so we're not going
to to split the layer and bring it back
together it looks almost the same with
the exception of um bringing it back
together so it's not a huge step to go
from this to an
API and the first thing we're going to
look at is um our convolutional neural
network in 2D uh so what's going on here
there's a lot of stuff that's going on
here um the default for well let's start
with the beginning what is a
convolutional 2d
Network well convolutional 2D Network
creates a number of small windows and
those small Windows float over the
picture and each one of them is her own
neural network and it's basically um
becomes like a um a categorization and
then it looks at that and it says oh if
we add these numbers up a certain way uh
we can find out whether this is the
right flower based on this this little
window floating around which looks at
different things and we have filters 32
so this is actually creating 32 Windows
is what that's
doing and the kernel size is 5x5 so
we're looking at a 5x5 Square remember
it's 150 by 150 so this narrows it down
to a 5x5 it's a 2d so it has your XY
coordinates um and when we look at this
5x5 remember each one of these is is
actually looking at 5x5 by3 uh so we're
actually looking at 15 by 15 different
um
pixels and padding is just um uh usually
I just ignore that activation by default
is railu we went ahead and put the ru in
there there's a lot of different
activations railu is for your smaller uh
when you remember I mentioned atom when
you have a lot of data data use an atom
kind of activation or use in atom
processing we're using the railu here uh
it kind of gives you a yes or no but it
it doesn't give you a full yes or no it
has a a zero and then it kind of shoots
off at an angle very common it's the
most common wand and then of course
here's our input shape 150 by 150 by 3
pixels and then we have to pull it so
whenever you have a two convolutional 2D
um uh layer we have to bring this back
together and pull this into uh neural
network and then we're going to go ahead
and repeat
this
uh so we're going to add another Network
here one of the cool things if you look
at this is that it as it comes in it
just kind of automatically assumes
you're going down to the next layer and
so we have another convolutional null
network uh 2D here's our Max pooling
again we're going to do that again Max
pooling uh and we're just going to
filter on down now one of the things
they did on this one is they changed the
kernel size they change the number of
filters and so each one of these steps
come kind of looks at the data a little
bit differently and that's kind of cool
because then you get a little added
filtering on there this is where you
start playing with the model you might
be looking at a convolutional no network
which is great for image
classifications um we get down to here
one of the things we see is flatten so
we add we just flatten it remember this
is 150 by 150 by 3 well and actually the
pool size changes so it's actually
smaller than that flatten just puts that
into a 1D array uh so instead of being
you know a tensor of this really
complexity with the the pixels and
everything it's just flat and then the
DSE is just another activation on there
um by default it is probably railu as
far as this
activation and then oh yeah here we go
in sequential they actually added the
activation as railu so this just because
this is sequential this activation is
attached to the dents uh and there's a
lot of different activations but Ru is
the most common one and then we also see
a soft Max uh soft Max is similar but it
has its own kind of variation and one of
the cool things you know what let me
bring this up because if we if you don't
know about these activations this
doesn't make
sense and I just did a quick Google
search on images of tensorflow
activations um I should probably look at
which website this is but this is the
output of the values uh so as your X as
it adds in all those uh weighted X
values going into the node it's going to
activate it a certain way and that's a
sigmoid activation and you can see it
goes between zero and one and has a nice
curve there this also shows the
derivatives um and if we come down the
seven popular activation functions
nonlinear activations there's a lot of
different options on this let me see if
I can find
[Music]
the O let me see we can find the
specific to
Rayo so this is a leaky Rilo
and you can see instead of it just being
zero and then a value between uh going
up it has a little leaky there otherwise
your Ru loses some noes they just become
inactive um but you can see there's a
lot of different options here here's a
good one right here with the railu you
can see The Rao function on the upper on
the upper left here and then the Leaky
railu over here on the right which is
very commonly used
also one of the things I use with
processing um language is the is the
exponential one or the tangent H the
hyperbolic tangent because they have
that nice uh funky curve that comes in
that um has a whole different meaning
and captures word use better again these
are very specific to domain and you can
spend a lot of time playing with
different models for our basic model uh
we'll stick to the railu and the softmax
on here and we'll go a and run and build
this
model so now that we've had fun playing
with all these different models that we
can add in there uh we need to go ahead
and have a batch size on here uh
128 epics
10 this means that we're going to send
128 uh rows of data or flowers at a time
to be processed and the Epic 10 that's
how many times we're going to Loop
through all the
data um and then there's all kinds of
stuff you can do again this is now built
into a lot of carass models already by
default
um so there's different ways to reduce
um the values and verbose verbose equals
one means that we're going to show
what's going on um value monitor what
we're monitoring we'll see that as we
actually train the model this is what's
what's going to come out of there if you
set the verbos equal to zero um you
don't have to watch it train the model
although it is kind of nice to actually
know what's going on
sometimes and since we're still working
on uh bringing the data in here's our
batch site here's our epics we need to
go ahead and create a data generator uh
this is our image data
generator and it has all the different
settings in here almost all of these are
defaults uh so if you're looking at this
going oh my gosh this is confusing most
of the time you can actually just ignore
most of this um vertical flip so you can
randomly flip pictures you can randomly
horizontally flip them um you can shift
the picture around this kind of helps
gives you multiple data off of them uh
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that um um setup because we already have
a huge amount of data if you're short
data you can start flipping like a
horizontal picture and it will generate
it's like doubling your data almost um
so the upsite is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have um
um 5,000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias uh that is the downside
of
that and so we have our model compile
and this you're going to see in all the
carass we're going to take this model
here we're going to take all this
information as far as how we want it to
go and we're going to compile
it this actually builds the model and so
we're going to run that and I want you
to notice uh learning
rate very important this is the default
001 um there's there you really don't
this is how slowly it adjusts to find
the right answer and the more data you
have you might actually make this a
smaller number um with larger with you
have a very small sample of data you
might go even larger than that and then
we're going to look at the loss
categorically categorical cross entropy
most commonly used and this is uh how
how much it improves the model is
improving is what this number means or
yeah that's that's important on there
and then the accuracy we want to know
just how good our model is on the
accuracy and then uh one of the cool
things to do is if you're in a group of
people who are studying the model if
you're in shareholders you don't want to
do this is you can run the model summary
I do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a
um we'll call it history but we want to
do a model fit
generator and so what this history is
doing is this is tracking what's going
on as while it fits the
model now there's a lot of new setups in
here where they just use fit and then
you put the generator in here um we're
going to leave it like this even though
the new default um is a little different
on that
doesn't really matter it does the same
thing and we'll go ahead and just run
that and you can see while it's running
right here uh we're going through the
epics we have one of 10 now we're going
through six of 25 here's our loss we're
printing that out so you can see how
it's improving and our accuracy the
accuracy gets better and better and this
is 6 out of 25 this is going to take a
couple minutes to process uh because we
are training 150 by 150 by 3 pixels
across uh six layers or eight layers
whatever it was that is a huge amount of
processing so this will take a few
minutes to process this is when we talk
about the hardware and the problems that
come up in data science and why it's
only now just exploding being able to do
neural networks this is why this process
takes a long
time now you should have seen a jump on
the screen here because I did uh uh
pause the recorder to let this go ahead
and run all all the way through its
epics let's go ahead and take a look and
see what these epics are and um if you
set the verbos to zero instead of one it
won't show what's going on in the behind
the scenes as is training it so when we
look at this epic 10 epics we went
through all the data 10 times uh if I
remember correctly there's roughly a gig
of data there so that's a lot of data
the first thing you're going to notice
is the 270 seconds um that's how much
each of those epics took to run and so
if you divide 60 in there you roughly
get about five minutes worth of each
epic so if I have 10 epics that's 50
minutes almost an hour of
runtime that's a big deal when we talk
about processing uh in on this
particular computer um I actually have
what is it uh uh eight cores with 16
dedicated threads so it runs like a 16
core computer it alternates the threads
going in and it still takes it 5 minutes
for each one of these epics so you start
to see that if you have a lot of data
this is going to be a problem if you
have a number of models you want to Fe
find out how good the models are doing
and what model to use and so each of
those models could take all night to run
in fact I have a model I'm running now
that takes over uh takes about a day and
a half to test each model um it takes
four days to do with the whole data uh
so what I do is I actually take a small
piece of the
data test it out to find out uh get an
idea of of how the different setups are
going to do and then I increase that
size of the data and then increase it
again and I can just take that that
curve and kind of say okay if um the
data is doing this then I need to add in
more dense layers or whatever uh so you
can do a small chunks of data then
figure out what it cost to do a large
set of data and what kind of model you
want the loss as we see here continues
to go down uh this is the error this is
how much errors is in there it really
isn't a um userfriendly number other
than the more it Trends down the better
and so if you continue to see the loss
going down eventually get to the point
where it stops going down and it goes up
and down and kind of waivers a little
bit that point you know you've run too
many epics you're you're starting to get
a bias in there and it's not going to
give you a good model fit the accuracy
just turns this into something that uh
we can use and so the accuracy is what
percentage of guesses in this case is
categorical so this is a percentage of
guesses are correct um value loss is
similar you know it's a minus a value
loss and then you have the value
accuracy and you'll see the value
accuracy is pretty similar to the
accuracy um just rounds it off basically
and so a lot of times you come down here
and you go okay we're doing 0.5
6 7 and that is 70% accuracy or in this
case
68 59% accuracy that's a very usable
number and it's very important to have
if you're identifying uh flowers that's
probably good enough if you can get
within a close distance and knowing what
flower you're you're identifying uh if
you're trying to figure out whether
someone's going to die from a heart
attack or not might want to rethink it a
little bit or uh rekey how you're
building your model so if I'm working
with a uh uh a group of um clients um
shareholders in a company or something
like that you don't really want to show
them this um you don't want to show them
hey you know this is what's going on
with the accuracy these are just numbers
and so we want to go and put the
finishing touches just like when you are
building a house and you put in the
frame and the trim on the house it's
nice to have something a nice view of
what's going on and so we'll go ahead
and do a pie plot and we'll just plot
the history of the loss uh the history
of the value
loss over here um epics train and test
and so we're just going to compute these
this is really important uh and what I
want you to notice right here
is when we get to about oh five epics a
little more than five six epics you see
a cross over here and it starts Crossing
as far as the um uh value loss and
what's going on here is you have the
loss in your actual model and your
actual data and you had the value loss
where it's testing it against the the
test data the the data wasn't used to
program your model wasn't used to train
your model on and so when we see this
crossing over this this is where the
bias is coming in this is becoming
overfitted and so when you put these two
together uh right around five and six
you start to see how it does this this
switch over here and that's really where
you need to stop right around five yeah
six um it's always hard to guess because
at this point the model's kind of a
black box uh so but you know that right
around here if you're saving your model
after each run you want to use the one
that's right around five epics cuz
that's the one one that's going to have
the least amount of bias so this is
really important as far as guessing
what's going on with your model and its
accuracy and when to stop uh it also is
you know I don't show people this mess
up here um I show somebody this kind of
model and I say this is where the
training and the testing comes in on
this model uh it just makes it easier to
see and people can understand what's
going
on so that completes our demo and you
can see we did what we were set out to
do we took our flowers and we're able to
classify them uh within about you 68 70%
accuracy whether it's going to be a uh
dollia sunflower cherry blossom Rose um
a lot of other things you can do with
your output as far as a different tables
to see where the errors are coming from
and what problems are coming
up and that brings us to the end of this
video on artificial intelligence 2022
full course by simply loan I hope you
liked it if you have any queries then
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video thank thank
you for
watching hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simplylearn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
[Music]
here
hi everyone welcome to this artificial
intelligence 2022 full course video by
simply Alan artificial intelligence Ence
applications are being widely used in
various fields to solve business
problems in this video you will learn
the important skills that will help you
understand Ai and its implementation
better our highly proficient trainers
will take you through this course so
let's look at the agenda for today's
topic we will start by learning the
basics of AI from a short animated video
then you will learn the top 10 AI
Technologies and companies for
2022 next you will understand machine
learning in detail and explore some of
the top machine learning algorithms that
are used to build intelligent machines
so here you will look at linear
regression logistic regression decision
tree k clustering KNN PCA and other
techniques such as regularization
reinforcement learning and Q learning
moving forward you will understand the
working of artificial neural networks
and deep learning algorithms such as
convolutional neural network Rec neural
network GIS image classification and
sequential model so let's get started
picture this a machine that could
organize your cupboard just as you like
it or serve every member of the House a
customized cup of coffee makes your day
easier doesn't it these are the products
of artificial intelligence but why use
the term artificial intelligence well
these machines are artificially
Incorporated with humanlike intelligence
to perform tasks as we do this
intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but AI may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact AI is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an AI do at
its core here is a robot we built in our
lab which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the AI robot must perform as expected
this ability to react appropriately to a
new situation is called generalized
learning the robot is now at a crossroad
one that is paved and the other Rocky
the robot must determine which path to
take based on the circumstances this
portrays the robot's reasoning ability
after a short stroll the robot now
encounters a stream that it cannot swim
across using the plank provided as an
input the robot is able to cross this
stream so our robot uses the given input
and finds the solution for a problem
this is problem solving these three
capabilities make the robot artificially
intelligent in short AI provides
machines with the capability to adapt
reason and provide
Solutions well now that we know what AI
is let's have a look at the two broad
categories an AI is classified into weak
AI also called narrow AI focuses solely
on one task for example alphao is a
maestro of the game go but you can't
expect it to be even remotely good at
chess this makes alpago a weak AI you
might say Alexa is definitely not a weak
AI since it can perform multiple tasks
well that's